WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND CALL
THIS JOINT THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE IN THE ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE HEARING --
TO ORDER IT IS THREE OH THREE PM --
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO
THE OVERSIGHT HEARING -- BUT OF
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE IN THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE THIS AFTERNOON
WE WILL BE DISCUSSING THE
FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS.
IDENTIFIED BY THE STATE AUDITOR
IN HER AUDIT REPORT RELEASED IN
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR TITLED
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
SEVERAL POURED MINISTRY
PRACTICES HAVE HINDERED
REDUCTIONS IN RECIDIVISM AND
TONIGHT INMATES ACCESS TO IN.
PRISON REHABILITATION PROGRAMS.
IN ADDITION.
TO THE IMPORTANT TOPIC OF IN
PRISON REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
WE WILL BE TAKING UP THE TOPIC
OF REENTRY PROGRAMS IN THIS
HEARING.
BOTH IN PRISON REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS AND REENTRY PROGRAMS
CAN HELP REDUCE RECIDIVISM I
LIKE TO THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REGINALD BYRON JONES SAWYER
SENIOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IAN CALDERON A
RECENT FATHER -- FOR THE SECOND
TIME. FOR REQUESTING THE AUDIT
THAT WE WILL DISCUSS TODAY.
THANK YOU ALSO FOR YOUR INTEREST
IN THE OVERSIGHT HEARING --
TODAY AS WELL THIS IS INDEED AN
IMPORTANT TOPIC -- THAT WOULD
BENEFIT FROM MORE OVERSIGHT
TODAY WILL ALSO BE DISCUSSING
THE PARTNER CORRECTION AND
REVERT TO REHABILITATION'S PLANS
FOR IMPLEMENTING.
CHANGES AND CORRECTIVE ACTION
SELF INSURE THAT THE
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS.
ARE WORKING EFFECTIVELY.
AS MANY HERE TODAY MAY KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE AND PART THANKS TO
MY COLLEAGUES HERE OF INCREASED
FUNDING SIGNIFICANTLY.
AND AN PRISON REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS I JUST THREE YEARS AGO
WE INCREASE FUNDING BY SIXTY
FOUR MILLION ARE APPROXIMATELY
30%.
OF THE OTHER REPORT IN TODAY'S
HEARINGS ARE AIMED AT MAKING
SURE THAT THIS FUNDING IS BEING
SPENT.
CORRECTLY IN A WAY THAT WILL
MOST EFFICIENTLY REDUCE
RECIDIVISM.
OUR DAUGHTER CLEARLY IDENTIFIED
SOME THINGS THAT NEED TO CHANGE
AT THE DEPARTMENT TO HELP REDUCE
RECIDIVISM -- SOME OF THE THINGS
IDENTIFIED IS ENSURING ONLY
EVIDENCE BASED CURRICULA IS
BEING TAUGHT -- SECONDLY
INSUREDS MEETING.
STAFFING GOALS FOR REHAB
PROGRAMS -- ESTABLISHING
PERFORMANCE TARGETS FOR REDUCING
RECIDIVISM.
EVALUATING WHETHER THE PROGRAMS
ARE REDUCING RECIDIVISM AND
VALIDATING -- THE FARMERS TOOLS
FOR EXCESS ASSESSING INMATES
REHABILITATIVE NEEDS LOOK FOR TO
REPRODUCTIVE AND ROBUST
DISCUSSION TODAY REGARDING THE
AUDIT REPORT -- WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS DOING TO IMPLEMENT
THE RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE
BENEFITS THAT CAN BE REALIZED
THROUGH BOTH REHABILITATION?
AND REINTERPRETED STE.
AS I SEE IT OUR GOALS FOR
TODAY'S HEARING IS TO ENSURE
THAT REHABILITATION AND RE ENTRY
PROGRAMS ARE WORKING PROPERLY.
I KNOW -- BOTH THE ORIGINAL
AUTHORS OF THE ADDED ARE UP HERE
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THEY'D --
MUCH LIKE TO SEE AS WELL.
I LIKE TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR
YOUR EFFORTS AND REDUCING
RECIDIVISM AND MAKE SURE THESE
PROGRAMS ARE WORKING EFFECTIVELY --
WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER FOR
OPENING COMMENTS FROM FIRST THE
CHAIR OF PUBLIC SAFETY -- MISTER
BYRON JONES SAWYER SENIOR.
THANK YOU AND AND I'M I'M SO
GLAD WE'RE FINALLY HERE SO DO WE
CANNOT TALK ABOUT.
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT I HAD
HOPED -- WE COULD GET -- TO AND
ESPECIALLY SINCE I I KNOW IT'S
PROBABLY A BAD TERMS SAY SAY I'M
THE CULPRIT THAT STARTED THIS
WHOLE THING WITH -- MISTER
CALDERON TO TRY TO GET THIS
STARTED AND I AND I JUST WANTED
TO BE CLEAR.
FROM THE ONSET BECAUSE I'VE
EITHER BEEN MISQUOTED
MISUNDERSTOOD OR P. WHICH IS
THAT IT IS MADE UP STUFF ABOUT
MY INTENT OF WHY I WANTED TO DO
THIS.
AND SO LET ME MAKE THIS CLEAR
HOPEFULLY ONCE AND FOR ALL -- I
AM 1100% -- 1100% OF MY BODY
BONE IN.
AND THINKING I BELIEVE THE BILL
PUSH REAL BILL TATIAN PROGRAMS
WORK.
MY ISSUE IS I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
PROBABLY HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WE WE FUNDING INTO THESE
PROGRAMS.
THAT THE BEST PROGRAMS ARE
CONTINUE TO BE FUNDED AND MORE
IMPORTANT THAT WE GROW EVEN MORE
SO -- I GUESS WHEN I ALWAYS
WOULD SAY THE SECOND PART WHICH
IS THE ONES THAT NEED SOME HELP.
THAT WE DO PROVIDE THE FUNDING
FOR THEM AND THAT WE GET THEM TO
CAPACITY WHERE THEY CAN GROW.
BUT MOST PEOPLE GENERALLY JUST
HERE THE ONES THAT DON'T WORK
AND WE CAN SHOW THAT THEY'RE NOT
WORKING AND IT NOT ABLE TO GET
UP TO CAPACITY.
WE HAVE A FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY TO CUT THOSE
PROGRAMS AND I'M HOPING THAT WE
THEN MOVED THOSE RESOURCES
REMEMBER WHAT I SAID THEM REMOVE
THOSE.
RESOURCES IN MONEY AND AND STAFF
OVER TO PROGRAMS THAT ACTUALLY
WORK. FOR ME THAT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THAT WE NEED TO
DO.
BECAUSE I WORK FOR CRLA FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND I AM
RECOVERING BUREAUCRAT AND I KNOW.
WE DON'T AS A GOVERNMENT WE
DON'T COOK CUP PROGRAMS.
BOB IS MANY TIMES WE LET THINGS
LINGER ON AND ON IN THIS WHOLE
PROCESS OF WIDGETS IN.
AND WE JUST CARE ABOUT HOW MANY
PEOPLE WE TREAT BUT WE NEVER
TALK ABOUT HOW MANY.
PEOPLE WE HELP THE MOST
IMPORTANT HOW EFFECTIVE THEY
HAVE BEEN ESPECIALLY TALK WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT A RETURN ON
INVESTMENT -- I NOTICED A NEW
TERM EVERYBODY WANTS TO USE THE
TERM -- DIVERSION PROGRAMS IN
EVIDENCE BASED WELL I LIKE A
BUSINESS TERM RETURN ON
INVESTMENT BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DOING WHEN WE PUT MONEY
INTO REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
BECAUSE WE'RE INVESTING IN
PEOPLE.
AND GUESS WHAT WE ACTUALLY DO.
GET A RETURN ON OUR INVESTMENT --
INSTEAD OF SPENDING. THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
FOR DJJ PROGRAMS -- AS OF WHICH
I'VE SAID A MILLION TIMES WE
PROBABLY COULD SEND SOMEONE TO
MY ALMA MATER USC.
GET A BRAND NEW MERCEDES HAVING
GIVEN THE CONDO BUT AFTER FOUR
YEARS DATE DATE HAVE A FOUR YEAR
DEGREE. TO BE ABLE TO WORK WE'RE
SPINNIN AT AND DEPARTMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE AND A LOT OF
TIMES THAT DOESN'T EQUATE THAT
EQUATES INTO SPENDING EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS YEAR.
KEEPING THEM INCARCERATED AND IN
THE PRISON SYSTEM AND WE DON'T
REALLY RUBIO BULLET TAKEN SO
THAT'S WHY.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT WE WE PUT
OUR THINKING CAPS ON AND REALLY
START TO TALK ABOUT HOW WE CAN
MAKE THESE THIS WORK.
IF WE SUCCEED EVERY ABILITY
ATION WILL BE ABLE TO
DRAMATICALLY CHANGE THE LIFE OF
A FORMERLY INCARCERATED INMATE
AND CUT DOWN ON THE EVER
INCREASING CORRECTIONS BUDGET.
WITH THIS KNOWLEDGE I REQUESTED
THE OUGHT THE AUDIT HOPING THAT
THE INFORMATION WE GOT BACK
WOULD HIGHLIGHT SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM.
AND ALSO ILLUMINATE WHICH
PROGRAMS ARE IN NEED OF
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. TO IMPROVE
THEIR SUCCESS RATES.
WHAT WE GOT BACK WAS PARTLY
POSITIVE IN THAT WE LEARN
COGNITIVE BEHAVIOR PROGRAM CBT
ARE AVAILABLE IN ALL STATE
PRISONS?
BUT UNFORTUNATELY MUCH MORE WORK
MUST BE DONE.
WE LEARNED A TO SYSTEMS FOR PARK
PRIORITIZING INMATES FOR
PROGRAMMING ARE OUTDATED.
WE LEARNED THAT INMATES ARE NOT
PRIOR TO RISE FOR PROGRAM
PLACEMENT BY NEED AND THERE IS
NO SYSTEM IN PLACE TO MAKE.
THAT.
MAKE SURE THAT THAT INMATES THAT
INMATES CLOSEST TO RELEASE ARE
PLACED IN PROGRAM.
WE LEARNED A PROGRAM'S REALLY
HAVE PERFORMANCE METRICS TO
EVALUATE OUTCOMES.
WE ALSO LEARNED SOME POSITIVE
THINGS AS WELL LEARN THAT.
THAT AT ELEVEN AT 11% SUCCESS
WORK RATE THAT WOULD MEAN TO
PROGRAMS PAY FOR THEMSELVES.
LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN.
IF ONE IN NINE PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS.
DO NOT RETURN TO JAIL OR PRISON.
WE COULD SAVE THE STATE NEARLY
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
WE LEARNED THAT THE CAL.
P. I. A PROGRAMS THOSE THAT
TRAIN INMATES AND UNION
AFFILIATED TRADE PROGRAMS ALSO
HAVE REMARKABLE SUCCESS.
NOT ONLY DO THESE PROGRAMS LEAD
TO INMATES ENTERING THE
WORKFORCE WOULD GOOD PAYING
UNION JOBS BUT THEY ALSO
REPORTED A RECIDIVISM RATE.
OF ONLY 7%.
IT'S DATA LIKE THIS THAT IS MY
INTEREST TODAY.
I THINK WE ABLE TATIAN PROGRAMS
WERE TOO IMPORTANT FOR US NOT TO
DO ANYTHING.
AND NOT TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO SEE THEM SUCCEED SUCCEED
FURTHER AS STEWARDS OF THE
PUBLIC'S MONEY IS IMPERATIVE
THAT WE MAKE WISE INVESTMENTS IN
TRACK DATA.
THIS IS THE SUBJECT OF MY
INTEREST TODAY.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT WORKS SO WE
CAN DOUBLE DOWN.
ON IT I WANT TO KNOW WHAT
DOESN'T WORK SO WE CAN ADJUST
AND FIX IT.
I WANT TO KNOW WHERE WE NEED
MORE RESOURCES SO WE CAN
ADVOCATE FOR THEM.
AND I WANT TO KNOW WHERE THERE
IS WAY SO WE CAN MAKE CHANGES
FOR ME REAL WITH PATIENT
REHABILITATION IS A MORAL ISSUE
BUT IS ALSO A FINANCIAL ONE AS
WELL.
IS THE FACT THAT EVERY INMATE
COSTS EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR TO HOUSE IN
ADDITION EACH PERSON KEPT BEHIND
BARS ALSO MEANS A LOSS OF
PROPERTY TAX.
INCOME TAX AND SALES TAX TO
SOMETHING OF DISTASTE NOTHING OF
THE VALUE OF EACH INDIVIDUAL TO
THE FAMILY COMMUNITY.
WE CAN QUALIFY QUANTIFY THE
SAVINGS AND CAPTURE THEM THIS IS
WHY THIS IS SO IMPORTANT WE CAN
PROVE THE VALUE REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS WE CAN LAY THE
FOUNDATION FOR FUTURE FUNDING.
WE CAN SUPPORT THE ARE.
IN CD C. R. BUT WE CAN ALSO DO
THAT WITH DEPARTMENTAL BY IN TO
HELP US UNDERSTAND SUCCESS.
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THAT CONVERSATION TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS I
THINK -- THAT'S THE ULTIMATE
GOAL FOR TODAY IS FINDING OUT
WHICH PROGRAMS ARE EFFICIENT
WHAT WORDS ARE NOT HOW DO WE GET.
PEOPLE TO HOW DO WE REDUCE
RECIDIVISM RATE WITH WHICH
PROGRAMS I APPRECIATE THE
AUDITOR AND HER.
HER WORK IN HELPING GUIDE SOME
OF THESE DISCUSSIONS TODAY --
AND FROM WHAT THAT WE HAVE AN
OPENING COMMENT FROM OUR
MAJORITY LEADER MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU AS CHAIR SAUCE AND AND
I ONE THING BOTH CHAIRS FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY TO
PARTICIPATE THIS OVERSIGHT
HEARING ALSO WANT TO THANK OUR
AUDITOR. FOR BEING HERE TO GO
OVER THE THAT THE ARTISTS
FINDINGS WITH US.
I LAST YEAR I I DID PARTNER WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER TO
REQUEST THAT THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE
APPROVING NOT IT -- TO EVALUATE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF CDC OURS IN
PRISON REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS.
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
REHABILITATION'S OFFERS INMATES
VARIOUS REAL BIT REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS WHILE THEY'RE IN PRISON
INCLUDING EDUCATION AND
SUBSTANCE USE OR THIS ORDER
TREAT TREATMENT PROGRAMS.
THE PRIMARY GOAL OF THESE
PROGRAMS IS TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM.
OUR AUTO REQUEST STEM FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
REPORT FROM DECEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ON IMPROVING.
IN PRISON REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS WHICH FOUND SEVERAL
SHORTCOMINGS LA OWES REPORT
CONCLUDED THAT THE CDC ARE HAS A
FLAWED APPROACH FOR MEASURING
PROGRAM PERFORMANCE WHICH MAKES
IT DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE
WHETHER.
EXISTING PROGRAM RESOURCES ARE
BEING USED EFFECTIVELY.
THE RESULTING AUDIT FINDINGS
WERE TROUBLING.
I WON'T GO INTO A LOT OF THE
FINING SINCE THE OTTERS HERE TO
GO INTO GREATER DETAIL.
THE AUDIT CONCLUDED WITH SEVERAL
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR CDC ARE AND
THE LEGISLATURE.
ALONG WITH MY JOINT AUTHORED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
I'VE INTRODUCED AB SIXTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH ENDEAVORS TO
PURSUE THOSE AUDITS
RECOMMENDATIONS.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT CDC OURS
WILL BE REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
REDUCE RECIDIVISM.
AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT WILL
REQUIRE CDC ARE TO DO THE
FOLLOWING.
ESTABLISH PERFORMANCE TARGETS
INCLUDING ONES FOR REDUCING
RECIDIVISM AND DETERMINE THE
PROGRAM'S COST EFFECTIVENESS.
PARTNER WITH EXTERNAL
RESEARCHERS TO EVALUATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF ITS
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS AND
IMPLEMENT A COMPREHENSIVE THREE
YEAR PLAN TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT A CORRECTIVE ACTION
PLAN.
IN ISSUE AN ANNUAL REPORT
BEGINNING FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO THAT SHOWS
THE PERCENTAGE REDUCTION AND
RECIDIVISM THAT CAN BE
ATTRIBUTED TO THE REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS PRIOR TO PURSUING ANY
LET ANY LEGISLATION A
RECOMMENDATION RECOMMENDING
CHANGES. TO ANY IN PRISON
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS WE
BELIEVED AN AUDIT WAS NECESSARY
TO FULLY UNDERSTAND THE CDC OURS
PROCESSES AND PROCEDURES. FOR
IMPLEMENTING THEIR REAR BELT
READ THEIR REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS.
AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY A WILL RESULT
IN A THOROUGH EVALUATION OF THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF A
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS TO
ENSURE THAT THESE PROGRAMS IN
STATE PRISONS AND DO NEED DO
INDEED PROMOTE.
REDUCTIONS IN RECIDIVISM WE HOPE
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
PUBLIC FUNDS ARE BEING PROPERLY
UTILIZED AND THE STATE IS
FEELING THE REHABILITATIVE
COMPONENT.
OF THE CORRECTIONAL EXPERIENCE
AND I ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM THE SECONDARY IN
BEING INVOLVED OVERALL IN THE
OVERSIGHT EVERITT AND JUST AS A
PERSONAL SIDE THE REASON THAT I
GOT INVOLVED IN THIS ISSUE.
IS THAT I LOS AN OFFICER IN MY
DISTRICT AND IN REVIEWING A BILL
IN DOING THE RESEARCH INTO
RECIDIVISM BRAWLING EVERYTHING
ELSE ONE OF THE ONE OF THE STAFF
TO SET OUT TO ME THE MOST WAS
THE FACT THAT -- ALTHOUGH WE AS
A STATE -- SPEND AROUND FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
ON REHABILITATION PROGRAMS THERE
HAD NEVER ONCE BEEN AN AUDIT.
OF THE REHABILITATION PROGRAMS --
THROUGH C. C. R. HOW CAN WE
EFFECTIVELY SPEND THAT MONEY
UNLESS WE'RE BEING TOLD OR HAVE
ANY EVIDENCE TO TO POINT
DIRECTLY -- TO SPECIFIC
INFORMATION THAT EITHER SHOWS US
THAT.
THESE PROGRAMS THAT WERE PAYING
FOR PAYING A LOT OF MONEY FOR
OUR AFFECTIVE OR THEY'RE NOT
EFFECTIVE THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO --
WITH ANYTHING OTHER THAN MAKING
SURE THAT WE ARE PERFORMING ARTS
OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITY AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY WHEN SPEAKER
RENDON TOOK OVER HE WAS VERY
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT HE WANTED US.
AS THE LEGISLATURE TO DO
ESPECIALLY THROUGH THE COMMITTEE
PROCESS AND THAT WAS TO
REESTABLISH OUR AUTHORITY
THROUGH OVERSIGHT.
AND THIS IS WHAT THAT IS
REESTABLISHING THE LEGISLATURE'S
AUTHORITY TO OVERSIGHT SO THAT
WE FULLY.
UNDERSTAND COMPETENTLY THE
DYNAMICS OF WHICH WE ARE MAKING
THE DECISIONS IN THE DETAILS
THAT ARE DRIVING THE DECISIONS
THAT WERE MAKING THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT THAT'S WHY WE
REQUESTED THIS AUDIT THIS AUDIT
V. YIELDED THINGS WE KNEW THINGS
WE DID AND NOW.
AND FOR THAT WE WERE ABLE -- TO
AT LEAST I WAS ABLE TO CRAFT A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT I HOPE
IS GOING TO GO TOWARDS MAKING --
THIS PROCESS AND A REDUCTION IN
RECIDIVISM -- MORTGAGE OF A
GUARANTEE AND THAT WE ARE.
WE AS A STATE AND THE MONEY THAT
WE PUT INTO WERE SEVEN REDUCTION --
IS IS IS A FACT IS AS EFFECTIVE
AS WE EXPECTED TO BE BUT IS AS
EFFECTIVE AS OUR CONSTITUENTS
AND THE PEOPLE THAT WE REPRESENT
IN WHOSE MONEY WE'RE SPENDING.
NEED THESE PROGRAMS TO BE SO
WITH THAT I I AM DONE AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU BOTH FOR ALLOW ME
TO BE A PART OF THIS HEARING.
THANK YOU FOR COMMENTS SO -- I
THINK LAST COUNT THERE WAS AT
LEAST FOR LEGISLATIVE BILLS A
RELATED TO THE AUDIT.
IN THE AUDITOR'S FINDINGS SO
WITH THAT WILL GO AHEAD AND
BEGIN NOT AS GOOD AS MINE BUT
YOU CAN HAVE.
MISTER CALDERON HAS A PREFERENCE
FOR HIS OWN.
LEGISLATIVE BILL WITH THAT LET'S
GO AHEAD AND BEGIN -- WITH
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER TWO AN
OVERVIEW OF OUR FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR.
WE HAVE WITH US OUR STATE
AUDITOR ELAINE HOWELL HERS A
SENIOR AUDITOR AIR AND FELT.
THANK YOU GUYS FOR JOINING US WE
JUST PROVIDE US A KIND OF AN
OVERVIEW OF YOUR FINDINGS AND
THEN WE'LL GO FROM THERE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
FOR THE RECORD MY NAME'S ELAINE
HOW CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR --
TO MY RIGHT IS MY COLLEAGUE
AARON FILM THERE HE WAS THE
PROJECT LEAD ON THIS PARTICULAR
AUDIT I'M GOING TO GO OVER THE
KEY FINDINGS IN THE ARE -- THAT
WE COMPLETED IN JANUARY MR
FELDER WILL STEP YOU THROUGH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS HE HE'S GROUP
THEM BY BY SUBJECT MATTER -- AND
THEN WE HAVE RECEIVED THIS SIXTY
DAY RESPONSE AS I'M SURE ALL THE
MEMBERS KNOW WHEN WE ISSUE AN
AUDIT REPORT THERE'S AN INITIAL
RESPONSE THAT'S INCLUDED IN
PUBLISHED WITH THE ACTUAL REPORT.
BUT THEN WE EXPECT THE ENTITY WE
AUDIT TO FOLLOW UP AND GIVE US
PROGRESS.
REPORTS ESSENTIALLY AT SIX
MONTHS SIXTY DAYS SIX MONTHS IN
ONE YEAR SO WE DO HAVE THE SIXTY
DAY AND HE WILL BE ABLE TO
COMMENT ON OUR REVIEW OF WHAT.
CORRECTIONS HAS PROVIDED TO US --
IN ITS RESPONSE AND WHAT WE
THINK NEEDS TO BE IMPROVED
THINGS WE THINK ARE POSITIVE --
STEPS IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION --
BUT MR FELDER WILL GO OVER THAT
SO MY PART OF THE PRESENTATION
WILL BE THE KEY FINDINGS IN THE
REPORT.
SO WE WE TALKED ABOUT THREE
DIFFERENT.
KEY AREAS IN THE REPORT AND IN
YOUR OPENING COMMENTS MEMBERS
YOU TOUCHED ON SOME OF IT.
THE FIRST SECTION OF THE REPORT
REALLY TALKS ABOUT -- THE
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS AND
WHETHER OR NOT THEY HAVE BEEN
EFFECTIVE IN.
REDUCING RECIDIVISM AND WE
ACTUALLY -- IDENTIFIED CONTROL
GROUPS WORKED WITH --
STATISTICIAN AND DID AN ANALYSIS
OF INMATES WHO HAD BEEN RELEASED
AND FISCAL YEAR.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN REASON WE
SELECTED THAT YEAR IT'S IT'S
SUBSEQUENT TO WHEN CORRECTIONS
WAS COLLECTING DATA THAT WAS
MORE ACCURATE THAN IN THE PAST
WHAT IT ALLOWED US TO DO IS LOOK
AT RECIDIVISM JUST TWO YEARS OUT.
SO -- IN IN THOSE TWO PARTICULAR
YEARS WE IDENTIFIED THAT THE
RECIDIVISM RATE ESSENTIALLY WAS
THE SAME. FOR INMATES WHO HAD
BEEN THROUGH SOME CBT COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL THERAPY PROGRAMS AND
THOSE WHO HAD NOT RECEIVED THAT
TYPE OF REHABILITATION -- AND
AND ACCESS TO THOSE PARTICULAR
PROGRAMS.
BOTH AT YEAR ONE AND A YEAR TO
YEAR -- ONE THE RECIDIVISM RATE
WAS AROUND 1213% FOR BOTH GROUPS
AT YEAR TWO IT WAS 2425%.
SEEM SURPRISING SO WE SAID WHY
IS THAT WHY IS THERE A
DIFFERENCE IS IT BECAUSE THERE'S
A PROBLEM WITH THE PROGRAMS NOT
NECESSARILY AS AS YOU INDICATED
MISTER JONES SAWYER.
SO WE LOOKED AT WHAT IS THE
METHOD WHAT IS CORRECTIONS DOING
TO ENSURE THAT.
THE CORRECT THE INMATES WHO HAVE
HIGH NEEDS.
AND A HIGH RISK OF RECIDIVISM
ARE BEING PRIORITIZED AND PLACED
IN THOSE PARTICULAR PROGRAMS ARE
WE ENSURING THAT THOSE PROGRAMS
ARE EVIDENCE BASED THOSE ARE THE
BEST PROGRAMS.
THAT WE THIS WE AS A STATE
SHOULD BE PROVIDING TO THOSE
INMATES.
AND WHAT WE FOUND IS.
FIRST OF ALL -- AND LOOKING AT
HOW THEY ARE ASSESSING THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
ASSESSES INMATES COMING IN AND
THEY USED THREE DIFFERENT TOOLS
AND WE IDENTIFIED THAT SOME OF
THOSE TOOLS HAVE NOT BEEN
VALIDATED.
AS TO AS TO THEIR EFFECTIVENESS
IN IDENTIFYING HIGH NEED HIGH
RECIDIVISM HADN'T BEEN EVALUATED
IN AT LEAST.
IN ONE CASE COMPASS WHICH IS
ASSESSES -- AN INMATE --
CRIMINAL RECORD LOOKS AT WHAT
TYPES OF A COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL
PROGRAMS WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
THAT INDIVIDUAL.
THAT HAD NOT BEEN REASSESSED
SINCE.
TWENTY TEN AND WHEN THEY'RE
ASSESSING IT TWENTY TEN THEY'RE
USING DATA THAT'S EVEN OLDER.
NOW ANOTHER ANOTHER TOOL THEY
USE IS CALL IS A CS ARE RAY.
AND THAT REALLY LOOKS OUT THERE
IT'S CALLED THE STATUS STATIC
RISK ASSESSMENT THAT'S LOOKING
AT THE RISK OF RECIDIVISM BUT
AGAIN THAT TOOL HAVEN'T BEEN
EVALUATED SINCE.
TWENTY THIRTEEN AND AGAIN
THEY'RE USING DATA THAT'S QUITE
OLD SO THESE ASSESSMENT TOOLS
COMPASS CS ARE A TAPE IS THEIR
ACADEMIC IT'S ARE BASICALLY A
TEST OF ACADEMIC BASIC EDUCATION.
ARM THAT HAD BEEN REASSESSED AND
EVALUATED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN SO
WE HAD A LITTLE BIT MORE
CONFIDENCE AND THAT PARTICULAR
PROGRAM AND THAT FEEDS INTO.
THE TYPES OF ACADEMIC PROGRAMS
THAT INMATES WOULD RECEIVE BUT
BOTH COMPASS AND CS ARE A HAVE
NOT BEEN EVALUATED AND DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE REALLY
THE APPROPRIATE TOOL TO BE USING.
AND ASSESSING INMATES IN
DETERMINING WHETHER THEY HAVE
HIGH NEEDS AND WHAT TYPES OF
PROGRAMS THEY SHOULD BE PLACED
IN SO THAT WAS THE FIRST CONCERN
THAT WE IDENTIFIED.
THE SECOND CONCERN IS WHEN WE
ACTUALLY LOOKED AT THE EVIDENCE
THAT THE THIS CBT PROGRAMS WE
FOUND THAT A VARIETY OF
INSTITUTIONS WERE NOT
NECESSARILY ENSURING.
THAT THE PROGRAMS WERE EVIDENCE
BASED -- THERE'S A UP YOU
CLEARING HOUSE THAT ACTUALLY HAS
AN EX THAT HAS DONE EXTENSIVE
RESEARCH ON EVIDENCE BASED
PROGRAMS HAS ESSENTIALLY A
CATALOG OF PROGRAMS THAT
INSTITUTIONS COULD USE -- AND
CORRECTIONS CONTRACTS ACTUALLY
REQUIRE VENDORS IS A CONTRACT
OUT FOR MOST OF THESE PROGRAMS.
TO USE EVIDENCE BASED.
CURRICULA.
BUT WHAT WE WERE FINDING IS THEY
ARE NOT MONITORING WHETHER OR
NOT THOSE VENDORS ACTUALLY ARE
USING THAT TYPE OF CURRICULA.
AND WHAT WE FOUND AT AT TEN OF
THE INSTITUTIONS IS.
THERE WAS A RANGE BETWEEN A LOW
OF THREE OR 4% TO A HIGH OF 22%
OF THESE CLASS OR NOT ACTUALLY
56% SO LET ME LET ME BACK UP FOR
SECOND.
SO WE REVIEWED VENDORS TEN
INSTITUTIONS ON AVERAGE ABOUT
17% OF THOSE PROGRAMS THOSE CBT
PROGRAMS WERE NOT EVIDENCE BASED
BUT THAT REALLY DID RANGE IT WAS
A LOW OF ABOUT 3% TO A HIGH OF
56% SO OVER HALF OF THE PROGRAMS.
AT A PARTICULAR INSTITUTION RJ
DONOVAN WERE USING CBT PROGRAMS
THAT WERE NOT EVIDENCE BASED SO
THERE WASN'T SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE
TO DEMONSTRATE THAT THIS IS THE
APPROPRIATE TYPE OF PROGRAM TO
BE PROVIDING. TO INMATES WHO
HAVE A HIGH NEED FOR THESE TYPES
OF SERVICES TO TO YOU KNOW
STRENGTHEN THEIR ABILITY FOR
WHEN THEY'RE RELEASED TO NOT
RESET OF EIGHT AND NOT RETURN TO
PRISON.
SO WE REALLY HAD CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT THOSE EVIDENCE BASED
PROGRAMS CORRECTIONS NOT
MONITORING THOSE PARTICULAR
PROGRAMS.
NOW THEY HIRED UC IRVINE TO
ASSIST THEM IN DETERMINING HOW
DO WE MANAGE THESE CONTRACTS
WHAT TYPES OF THINGS SHOULD WE
BE DOING AND FAR AS FAR AS A
PROGRAM REVIEW.
NOT JUST IDENTIFYING WHETHER
IT'S EVIDENCE BASED BUT ACTUALLY
GOING OUT AND OBSERVING.
US SOME OF THE PROGRAMS SPENDING
MORE TIME OUT AT THE
INSTITUTIONS INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF OBSERVATIONS SO THE UC
IRVINE HAD A VARIETY OF
RECOMMENDATIONS. TO GIVE OUR
CORRECTIONS THE OPPORTUNITY GET
OUT THERE AND DO A BETTER JOB OF
MONITORING THESE VENDORS WHO ARE
PROVIDING THESE PROGRAMS.
WHEN WE ASKED CORRECTIONS ABOUT
THAT THEY THEY INTENDED TO PILOT
IT AND STARTED PILOTING -- THIS
NEW PROGRAM REVIEW AND A COUPLE
OF INSTITUTIONS AND THEY INTEND
TO ROLL THAT OUT TO MORE
INSTITUTIONS OR OVER THE COMING
YEAR THEY THEY INTENDED TO START
DOING THAT IN JANUARY OF THIS
YEAR SO HOPEFULLY WHEN THEY
PRESENT.
THEY'LL HAVE MORE INFORMATION
FOR YOU ABOUT THAT BUT THAT'S A
KEY ISSUE IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
THE PROGRAMS AREN'T ANY GOOD BUT
YOU'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE YOU'RE
USING THE APPROACH.
TYPES OF PROGRAMS THAT ARE GOING
TO BENEFIT THE INMATES AND THAT
ARE PROVEN PROGRAMS AND EVIDENCE
BASED PROGRAMS HAVE CLEARLY BEEN
PROVEN TO BE VERY EFFECTIVE IN
REDUCING RECIDIVISM SO WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
INSTITUTIONS ARE USING THOSE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS.
THE SECOND AREA THE REPORT --
TALKS ABOUT PLACEMENT AND
DETERMINING WHETHER OR NOT THE
INSTITUTIONS ARE APPROPRIATELY
PRIORITIZING INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE HIGH NEED.
AND HIGH RISK A RESET OF A RESET
EVADING -- INTO INSTITUTIONS AND
WHAT WE FOUND IS THEY ARE NOT
DOING THAT -- UNFORTUNATELY WE
FOUND THAT IN FIFTY FISCAL YEAR
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WE IDENTIFIED
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND INMATES WHO
HAD BEEN RELEASED -- WHO HAD
MODERATE TO HIGH RISK IN BOTH
CATEGORIES HIGH RISK HIGH NEEDS
AND HIGH RISK OF RETURNING TO
PRESENT RESET EVADING-- BUT OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ONLY ABOUT 30%
38% OR EVEN A SIGN.
TO A REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS OR
HAD COMPLETED ANY PORTION OF
THOSE PARTICULAR PROGRAMS THERE
WAS A HIGH NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS.
WHO DIDN'T HAVE HIGH NEEDS OR
WHO WERE AT HIGH RISK OF
RECIDIVISM RECEIVING CORPS
ENDING UP IN SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS SO CORRECTIONS WAS NOT
DOING A GOOD JOB AT THE VARIOUS
INSTITUTIONS?
OF MAKING SURE THAT THEY PUT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO.
REALLY NEEDED THESE PROGRAMS AT
THE TOP OF THE LIST AND GAVE
THEM PRIORITY TO GET INTO SOME
OF THESE THESE COURSES.
I'M ANOTHER ISSUE THAT THAT WE
HEARD FROM THE DEPARTMENT AND
REALLY WAS VALIDATED BY SOME OF
THE WORK THAT THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL DOES THEY DO
SOME OVERSIGHT OF THE DEPARTMENT
CORRECTIONS AS I'M SURE YOU'RE
AWARE.
AND THEY FOUND THAT.
YOU KNOW THE VACANCY RATE THEY
STILL SUFFER FROM ISSUES RELATED
TO TRYING TO HIRE INDIVIDUALS
BOTH FOR ACADEMIC AND VOCATIONAL
PROGRAMS AS I SAID THERE
COGNITIVE BEHVIOR PROGRAMS THEY
PRETTY MUCH CONTRACT THAT OUT
WITH VENDORS -- BUT FOR ACADEMIC
AND VOCATIONAL EDUCATION%
PROGRAMS THEY CONTINUE TO HAVE.
A VACANCY RATES THAT ARE A
LITTLE HIGHER THAN THEY THEY
BELIEVE WOULD BE BEST -- FOR THE
INSTITUTIONS AND FOR THEM TO BE
ABLE TO MEET THEIR THEIR TARGETS
FOR PROVIDING THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS TO THE INMATES -- SO
THAT REMAINS AN ISSUE NOW WHAT
DID WE HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT
ONE OF THE THINGS WE HEAR IS
THEY DO HAVE DIFFICULTY IN
HIRING INDIVIDUALS.
IN CERTAIN LOCATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA A CERTAIN
INSTITUTIONS AND I'M SURE
MEMBERS YOU HAVE HEARD THAT IN
THE PAST.
THE LAST ISSUE WITH RESPECT --
TO PLACEMENT.
IN INTO THESE VARIOUS PROGRAMS
IS THE ENROLLMENT RATES.
SO THEY HAVE THEY HAVE A GOAL OF
PROVIDING AT LEAST 70%.
OF THE TARGET POPULATION THESE
TYPES OF REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS
BUT WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
CAPACITY FOR ACADEMIC PROGRAMS
VOTE GET PROGRAMS AND C. B. T.
PROGRAMS THEY WERE NOT AT
CAPACITY THEY HAD THE BUDGET FOR
IT.
BUT THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO ENROLL
AS MANY INMATES AS THE PROGRAMS
WERE PROVIDED -- BUDGET
AUTHORITY -- ACADEMIC WAS ABOUT
76% OF CAPACITY BUDGETED
CAPACITY CBT ABOUT 76% INVOKE AT
ABOUT 68%.
NOW IN ADDITION TO THE HIRING
ISSUES SOME OF THE INSTITUTIONS
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT PHYSICAL
SPACE -- AT FOLSOM IN PARTICULAR
THERE WERE SOME ISSUES RELATED
TO THE FACILITIES THEIR WORDS A
ROOF THAT NEEDED REPAIR SO THEY
WERE HAVING TO SHUT DOWN SO.
SOME OF THE COURSES AND SOME OF
THE CLASSES WERE NOT AVAILABLE
TO INMATES BECAUSE THEY HAD TO
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES.
AT RJ DONOVAN THEY TALK TO US
ABOUT -- ISSUES THAT THE FIRE
MARSHAL REYES WHERE THEIR CLASS
CLASS SIZES WERE TOO LARGE SO
THEY WERE FORCED TO REDUCE SOME
OF THOSE CLASS SIZES.
BUT WHEN WE ASK CORRECTIONS OKAY
WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THESE ISSUES -- OF SOME
OF THE RESPONSES WERE RELATIVELY
SHORT THEY HAVEN'T FIGURED OUT
WHAT THEY NEEDED TO DO TO
INCREASE YOU KNOW PHYSICAL
CAPACITY IN ADDITION TO THE
HIRING -- ISSUES THAT I JUST
SPOKE ABOUT A LITTLE BIT AGO.
NOW ON THE POSITIVE SIDE AS YOU
SAID MISTER JONES SAWYER WE
LOOKED AT CAL PIAA AND THEIR
THEIR RECIDIVISM RATE IS QUITE
LOW I MEAN IT WAS ASSESSED BACK
IN JULY OF TWENTY ELEVEN AND IT
WAS AT 7% -- BUT CALPE CALPE I
ATE THEIR ENROLLMENT RATES WERE
RELATIVELY LOW WHEN WE LOOKED AT
THEM WAS ABOUT 48%.
SO WE TALK TO THEM ABOUT THAT
AND AND WHAT THEIR RESPONSE TO
US WAS.
THEY WEREN'T NECESSARILY AND
I'LL USE MY TERMINOLOGY IN THE
ROOM WHEN DECISIONS WERE MADE
ABOUT ASSIGNING INMATES -- TO
EITHER REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS
ARE PRO OR JOBS IN THE
INSTITUTIONS AND AND CAL P. I.
A.'S SAYING WE NEED TO BE PART
OF THAT DECISION MAKING PROCESS
BECAUSE THEN WE CAN INCREASE THE
ENROLLMENT.
AND SOME OF THE PROGRAM -- THAT
WE HAVE AND THAT HAVE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL -- WITH RESPECT -- TO
INMATES WHO ARE RELEASED TO GET
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT AND DO NOT
RESET AVE IT'S A VERY LOW
PERCENTAGE AND AND THEY INTEND
TO HAVE AN UPDATE OF THEIR
ANALYSIS ON RECIDIVISM IN MAY OF
THIS YEAR -- AND HOPEFULLY IT'S
RELATIVELY CLOSE TO TO PASS
PERFORMANCE NOW THERE HAS BEEN.
A PILOT PROGRAM THAT HAS BEEN
STARTED -- BY CAL P. I. A AND
WERE WORKING WITH CORRECTIONS
WORK CAL P. I. A IS NOW PART OF
THAT DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
AND WE'RE SEEING INCREASING
ENROLLMENT AND SOME OF THE CAL
PI AIR PROGRAMS IT INCREASED
FROM JULY THIS PILOT JUST
STARTED THIS LAST YEAR -- IN IN
JULY IT INCREASE IT WAS AT 44%
AND IT WENT UP 253% IN OCTOBER
OF EIGHTEEN SO HOPEFULLY THIS
PROGRAM WILL CONTINUE -- TO
ALLOW AND ENCOURAGE INMATES TO
ENROLL IN SOME OF THE P. I. A
PROGRAMS AND WHERE THEY CAN
REALLY GAIN SOME.
SOME -- AND VALUABLE SKILLS --
UPON YOU KNOW PRIOR TO THE
RELEASE OFF FROM THE
INSTITUTIONS.
THE LAST SECTION IS RELATED TO
OVERSIGHT PERFORMANCE MEASURES
METRICS THOSE SORTS OF THINGS
AND AGAIN THIS IS ANOTHER AREA
WHERE THE DEPARTMENT CORRECTIONS
IS FALLING SHORT WE WEREN'T
SEEING A LOTS OF PERFORMANCE
MEASURES.
ARE DEVELOPED WE ACTUALLY LOOKED
AT WHAT SOME OTHER STATES WERE
DOING THE STATE OF MINNESOTA
ACTUALLY RECEIVE SOME FEDERAL
MONEY THERE'S A FEDERAL GRANT.
THAT'S AVAILABLE TO STATES
CALLED STATEWIDE RECIDIVISM
REDUCTION GRANT THE STATE OF
MINNESOTA PUT TOGETHER SOME
METRICS AND SOME GOALS FOR
REDUCING RECIDIVISM -- THEIR
FIRST CALL WAS TO REDUCE IT BY
THREE I THINK IT WAS AROUND 3%
AND THEY RECEIVED A THREE
MILLION DOLLAR GRANT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT US DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE. TO BASICALLY ENHANCE
SOME OF THEIR PROGRAMS TO REALLY
FOCUS ON COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL
THERAPY PROVIDING.
SERVICES TO INMATES IN IN THE
STATE OF MINNESOTA TO HOPEFULLY
REDUCE THAT RECIDIVISM RATE AND
THEIR STATE AS WELL.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT WE
BELIEVE THE DEPARTMENT
CORRECTIONS REALLY NEEDS TO
DEVELOP METRICS.
FOR HOW MANY INMATES DO THEY
WANT TO ENROLL IN THESE
PARTICULAR -- PROGRAMS WHAT
ABOUT COMPLETION RATES YOU KNOW
YOU'RE NOT NECESSARILY GOING TO
HAVE A 100% COMPLETION BUT
YOU'VE GOT TO SET YOURSELF SOME
GOALS. FOR GETTING.
THE CORRECT INMATES WHO HAVE
HIGH NEEDS AND HIGHER AND HIGHER
RISK A RESET OF AIDING INTO THE
PROGRAMS -- AND REALLY MEASURE
AGAINST HOW SUCCESSFUL YOU ARE
DOING THAT.
NOW THEY THEY DEPARTMENT TALK TO
US A LITTLE BIT ABOUT --
COORDINATING AND WORKING WITH
EXTERNAL RESEARCHERS TO CONDUCT
A PERFORMANCE EVALUATION OF
THEIR PROGRAMS FROM A COST
EFFECTIVENESS STANDPOINT AND
LOOKING AT A DEVELOPING METRICS
ETCETERA THAT WAS DURING DURING
THE AUDIT ITSELF -- BUT ALTHOUGH
THEY HAD DONE THAT BY THE TIME
WE HAD COMPLETED OUR FIELD WORK
THEY REALLY HADN'T TAKEN ANY
FORMAL STEPS.
ARE TO INITIATE THE PROCESS
THAT'S WHY WE FELT THE
LEGISLATIVE RECOMMENDATION --
AND WE'VE SEEN THE BILLS -- THAT
THAT ARE ARE OUT THERE A LOOKING
AT CARRYING OUT SOME OF OUR
IMPLEMENTING SOME OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS AND AND WE WERE
WE'RE EXCITED TO SEE THAT
BECAUSE WE THINK THAT'S REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT NEEDS TO HAPPEN --
BUT WE HAVE NOT SEEN MUCH
PROGRESS WITH RESPECT TO THAT --
THE ALSO THE THE DEPARTMENT
CORRECTIONS HADN'T ANALYZE
WHETHER OR NOT THERE PROGRAMS
WERE REDUCING RECIDIVISM -- THEY
DID CONTRACT WITH UC IRVINE
AGAIN TO EXAMINE WAYS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR C. B. T. CLASSES
WERE UNIFORMED AND WERE BEING
PRESENTED.
AND ANY UNIFORMED MANNER THEY
TALK ABOUT PROGRAM FIDELITY AND
THERE HAS BEEN RESEARCH DONE AS
FAR AS PROGRAM FIDELITY IF THESE
PROGRAMS ARE REALLY TRULY
EVIDENCE BASED.
AND ARE BEING PROVIDED TO
INDIVIDUALS ARE INMATES IN THE
INSTITUTIONS CONSISTENTLY THEN
YOU WILL REALLY HAVE POSITIVE
OUTCOMES SO YOU'VE GOT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU'RE USING EVIDENCE
BASED PROGRAMS YOUR YOUR
ADMINISTERING THOSE PROGRAMS
CONSISTENTLY BECAUSE THEN WHEN
YOU MEASURE YOU CAN GET A TRUE.
ARE TRUE IDEA OF HOW SUCCESSFUL --
THE PROGRAMS ARE AND MAKE.
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT WHERE
TO CONTINUE TO INVEST FUNDS OR
WHERE TO PERHAPS PULL FUNDS BACK
AND AND SHIFT TO THE MORE
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS BUT THAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN -- UC IRVINE
ACTUALLY PROVIDED A REPORT TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS IN
JUNE OF EIGHTEEN AT WEST
BASICALLY CAME UP WITH A
CHECKLIST AND A WAY FOR
CORRECTIONS TO IDENTIFY.
THE CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE BOARD
AND THAT PROGRAM FIDELITY WHEN
CORRECTIONS -- TALK TO US ABOUT
THAT WE QUESTION THEM ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT.
THEY ASSERTED TO US THAT THEY'RE
NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO DO THAT
UNTIL THE BEGINNING OF THIS NEXT
FISCAL YEAR A NINETEEN BY JULY
OF OF NINETEEN LATER THIS YEAR --
THEY'VE HAD THE REPORT AS I SAID
FROM IRVINE.
AS AS FAR BACK AS JUNE OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SO AGAIN A LITTLE BIT
OF CONCERN THERE WHERE WE NEED
TO BE MAKING BETTER PROGRESS
STRONGER PROGRESS IN SOME OF
THESE AREAS.
ON THE LAST COUPLE OF ISSUES
WITH RESPECT TO PROGRAMS IS
FALLEN VOLUNTEER PROGRAMS AND A
LOT OF THESE DO GET ATTENTION.
CERTAINLY FROM THE MEDIA BECAUSE
THEY'RE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PROGRAMS AS FAR AS A HORSE
THERAPY IN THOSE SORTS OF THINGS
THEY HAVE A HUGE NUMBER OF THESE
PROGRAMS -- THAT CAN BE VERY
BENEFICIAL AGAIN THE PROBLEM IS
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
HAS NOT ASSESSED THE THE SUCCESS
OF THESE PROGRAMS THERE ARE A
LOT OF INDIVIDUALS ARE
INTERESTED IN PARTICIPATING IN
THESE PROGRAMS.
CERTAINLY BECAUSE PART OF THE
BENEFIT TO THEM IS SOME OF THEIR
SENTENCES REDUCED IF THEY THEY
PARTICIPATE IN COMPLETE SOME OF
THESE VOLUNTARY PROGRAMS.
BUT THE IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
CORRECTIONS.
INVESTED ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN THESE PROGRAMS HAD ON AVERAGE
ABOUT SIXTY THOUSAND INMATES
PARTICIPATING IN THESE PROGRAMS
WHERE THEY FELL SHORT IS THEY
HAVEN'T ASSESSED THESE
PARTICULAR PROGRAMS HOW
SUCCESSFUL HAVE THEY BEEN -- IN
AND HELPING INMATES WITH ANGER
MANAGEMENT WITH OTHER TYPES OF
OUR CHARACTERISTICS THAT THEY
NEED TO WORK ON TO MAKE THEM --
MORE SUCCESSFUL WHEN THEY ARE
RELEASED FROM PRISON --
CORRECTIONS DID.
INFORM US THAT THEY INTENDED TO
PARTNER WITH PP I SEE BUT AGAIN
WHEN WE FINISHED OUR FIELD WORK
ON IT LATE LAST YEAR IN NOVEMBER
DECEMBER AT THAT POINT THEY
HADN'T REACHED ANY AGREEMENT
WITH PP I SEE RELATED TO THE
SCOPE OF THE REVIEW.
HOW THEY WOULD GO ABOUT
REVIEWING THESE VOLUNTEER
PROGRAMS AND WE THINK IT'S
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
THOSE PROGRAMS BE ASSESSED AS
WELL AS?
THE EVIDENCE BASED OTHER TYPES
OF PROGRAMS BECAUSE IN
CONJUNCTION THEY COULD BE VERY
BENEFICIAL TO INMATES.
IN THE VARIOUS INSTITUTIONS.
AND THEN THE LAST PIECE IS
LOOKING WE LOOKED AT SEE ROB --
WHICH I'M SURE YOU'RE ALL
FAMILIAR WITH THAT
REHABILITATIVE OVERSIGHT BOARD
THE OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL AND THE BENEFITS THAT
THEY COULD PROVIDE -- IN
MONITORING REHAB PROGRAM
PERFORMANCE REQUIRING
CORRECTIONS TO REPORT BACK TO
THEM OVERSEEING AN EXTERNAL
RESEARCHER AT WE TALK ABOUT IN
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS -- BECAUSE
THEY DO HAVE THAT RESPONSIBILITY
AND WE THINK THAT COULD PLAY A
VERY VERY IMPORTANT ROLE.
IN ASSESSING THE SUCCESS OF
THESE PARTICULAR PROGRAMS AND
THE PROGRESS THAT CORRECTIONS
HAS OR HAS NOT MADE -- AS WE
MOVE FORWARD.
IN IN HOPEFULLY IMPLEMENTING
SOME OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS WE
MADE IN THE REPORT AND IMPROVING
THE THE REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS
IN OUR INSTITUTIONS.
SO WITH THAT MEMBERS I WILL TURN
IT OVER TO MR FELDER AND HE'LL
GO THROUGH -- THAT THE
CATEGORIES OF RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WE MADE WE DID TALK ABOUT A
THREE YEAR PLAN.
WITH RESPECT TO HIRING AT AN
EXTERNAL RESEARCHER REPORTING
BACK AND THEN CONTINUING TO
MONITOR BUT I'LL HAND IT OFF TO
MISTER FILNER.
AND HE CAN TAKE IT FROM HERE
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON --
OF THE FOURTEEN RECOMMENDATIONS
DIRECTED THE CDC ARE IT IS STILL
IN THE PLANNING STAGES FOR
IMPLEMENTING THIRTEEN OF THOSE
AND HAS PARTIALLY IMPLEMENTED.
ONE SO SPECIFICALLY WE
RECOMMENDED THAT CDC ARE RE
VALIDATE COMPASS AND CS ARE A
THAT IS THE MEASURE THAT
MEASURES AND INMATES
REHABILITATIVE NEEDS AS WELL AS
THEIR RISK -- IT'S IMPORTANT TO
KEEP THESE TOOLS ACCURATE
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY YOU NEED TO
ASSESS THE CORRECTLY BUT ALSO
ANY TIME THE INMATE DEMOGRAPHICS
CHANGE THOSE TOOLS COULD BECOME
AN ACCURATE AND WE'VE SEEN A BIG
CHANGE IN THE WAY POPULATION
SINCE REALIGNMENT -- FOR EXAMPLE --
IN TWENTY TEN FOR CRIMES AGAINST
PEOPLE'S THE NUMBER OF INMATES
CONVICTED OF THOSE CRIMES IN A
AND INSTITUTIONALIZED WAS 56% OF
THE POPULATION.
NOW IT'S SEVENTY NINE SO YOU SEE
A BIG JOB THAT MEANS YOU NEED TO
MAKE SURE THESE TOOLS ARE STILL
ACCURATELY ASSESSING INMATES.
CCIR HAS A TEAM WORKING ON A
SCHEDULE AND IS RE ABOUT TO
RETALIATE THE TOOLS AND THAT
SCHEDULE SHOULD BE AVAILABLE
SOMETIME THIS MONTH.
SO OTHER MAKING PROGRESS THERE
AT LEAST TO GET A SCHEDULE GOING
FOR THAT RETALIATION WE ALSO
RECOMMENDED THAT CDC ARE AMEND
ITS CONTRACTS TO ENSURE THE
VENDORS WERE ONLY USING --
EVIDENCE BASED FOR THEIR CBT I
CURRICULA.
AS DESIGNATED BY PEW -- CDC ARE
HAS.
SO FAR RIDE REVISED ITS TEMPLATE
FOR THE CONTRACT FOR THE SCOPE
OF WORK TO MANDATE ONLY EVIDENCE
BASED CURRICULUM
NOW THAT SHOULD BE IN YOU
SOMETIME NEXT MONTH AND THAT'LL
BE USED AN ONGOING BASIS SO
ANYTIME THEY NEED TO MAKE TO
CONTRACTS WITH THE VENDORS.
NOW THEIR RESPONSE DID NOT
INCLUDE ANY MENTION OF ANY
OVERSIGHT MECHANISM SO HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO ACTUALLY ENSURE
THAT.
THESE EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES
ARE EVIDENCE BASED CRIGLER USED
SO WE'RE STILL WAITING ON THAT.
IN ADDITION WE RECOMMENDED THAT
A PRIORITIZE INMATES
APPROPRIATELY AND IT UPDATE IT'S
WAIT LIST SYSTEM -- THIS MONTH
CDC OR IS PLANNING ON
IMPLEMENTING A WEIGHTLESS SYSTEM
THAT PRIORITIZES INMATES BASED
ON THE REHABILITATIVE NEEDS AND
RISKS SO ONCE WE SEE THAT AND
THEN THE SIX MONTH.
RESPONSE PERIOD IN JULY WILL
HOPEFULLY GET SOME EVIDENCE THAT
IN FACT THAT NEW WEIGHTLESS
SYSTEM IS ACTUALLY SHOWING A
COMPASS AND CS SORRY SCORES.
AND THEN ACTUALLY SLIDING
INMATES NOT JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE
ON A SIGN FOR BECAUSE THEY HAVE
HIGH NEED TO THE RISKS -- IS
ALSO PLANNING ON GIVING
ADDITIONAL TRAINING -- AND WE'LL
BE DISTRIBUTING GUIDANCE TO
CORRECTIONAL COUNSELORS THOSE
THE ONES THAT ACTUALLY ASSIGN
THE INMATES INTO THE PROGRAMS --
WE RECOMMENDED THAT CDC OUR
PARTNER WITH THE RESEARCH
ORGANIZATION TO CONDUCT AN
EVALUATION OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS INCLUDING VOLUNTEER
PROGRAMS DOT IN FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN TWENTY SO NEXT FISCAL
YEAR WE WANTED THEM TO BE
DRAFTING THE SCOPE OF WORK IN
CONTRACTING.
THAT WAY -- IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE VENDOR CAN
ACTUALLY ARE THE CONTRACTOR
COULD DO THAT WORK THAT OUTSIDE
RESEARCH ORGANIZATION -- CCR IS
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH AN
EXTERNAL ORGANIZATION AND
ANTICIPATE HAVING A FORMAL
CONTRACT AND SCOPE OF WORK
COMPLETED BY APRIL OF TWENTY
TWENTY NOW THAT IS WITHIN OUR
TIME FRAME OF FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN TWENTY HOWEVER WE'D
LIKE TO SEE THE SCOPE OF WORK
COMPLETED AND POLICE TO RELEVANT
STAKEHOLDERS.
EARLIER SO WE COULD SEE EXACTLY
WHAT -- WHAT THAT WORK WITH A
TAIL BEFORE ANY CONTRACT IS
FINALIZED?
NOW -- THERE ARE SOME AREAS
WHERE WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANY
NOTABLE PROGRESS -- FOR EXAMPLE
WE RECOMMENDED THAT CDC OR
CREATE A PLAN TO MEET ITS
STAFFING GOALS AND MONITOR THOSE --
EFFORTS NOW CDC ARE DOES HAVE
MECHANISMS TO MONITOR THE
VACANCY RATES OF ITS STAFF AND
ALL OF ITS INSTITUTIONS ON A
MONTHLY BASIS THAT'S GOOD.
BUT IT STILL HAS A YET TO
DEVELOP ANY PLAN TO ENSURE THAT
IT MEETS THOSE STAFFING GOALS
ESPECIALLY INSTITUTIONS WHERE
THEY'VE HAD VACANCIES IN
VOCATIONAL EDUCATION FOR YEARS.
AND THE OF THESE ARE THE SPOTS
ARE SOMETIMES DIFFICULT TO FILL
BECAUSE OF THE GEOGRAPHY WORTH
PRISONS LOCATED SO DOES GOING TO
TAKE A LITTLE EXTRA ATTENTION
AND ON CORRECTIONS BEHALF
ACTUALLY GET PEOPLE IN THERE.
AND SO WE'D LIKE TO SEE THAT
PLAN DEVELOPED.
IN ADDITION CDC OURS YET TO
DEVELOP ANY PROGRAM TARGETS OR
METRICS FOR ITS REBUILT ASIAN
PROGRAMS.
THAT THOSE WOULD INCLUDE SAY THE
YOU KNOW THE PERCENTAGE OF
INMATES AND ROLLED AND
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS THE
PERCENTAGE THE COMPLETE WE'D
LIKE TO SEE WHAT YOU KNOW WHERE
WE'RE TO SEE TO SEE I THINK THAT.
THAT NUMBER SHOULD BE AS WELL AS
YOU KNOW EVENTUALLY WITH THE HOW
WELL THESE PROGRAMS ARE ACTUALLY
REDUCING RECIDIVISM.
AND SETTING GOALS THERE.
FINALLY -- ONE REASON IN ME TO
ROLL MADE.
IN THESE CLASSES WAS LOW --
CITIES ARE IDENTIFIED AS SPACE
LIMITATIONS.
SO -- WE RECOMMENDED THAT CDC
ARE PREPARE REPORT ON ITS
CURRENT SPACE YOU KNOW WHAT WAIT
WHERE DID IT NEED TO ADD MORE
AND HOW MUCH WOULD THAT COST TO
PRESENT TO THE LEGISLATURE.
CDC ARE STATED THAT IT WOULD NOT
HAVE A FUNDING REQUEST READY
UNTIL FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO SETS OVER THREE
AND A HALF YEARS FROM NOW -- WE
THINK THAT THEY CAN SB THAT UP A
LOT BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO GET THESE IN ROMAN
NUMBERS AT THE MAXIMUM BUDGET
CAPACITY UNLESS YOU HAVE THE
SPACE FOR IT SO THE SOONER YOU
GET THAT SPACE THE SOONER YOU
CAN ACTUALLY GET MORE.
INMATES WHO NEED THAT --
RESULTED OF PROGRAMMING.
AND WELL WE'LL BE FOLLOWING UP
WITH CDC ARE AT SIX MONTH AND
ONE YEAR FROM REPORT ISSUANCE.
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE AT THIS
TIME.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
APPRECIATE THAT OVERVIEW I THINK
THERE WAS A LOT IN THERE AND
THERE'S A LOT OF QUESTIONS FOR
THE NEXT PANEL.
BASED OFF OF YOUR INFORMATION
BUT LET ME JUST ASK A GENERAL
FIRST QUESTION MAYBE YOU KNOW
BECAUS WE READ THE HEADLINES
AND YOU MENTIONED -- MADAM
AUDITOR THE THE HEADLINES THAT
WE'VE BEEN READING OUT IN THE
MEDIA ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES
TO CORRECTIONS ON WHETHER OR NOT
THEY ARE BEING EFFECTIVE -- THAT
A FAIR ASSESSMENT IN YOUR VIEW
BECAUSE I THINK YOU POINTED OUT
SOME OF THE PROGRAMS AND SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
LOOKED AT BUT YOU KNOW I ALSO
LOOKED AT THE AUDITED I FOUND
THINGS LIKE FOR INSTANCE
SATISFIED IN CORCORAN IN MY AREA.
SEEM TO BE DO AND AN OKAY JOB IN
TERMS OF THE ACTUAL RECIDIVISM.
I MEAN CAN YOU TALK TO THE
PARENTS OF WHICH PROGRAMS THAT
YOU SOLVE PROBABLY ARE WORKING
BUT THEN MAYBE WE ASK QUESTION
WHY AREN'T THOSE BEING
REPLICATED EVEN IF.
IT'S ALREADY IN THE SYSTEM AND
SOMETHING THAT'S ACTUALLY
WORKING COMPARED TO SOME OF
THESE OTHERS WHERE THEY DON'T
HAVE THE METRICS OF THE
ANALYTICS TO ACTUALLY SHOW.
ANY PROGRESSION OR TOWARDS
REDUCING THE RECIDIVISM RATE.
WELL I I THINK I'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS AT A FIRST PLEASE THAT'S
THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
FACILITY.
AND YOU THAT WAS NOT ONE OF THE
PRISONS WHERE WE CONDUCTED AN IN
DEPTH REVIEW THAT WAS ENERGY DOT
OF IN SYNC WONDERFUL SOME BUT WE
DID HAVE A CHANCE TO SPEAK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATOR THERE -- AND
HE INDICATED THAT THAT SEVERAL
THINGS KIND OF SET THAT PROGRAM
APART FROM OTHER FACILITIES AT
CDC OURS PRISONS SPECIFICALLY --
THEY OFFERED INCENTIVE PROGRAM
SO IF YOU STATE ON TRACK WITH
YOUR PROGRAMMING -- YOU THERE
WERE INCENTIVES IN IN MAY COULD
RECEIVE SUCH AS HAVING AS SOLO
SELL -- AND IN ADDITION -- HE
INDICATED THERE WAS KIND OF
IMMERSIVE CBT ENVIRONMENT WHERE
YOU WERE HOUSED WITH PEOPLE ALL
TAKEN THE SAME COURSES AT THE
SAME TIME.
AND THAT REALLY THAT WAS MUCH
MORE CONDUCIVE -- TO HAVING MORE
INMATES COMPLETE THE PROGRAM --
WITH WHATEVER THE PROGRAM A. B. --
HOWEVER IF YOU NEED MORE DETAILS
ON CAN THE PAST OR CURRENT
PRACTICES AT SAD IF I'M SURE
CITIES HERE CAN PROVIDE YOU MORE
DETAILED INFORMATION ON THAT --
AND I I SHE TO THE SECOND PART
YOUR QUESTION RELATED TO THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PROGRAMS
AND BY.
SO WHAT WE DID FIND WAS THAT.
WE FOCUSED ON C. B. T. BECAUSE
ITS THE NEWEST SUITE OF
PROGRAMMING OFFERED BY
CORRECTIONS AND ALSO THAT.
YOU KNOW 70% OF THE BUDGET AND
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN WHEN THEY DID
MAKE THAT BIG EXPANSIVE EFFORT
TO INCREASE REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING 70% OF THAT WAS
TARGETED CBT.
SO IT ME ALTHOUGH IT MAKES UP
ONLY ABOUT 25% OF THE INMATES --
AVAILABLE SLOTS FOR
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING WE
FELT THAT THAT WAS THE HIGHEST
RISK POPULATION TO GO AFTER.
AND YOU KNOW ALTHOUGH OUR
PRELIMINARY ANALYSIS FOUND THAT
WILL THAN TWO YEARS RECIDIVISM
REALLY DIDN'T CHANGE THAT MUCH.
FOR US TO DRIVE TRIGGERED YOU
KNOW -- KIND OF A TWO FOLD IDEA
THAT ONE THERE NEEDS TO BE A
MUCH MORE COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS
CONDUCTED. TO SEE OKAY WHAT IS
WORKING WHAT ISN'T IMPROVE
BETWEEN ALL THE PROGRAMS NOT
JUST C. B. T. AND WITH THREE
YEAR ANALYSIS OF ALL THREE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING --
AND THEN YOU CAN START MAKING
DECISIONS ON WHAT'S EFFECTIVE
WHAT ISN'T BASED ON THAT
ANALYSIS BECAUSE OURS OBVIOUSLY
IS THE FLAG TO GOES UP THAT SAYS
YOU NEED TO DO MORE WORK HERE.
I THINK SECONDLY IT YOU KNOW IT
SAYS THE CDC ARE THAT.
THERE'S WAYS -- THAT YOU COULD
ADMINISTER THESE PROGRAMS BETTER
THAT IN FACT THE POOR
MINISTRATION IS LIMITING THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THESE PROGRAMS
AND THAT WITH YOU KNOW --
PRIORITIZING THE WEIGHTLESS
ISSUE -- THE EVIDENCE BASED
ISSUE OF YOU KNOW YOU FIX THESE
YOU FIX THESE ADMINISTRATIVE
AREAS YOU COULD SEE -- BETTER
RESULTS.
THAT ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION.
YES THANK YOU.
LET ME OPEN IT UP LET ME ASK
THERE'S ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
MISTER JONES SAWYER.
SO -- YOU KNOW I'VE I'VE -- WE
PUT IN THIS CONTEXT IS THIS
WHOLE DISCUSSION OF EVIDENCE
BASED I KIND OF WANT TO GET YOUR
YOUR DEFINITION OF IT -- BECAUSE
WHEN I WHEN I SPEAK TO
INDIVIDUALS AND I'LL GIVE AN
EXAMPLE WHEN TIM ROBBINS CAME
INTO MY OFFICE TO TALK ABOUT.
THE THE ACTORS GANG.
ANY HAD TO INDIVIDUALS -- WHO
HAD GONE TO HIS PROGRAM
[inaudible]
AND ED NOT WE SHOULD HAVE AIDED
IN A YEAR.
ARMY LOOK ME STRAIGHT IN THE EYE
AND SAID WE'RE NOT AN EVIDENCE
BASED.
PROGRAM.
AND I'M I'M SITTING THERE GOING.
I LOOK AT ONE PERSON HERE.
L. ONE PERSON THERE.
THAT WE NO LONGER HAVE TO SPEND
EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR.
IN MY MIND.
THERE'S EVIDENCE THAT WE JUST
SAVE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HUNDRED SIXTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR BECAUSE THESE TWO
INDIVIDUALS DID NOT.
WE SHOULD HAVE A BECAUSE OF THE
WAY WE THINK OF BANKS.
BY THE WAY WE CALCULATED A NO
DISRESPECT TO THE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE SORT OF FINANCE OR TO THE
LA OWES IN THE OF THE WORLD ANY
OTHER.
PENCIL PUSHERS THEY HAVE A THEY
HAVE A WAY OF LOOKING AT THINGS
THAT MAY NOT HELP.
US ACTUALLY.
DO EVIDENCE BASED.
AND THEN IT ALSO MEAN NO
DISRESPECT TO ACADEMICS IS
SPECIALLY UCI BUT THEY MAY HAVE
SOME IDEA OF WHAT IT IS.
BUT WHAT ACTUALLY WORKS.
YOU MAY NOT BE ABLE TO GET THAT
EVIDENCE BASED ON THE FRONT END
BUT YOU MAY BE ABLE TO GET IT ON
ON THE BACK IN THE SAME WAY WITH --
THERE'S A PROGRAM [inaudible]
THAT -- A MAJOR TRAINING --
SERVICE DOGS SERVICE ANIMALS.
AND THEN THEY GIVE OUT TO PEOPLE
WHO NEED THEM.
BUT THEY ALSO FOUND THAT
INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED IN THAT
PROGRAM -- THE NUMBER OF
INCIDENTS THAT THEY'RE INVOLVED
IN VIOLENCE.
DRUG OFFENSES BEING ON DRUGS --
HAVE GONE WAY DOWN AND I AND AND
I AND I ASKED THE THE SECRETARY.
WE KINDA HAD OF JUST A QUICK
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT AND HE
SAID YOU KNOW EVERY TIME WE
WRITE A REPORT ABOUT AN INCIDENT.
THAT'S LIKE A THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND IF THERE'S LIKE [inaudible]
NINETEEN HUNDRED A YEAR.
IN ONE FACILITY THAT'S ONE POINT
NINE MILLION.
IF YOU COULD REDUCE THAT DOWN
SIGNIFICAN THAT'S ANOTHER
SAVINGS AND THAT COULD BE
SOMETHING YOU COULD USE TO SAY.
YOU KNOW THIS PROGRAM WERE
SOMEBODY THAT MIGHT BE A LITTLE
MORE HARD KNOWS ABOUT
REHABILITATION.
THEY MAY LAUGH AT THAT PROGRAMS
LIKE THAT.
WE COULD ACTUALLY SHOW THAT IT
WORKS BUT IT MAY NOT FIT IN HIS
BOX.
CALLED EVIDENCE BASED SO I KIND
OF WANT TO GET YOUR TAKE.
ON EVIDENCE BASED BECAUSE FOR ME.
STOP IT IT COULD BE.
IF WE ALL SAT IN REALLY THOUGHT
ABOUT IT -- AND I MAYBE WE NEED
TO ELIMINATE THIS TERM EVIDENCE
BASE AND TALK ABOUT RETURN ON
INVESTMENT.
R. A WHY THAT MIGHT GET US. TO A
BETTER PLACE OF OF OF GETTING
MORE MONEY GETTING MORE.
MORE SKEPTICAL MEMBERS IN THE
ASSEMBLY -- INVOLVED IN THIS.
SO FAR IT'S RESPOND I THINK THE
BATTERY ME THE CLINICAL
DEFINITION OF EVIDENCE BASED
OKAY GOT IT.
THAT'S ALL -- WE WE'VE GOT A
WE'VE DIVIDED IS SIMPLY --
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN PROVEN
THROUGH RESEARCH TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM BUT WE'RE ONLY
SPEAKING TO THAT OF THE CVT
PROGRAM SO THAT'S JUST FAMILY
RELATIONSHIPS CRIMINOLOGICAL
THINKING SUBSTANCE ABUSE -- AND
ANGER MANAGEMENT SO THAT THAT'S
KIND OF ITS BOX OVER HERE
THERE'S THERE'S HUNDREDS AND
THOUSANDS OF OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
CDC ARE OFFERS THEIR VOLUNTEER
PROGRAMS THAT NEED TO BE STUDIED
AND THOSE.
THE YOU KNOW IT ENTITIES -- IT
OUTSIDE RESEARCH ORGANIZATION
CAN KIND OF LOOK AT SOME OF
THOSE -- IN QUALITY OR PROGRAMS
AND SAY OKAY WE OF BASED ON THE
EVEN A SMALL SAMPLE SIZE THIS
THIS WORKS A COULD BE SHOULD BE
EXPANDED TO OTHER INSTITUTIONS.
WE THINK THAT THAT WORK SHOULD
BE DONE SO IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
EVIDENCE BASED FOR EVERYBODY BUT
WE DO THINK THAT YOU NEED TO
LOOK AT YOU KNOW X. AMOUNT OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO LEFT IN TAKEN
THIS.
PARTICULAR VOLUNTEER PROGRAM
WOULD HAVE BEEN THE RESULTS OF
THAT.
SO DON'T NECESSARILY EVIDENCE
BASED BUT SIMPLY JUST -- YOU
KNOW.
AND I'M LOOKING AT THE OUTCOMES.
RIGHT MISTER JONES ARE THE WAY
AND I APPRECIATE AARON'S ANSWER
I THINK WHAT WHAT YOU'RE GETTING
AT IS.
WE DON'T NEED JUST ONE
PARTICULAR TYPE OF PROGRAM WHICH
IS C. B. T. EVIDENCE BASE THERE
ARE A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS THERE'S ACADEMIC
THERE'S VOCATIONAL EDUCATION.
AND THERE'S A VOLUNTEER PROGRAMS
AND LET'S NOT JUST DISMISS THOSE
OTHER PROGRAMS BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT EVIDENCE BASED WE WOULD
ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH THAT AND
THAT'S WHY WE DISCUSSED IN THE
REPORT.
BOTH ACADEMIC AND VOCATIONAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND THE
ISSUES THERE WITH RESPECT TO
THEY HAVE MORE BUDGET CAPACITY
THEY MIGHT NEED TO HIRE MORE
INDIVIDUALS TO PROVIDE THOSE
TYPES OF THE ACADEMIC TRAINING
FOR IT FOR INDIVIDUALS TO GET
THEIR READING LEVEL UP AT CETERA.
VOCATIONAL EDUCATION ALLOWED THE
FOLK AT WORK THAT IS DONE AND
CAL PA A IS BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL.
WHAT WE'RE SUGGESTING IS IF
YOU'RE GOING TO USE CBT PROGRAMS
THEY RESEARCH PROVES THAT THE
EVIDENCE THE MOST EFFECTIVE CBT
PROGRAMS ARE THOSE THAT ARE
EVIDENCE BASED?
THAT IS NOT TO SUGGEST THAT
THESE VOLUNTEER PROGRAMS LIKE
YOU SAID SERVICE DOGS WE TALK
ABOUT HORSE THERAPY AND SOME
PEOPLE MAY SAY OUT.
YOU KNOW WHY ARE YOU PROVIDING
THESE KINDS OF PROGRAMS
INDIVIDUALS WELL IT IT'S LOOKING
OUT OF THE INDIVIDUAL AN INMATE.
FROM A HOLISTIC PERSPECTIVE AND
IF A HORSE THERAPY PROGRAM IS
GOING TO SUGGEST THAT INDIVIDUAL
AND WE'VE EVALUATED AND
DETERMINED THAT IT HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN REDUCING --
INCIDENTS IN THE INSTITUTION
ANGER MED ADDRESSED ANGER
MANAGEMENT THOSE SORTS OF THINGS
TEACHING DISCIPLINE ETCETERA
LET'S CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THOSE
PROGRAMS SO.
I DON'T WANT ANYBODY TO CONCLUDE
FROM OUR REPORT THAT.
THERE ARE PROGRAMS IN THE
INSTITUTIONS THAT IF THEY'RE NOT
EVIDENCE BASED THEY SHOULD BE
TOSSED THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE
SUGGESTING WE ARE SUGGESTING IF
YOU'RE GONNA USE THESE COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL TREATMENT PROGRAMS.
THE RESEARCH SHOWS EVIDENCE
BASED THIRD THAT.
YOU WORK THE BEST LET'S CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT OUR OUR VOLUNTEER PRO
BONTA EERIE PROGRAMS BUT LET'S
ASSESS THOSE TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WORK IF THEY
DO WORK AND MANY OF THEM I WOULD
ASSUME DUE.
OUT LET'S CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
THAT AND THEN LET'S ALSO ASSESS
OUR ACADEMIC AND VOCATIONAL SO I
THINK IT'S A COMBINATION OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PROGRAMS BUT
AS WE INDICATED IN THE REPORT
CORRECTIONS NEEDS TO EVALUATE.
FIRST OF ALL EVALUATE YOUR
ASSESSMENT TOOLS BECAUSE THE THE
POPULATION HAS CHANGED THE TOOLS
HAVEN'T BEEN VALIDATED FOR A YOU
KNOW NEARLY A DECADE SOME OF THE
DATA THEY'VE USED TO VALIDATE
SOME OF THESE.
ASSESSMENT TOOLS IS IS BACK FAR
AS 200-022-0003 THAT'S TOO OLD --
AND SO.
THERE'S A VARIETY OF THINGS THAT
DEPARTMENT CORRECTIONS NEEDS TO
DO TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
CONDUCT IN THE APPROPRIATE
SETTLEMENTS AND THEN GIVING
THOSE INMATES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PROGRAMS
EITHER.
CVT PROGRAMS OR VOLUNTEER
PROGRAMS OR A COMBINATION OF
MULTIPLE PROGRAMS SO THAT THAT
INMATE IS GIVEN THE BEST
OPPORTUNITY BE SUCCESSFUL WHEN
HE OR SHE IS RELEASED FROM.
FROM PRISON IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IN THE REAL REASON I ASKED
THAT BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S KEY
TO WHAT WE ALL NEED ABOUT
EVIDENCE BASED AND AND EVEN.
THE DEPARTMENT I WANT THEM. TO
TO OPEN UP THEIR MINDS AND BE.
INVENTIVE IF THEY HAVE TO TO TO
DO THAT I MEAN WHEN I ASKED.
HOW DO YOU KNOW?
SOMEONE HAS A MISTER DAVID DATE
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS AYE AYE
SOME KIND OF WE GET AN ANSWER WE
DON'T KNOW.
AND I WOULD SAY WHAT.
DEAR IS A WAY YOU CAN CALCULATE
THAT NAY SAID HOW I SAID WELL
YOU GO.
TO THE STATE FRANCHISE BOARD AND
SEE HOW MANY HAVE PAID TAXES
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
I'M PRETTY SURE UNLESS THEY'RE
REALLY GOOD CRIMINALS THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO WORK NINE TO
FIVE EVERY DAY.
MONDAY TO FRIDAY AND TAKE CARE
TO KIDS OR WEAKENED IF THEY AND
ARE PAYING TAXES THEY GOT A
HOUSE NOTE THERE.
THERE'S A THERE'S A HIGH
PERCENTAGE THAT THEY'RE NOT
DOING CRIME AGAIN.
AND IS PROBABLY 1100% CHANCE
THAT IF THEY'RE GOING TO WORK
EVERY DAY DURING THOSE FIVE
YEARS THEY DID NOT.
RECEIVE A VAGUE.
SO YOU CAN ACTUALLY SHOW THAT
THE SAVE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR SO OVER. FOR FIVE YEARS
TAKES A A HALF A MILLION THEY
GOT A THOUSAND PEOPLE DOING THAT.
NOW YOU CAN SHOW.
A REAL NUMBER.
AND THEY SAID WELL WE DON'T KNOW
HOW TO GET A FROM THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD OR WERE PRECLUDED OR
IS IT.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT SOMEONE I CAN
CHANGE THE LAW.
SO DID YOU ASK AND SO I THAT'S
WHY I'M ASKING THE DEPARTMENT.
GET ON BOARD THIS WILL ONLY HELP
YOU IN AND AND THAT'S WHY SAID
MAYBE I NEED TO CHANGE.
DO LEGISLATION TO CHANGE
EVIDENCE BASED TO RETURN ON
INVESTMENT BECAUSE THAT MIGHT
GET PEOPLE TO REALLY.
LOOK AT THIS WHOLE THING ABOUT
MAKING SURE THE PROGRAMS WORK
BECAUSE THIS.
IS BENEFICIAL AND I HAVE ONE
MORE QUESTION AS I GOT PEOPLE.
SO THIS IS MORE BECAUSE I'M A
BUDGET.
AND PUT IN I USED TO BE DIRECTOR
OF REAL ESTATE FOR THE CITY AND
THE WHOLE FACILITIES -- JUST
DISCUSSION I AGREE WITH YOU YOU
WE NEED TO HAVE SOME TYPE OF
ASSESSMENT ON WHAT SPACE NEEDS
ARE -- NOW.
SO THAT WE CAN START BUDGETING
FOR IT I'M STEP -- FIVE YOU KNOW
IT IT IT.
IT WOULD BE NICE IF WE'RE ABLE
TO HIRE ALL THE PEOPLE WE NEED
TO DO THE TEACHING IN.
AND AND HELP FACILITATE -- BUT
CBT CLASSES AND OTHER THINGS AND
LET'S JUST SAY WERE FULLY
STAFFED.
IF THE ONLY SPACE YOU HAVE OR IS
IS PROBABLY TO IS IS THE IS THE
SIZE.
OF THE SMALLEST ASSEMBLY OFFICE
YEAR YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE
TO TEACH A WHOLE LOT OF PEOPLE.
I SAY WHO'S OFFICER WAS BUT IT'S
IT COULD BE REALLY DIFFICULT IF
YOU GOT A HUNDRED PEOPLE OR MORE.
THAT ONE IN.
GET SOME THAT SO THAT'S THAT
COULD BE CRUCIAL.
IN MAKING SURE THIS HAPPENED SO
I I I TO WILL URGE.
CDC ARE TO GET THAT GET THOSE
SPECS TO ASSIST SOON AS POSSIBLE.
SO WE CAN FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER I
KNOW WE HAVE A QUESTION BY
MISTER CALDERON BUT LET ME ASK
REAL QUICK JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON
HIS BECAUSE YOU -- MADAM WATER
YOU HAD TALKED ABOUT THE C. B.
D. PROGRAMS BUT WE'RE ONLY
LOOKING AT UP 225% OF THOSE AND
MISTER -- JONES SAWYER WAS
TALKING ABOUT A LOT OF OTHER
PROGRAMS AND SOME I'VE ACTUALLY
SEEN AS WELL OVER A CAL CITY AND
THE DOGS AND WHAT THAT ACTUALLY
DOES FOR THE INMATES.
WHO WERE YOU ABLE TO FIND
ANALYTICS FROM?
THE CDC ARE ON HOW THAT HAD AN
AFFECT MEAN BECAUSE IT SOUNDED
LIKE YOU WERE.
HAVING ISSUES WITH THE NUMBERS
IN THE ANALYTICS FOR THE C. B.
T. PROGRAMS BUT THESE OTHER
PROGRAMS I WOULD IMAGINE.
WAS IT THE SAME.
OUTCOME OR NOT BECAUSE AND
THAT'S QUESTION WE CAN ASK THE
NEXT BATTLE.
RIGHT WHAT WHEN WE I TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE VOLUNTEER
PROGRAMS AND THEY WERE WERE OF
HOW SUCCESSFUL THOSE PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN BUT WE HAVEN'T SEEN
ANY PROGRESS TO DATE WITH
RESPECT TO THAT SO WE DIDN'T SEE
ANY ANALYTICS.
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG WE
DIDN'T SEE ANY ANALYTICS RELATED
TO HOW SUCCESSFUL OR HOW COST
EFFECTIVE THESE VOLUNTEER
PROGRAMS ARMY WE TRY TO USE SOME
OF THAT TERMINOLOGY IN THE
REPORT COST EFFECTIVENESS.
OF THESE PARTICULAR PROGRAMS AND
THAT'S WHY WE DID THE ANALYSIS
OF IF YOU.
YOU KNOW PREVENT ONE ONE OUT OF
NINE FROM RECENT EVADING IT THE
PAPER THE THE FOR SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS PAY FOR THEMSELVES.
SO THERE NEEDS TO BE THAT FISCAL
ANALYSIS OF THE BENEFITS OF SOME
OF THESE PROGRAMS AND WE DID NOT
SEE THAT WE LOOKED AT C. B. T.
BUT WE ALSO TALK TO THEM ABOUT
THE VOLUNTEER PROGRAMS.
AND DID NOT SEE ANY IN ANALYTICS
OR ANY ANALYSIS OF THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS OF THOSE
PARTICULAR PROGRAMS AND I WAS
GONNA ASK THIS LATER A BABY
ASSETS NOW.
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS YOU CAME
OUT WITH BECAUSE NOW WE'RE AT
THE SIXTY DAY MARK I COUNTED
TWENTY FOUR RECOMMENDATIONS.
THAT WERE LISTED THERE AND OF
THOSE TWENTY FOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS HOW MANY.
THE MISTER PHONE OR YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT HOW MANY WERE
ACTUALLY BEING IMPLEMENTED OF
THE TWENTY FOUR SO WE CAN AT
THIRTEEN IS PENDING SO THEY'RE
IN THE PLANNING STAGES TO BE
PLANNING IMPLEMENTING OF THOUGHT
FOR SO THEIR FOURTEEN FOR CDC
ARE -- THIRTEEN OF THOSE WITH
CANADA'S PENDING IS AND THERE
WERE SOME ACTION BUT IT KIND OF
WAS SO PRELIMINARY THAT WE COULD.
MAKE A JUDGMENT CALL ON WHETHER
WAS IMPLEMENTED OR NOT.
AND THEY HAD PARTIALLY
IMPLEMENTED ONE RELATED -- TO
STAFFING.
AND FOR MONITORING THE STAFFING
VACANCIES OUT SO WHAT'S THE NEXT
PANEL ON AN UPDATE ON THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS RIGHT I LIST YOU
CAN GO AHEAD AND JUST REAL
QUICKLY I'M SORRY MISTER
CALDERON SO.
WE MADE A VARIETY OF
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND CERTAINLY MADE
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS TO SEE ROB
BUT THE OTHER THE OTHER POINT
THAT I WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
MEMBERS UNDERSTAND IS.
WHEN THAT WHEN THE REPORT IS
ISSUED IN JANUARY LATE JANUARY
THROUGH THE LAST DAY GENERATE
THIRTY FIRST OF OF THIS YEAR?
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT'S THE
FIRST TIME OR WITHIN A FEW WEEKS
CDC ARE WAS AWARE OF THESE
ISSUES WHENEVER MY OFFICE IS
CONDUCTING AN AUDIT WORK
CONSTANTLY IN CONTACT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION -- AND THE
PROGRAM OFFICIAL SO.
WHEN WE'RE PRETTY CLOSE TO
DRAFTING REPORT SO A LOT OF
THESE ISSUES AND MANY OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS THE THE
DEPARTMENT WAS AWARE OF MONTHS
AGO?
LONG BEFORE WE ISSUED A REPORT
IN JANUARY SO THEY HAVE HAD A
FAIR AMOUNT OF TIME TO REALLY
THINK ABOUT SOME OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND GET SOME
PROGRESS MADE.
NOW OFTENTIMES I SAY WE DON'T
LOOK FOR A LOT OF PROGRESS IN
SIXTY DAYS.
BUT WE WOULD EXPECT OUR SIX
MONTH RESPONSE TYPICALLY IS
WHERE WE REALLY EXPECT PROGRESS
TO BE MADE AND WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS BASED ON HISTORICAL.
OUR WORK IN AUDITING THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS IN AND
SOME OF THE DISCUSSION I HAD.
A WITH YOU REGARDING YOU KNOW
THEY'VE THOUGHT ABOUT USING AN
EXTERNAL RESEARCHER BUT THEY
HAVEN'T DEVELOPED A SCOPE YET
THEY'RE SUGGESTING THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE A SCOPE.
AND A CONTRACT BY APRIL OF
TWENTY TWENTY THEY SHOULD BE
WORKING ON THAT NOW THEY SHOULD
BE ABLE TO SHOW THE LEGISLATURE
AND PERHAPS US AT LEAST.
THE BEGINNINGS OF A SCOPE BY THE
SIX MONTH REACHED A RESPONSE IN
JULY.
US BECAUSE WE'RE WE'RE GIVING
THEM A THREE YEAR PLAN BUT WE
NEED TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE TO
THAT PLAN.
AND AS AS MR FELDER SAID A LOT
OF MORE PENDING AND THAT'S A
REALLY THAT'S A CONCERN TO US TO
ME IN PARTICULAR AS THE STATE
AUDITOR.
I WANT TO SEE MORE PROGRESS FROM
THE DEPARTMENT -- AND HOPEFULLY
WE WILL SEE THAT AT THE SIX
MONTH OR PERHAPS WILL BE OVER
HERE FROM THE DEPARTMENT TODAY
WHERE THEY'VE MADE A BIT MORE
PROGRESS IN SOME OF THESE AREAS
BECAUSE THAT EXTERNAL RESEARCHER
GETTING THE DATA.
THEY WILL HAVE THE INFORMATION
TO BE ABLE TO DO AN ANALYSIS OF
THE RECIDIVISM RATE.
YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
SCOPE IS IS COPING TO BE LIMITED
TO CBT PROGRAMS IS GOING TO BE
LOOKING AT THE ACADEMIC IS A
GOING TO BE LOOKING AT FOLK AT
IS GOING TO BE LOOKING AT
VOLUNTEER.
ARE YOU GONNA LOOK AT HOW ARE
THEY PRIORITIZING WHEN ARE THEY
GOING TO RE ASSESS THESE TOOLS
THERE'S A VARIETY OF FACTORS
THAT IN IMPACT.
THE STATE'S ABILITY TO REALLY
PROVIDE SERVICES AND MY WORDS TO
INMATES TO TO INCREASE THEIR
THEIR POSSIBILITY BEING
SUCCESSFUL MAKE WHEN THEY ARE
RELEASED FROM PRISON IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO THAT THEY ARE NOW AND I WOULD
IMAGINE IT WOULD BEHOOVE THE
DEPARTMENT ACTUALLY HAVE SOME OF
THOSE ANALYTICS ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT EDUCATION
PROGRAMS OF YOU COULD SAY 80% OF
THE FOLKS.
THAT RUN IT IS PROGRAM GRADUATE
WITH A DEGREE ECCENTRIC -- SO
DEFINITELY AGREE WITH YOU LET'S
GO TO MOVED -- MISTER CALDERON
THANK YOU MISTER SAUCE AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE POINT THAT --
MISS JONES SAWYER WAS TRYING TO
MAKE BECAUSE YOU KNOW.
OUR INTENT IS IN -- TO BE MYOPIC
WHEN IT COMES TO THE APPROACH
THAT WE EXPECT THE DEPARTMENT TO
TAKE WHEN IT WHEN IT COMES TO
THESE PROGRAMS WE WE WANT ALLOW
FOR CREATIVITY WE WANT ALLOW FOR
INNOVATION -- BUT ONE THING THAT
HAS BEEN SO -- PREVALENT IN MY
IN MY EXPERIENCE IN THE SEVEN
YEARS THAT HAVE BEEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE OUR STATE AGENCIES
IN THE COMPLACENCY WITHIN THE
STATE AGENCIES TO JUST GO ALONG
AND GO WITH WITH THIS IS THE WAY
THINGS HAVE ALWAYS BEEN DONE.
THAT'S THAT'S WHY WE GET INTO A
LOT OF TROUBLE AND THAT'S WHY --
OVERSIGHT OVER THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY HAS BECOME SO IMPORTANT IN
SUCH A IT ISSUE SUCH THAT WE ARE
FOCUSING A LOT MORE ATTENTION ON
I'M A LOT MORE ATTENTION ON OUR
OVERSIGHT -- CAPACITY BECAUSE
YOU KNOW.
WE SPENT A LOT OF MONEY AND WE
DO KNOW THAT THAT MONEY IS BEING
SPENT IN THE RIGHT PLACES -- YOU
KNOW THERE COULD BE A PROGRAM
YOU KNOW IT FROM FOLKS THAT I'VE
BEEN ABLE TO TALK TO THAT'S IN
OUR PROGRAM.
THAT DOES WONDERS FOR CERTAIN
GROUP CERTAIN GROUP OF PEOPLE
AND WE WERE DEALING WITH SO MANY
DIFFERENT PERSONALITIES SO MANY
DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS.
YOU KNOW VARIETY AND PROGRAMS
ARE IMPORTANT -- AND YOU KNOW IT
IT WAS IT IS INTERESTING HERE
ABOUT THE EVIDENCE BASED
PROGRAMS THAT THE THE LIMITED
PULL I IN TERMS OF THE SCOPE OF
THOSE PROGRAMS THAT THAT IT
DOESN'T REALLY GO BEYOND LIKE
SAY JOB TRAINING PROGRAMS -- I
THINK JOB TRAINING PROGRAMS ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT -- WHEN IT
COMES TO REHABILITATION YOU HAVE
SOMEBODY WHO SPENT TEN YEARS IN
PRISON?
YOU KNOW THEY MAY MAY HAVE GONE
IN FOR A DRUG CHARGE -- BUT TEN
YEARS IN PRISON IF THEY DIDN'T
GET THE THE THE SERVICE AT THAT
THEY THAT THEY NEEDED TO TAKE
CARE OF THEIR JOB DRUG PROBLEM
WHICH OFTEN HAPPENS -- AND
SOMETIMES THEY HAVE A DRUG
PROBLEM THIS DEVELOP BECAUSE OF
OF A MISDIAGNOSIS UNDIAGNOSED
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE -- BUT THEY
SPEND TEN YEARS PLUS IN PRISON
BECAUSE OF THAT.
AND THEY COME OUT THEY'RE
DIFFERENT PERSON -- AND IT IS
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO EXPECT
THEM TO BECOME AN ACTIVE
PARTICIPANT IN SOCIETY WHEN YOU
KNOW WE ARE NOT OFFERING.
PROGRAMS THAT ARE RELEVANT TO
WHAT THEIR LIFE IS GOING TO BE
LIKE WHEN THEY GET OUT OF PRISON
BECAUSE ALSO WHEN THEY WENT INTO
PRISON THE WORLD WAS A VERY
DIFFERENT PLACE THAN WHEN
THEY'RE COMING OUT.
OF PRISON -- AND SO YOU KNOW OUR
INTENT OUR INTENT IS IN TO TO
LIMIT THE ABILITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO BE CREATIVE AND
INNOVATIVE IN THE PROGRAMS
AREN'T OUR INTENT IS TO
HOPEFULLY INSPIRE THEM -- BUT
ALSO WE NEED METRICS TO
PERFORMANCE METRICS IN ORDER TO
DETERMINE THAT -- WE ARE GETTING
THAT RETURN ON INVESTMENT IS
JONES JONES SAWYER DOES.
ALLUDE TO AND WE HAVE TO HAVE A
HIGH STANDARD WHEN IT COMES TO
THE PEOPLE THAT WE ALLOWED TO
COME AND RUN A REHABILITATION
PROGRAM BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE PROGRAMS THAT ARE RUN
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT -- THAT
SOMETIMESME THEY GET PAID BASED
OFF OF THE INDIVIDUAL SOME
INDIVIDUALS THEY GET TO SIGN UP
AND MAYBE -- IT ISN'T SO MUCH
ABOUT ACTUALLY HAVING THEM DO
WHATEVER THE PROGRAM IS SAYING
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO OFFER
WHATEVER.
WHATEVER THEY'RE OFFERING IT'S
IT'S ABOUT GETTING THE
SIGNATURES AND GETTING THE NAMES
AND NOW TAKEN OFF AND MAYBE GO
FOR A WALK OR DOING SOMETHING
ELSE NOT NECESSARILY ACTUALLY
PARTICIPATING.
IN THE PROGRAM THAT'S SUPPOSED
TO BE REHABILITATED FOR THEM YOU
KNOW AND AND THEIR DIFFERENT
INCENTIVES THAT ARE THAT MY AND
FROM MY UNDERSTANDING ARE
OFFERED TO THE INMATES FOR BEING
ABLE TO SIGN UP.
OFFER A PROGRAM.
WITHOUT NECESSARILY HAVING TO
PARTICIPATE.
IN THAT PROGRAM THE WIDGET WE WE
SPEND SO MUCH MONEY WE HAVE TO
WE HAVE TO KNOW WHERE THAT
MONEY'S GOING AND HAS TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND HOW THESE
PROGRAMS ARE.
ADMINISTERED WELL.
I I'M GONNA HAVE TO LEAVE
BECAUSE I HAVE -- MEETING THEM
HAVE TO GO ATTEND BUT AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING THE TESTIMONY
AND THE MEN THE SUMMARY FROM MY
STAFF WHEN IT COMES TO THE
TESTIMONY OF THAT -- THE THE THE
DEPARTMENT BOB.
BUT THIS MATTERS AND WE SPEND A
LOT OF MONEY NOT JUST IN A
REHABILITATION PROGRAM BUT ON
CORRECTIONS.
AND SO THE WHOLE POINT OF THIS
AUDIT WAS TO GET.
WAS TO GET THE INFORMATION THAT
WE GOT IT ISN'T SURPRISING TO ME
THAT THE MAN FROM NATION.
THE INFORMATION THAT WE DID
RECEIVE BECAUSE THAT WAS THIS
THAT'S DOUBTS WHAT WE SUSPECTED
BUT IT'S ALSO PARTLY OUR FAULT
BECAUSE WE NEVER.
LOOKED AT IT BECAUSE WE WERE
NEVER FOR SMALL IN AND IN OUR IN
OUR ABILITY TO ASK FOR THAT
INFORMATION IN TO GET THAT A
TYPE OF INFORMATION SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE I REALLY APPRECIATE.
THE WORK THAT YOU GUYS HAVE DONE --
BUT I REALLY WANT THIS TO BE
MOTIVATING.
FOR EVERYONE INVOLVED ESPECIALLY
THE DEPARTMENT TO HAVE A HIGHER
STANDARD HOLD THEMSELVES TO A
HIGHER STANDARD AND UNDERSTAND.
THE IMPORTANCE OF RUNNING THESE
PROGRAMS AND MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE BEST POSSIBLEPROGRAMS
THAT ARE PROVIDING THESE PEOPLE
THAT ARE GONNA GET OUT
EVENTUALLY THE THE BEST
OPPORTUNITIES TO BE SUCCESSFUL
SO THAT THEY DO NOT RECEIVE A
BECAUSE IT COSTS TOO MUCH MONEY.
AND WE ARE MOVING AWAY FROM THIS
IDEA OF LOCK HIM UP AND THROW
AWAY THE KEY.
AND TOWARDS THE IDEA AND TOWARDS
A PRACTICE OF REHABILITATE AND
THEN ALSO INJECT MORE MONEY INTO
LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES WHICH
WE STILL NEED TO DO THIS AND TO
LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES TO
PREVENT.
THOSE KIDS ARE GROWING UP IN
THIS LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES TO
FROM EVER BELIEVING THAT THE
ONLY WAY THAT THEY CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL AND HAVE A GOOD LIFE
IS TO SELL DRUGS TO JOIN A GANG.
BECAUSE THAT'S ALL THEY KNOW AND
THAT'S WHAT THEY GREW UP WITH
AND THAT'S WHAT THE ROLE MODELS
DID.
IN ORDER STE IN ORDER TO SURVIVE
AND SO THAT'S WHERE THE FOCUS
NEEDS TO BE NOT NECESSARILY ON
YOU KNOW.
THIS LOCK THEM UP AND THROW AWAY
THE KEY ENTRY EVERYBODY THE SAME
AS IF EVERYBODY'S LIFE TO BE
EXPERIENCES ARE THE SAME
EVERYBODY GREW UP THE SAME SET
OF CIRCUMSTANCES BECAUSE IT
MATTERS AND THAT EVERYBODY DID.
BUT I REALLY THINK YOU -- AND
CALIFORNIA HEARING ABOUT THE
REST OF THE THE PANEL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS I KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'VE BEEN ALLUDING TO IS.
AND MY OPENING COMMENTS I TALKED
ABOUT THE SIXTY FOUR MILLION WE
GAVE THREE YEARS AGO AND WHAT
ARE WE GETTING OUT OF THAT ARE
MORE THE ANALYTICS FOR IT -- THE
SIXTY DAY CHECK IN BUT WE ALSO
HAVE THE SIX MONTH AND
ESPECIALLY AS WE MOVE INTO THE
MAY REVISE.
AND THE ULTIMATE -- BUDGET IN
JUNE THESE ARE THESE ARE ANSWERS
THAT WE ALL UP HERE WANT. TO
HAVE SO THAT WERE INFORMED ABOUT
HOW WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT I
KNOW MISS COM LONGER DOVE HAS A
QUESTION.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO MESS
BAUER-KAHAN.
FIRST PLACE RIBBON.
COMMENTED AFTER.
YES -- THANK YOU FOR THIS REPORT
AND FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS I
WANT TO ECHO THE OPINIONS OF MY
COLLEAGUES THAT YOU KNOW WE WANT
TO RETURN ON OUR INVESTMENT WHEN
IT COMES OR SPENDING.
IN OUR PRISON SYSTEM BUT I ALSO
WANT TO SAY THAT.
RECIDIVISM ALSO MEANS CRIMES ARE
BEING COMMITTED OUR COMMUNITIES
WHICH MEANS WHEN WE REDUCE
RECIDIVISM WE MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFER WE ALSO
INCREASE WE ARE OUTCOMES ARE
BETTER FOR THOSE WHEN THEY CAN
REENTER SOCIETY AND DO SO
SUCCESSFULLY SO THERE'S A WHOLE
HOST OF REASONS.
WHY WE SHOULD BE DRIVING FOR
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMMING OUR
PRISONS AND SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK ON THAT -- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE KEEP TALKING
ABOUT IS EVIDENCE BASED IN
METRICS IN THE IMPORTANCE OF
THAT.
I AM NEW TO POLITICS INTO
GOVERNMENT I COME OUT OF THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AND TO ME IT IS
FASCINATING THAT WE CAN'T MAKE
MORE DATA DRIVEN DECISIONS.
WHICH IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR IS
HOW WE MAKE DECISIONS IF YOU
KNOW SO ONE OF THE THINGS I'M
LEARNING IS THAT OUR DATA IS SO
SEGREGATED THAT IT IS HARD TO
KNOW OBVIOUSLY THE QUESTION THE
ONE NEEDS TO ASK TO SEE IF THESE
PROGRAMS.
ARE WORKING -- VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD WEEK PEOPLE SIGN
UP WE KNOW WHICH PROGRAMS EACH
INMATE TAKES IF THEY COMMIT A
CRIME THERE'S A SEPARATE SYSTEM
THAT TELLS US THAT THEY'VE BEEN
CHARGED WITH A CRIME.
SO THE QUESTION OF RESIDENT
RECIDIVISM AND THE PROGRAMMING
THAT WORK SHOULD BE VERY
STRAIGHT FORWARD BUT WHAT I'M
HEARING TODAY IS THAT WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO PUT THAT DATA TOGETHER
TO MAKE DATA DRIVEN DECISIONS
ABOUT WHICH OF THESE PROGRAMS.
ARE SUCCESSFUL REPLICATE THOSE
INSURE THOSE ARE BEING PUT INTO
ALL OF OUR PRISONS AND ENSURE
THE PEOPLE OF ACCESS TO THOSE DO
YOU HAVE A SENSE AND WE CAN ASK
THE DEPARTMENT THIS IS WELL.
YOU KNOW WE'RE IS THE FAILURE IN
OUR DATA SYSTEM TO BE ABLE TO
PUT THESE ANSWERS TOGETHER.
I THINK A GOOD EXAMPLE THAT FROM
OUR REPORT IS -- THE LACK OF
COORDINATION BETWEEN EDT AND CDC
ARE REGARDING VOCATIONAL
PROGRAMMING SO WE THOUGHT THAT
IT BE PRETTY STRAIGHT FORWARD TO
HEAD INMATE.
ALL RIGHT THEY'VE GOT YOU KNOW
THEY GET THE X. RECEIVES A
VOCATIONAL TRAINING AND THEN
THEY'RE GOING TO GO OUT WELL DID
THEY GET A JOB.
IS AND THE THING THEY WERE
TRAINED IT RIGHT IN THERE IN
THAT FIELD.
AND THAT CDC ARE IN ET DE HAD
BEEN TRYING TO WORK TOGETHER FOR
A LONG PERIOD OF TIME BUT THERE
HAD BEEN SEVERAL ISSUES RELATED%
TO SHARING AND SOCIAL SECURITY
pRELATED CONCERNS.
AND IT'S A WE HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION ALL REPORT -- ONE
LEGISLATIVE TO AMEND THE LAW TO
MAKE IT EASIER TO COORDINATE.
AND SECONDLY JUST TO ENCOURAGE
YOU TO SEE OUR I NEEDED TO WORK
TO WORK OUT THEIR DIFFERENCES
NOW THERE ARE THERE ARE.
DIFFICULTIES BECAUSE OF SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS -- YOU NOTED
THAT -- A FORMER APART MAYBE BY
USING MULTIPLE SO SECURITY
NUMBERS ARE DIFFERENT NAMES.
BUT THE THERE ARE CERTAINLY WAYS
YOU CAN DO THIS AND THAT YOU
KNOW.
THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE FOUND IT OKAY IF WE CAN IF WE
CAN BRING THESE TWO ENTITIES
TOGETHER AND GET A WORKING
TOGETHER.
THEN WE CAN ACTUALLY SEE WHICH
VOCATIONAL PROGRAMS WORK BEST
AND THEN FINAL IT'LL BE FUN TO
MORE MONEY TOWARD THOSE GUYS
WERE SAYING -- THESE ARE THE
ONES THAT WORKING THERE COULD
NOT ONLY KEEP PEOPLE PLOY THAT
THAT MEANS ARE NOT POSITIVE
AIDING.
SO -- THAT.
THAT KIND OF GIVES YOU SOME IDEA
OF WHAT WE'RE TO WHAT WE FOUND.
YEAH I MEAN AS I'VE COME HERE
AND YOU KNOW ASK THESE QUESTIONS
YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE NEED TO LOOK
AT THE STATE LEVEL BUT ALSO THE
COUNTY LEVEL RIGHT WHICH WERE
IMPRISONED MORE PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTY PRESENCE AS WELL THESE
DAYS. ONE OF THE ANSWERS I GOT
WAS WELL WE DON'T WANT TO TELL
YOU THAT BECAUSE YOU MIGHT TAKE
THE MONEY AWAY CLICK WELL.
YES OF ITS NOT WORKING WE ARE
GOING TO STOP WE SHOULD NOT BE
SPENDING ON THAT PROGRAM THAT
ISN'T TO SAY WILL TAKE MONEY
AWAY FOR PROGRAMMING BUT LET'S
SPEND IT ON THE ONES THAT WORK
AND I THINK THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
A MORE.
OPEN DIALOGUE ABOUT WHAT IS
SUCCESSFUL WHAT IS WORKING AND
SPEND APPROPRIATELY AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT THEIR FIXES THAT WE
CAN PUT IN TO MAKE THAT EASIER I
THINK WE SHOULD LOOK LONG AND
HARD AT THAT THANK YOU.
AND I THINK THAT'S CORRECT WAIT
ACTUALLY ASSASSIN LOOK AT IT
BECAUSE YOU DON'T SHOW IF IT'S
ACTUALLY WORKING.
YOU KNOW I KNOW THE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEES WILL PROBABLY BE LIKE
WELL IF YOU CAN'T PROVE THAT
IT'S WORKING WILL PUT IT TO
ANOTHER PROGRAM THAT DOES SHOW.
THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY REDUCING
RECIDIVISM AND I KNOW THAT'S A
DISCUSSION I HAD WITH MY
COLLEAGUES UP HERE WITH THAT
WILL MOVE TO MISS COME LONGER
TOUGH.
THANK YOU SO -- YOU KNOW THIS
MIGHT HAVE BEEN A LONG DAY FOR
ME BUT HE DID THIS IS VERY
DISCOURAGING THERE'S SOME HOPE
BUT IT'S DISCOURAGING.
I ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT YOU KNOW --
YOU DON'T EVALUATE WHAT YOU
DON'T VALUE.
YOU KNOW AND IF WE AREN'T
VALUING.
CORRECTIONS AND THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE INCARCERATED.
THEN WE'RE ACTUALLY NOT GOING TO
TAKE THE DEEP DIVES THAT WE NEED
TO TO FIGURE OUT WHAT PROGRAMS
ARE WORKING.
I WOULD ALSO ARGUE THAT SOME
PEOPLE MAY BE VERY EXCITED ABOUT
RECIDIVISM RATES EITHER GOING UP
OR STAYING AT HIGH RATES.
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY THAT MEANS
THAT THOSE SYSTEMS ARE STILL
RUNNING AND PEOPLE ARE STILL
BEING EMPLOYED OPERATING THEM.
AND SO HOW DO WE GET TO A
CONVERSATION OR A PLACE WHERE WE
CAN REDUCE RECIDIVISM BUT STILL
HAVE.
YOU KNOW ROBUST EMPLOYMENT.
MAYBE JUST HAVING FOLKS DOING
DIFFERENT THINGS RIGHT IN I'M
INTERESTED IN HOW WE GET TO A
PLACE WE CAN BOTH PROTECT THE
RIGHTS OF THE INNOCENT.
WHILE RESPECTING THE HUMANITY OF
THE GUILTY.
AND YOU RESPECT THE HUMANITY OF
THE GUILTY WHEN YOU'RE ACTUALLY
PUTTING PROGRAMS WITHIN
CORRECTIONS.
AND EVALUATING THEM AND FIGURING
OUT WHAT WORKS BECAUSE PEOPLE
SHOULD KNOW THEIR RIGHTS THEY
SHOULD BE GAINING FINANCIAL
LITERACY THEY SHOULD BE WORKING
ON COGNITIVE DEVELOPMENT.
THEY SHOULD BE WORKING ON
THERAPY THEY SHOULD BE WORKING
ON EDUCATION AND WE SHOULD BE
WORKING WITH THEM TO HELP THEM
HAVE THE TOOLS THAT THEY NEED.
TO INTEGRATE BACK INTO SOCIETY.
THE CHALLENGE MAY BE.
THAT NO [inaudible]
ONE APPRECIATE FAILURE.
IT'S OKAY TO ACTUALLY HAVE A
PROGRAM.
YOU EVALUATE IT YOU LOOK AT THE
DATA THE DATA IS AS IS NOT
WORKING.
YOU TRY SOMETHING NEW.
YOU KNOW NOT EVERY IDEA IS A
GREAT IDEA BUT IF PEOPLE ARE
AFRAID TO EVALUATE IT BECAUSE TO
MS BAUER CANS POINT IF IT FAILS
THEN YOU JUST TAKE AWAY THE
MONEY.
THEN OF COURSE WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE THESE HALF BAKED.
BIG DOESN'T THE WORD I WANT TO
USE HALF BAKED PROGRAMS.
WHICH GOES BACK TO OT VALUING.
THE CORRECTIONAL AND THE
REHABILITATION.
COMPONENTS OF CDC ARE.
SO.
IS THAT IT'S A CULTURE SHIFT IN
MY MIND IN TERMS OF HELPING
FOLKS UNDERSTAND THAT YOU KNOW
THIS IS A CONTINUUM RIGHT IN
TERMS OF THESE CHECK INS THAT WE
SHOULD ALL BE DOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE ON THE RIGHT PATH.
BECAUSE YOU ACTUALLY CAN GET
RETURN ON INVESTMENT.
RIGHT I THINK THE ECONOMICS WORK
IN THE OTHER WAY IF YOU GET
FOLKS OUT.
IN THEIR IN COMMUNITIES OR IF
YOU'RE FIGURING OUT WHO THE
RIGHT PEOPLE ARE THAT YOU SHOULD
BE CONTRACTING WITH TO BRING
THEM INTO CORRECTIONS AND INTO
THE PRISONS.
YOU CAN PROBABLY CUT COSTS
BECAUSE YOUR OPERATING PROGRAMS
THAT ACTUALLY INMATES MEET
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WAS COMMANDEERED OF I
BELIEVE MISTER JONES SAWYER HAS
A QUICK COMMENT REALLY WILL MOVE
WITH THE NATIONAL.
IN YOUR REPORT -- YOU SAID THAT --
BASICALLY -- AS FAR AS THE
BUDGET IS CONCERNED FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE EMPLOYED IN
REHABILITATION MONIES YOU NEED
TO CONTINUE REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS.
THAT YOU DIDN'T SEE US GIVEN AN
ADDITIONAL APPROPRIATION THAT
THE DEPARTMENT.
HAS THE RESOURCES FINANCIALLY.
I'LL TAKE AWAY THE SPACE
REQUIREMENT TO THAT'S A
DIFFERENT DISCUSSION. FOR RIGHT
NOW -- PRETTY ON THE SPOT KIND
OF PUTTING THEM ON THE SPOT THAT
THEY CAN.
THEY CAN MAKE THE CHANGES WITH
EXISTING FUNDING.
THAT'S CORRECT AS FAR AS THE THE
BUDGETED AMOUNT THEY HAVE TO
STAFF THE VARIOUS PROGRAMS WE
FELT THAT THEY HAD SUFFICIENT
BUDGET -- TO BE ABLE TO TO HIRE
PEOPLE AND PROVIDE --
INSTRUCTORS FOR THOSE VARIOUS
PROGRAMS SO WE DIDN'T SEE A NEED
FOR INCREASED RESOURCES FROM
THAT PERSPECTIVE BUT FACILITIES.
AS AS MUCH OF MISTER FILNER SAID
THEY'VE GOT TO DO -- AND IT'S AN
ANALYSIS OF ALL THEIR DIFFERENT
FACILITIES AND WHAT SPACE DO
THEY HAVE ONE OF THE LIMITATIONS
AND WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
SOLUTIONS -- THAT THEY COULD
BRING FORWARD TO EXPAND -- THOSE
COURSES.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU WITH THAT NUMBER
QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
FRENCH RESTAURANT HERE MEMBERS
YES SIR SHARE IT.
THANK YOU AND MORE THAN WELCOME
TO SET THE TABLE IF NOT WE'LL
MOVE ON TO THE SECOND PANEL
[inaudible]
OF ITEM NUMBER THREE COMMENTS
AND RESPONSES ON AUDIT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
WE HAVE MISTER DE AS A SECRETARY
AND WE HAVE MISTER -- SO THOSE
ARE THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR DIVISION
OF REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS AND
I'D LIKE TO THANK MISTER VOEPEL
FOR JOINING US.
WE ARE READY TO BEGIN.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON -- YOU
THEIR SEXUAL YOU DON'T GET IT
ANY TROUBLE WHAT IS YOUR FISHER
TODD YOU'RE NOT IN A ROOM YOU'RE
I AM THE SECRETARY OF
CORRECTIONS I'VE BEEN APPOINTED
BY GOVERNOR TO SOME AS OF OR YOU
ARE YOU OFFICIALLY CONFIRMED BY
THE SENATE.
I AM NOT OFFICIALLY CONFIRMED BY
THIS AND YET JUST APPOINTED BY
THE GOVERNOR OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
REMINDING ME OF THAT HOW MUCH
DID YOU TROUBLED THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE HAD MEMBERS
I DO APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
OF THE PRESENTATION BY THE
AUDITOR I I REALLY TAKEN MANY
NOTES AND TAKEN SOME OF POINT
TWO AND I KNOW.
THAT THE DIRECTORS WHOSE -- WILL
BE MAKING SOME COMMENTS ON THE
AUDIT ITSELF AND EVEN SOME OF
THE POINTS THAT WERE DISCUSSED --
IN THE FIRST PANEL -- THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN SAID THAT I AM THE
NEWLY APPOINTED SECRETARY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION APPOINTED BY
GOVERNOR NEW SOME.
AND I COME TO YOU WITH NEARLY
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS OF
CORRECTIONAL EXPERIENCE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND I
BELIEVE I CAN WITH THE UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE.
OF WHAT THAT IS -- I BEGAN THE
DEPARTMENT WHEN IT WAS JUST --
CDC IT WAS OVERCROWDED THERE WAS
NO ARE THE PROGRAMS WEREN'T AS
ROBUST AND THEY WEREN'T FUNDED
AS THEY ARE TODAY.
I SARS A CORRECTIONAL OFFICER IN
THE NINETEEN NINETIES -- AND
MADE MY WAY UP AND DURING THE
HEIGHT OF OVERCROWDING I WAS THE
CAPTAIN ON A FACILITY RIGHT
ABOUT THE TIME THAT THE
RECESSION HIT THE PROGRAMS WERE
CUT.
AND THAT WAS A PRETTY HIGH
INTENSE FACILITY WITH A LOT OF
NEEDS BUT THAT WHEN THE FUNDING
GOT CUT FOR THESE PROGRAMS.
BECAME VERY INTENSE AND IT WAS A
HARD PLACE TO MANAGE FOR THE
INMATES AND THE EMPLOYEES.
I BEGAN WITH THE IDEA YOU KNOW
AT THAT TIME.
THAT -- WHEN I BEGAN MY CAREER
IT WAS ALL ABOUT JUST LOCKING
THE DOORS AND COUNTING -- AND
HOPEFULLY WE ALL GO HOME SAFELY.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THE
TRAJECTORY THAT I'VE MADE FROM A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER DURING
THOSE REALLY DARK TIMES AND
CORRECTIONS TO WHERE I AM NOW.
AS AGENCY HEAD INTO WHERE WE
HAVE DEVELOPED AND WHERE THE ARE
WAS PLACED ON IN CORRECTIONS.
I BELIEVE WE ARE WHAT WE NEED TO
BE IN CORRECTIONS HOWEVER.
I DO NEED TO SAY THE TWO YEARS
AGO SOMETHING HAPPENED
CALIFORNIA THAT I BELIEVE WAS
SIGNIFICANT.
THE RAMIFICATIONS OF OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF REHABILITATION
IS -- HASN'T FULLY BEEN
UNDERSTOOD JET AND WE ARE STILL
WORKING THROUGH.
IN OURPRISONS EMPIRE AND BY OUR
POPULATION AND OUR STAFF AND
THAT IS PROPOSITION.
FIFTY SEVEN PROPOSITION.
FIFTY SEVEN WAS VOTED
OVERWHELMINGLY BY THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA IT GAVE AUTHORITY TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND IN PARTICULAR TO THE
SECRETARY. TO AWARD CREDITS IN
INMATES FOR PARTICIPATION
MEANINGFUL REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS.
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE PROGRAMS
BY THE PRIOR SECRETARY AND
MYSELF -- WE STRUGGLED WITH IT
TO DETERMINE WHAT THAT MEANT. TO
HAVE MEANINGFUL PROGRAMS BECAUSE
WE BOTH WORK IN A DAY WHEN THIS
DIDN'T MEAN A WHOLE LOT.
AND WE KNEW THAT THERE WAS A DAY
THAT WE COULD BE BETTER AND WE
KNEW THAT THERE WAS A DAY THAT
WERE AT THE TIME.
WITH THE SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATURE THIS PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION WE CAN DO BETTER
BY CORRECTIONS.
THE MORE TRADITIONAL
CORRECTIONAL STAFF ARGUED THAT
THE THAT ONLY COGNITIVE BEHAVIOR
PROGRAMS AND ONLY GETTING
MANAGEMENT ANGER MANAGEMENT IN A
IN A IN WERE THE ONLY WAY TO GO
THAT WOULD BE YOUR TRADITIONAL
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAM THAT'S
THE ONLY WAY TO GO.
NOW OTHERS IN THE DEPARTMENT
THEY ADVOCATED THAT WE NEED TO
GO A DIFFERENT DIRECTION.
AND THAT OTHERS PERSONALLY
WITNESSED SOME OF THE OTHER
TYPES OF PROGRAMS OF INSIDE THE
WALLS OR MAKING POSITIVE IMPACTS
ON THE POPULATION NOT ONLY UPON
RELEASE.
BUT WHILE THEY WERE IN PRISON
AND THAT'S WERE.
RECIDIVISM IMPACTS BEGIN WHILE
THEY ARE IN PRISON NOT SO MUCH
FROM THE RELEASE BECAUSE YOU
BEGIN THAT PROCESS WHILE THEY'RE
IN PRISON.
IN MAY TWO LIVES ARE CHANGED BY
PERFORMING.
THINGS LIKE SHAKESPEARE.
LEARNING HOW TO CODE.
LEARNING HOW TO CARE FOR ANIMALS
SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
BARBARA TALKED ON THE FIRST
PANEL BUT I CAN'T EMPHASIZE
ENOUGH.
HOW IMPORTANT A SHIP THAT HAS
BEEN IN CORRECTIONS JUST BY SOME
OF THOSE PROGRAMS AND WE HAVE A
MYRIAD OF OTHERS? ONE MAN'S
REHABILITATION WAS SPARKED AT ST
QUIT AND WHEN HE JOINED A
RUNNING GROUP AND SANG QUITTING.
THAT INDIVIDUAL NOW IS GONNA BE
RUNNING IN THE BOSTON MARATHON
THIS WEEK WE'RE JUST A FEW
MONTHS AGO HE WAS A LIFE FROM
ONE OF OUR INSTITUTIONS.
HIS LIFE SHIFTED BECAUSE OF THE
PROGRAM'S HE PARTICIPATED IN.
OUR STAFF WHAT SHOULD REMIND YOU
ALSO STRUGGLE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SUICIDALITY
POOR HEALTH.
AND THEY HAVE THEIR OWN ISSUES
ALSO HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING THAT
REHABILITATION INCLUDED THESE
TYPES OF ACTIVITIES WITHIN THE
POPULATION BECAUSE THIS THIS
POPULATION BUT THEY TAKE CARE OF
ON A DAY TO DAY BASIS.
THESE ARE RANK AND FILE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS ARE
CORRECTIONAL STAFF WHO ARE ALSO
ADVOCATING FOR THE SET TO
PROGRAM.
AND YES THEY ARE PROGRAMS LIKE
GARDENING THEY'RE LIKE FAITH
BASED PROGRAMS AND EVEN YOGA.
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF REAL ABATE
REHABILITATION THIS TRANSFORM BE
OUR TRADITIONAL DISCUSSIONS OF
EVIDENCE BASED.
COGNITIVE BEHAVIOR DIALECTICAL
BEHAVIOR RISKING NEEDS
ASSESSMENTS AND UNDERSTANDING
THAT WE ARE TRYING TO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO.
IN THE DEPARTMENT IS TRYING TO
BUILD.
WHOLE HEALTHY INDIVIDUALS WHO
WIN ONE PILLAR OF THE
REHABILITATION FALLS DOWN
ANOTHER IS ARE SUPPORTED TO HOLD
THEM UP.
AND THAT'S WHERE THIS THIS VAST
REHABILITATION CATALOGUE THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
THAT THAT IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO
THE ONGOING WORK OF
REHABILITATION.
WE RESEARCH NATIONALLY HOW TO
EVALUATE THE REHABILITATIVE
IMPACTS AND SELF HELP PROGRAMS
FAITH BASED PROGRAMS
RECREATIONAL PROGRAMS CULTURAL
PROGRAMS AMONG OTHERS.
AND FOUND THAT THERE WAS LITTLE
TO NO RESEARCH STUDIES THAT
SHOWED FOR INSTANCE THAT A DOG
PROGRAM.
COULD BE DIRECTLY CORRELATED TO
RECIDIVISM AND WE TALKED ABOUT
THAT A LITTLE BIT ALREADY BUT
YET WE KNOW THAT THE BONDING THE
AFFECTION.
AND THE CARE OF LIVING CREATURES
CAN HELP CULTIVATED CHANGED IN
AN INDIVIDUAL BUT ALSO ON A
PRISON YARD.
I HAVE WITNESSED THAT PERSONALLY.
PROGRAMS LIKE THAT A VERY
INNOVATIVE TO ATTACH AN ANALYTIC
TO SAY THAT IT IS -- EVIDENCE
BASE AND IT DOES AFFECT
RECIDIVISM BUT WHAT IT DOES DO.
IT AFFECTS THE CULTURE OF THE
YARD.
AND I HAVE WITNESSED I
PERSONALLY WE HAVE FOUND NO
EVIDENCE.
THE MEXICAN AMERICAN OR AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND NATIVE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATIONS IN THESE GROUPS
CULTURAL GROUPS.
HAVE ANY IMPACTS ON RECIDIVISM
BUT YET WE KNOW HONORING THAT
SHARED HISTORY AND TRADITION
GIVES PEOPLE A SENSE OF
BELONGING THAT GOES DEEPER THAN
ANY GANG AFFILIATION.
WE FIND NO RESEARCH THAT GOING
TO CHURCH REDUCES RECIDIVISM.
AND YET WE KNOW THAT FAITH
CREATES A STRONGER MORAL CODE
THAT ANY LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
COULD ENFORCE.
I DO WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SOARING CALDERON.
AND THIS COMMITTEE. FOR REQUEST
IN THIS AUDIT BECAUSE IT IS
GIVING ME A FORM TO DISCUSS A
MORE PROFOUND.
PHILOSOPHICAL SHIP IN
REHABILITATION BUT IT ALSO HAS
MADE IMPORTANT TO TO EXPLAIN HOW
WE HOW WE ANALYZED FOR THE
METRICS HOW WE IMPROVE HOW WE
AUDIT HOW WE HOLD EACH OTHER
ACCOUNTABLE HOW WE HOLD
OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE. TO THE
FUNDS THAT ARE GIVEN TO US BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND THAT'S WERE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR RANTS WHOSE IS
GONNA TAKE YOU LET A LITTLE BIT
MORE.
ON THE FINDINGS OF THE AUDIT BUT
ALSO SOME OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WE'VE ALREADY PUT IN PLACE
SINCE UP ON IT.
WAS -- CONDUCTED.
I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT THE OUT
OF FOCUS MAINLY ON DATA GATHERED
FROM TWENTY FOURTEEN AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND THE RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE CONSISTENT WITH EFFORTS
ALREADY UNDERWAY WITHIN DIVISION
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS.
AND MY REMAINING TIME I WOULD
LIKE TO TELL YOU THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS CHANGED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN WITH THAT DATA.
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN WHICH I
SPOKE OF BRIEFLY.
DEPART WITHIN PROPOSITION.
FIFTY SEVEN THE DEPARTMENT HAS
AWARDED FOUR POINT EIGHT MILLION
CREDITS TO THE INMATES AT A
PARTICIPATED IN THESE PROGRAMS
I'M GONNA BREAK DOWN WHAT THAT
MEANS IN PRISON YEARS EARNED SO
IN MISSING GET OUT SOONER.
AND I AGREE THAT WE KNEW WE DO
NEED TO ATTACH AN ANALYTIC ON TO
THOSE NUMBERS ON HOW MUCH YOU'VE
SAVED JUST BASED.
ON THAT.
ON THE EDUCATION MERIT CREDITS
IN MISS PARTICIPATED AND AND
EDUCATION PROGRAMS FOR THE
ACHIEVE CERTIFICATES DIPLOMAS.
THEY HAVE EARNED NINE THOUSAND
FORTY ONE AWARD AND THAT EQUATES
TO TWO THOUSAND FORTY ONE YEARS
OFFER PRISON SENTENCES.
MILESTONE CREDITS WHICH ARE ALSO
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS THEY'VE
BEEN AWARDED 200-190-00100 AND
FIFTY AWARDS AND THAT EQUATES
290-007-0090 FIVE YEARS OFF OF
PRISON SENTENCES.
AND THE REAR BILL HEAD OF
ACHIEVEMENT CREDITS IN THOSE ARE
IN ESSENCE OUR TRADITIONAL SELF
HELP SOME OF THE PROGRAMS THAT
WE THAT WE TEND TO LABEL MAYBE
NON EVIDENCE BASE BUT WE KNOW
THEY'RE GOOD FOR THE POPULATION --
THEY HAVE BEEN AWARDED FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED NINE AWARDS
AND THAT EQUATES TO NINE HUNDRED
NINETY YEARS OFF A PRISON
SENTENCES.
OFFENDERS RELEASED FROM THE DATA
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN WAS
ENACTED.
ON AN AVERAGE OF HAD THEIR
SENTENCES SHORTENED BY ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS AND THAT
THEY'RE NOT GIVEN ANYTHING.
WE DON'T GIVE THESE INMATES
ANYTHING JUST BECAUSE THEY SHOW
UP.
THEY HAVE TO EARN THEM.
WE OVERSEE THEM WE MAKE SURE
THEIR PRESENT.
AND BUT WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT
NOT EVERYONE YOU CAN'T RECEIVE A
CERTIFICATE FOR ON WHAT.
HOW AN INDIVIDUAL CHANGES THEIR
MIND SET FOR THEIR APTITUDE IS
HOW THEY COMPORT THEMSELVES
DIFFERENTLY?
AND THAT IN ITSELF BEGINS WITHIN
THOSE PRISONERS BY TAKING THESE
PROGRAMS I HAVE WITNESSED IT.
I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT THE LIFE OF
POPULATION FOR A MINUTE.
WHEN I WAS AN OFFICER AND
INDETERMINATE SENSE LIVE FOR AND
MET WITH THE POSSIBILITY OF
PAROLE SAY FIFTEEN TO LIFE?
WHEN I WAS A CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER AND EVEN THE CAPTAIN
EVEN EVEN TO THE POINT WHEN I
WAS A WARDEN AT S. A. T. F.?
THAT SENTENCE IN ESSENCE MEANT
LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE.
PAROLE DATES WERE GIVEN AND THAT
WAS VERY DISCOURAGING.
AND THAT WAS AT A TIME WHEN THE
RECESSION HIT.
PROGRAMS WERE CUT.
PEOPLE THOUGHT DIFFERENTLY ABOUT
THE INCARCERATED AND IT WAS
REALLY HARD FOR ME AS PRISON
ADMINISTRATIVE GOING TELL THE
POPULATION STAYING COURAGE
PARTICIPATING PROGRAM.
BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T GETTING
DATES.
SINCE 200-014-3000 LIFERS HAVE
BEEN RELEASED INTO THE COMMUNITY
WITH ONLY THREE POINT ONE
RECIDIVISM RATE.
AND I THINK THAT NUMBER ITSELF
DEMONSTRATE TO THE OTHER
POPULATION THAT IF YOU
PARTICIPATE IN THESE PROGRAMS
THE FULL BREADTH OF THEM.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT IT IS THAT
HOPE IS THERE AND I CAN'T
EXPRESS HOW MUCH HOPE IS
IMPORTANT IN THESE PRISON
SYSTEMS NOT ONLY TO THE INMATES.
BUT TO THE STAFF TO FACILITATE
THESE PROGRAMS.
ADDITIONALLY MYSELF FROM THE
SECRETARY BEFORE ME HAVE BEEN
EXERCISING AUTHORITY VESTED IN
THIS IN STATUTE UNDER PENAL CODE
ELEVEN SEVENTY D. WHICH THERE IS
A PROGRAMMING COMPONENT TO THIS.
AND THAT -- THIS ELEVEN SEVENTY
HAS EXISTED FOR MANY YEARS BUT
WE RARELY USED IT.
AND WHAT THAT DOES IT GIVE THE
AUTHORITY FOR THE SECRETARY
CORRECTIONS TRUST JUDGES TO
REVIEW SENTENCES FOR
DISCREPANCIES THAT INMATES FOR
EXCEPTIONAL CONDUCT.
OVER NINE HUNDRED LETTERS HAVE
BEEN MAILED TO THE COURTS SINCE
WE STARTED UTILIZING THIS.
WE PROVIDE JUDGES WITH
INFORMATION REGARDING THE
PROGRAMS IN MESA PARTICIPATED IN.
BUT THEY HAVE RECEIVED IN THE
BENEFITS OF STAFF HAVE WITNESSED
BECAUSE THEY PARTICIPATED IN
THESE PROGRAMS.
WE NOW SPEAK TO THEIR
DISCIPLINARY HISTORY THEIR DRUG
FREE HISTORY -- AND THE JUDGES
HAVE THE ABILITY TO CHOOSE
WHETHER TO RE SENTENCE OR NOT.
CALIFORNIA JUDGES HAVE REDUCED
SENTENCES IN OVER THREE HUNDRED
CASES BY A COMMUNITY OF TOTAL OF
NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN YEARS.
AND THAT'S DIRECTLY RELATED TO
THE REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE BEING UTILIZED FACILITATED
BY THE INSTITUTIONS FIVE LIFERS
HAVE BEEN RE SENTENCED BY THE
COURTS FOR THIS EXCEPTIONAL
CONDUCT.
THE RECIDIVISM RATE FOR INMATES
BEING RELEASED FROM CDC YEAR NOW
IS FORTY SIX POINT 1%.
THAT'S FIVE POINT FOUR PER
PERCENT LOWER THAN IT WAS IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN AT THE MAX
OVERCROWDING IN EIGHT POINT 2%
LOWER THAN IT IS PEAK IN.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN WELL THE
RESEARCHER RAISE THEM IS NOT
CHANGED IT HASN'T CHANGED IN THE
LAST YEAR I WANT TO POINT OUT IT
I THINK IT'S ALREADY BEEN
DISCUSSED HERE -- IN THE PRIOR
PANEL.
THAT -- THAT'S BEEN STABLE EVEN
THOUGH THE OFFENDERS -- THAT ARE
IN PRISON NOW ARE ARE SERIOUS
ABOUT AN OFFENDER'S.
AND I WOULD THINK THAT.
YOU KNOW YOU WOULD THINK THAT
THOSE NUMBERS WILL BE GOING UP.
BUT THE REMAINING STABLE AND
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO FUTURE
RECIDIVISM NUMBER SO WITH.
THAT WE WOULD GO DOWN.
WE HOUSE INMATES -- DIFFERENTLY
THAN WE DID IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN A DECADE
AGO ONLY A QUARTER OF OUR
POPULATION WAS HOUSING OR MOST.
PROGRAMMING FACILITIES ARE LOWER
LEVELS ONLY A QUARTER OF THEM
BECAUSE WE WERE THINKING
DIFFERENTLY WE DIDN'T THINK THAT --
IT MAKES COULD -- BEHAVE IN A
WAY THAT THEY WILL TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THESE PROGRAMS BUT
WE HAVE OVER A THIRD OF OUR
POPULATION HOUSE AND OUR LEVEL
TO LOWER LEVEL FACILITY SO NOW
THESE POPULATIONS A THIRD OF
THEM.
ARE PARTICIPATED IN ROBUST
PROGRAMMING AND THE POPULATION
IS EXPECTED TO GROW IN COMING
YEARS.
FURTHER MORE IN MY POPULATION --
IN OUR SHOE UNITS HAS PLUMMETED
ALSO.
WE USED TO HOUSE INMATES I THINK
WE OVER UTILIZED ISSUE.
AT ONE TIME WERE AT ABOUT.
FOUR THOUSAND INMATES ISSUE IN
THE TERM REALLY JUST BECAUSE OF
GANG STATUS AND NOW WE HAVE
LISTED EIGHT HUNDRED BECAUSE WE
NOW ARE UTILIZING SOME OF THOSE
SAME FACILITIES WHERE WE HOUSE
SHOE INMATES. TO FACILITATE AT
PELICAN BAY SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS I'M TALKING ABOUT.
WE ARE THINKING DIFFERENTLY WE
ARE BEING INNOVATIVE WE'RE DOING
A COATING PROGRAM AT PELICAN BAY
WE RECENTLY HAD A GRADUATION.
SO AGAIN EVEN OUR POPULATION IS
ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY SERIOUS
COMBINED OFFENDERS.
THE DEPARTMENT IS PROUD TO SAY
WE'RE HOUSING AS MANY OFFENDERS
AS WE CAN AT LOWER LEVELS.
AT A RELATED -- AND RELATED AND
THAT -- THESE MASSIVE CHANGES IN
HOUSING CLASSIFICATION ACCESS TO
JOBS AND PROGRAMS WE REALLY ICE
WE REALLY CAN'T ISOLATE THE
AFFECTS OF HOW WE'RE ABLE TO DO
THIS SUCCESSFULLY ON ONE PROGRAM
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMMING.
IT'S IT'S IT'S JUST A BREATH OF
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE OUT THERE
THAT WE SEE THE SUCCESS THAT
WE'RE WITNESSING INSIDE PRISON.
THE AUDITOR DID PUT OUT A REPORT
THAT IS VERY CRITICAL ON HOW WE
ARE NOT -- BEING AS BEING AS
ACCOUNTABLE TO THIS COMMITTEE
INTO THE LEGISLATURE OF THE
FUNDING GIVEN TO US.
AND MR SHOES IT IS GOING TO
ILLUSTRATE AND TALK ABOUT WHAT
WE ARE DOING.
BUT I CAN SAY IF ANY OF THOSE
OVERSIGHT THROUGH THE AUDIT
WHICH WE DID TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY
IT WASN'T THE FACT THAT.
WE WE DIDN'T CARE THAT WE
THOUGHT WE COULD JUST DO IT AND
WE ARE NOT JUST THE STATUS QUO
DEPARTMENT OF THE PAST WHAT WE
SAY.
IF IT WORK FIVE YEARS AGO MUST
WORK TODAY WE'RE NOT THAT AGENCY.
I'VE HEARD SOME COMMENTS HERE
AND I APPRECIATE THEM AND I TAKE
THEM TO HEART WE ARE A DIFFERENT
AGENCY THAN WE WERE TEN FIFTEEN
AND TWENTY YEARS AGO.
SO JUST A FEW QUICK STATS AND
I'M GONNA IN REAL QUICK. TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND OFFENDERS ARNOLD
AN ACADEMIC PROGRAMMING.
WE HAVE OVER FIVE THOUSAND
INMATES IN FACE TO FACE COLLEGE
PROGRAMS IN PRISON IN OUR THIRTY
FIVE INSTITUTIONS.
WE NOW OFFER TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED REHABILITATIVE
ACHIEVEMENT THESE ARE SELF HELP
TYPE PROGRAMS IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND WE'RE GOING TO
BE GROWING THEM.
I WANT TO END WITH THE STORY
THOUGH.
IT WASN'T THAT LONG AGO IT'S
PROBABLY LESS THAN SIX MONTHS
AGO I WAS AT A GRADUATION THE LA
TRADE TECH IN LOS ANGELES FOR A
SECOND CHANCE TRADES GRADUATION.
AND THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT IS
THE PRISON TO EMPLOYMENT --
PRISON TO APPOINTMENT CONNECTION
THAT WAS SPOKE OF IN THE PRIOR
PANEL THAT DOES EXIST IN THE
AGENCY.
THE INDIVIDUAL I SPOKE TO WAS A
PART OF THIS PROGRAM.
HE WAS ABLE TO UTILIZE THE
CERTIFICATES THAT HE ACHIEVED IN
PRISON. TO GET A JOB AND
GRADUATE L. L. A. TREY TAKEN NOW
HE'S HELPING BUILD THE LA RAMS
STADIUM.
AT THIS GRADUATION OF THE
KEYNOTE SPEAKER THIS YOUNG MAN
CAME TO ME AND HE SAID MISTER DE
AS I DON'T KNOW IF YOU REMEMBER
ME.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE THE WARDEN AT S.
A. T. F. YOU SENT ME TO SHOE FOR
DEALING DRUGS.
AND I THOUGHT WELL I DON'T KNOW
HOW THIS IS GOING TO GO SO I'LL
JUST I'LL HEAR YOU OUT.
WELL THE YOUNG MAN WAS VERY
POSITIVE HE SAID YOU KNOW MISTER
DE IS THAT THAT COMMITTEE YOU
SAID SOMETHING TO ME.
THEY CARRIED ME UNDER THE SHOE
AND BROUGHT ME RIGHT WHERE I AM
TODAY HE TOLD ME YOU'RE BETTER
THAN THIS.
YOU'RE BETTER THAN WHAT I'M
READING IN THIS FILE.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT'S THE
DEPARTMENT WE ARE TRYING TO BE
AND IF I WOULD ASSOCIATE AND SAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S THE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT WAS OUR EVIDENCE
BASED.
ANYTHING EVIDENCE BASED BY WHAT
I TOLD THIS INDIVIDUAL ON THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE SENT THEM.
TO I CAN TELL YOU I I CAN'T PUT
A NUMBER ON IT BUT I CAN TELL
YOU I DID MEET HIS MOTHER.
AMID HIS WIFE AND I MET HIS
CHILD.
AND FOR ME IF WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO BREAK THE CHAIN OF
ACCULTURATION BY THESE PROGRAMS
TO ME THAT'S THE ULTIMATE GOAL
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW TO PUT A
NUMBER OF BREAKING THE CHAIN OF
ACCULTURATION.
IN THE FAMILY OR COMMUNITY AND
THAT IS OUR GOAL IS AN AGENCY.
BY THE GRACE OF THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE SUPPORT OF THAT ON THE OF
OUR ADMINISTRATION ARE RE HAVE
BUDGET AN OPERATION WE WE ARE
REALLY BEING MADE WHOLE.
THE BEGINNING OF TWENTY FIFTEEN
AND I SPOKE ABOUT THE RECESSION
IN THE PROGRAMS WERE CUT WE WERE
MADE HOLDEN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN WE BROUGHT THINGS
UP REALLY FAST AT THAT TIME.
AND IN THE AFTERMATH WE
ABSOLUTELY HADTO CLEAN UP TO DO
AS POINTED OUT IN THE AUDIT.
A JUST AS A STATE HONOR
DESCRIBED AND I APPRECIATE THE
AUDIT I DO BELIEVE IN WHAT I
SAID AND EARLIER OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF REHABILITATION.
AND WHAT IT TAKES TO HEAL MEN
AND WOMEN NOT INMATES
[inaudible]
PEOPLE.
WE'RE ON THE VERGE OF A MAJOR
PHILOSOPHICAL SHIFT IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I'D LIKE YOUR FORBEARANCE TO
SEE US THROUGH IT.
I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
QUESTIONS THAT THAT -- AND I'M
I'M I I WISH THE OTHER -- PANEL
MEMBERS WERE TO STAY THE THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS LOGISTICS I DO
BELIEVE SOME OF THE RESPONSES
WERE GONNA SEVE -- HERE AT THE
DIRECTION THAT I GAVE THE
DIVISION OF REAL BITS AT A
PROGRAM ONCE IT OUGHT TO CAME
OUT WE NEED ANSWERS YOU NEEDED
ANSWERS.
SENATE TURNED OVER TO OUR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR TO TALK ABOUT THE CAP
TO SPEAK TO THE DIRECTION I GAVE
AND WHAT WE ARE.
WITH THE AUDIT.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT
AWESOME QUESTIONS IT'S A GOOD
STORY THAT YOU SURE SO WAS FALL
QUESTIONS OF THE LOS PLEASE MR
SAYS.
GOOD AFTERNOON TERRY MEMBERS --
ONCE AGAIN MY NAME'S RYAN SEES
ON THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DIVISION OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS.
I WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TAKE SOME
ADDITIONAL TIME TO DISCUSS OUR
REHABILITATE ABOUT IT.
THE FINDINGS THAT SOME OF THE
WORK THAT IS CURRENTLY UNDER WAY
WITHIN THE DIVISION.
I'M AS NOTED IN THE AUDIT
RESPONSES CDC ARE GENERALLY
AGREES WITH THE FINDINGS --
REGARDING ADMINISTRATIVE
PRACTICES -- WHICH ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE WORK THAT
WE'VE ALREADY BEGUN -- IN LATE.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE IN
TERMS OF THE AUDIT FINDINGS
NOTHING WAS A SURPRISE TO THE D.
R. P. ADMINISTRATION.
IN LATE -- TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WE STARTED AS THE DOWN
INTO A FACT FINDING DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE PROGRAMS THAT HAD
SUBSTANTIALLY ROLLED OUT.
WE FULLY UNDERSTOOD AND
APPRECIATED OUR RESPONSIBILITY
TO IMPLEMENT PROGRAMMING TO
ENHANCE THE PRISON ENVIRONMENT
IMPACT PUBLIC SAFETY AND BE
TRANSPARENT AND NOT WORK -- I
WILL TAKE A COUPLE MINUTES TO
JUST DISCUSS EACH OF THEM I'M
AND AND THEN BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AFTERWARDS.
AGAIN IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WE SAT DOWN AS A GROUP WE
STARTED A FACT FINDING MISSION
TO SAY WHAT ARE ALL THE REASONS
THAT -- ADMINISTRATIVELY THESE
PROGRAMS WOULD NOT BE AS
EFFECTIVE AS THEY SHOULD BE OR
WHEN WE GO TO DO FUTURE RESEARCH
WHERE THERE WOULD BE -- LACKING
OUTCOMES BECAUSE OF CERTAIN
VARIABLES THAT IMPACT ABOUT
RESEARCH WE SAT DOWN AND REALLY
WALK THROUGH EACH OF THOSE
THINGS THAT OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS WE REALLY DISCUSSED THOSE
THINGS -- AND WORKED ON
SOLIDIFYING IN WHICH IS GOING TO
BE A REPRESENTED IN THE AUDIT
FINDINGS AND AND IS WHY WE ARE
ABLE TO DO IT.
AND A SUCH A SHORT TIME.
SO IN THE FIRST TWO FISCAL YEARS
WE BEGIN WORK WITH THAT P.
RESULTS FIRST CLEARING HOUSE
THAT WORK REALLY GAVE US INSIGHT
INTO THE BROAD CURRICULA THAT
WAS.
ON THE REPRESENTED IN OUR
CORRECTIONAL EXCUSE ME IN OUR
PROGRAMS -- WE CATEGORIZE THAT
WE REVIEWED IT WITH THE RESULTS
FIRST CURRICULUM IT WAS RELATED
TO OUR TREATMENT PROGRAMS ARE
COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL TREATMENT
WHICH WAS REVIEWED BY THE
AUDITOR.
THAT GAVE THE R. P. THE ABILITY
TO UNDERSTANDING CATEGORIES HOW
TO WORK WITH RESULTS FIRST TO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACTS OF THE
RESULTS FIRST CLEARING HOUSE
THAT IS EVIDENCE BASED ON
RESEARCH TO NOT CLEARING HOUSE.
AND HE GAVE US THE ABILITY TO
FOCUS ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
CURRICULA COLOR COLLECTION AND
CASE MANAGEMENT.
AND SO.
THROUGH THAT EFFORT WE INITIALLY
SAID OKAY THERE ARE -- BASICALLY
WHAT WAS REPRESENTED THE AUDIT
ABOUT 20% OF OUR CURRICULUM
WHICH HAS NOT BEEN -- EVIDENCE
BASED AND RESEARCHED AND IS
CONTAINED WITHIN THE FEW RESULTS
FIRST CLEARING HOUSE NOW IT
MIGHT BE EVIDENCE BASED IT HAS
BEEN AROUND FOR DECADES IN SOME
CASES BUT NIGHT MIGHT NOT HAVE
JUST BEEN ANY EVIDENCE BASED
RESEARCH WITHIN CLEARING -- THE
RESULTS FIRST CLEARING HOUSE SO
WE SAID LET'S FOCUS ON DATA
COLLECTION AN EXTRACTION NOW
THAT WE'VE GOTTEN THAT FIGURE
BECAUSE THAT IS ONE OF THE MAIN
THINGS I THINK THE DEPARTMENT
HAS ALWAYS HISTORICALLY
STRUGGLED WITH.
IS REALLY SAYING THAT WE HAVE
THE DATA AVAILABLE.
WE FINALIZE THE CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM THAT WAS RELATED TO
TREATMENT IN THE LAST TWO YEARS --
ROLLED OUT ROBUSTLY AND NOT
ALLOWED US TO GET INSIGHT INTO
TREATMENT PLANS CASE NOTES --
ENROLLMENT WITHIN OUR TREATMENT
PROGRAMS TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
THE IMPACT THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
WHEN WE LOOK AT ACCOUNTABILITY
INFIDELITY IN THE FUTURE -- THAT
CASE MANAGEMENT PLAN COMBINED
WITH OUR TEAM SITTING DOWN AND
DEVELOPING OR CREATING HUNDREDS
OF COUNTING RULES AND BUSINESS
RULES RELATED TO OUR STRATEGIC
OFFENDER MANAGEMENT SYSTEM.
REALLY COLLECTS AT THIS POINT
MILLIONS OF INMATE LEVEL DATA
POINTS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO US
FOR FUTURE OUTCOME EVALUATIONS
OUTPUT EVALUATIONS AND CONSTANT
OPERATIONAL MONITORING.
DON'T THE STAR THIRD THING WE
REALLY FOCUSED ON WAS --
PRIORITIZE PLACEMENT.
THAT'S MENTIONED IN THE AUDIT
REPORT A NUMBER OF TIMES RELATED
TO THE WAIT LIST OR AN ACCURATE
PLACEMENT PROGRAMS WE RECOGNIZE
THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT OUR
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS.
THEY HAD AN ARCHAIC PERSPECTIVE
IN TERMS OF PLACING PEOPLE THEY
WERE VALUABLE WHEN THEY WERE
CREATED BUT WHAT IT TOOK WAS AN
INDIVIDUAL ANALYSIS OF OFTEN ARE
IN ME TO SIGN IN OFFICE. TO SAY
WHO WAS PRIORITIZE BASED ON
MEMORANDUMS THAT WE HAD SUBMIT
OUR WITH THAT WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED IN TERMS OF POLICY
THAT IS IMPOSSIBLE IN A SYSTEM
THIS LARGE AND COMPLEX.
SO IN LATE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN LONG BEFORE THE AUDIT
WE BEGAN WORK WITH OUR STRATEGIC
OFFENDER MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
UPDATE THE BACK END OF THE
SYSTEM IN THOSE WAIT LIST SO
THAT WE ARE PRIORITIZING PEOPLE
IN THE RIGHT MANNER.
CONSISTENT WITH THE POLICIES
THAT WE PUT IN PLACE -- AND TO
RELY ON TECHNOLOGY SO THAT WE
CAN START NOT ONLY RELYING ON
TECHNOLOGY BUT MAKE DATA DRIVEN
DECISIONS BASED ON THAT
TECHNOLOGY.
SO WE ISSUED IN THAT TERM --
CLEAR POLICY DIRECTIVES -- IN
LATE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
FOCUSING ON THOSE RISKS TO RE
OFFEND AND THOSE CRIMINAL GENIC
NEEDS -- AGAIN POLICY DIRECTIVES
ARE ARE NOT IDEAL BECAUSE THEY
DO NOT RELY ON THE TECHNOLOGY
AND THAT'S WHEN WE BEGIN THAT
WORK WITH THE TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS --
THAT TECHNOLOGY SYSTEM THE WAIT
LIST -- AS MENTIONED BY THE SEA
OTTER AND IN PREVIOUS HEARINGS
WENT INTO EFFECT THIS WEEK AND
THAT CREATES AN AUTOMATED
PRIORITIZATION FOR AWAY THE SO
WE EXPECT TO SEE SUBSTANTIAL
GROWTH.
IN THE PLACING THE RIGHT IN MADE
IN THE RIGHT PROGRAM AT THE
RIGHT TIME -- THAT WILL HELP
LEVERAGE ALL OF THE STUFF THAT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON AND MAKING
SURE THAT IT'S MOVING FORWARD.
WE ALSO IN THIS PROCESS IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS -- DEVELOPED TO
DATA ANALYTICS TOOLS FOR
OPERATIONAL USE THOSE DATA
ANALYTICS TOOLS CAN MONITOR
PEOPLE BOTH IN PROGRAMMING TO
ENSURE THAT THEY'RE THE RIGHT
PERSON IN THE RIGHT PROGRAM.
AND THEY'RE AVAILABLE TO OUR
CORRECTIONAL COUNSELORS IN THE
FIELD AND WILL BE AVAILABLE IN
THE NEAR FUTURE TO PRINCIPLES
AND EVERYONE ELSE THAT HAS AND
ONCE ACCESS TO THAT INFORMATION
SO THAT THEY CAN.
ON THE FLY IN REAL TIME SEE HOW
THEY'RE INTERACTING WITH THEIR
POPULATIONS AND MAKE SURE AGAIN
THAT THEY HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY TO
HELP THEM SO THEY'RE NOT
INDIVIDUALLY PULLING PEOPLE UP
AND SEEING IF THERE PRIORITIZE
FOR PROGRAMMING.
AGAIN -- THOSE TWO DATA
ANALYTICS TOOLS HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED IN THE LAST TWO YEARS --
AND THEN WE ALSO -- ARE AROUND
PERFORMANCE ACCOUNTABILITY
INFIDELITY WAS A HEAVY TOPIC IN
THE AUDIT ABOUT ADMINISTRATIVE
PRACTICES WE RECOGNIZED IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THAT IF YOU
DO NOT HAVE THE PROPER
ADMINISTRATIVE STRUCTURES AND
SITE.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
MEASURE IT AND IT OFTEN IMPACTS
RECIDIVISM ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO FIDELITY.
WE BEGAN WORK -- I STATED IN THE
AUDIT -- IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IRVINE
TO CREATE TWO TOOLS THOSE TOOLS
ARE OUR PROGRAM ACCOUNTABILITY
REVIEW TOOL -- WHICH ESSENTIALLY
MONITORS CONTRACT COMPLIANCE --
AT THE VERY MINUTE LEVEL THAT IS
ONLY ABLE TO BE ACCOMPLISHED
BECAUSE OF THE CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM WE ARE ALSO ROLLING OUT
AT THE SAME TIME AND OUR DATA
COLLECTION EFFORTS SO WE KNOW
THAT THESE -- ITEMS ARE ALL
INTERTWINED AND ARE PART OF THE
SUCCESS IN THE FUTURE -- THAT WE
PLAN ON DISPLAYING.
THAT PROGRAM ACCOUNTABILITY TOLD
WAS FINALIZED IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND WE
DID STAFF TRANING -- AND SOME
PILOTING FOR THE FIRST COUPLE OF
MONTHS AND THAT'S WHAT WAS
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTED IN JANUARY
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WE ARE
DOING STATEWIDE ASSESSMENTS ON
PROGRAM ACCOUNTABILITY AT THIS
POINT -- AND WE PLAN ON DOING
TWO TO THREE OF THOSE
ASSESSMENTS EACH YEAR SO WE HAVE
MEASURABLE MARKERS FOR FUTURE
RESEARCH.
IN ADDITION TO THAT WE HAD
DEVELOPED WITH UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IRVINE -- PROGRAM
FIDELITY MARKERS AND TOOLS AND
REPORTS AND THAT IS AGAIN A
PRODUCT OF OUR DATA COLLECTION
EFFORTS IN OUR CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM THAT WE ROLLED OUT --
CONCURRENTLY.
THOSE FIDELITY MEASURES ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO THE
SUCCESS OF PROGRAMMING IF THE
THERE'S NO EFFICACY TO THE
PROGRAM IT'S NOT BEING INTENDED --
IT'S NOT BEING IMPLEMENTED AS IT
WAS INTENDED WE KNOW THAT THERE
ARE JUST BEAR IMPACTS AND
ULTIMATELY AFFECTS ON RECIDIVISM.
SO ALL OF THOSE THINGS REALLY
ADDRESS A LOT OF WHAT THE
AUDITOR -- RECKON -- RECOMMENDS
AND THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
RESPONSES WE'VE DEVELOPED
ADDITIONALLY WE'VE DEVELOPED
WEEKLY BASED ON THOSE DATA
POINTS AND A CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM WE DEVELOPED A WEEKLY
OPERATIONAL REPORTS SO THAT WE
CAN MAKE REAL TIME DECISIONS ON
PLACES WHERE THERE'S LACKING
ENROLLMENT.
OR LOWER CAPACITY WE HAVE
MONTHLY OPERATIONAL REPORTS THAT
WE NOW SEND OUT -- AND THAT HAVE
DEVELOPED THAT DEAL WITH --
ATTENDANCE -- COULD PERCENTAGES
WE NEED TO WE HAVE GOALS AND
MARKERS RELATED COMPLETIONS
GOALS AND MARKERS RELATED TO
ENROLLMENT ALL OF THOSE THINGS
ARE DEVELOPED IN IN PLACE AND
HAVE BEEN IN PLACE.
NOW FOR A YEAR THE AUDITOR --
HAD MENTIONED THAT WE HAD NOT
FORMALLY DEVELOPED --
PERFORMANCE MEASURES AND WE HAVE --
IN TERMS OF ATTENDANCE
COMPLETIONS ENROLLMENTS THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS ARE NOW IN OUR
MONTHLY REPORTS AND THEY HAVE
BEEN INFORMALLY WELL WE HAVEN'T
DEVELOPED IN WHAT WE PLAN ON
DEVELOPING WITH RESEARCH IS
REALLY MAKING THOSE DATA DRIVEN
DECISIONS.
ON RECIDIVISM REDUCTIONS THAT'S
SOMETHING I THINK WE STILL HAVE
TO WORK ON TO MAKE SURE THAT
WERE APPROPRIATELY FINING THOSE
MARKERS -- AND THEN FINALLY THE
RESEARCH IT'S A BIG TOPIC WE
KNEW WE WANTED TO IMPLEMENT ALL
OF THESE THINGS BECAUSE OUR FEAR
WAS HIRING A RESEARCHER HAVING
ENOUGH QUANTITY WHICH NEEDED
ENOUGH LONGITUDINAL DATA AFTER
THE ROLL OUT OF THE ARE PEOPLE
COMING.
AND THEN HAVING THAT RESEARCHER
COME BACK AND SAY WELL YOU
SHOULD HAVE BEEN COLLECTING THIS
OR YOU REALLY IT MIGHT BE
RELATED TO THE FIDELITY AND I
REALLY TO BE RELATED TO THE
CONTRACT ACCOUNTABILITY.
SO ALL OF THESE PIECES COME
TOGETHER TO SAY AS WE HAVE
ENOUGH LONGITUDINAL DATA WHICH
IS STILL LIMITED AT THIS POINT
WE BELIEVE THAT OUR RESEARCH
UPON WILL HAVE EVERYTHING THEY
NEED TO MAKE REALLY RELEVANT
DECISIONS.
ON PROGRAMMING AND ITS SUCCESS --
SO THAT'S A IN GENERAL -- THE
STUFF THAT WE REALLY FOCUSED ON
I DID WANT TO GO BACK AND JUST
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
LONGITUDINAL DATA WHICH OFTEN
COMES UP -- SECRETARY TIAS
MENTIONED IT AND IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
HIS MERE BLUEPRINT WHICH WAS TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE THIRTEEN TO THE
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN WE HAD I HAD A
BASE LEVEL OF OUR PROGRAMS IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN WE
EXPANDED TO TEN ADDITIONAL
INSTITUTIONS FOR SUBSTANCE USE.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN WE EXPANDED ALL OF OUR
C. B. T. PROGRAM SO THE
REMAINING INSTITUTIONS THAT WERE
NOT INCLUDED IN BROUGH BLUEPRINT.
AND EXPANDED C. B. T. AT ALL OF
OUR PROGRAM SO IN THAT SHORT
TIME PERIOD WE COMPLETELY ARE.
YOU KNOW ROLLED OUT A MASSIVE --
PROGRAM FOR D. R. P. RELATED TO
C. B. T. TREATMENT SO SOME OF
THAT COMPONENT IS REALLY WAITING
FOR THE LONGITUDINAL DATA TO
MAKE SURE THAT RESEARCHERS HAVE
THAT THE CAPACITY. TO MEASURE
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN SO -- FEW
FISCAL YEAR SINCE THE ROLLOUT.
AND SO THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE DONE IN TERMS OF REALLY
PUTTING IN PROCESSES IN PLACE
THE RISK IN NEEDS TOOLS THAT THE
AUDITOR MENTIONEDARE ABSOLUTELY
RELEVANT TO OUR PLACE AND
PROGRAMS WE IDENTIFIED BATHROOM
SECRETARY D. AS A NUMBER OF
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
DEPARTMENT.
THAT ARE CURRENTLY HAVING A WORK
GROUP AS THEY REFERENCE AND
THEY'RE COMING BACK WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS ON WHAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING FOR THOSE RISK
ANY TOOLS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE PUTTING IN PLACE.
THE SAME THING WITH -- THE SPACE
SURVEY AND CONTRACTS FOR
RESEARCH WE ARE ACTIVELY AND
AGGRESSIVELY ENGAGING ON THESE
THE SPACE SURVEYS WE ARE KIND OF
CURRENTLY CONDUCTING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE DOING IT
CORRECTLY.
PART OF WHAT WE WANTED TO AVOID
IN TERMS OF A SPACE SURVEY IS D.
R. P. ACTING IN A SILO WHEN
THERE'S OTHER DIVISIONAL THINGS
HAPPENING AND GOING OUT AND
ATTEMPTING TO SAY WE HAVE A
DEFICIT IN SPACE WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS.
AS A DEPARTMENT REALLY GETTING
TOGETHER AND SAYING WE ALL NEED
TO BE GOING OUT HERE WE ALL NEED
TO BE ASSESSING THIS TOGETHER SO
THAT WE ARE NOT HAVING A SHOVING
MATCH ON WHO SHOULD BE WHERE.
AND SO THAT'S ACTIVELY HAPPENING
AT THIS POINT.
AND WE'RE BEGINNING TO DEVELOP A
PLAN OF ACTION ON HOW TO GET OUT
THERE WE DO EXPECT THAT TO TAKE
SOME TIME BECAUSE IT IS THE VERY
LOCAL LEVEL THERE ARE THOUSANDS
OF PROGRAMS WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
OUR ACCOUNTED.
FOR BUT THAT IS BEGINNING AND
THEN THE LAST THING.
BUT I JUST WANTED TO MENTION WAS --
THAT THE RESEARCH CONTRACTING
POINTS WE HAVE BEEN HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH RESEARCHERS
BUT WE DIDN'T WANT ENGAGE THEM
TOO EARLY BECAUSE GETTING INTO A
CONTRACT BEFORE THEY CAN
ACTUALLY ACCOMPLISH THE RESEARCH
WAS NOT WHAT WERE OUR INTENTION --
WHAT WE DO WANT TO WORK WITH
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE AUDITOR'S
AN ABSOLUTELY SUBMIT ANY SCOPES
OF WORK AND WE THINK THAT THE
SCOPES OF WORK WILL GENERALLY BE
DRAFTED -- LONG BEFORE OUR APRIL
TIMELINE THAT WE HAD REFERENCE
IN TERMS OF THE CONTRACT
EXECUTION SO WE'RE HAPPY TO
SHARE ANY OF THAT INFORMATION
AGAIN SOMETHING THAT I PRIDE
MYSELF IN.
IS REALLY ATTEMPTING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE BEING
TRANSPARENT AND I'M HAPPY TO
HELP -- AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THE AUDITOR UPDATES WITH
ALL OF THOSE THINGS THAT WILL BE
DOING.
THAT THE LAST THING IS --
SOMETHING THAT EVERYONE HAS
TALKED ABOUT A BIT TODAY WHICH I
APPRECIATE IS DEAR P. -- IN
TERMS OF OUR CONVERSATIONS WE
UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEXITIES OF
RACISM -- RECIDIVISM ANALYSIS
AND DATA LIMITATIONS AND WE
RETREAT WE THINK THERE IS NO
SILVER BULLET TO RECIDIVISM
EVERYONE MENTIONED HERE TODAY
THAT IT CREATES A LAYERED
APPROACH WE MUST EDUCATE --
INMATES WHILE THEY'RE
INCARCERATED LAYER TIME SPRINT --
SPENT IN PRISON WITHIN WITH
ACTIVITY GROUPS THAT ARE LED BY
OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS CONNECT TO OUR
TREATMENT PROGRAMS PRIOR TO
RELEASE.
CONNECT IN THE COMMUNITY REENTRY
RESOURCES AFTER RELEASE AND THEN
ULTIMATELY CREATE COLLABORATIONS
WITH THE COUNTY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S LONG TERM
SUSTAINABLE HOUSING AND
EMPLOYMENT SO ALL OF THOSE
THINGS CREATE.
THE ANALYSIS THAT WERE AIMING
FOR SO THAT WE CAN'T LOOK AT
SOMETHING -- IN A TARGET WE CAN
LOOK AT IT HOLISTICALLY THIS
EVERY MEETING THE INDIVIDUAL
NEEDS OF THESE -- INMATES AND
THEN AS WAS MENTIONED HERE TODAY
THERE THE NEEDS VASTLY ARE
VASTLY DIFFERENT.
AND WE MUST PROVIDE THIS
FOUNDATIONAL PIECES -- I I WOULD
YOU KNOW HAVE MORE TO DISCUSS ON
THE ON EVIDENCE BASED BUT I
THINK EVERYONE HERE STATED
EXACTLY WHAT I HAD ORIGINALLY
WRITTEN DOWN.
IT'S THAT -- THERE ARE CERTAIN
PROGRAMS THAT WE BELIEVE SHOULD
BE EVIDENCE BASED AND CONTAINED
WITHIN THE RESULTS FIRST
CLEARING HOUSE AND THOSE ARE
TREATMENT PROGRAMS WE THINK THAT
THE INTERVENTION OUR CURRICULUM
LEVEL THAT'S APPROPRIATE FOR A
TREATMENT PROGRAM.
BUT I'D JUST LIKE -- MISTER
JONES SAWYER NOTED WE WANNA TAKE
CAUTION AND BEING TOO EXTREME IN
THAT -- INTERPRETATION BECAUSE
IT LEAVES OUT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
WITH THE EUROPEAN THIS
DEPARTMENT THROUGH THICK AND
THIN WHEN THEY WERE YOU KNOW
NGUYEN REHABILITATION WAS TAKEN
AWAY ARE MINIMIZED -- OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WERE THERE AND I GO OUT TODAY
AND GET TO SEE THE IMPACTS OF A
PARENT READING TO A CHILD ARTS
CLASSES THAT HAVE.
DIFFERENT RACES COMING TOGETHER
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN DESCRIBING
THAT TO ME AND THOSE IMPACTS I
KNOW EXIST AND THAT'S WHERE WE
WANTED TO FIND WITH RESEARCHERS --
IT DIDN'T IT DOESN'T HAVE TO
JUST BE ABOUT -- RECIDIVISM THAT
IS THE ULTIMATE GOAL AND WE
SHOULD BE MEASURING THAT BUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL HOW ARE THEY OUTPUTTING
CHANGES RIGHT NOW HOW ARE THEY
REDUCING RIGHT UP POWER THERE
LESS VIOLENCE ON THE ARTS THOSE
ARE ALL THINGS WE BELIEVE WE CAN
MEASURE.
WE BELIEVE THAT -- THESE
PROGRAMS ARE PROVIDING
SUBSTANTIAL BENEFIT TO THE THE
POPULATION -- THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TAKE THE TIME TO
DISCUSS THESE THINGS -- I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS RELATED TO THE AUDIT
OR THINGS THAT WERE IMPLEMENTING
THAT SHOULD BE ADDRESSED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY IN ON THAT LAST POINT
I KNOW I'LL BE INTERESTED IN
HEARING WHAT THE NEXT PANEL HAS
A SAY ON SOME OF THOSE -- SOME
OF THE DISCUSSION UP HERE HAS
BEEN YOU KNOW THE DISTINCTIONS
BETWEEN ALL THE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS A CVT PROGRAMS AND THEN.
SOME OF THE OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
WE'VE ALREADY MENTIONED -- NOT
WITHSTANDING THAT AT FIRST OF
QUESTIONS I'D LIKE TO ASK JUST
KIND OF BASED OFF THE AUDITOR'S
PRESENTATION AND MAYBE WE JUST
START.
START THERE KNOWING THAT THERE'S
A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ALL THE
PROGRAMS AND HOW WE ACTUALLY
MEASURE THOSE OUTCOMES BUT LIKE
YOU SAID A CHILD.
READING TOO I MEAN -- A FORMER
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUAL EADING
TO THEIR CHILD YOU KNOW THERE BE
A METRIC THERE TO SHOW THAT THEY
DID NOT GO BACK INTO PRISON.
AS WELL AND I THINK THAT'S ONE
OF THE MAIN THINGS IS.
HOW?
HISTORICALLY HOW ARE WE MOVING
TO ACTUALLY IMPROVE THOSE
ANALYTICS YOU KNOW EARLIER WE
HAVE TALKED ABOUT -- YOU KNOW
COMPASS AND CS ARE A BUT WHAT IS
PART IT MOVING AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS SAYING YOU KNOW
THIS ISN'T SAME DEPARTMENT AS
FIVE YEARS AGO WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT THINGS DIFFERENTLY AND HOW
WE'RE DOING THAT AND SO YOU KNOW.
TO BE A LOT OF THE AUDIT IS YOU
MAY BE DOING GREAT PROGRAMS BUT
WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE ANALYTICS
OR THE DATE AND ACTUALLY BACK
THAT UP.
AND I THINK YOU'RE HEARING FOR
MEMBERS OF THE BIASES WE WANT TO
JUST MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE WORKING EFFECTIVELY
WE CONTINUE THEM IN THOSE THAT
ARE NOT.
MAYBE WE RE THINK ABOUT HOW WE
DO THAT APPROACH -- WE TO
BOLSTER UP THOSE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE.
AND SO IF YOU COULD JUST SPEAK
TO YOU KNOW GOING FROM COMPASS
AND C. C. S. R. A. AND HOW WE'RE
ACTUALLY DOING THAT -- I THINK
THAT BE BENEFICIAL FOR US.
I'LL SPEAK TO CAMPUS -- COMPASS
HAS BEEN WITH AS A PART OF OUR
ASSESSMENT TOOLS ON HOW WE'RE
GOING TO ASSIGN INMATES. TO
PROGRAMS AND WHAT WE FOUND AS WE
IMPLEMENTED IT'S IT'S NOT A
DYNAMIC TOOL.
IT IS VERY STATIC.
WHAT WE FIND IS THAT AS
INDIVIDUAL STAR PARTICIPATED IN
PROGRAMS FOR THE BE?
EDUCATION LOCATION OR
NONTRADITIONAL PROGRAMMING OR
YOUR SELF HELP GROUPS.
EVEN THOUGH WE HAD ACHIEVEMENTS
AN INDIVIDUAL GOT EDUCATED THEN
DID RECEIVE CERTIFICATES.
THERE'S NO METRIC TO CHANGE WITH
THE COMPASS AND WE NEEDED MORE
DYNAMIC ASSESSMENT -- I WANT
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
THAT NEED AND THAT'S WHY WE ARE
NOT LOOKING FOR THAT TOOL.
WE'RE LOOKING AT AT THE STATE'S
WE'RE LOOKING AT OTHER AGENCIES
ON WHAT IS THE BEST TOOL TO USE
AND WHAT IS DYNAMIC AND HOW IT
CAN BE MORE -- USEFUL AT THE ON
A YEAR BY YEAR BASIS SO THE
CORRECTIONAL COUNSELOR CAN DO
ASSESSMENTS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
INDIVIDUAL INDIVIDUAL AS A GROWN
PROGRESS IN THE REHABILITATION.
AS THEY GET CLOSER TO THEIR
PAROLE DATES AS WE GET CLOSER TO
BOARD DATES ARE THEY IN THE
RIGHT PROGRAM AND IT'S JUST --
IT IN WHAT WE FOUND IS IT THESE
ARE NOT TOOLS IN THESE ARE TOOLS
THAT ARE OFF THE SHELF THAT FIT
PERFECTLY WITH CDC ARE.
AND THE LAST WE WANT TO DO IS
GET A A TOOL OR AN ASSESSMENT
TOOL AND PLUG IT IN.
AND FIND OUT A YEAR LATER IT
DOESN'T WORK FOR US.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE TAKING THIS
CAUTIOUS APPROACH WE ARE WORKING
WITH -- VARIOUS OTHER WE'RE
LOOKING AT OTHER AGENCIES BUT
INTERNALLY WE HAVE DIVISION OF
RESEARCH A DIVISION OF AUDITING
AND COMPLIANCE AND THEY ARE IN
THIS ALSO ALONG WITH THE VISION
OF REALLY BUDGET A PROGRAM. TO
FIND THAT TOOL -- WHETHER WE
HAVE TO DEVELOP BETTER ON OUR
OWN BUILD OUR OWN OR PICK ONE
OFF THE SHELF I THINK THE MOST
IDEAL IS TO MAKE IT OFF THE
SHELF IN ITS PLUG AND PLAY.
BUT WE FIND IS IT MAY WORK FOR
THE FIRST YEAR BUT ASK
CORRECTIONS EVOLVES AND AS
PROGRAMS CHANGING AS WE SEE
GROWTH.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE ONE
IN PLACE AT ITS -- IS JUST AS
DYNAMIC AS THE DEPARTMENT IS
RIGHT NOW.
AND HAS IDENTIFIED AS A
DEPARTMENT IDENTIFIED MAYBE A
PROGRAM OFF THE SHELF OR
SOMETHING THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
HELP.
AT THOSE ANALYTICS AND DRIVE
THAT DATA.
I HAVE I HAVE A BRIEFING FROM
THAT GROUP -- THIS MONTH -- AND
THE INITIAL INFORMATION I DID
RECEIVE I WASN'T SATISFIED
BECAUSE THE SOUND A LOT LIKE
COMPASS.
IN THIS WITH A DIFFERENT PRODUCT
TO YOU -- AND THEY REGION FROM
THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND WE'RE
VERY CAUTIOUS IN WHO WOULD BRING
IN ON IT HAS TO FIT OUR MOLD AS
HAS TO FIT OUR NEEDS NOT THEIR
FINANCIAL NEED.
CORRECT AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT
WE WANT TO SEE RIGHT.
NOW AS WE DRIVE TO THIS BECAUSE
ONE OF THE THINGS YOU KNOW FOR
MY PERSPECTIVE.
YOU KNOW LIKE I SAID WE'VE THREE
YEARS AGO WE DID THE SIXTY FOUR
MILLION BUT FOR FOR PUTTING
MONEY INTO THE ARE PART OF CDC
ARE THE RE HAVE BUT THEN WHEN WE
HERE WE SEE AUDIT.
TALKING ABOUT EMPTY SEATS ARE
UNDER UTILIZATION I WOULD CALL
IT.
AND YOU KNOW THAT I'M HEARING
FROM THE DEPARTMENTS WELL WE
DON'T HAVE.
PROGRAMS OR MAYBE IS IT I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IS IT
ADMINISTRATIVE IS A PROGRAM HOW
DO WE CAPITALIZE ON THE
INVESTMENTS WE MADE ON THE OUR
PART AND THEN THE SECOND PART OF
THAT IS.
ACTUALLY SEEING THE ANALYTICS TO
SAY THAT PEOPLE ARE AYE I HAVE
SEVERAL RESPONSES OF AND I
REALLY DON'T WANT TO COME OFF AS
DEFENSIVE AND ALL THESE MAKING
AN EXCUSE BECAUSE I DON'T ACCEPT
THAT FROM MY PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR
ME.
BUT I CAN SAY THAT THE DATA THAT
WAS USED FROM.
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN THE SHIPS THAT
WERE GOING ON WITHIN CORRECTIONS
AND FOURTEEN FIFTEEN EVERYTHING
I'VE EXPLAINED FROM.
BRINGING DOWN A SECURITY HOUSING
UNITS CHANGING HOW WE CLASSIFY
INMATES TAKING GREATER --
ALLOWING INMATES WHO AT ONE TIME
WE WOULD NEVER PUT AT LOWER
LEVELS -- ON YARDS THAT WE THINK
THAT -- THAT THE TWO DANGERS TO
BE ON THE RECOGNIZING THE GOING
HOME ANYWAY.
I WOULD RATHER THAN PAROLE FROM
THE LOWER LEVEL FACILITIES --
EVEN THOUGH THEY MAY HAVE A
TRADITIONAL WRIST LEVEL THAT
WE'RE NOT COMFORTABLE WITH THAT
THE REALITIES ARE GOING HOME.
AND I NEED THEM ON FACILITIES
WHERE THEY HAVE -- ACCESS TO
PROGRAMS ACCESS TO LOWER -- MORE
PROGRAM RICH OPPORTUNITIES BUT
THE PROBLEM WAS.
WE HAD POLICY CHANGES IN PLACE
WE HAD -- FACILITY SHIFT IN
POPULATION WHICH IN ESSENCE
CREATES VACANCIES AND SOME OF
THESE PROBLEMS OTHER ISSUES THAT
WE HAD TO HAVE A WE HAVE WORK
THROUGH.
AND SO I KNOW IT SOUNDS LIKE AN
EXCUSE BUT WE HAD A SHIFT IN HOW
WE HOUSE WHERE WE HOUSE AND WHAT
TIME WE HOUSING EVEN.
THERE WERE TIMES WHEN WE DIDN'T
EVEN ALLOW INMATES OUT AFTER A
CERTAIN TIME.
WHEN THE SUN WENT DOWN CERTIN
INMATES WEREN'T LET OUT OF THEIR
CELLS?
WHICH WAS WHICH WAS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR I HAVE MORE
SPACE IN PRISONS BECAUSE FOR
PROGRAMMING BECAUSE THOSE
CLASSROOMS AT TRADITIONALLY ARE
THERE FROM.
EIGHT TO FOUR ARE BEING UTILIZED
FROM FIVE TO WHENEVER.
BUT BECAUSE OF SECURITY CONCERNS
ON OUR AND WE HAD TO CHANGE
POLICY AND THAT TOOK TIME.
SO HOW DO YOU BALANCE --
FULFILLING THOSE VACANCIES WITH
THE SECURITY CONCERNS.
RIGHT NOW THE BALANCE IS WE ARE
LOOKING AT THE REHABILITATIVE
NEEDS OF THE IN MAY AND WE BASE
HIS CURRENT BEHAVIOR AND WHERE
WE PUT HIM NOT HIS PAST BEHAVIOR.
HIS CURRENT BE HERE RECOGNIZING
THAT HE NEEDS A REHABILITATIVE
OPPORTUNITY.
THAT TOOK TIME A CULTURE SHIFT
INSIDE THE PRISON FOR STAFF.
AND SOME OF THE FACILITATORS
ALSO BECAUSE IT IS A HUGE SEA
CHANGE THAT WHY ARE YOU ALLOWING
MORE INMATES OUT IN THESE
PROGRAMS AT THESE TIMES.
AND AS IT AT THE TIME I WAS THE
UNDERSECRETARY EVEN DEPUTY
DIRECTOR TELLING THESE WARDENS
BECAUSE ARE GOING HOME.
WE NEED TO GIVE THEM ON OUR PART
OPPORTUNITY WE NEED TO GET THEM
TO THESE LOWER LEVEL FACILITIES.
IT TOOK TIME.
IT WAS A CULTURE SHIFT WITHIN
OUR PRISON SYSTEM FOR OUR
WARDENS AND OUR CUSTODY STAFF IN
OUR CUSTODY SUFFER MORE ENGAGED.
BECAUSE THEY SEE THE CHANGE THEY
SEE THAT THEY ARE TAKING PART IN
THE REHABILITATIVE PROCESS OF
THE IN RIGHT NOW WHICH WHICH
WILL.
WHICH IS LEAD TO BETTER NUMBERS
UTILIZATION IN THESE PROGRAMS.
I WISH I HAD MORE SPACE AND GOT
TALKED ABOUT A LITTLE BIT
EARLIER THE SPACE ISSUES I KNOW
THERE WE DO HAVE -- ROOF ISSUES
WE DO HAVE FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
ISSUES AND THAT'S THE DISCUSSION
THAT THAT WE ARE IN -- IN THE
BUDGET DISCUSSION NOW AND THIS
REALLY GEARED TOWARDS.
FINDING MORE SPACE SO WE CAN
PROVIDE BETTER UP REHABILITATIVE
OPPORTUNITIES BECAUSE WHEN THESE
PRISONS WERE BUILT WHAT WE HAVE
A LOT OF OUR INMATES.
THE BILL FROM THE EIGHTIES TO
THE TWO THOUSANDS.
THE PRISONERS THAT WERE BUILT
WEREN'T BUILT WITH
REHABILITATION IN MIND.
I I I'M FROM THAT ERA I WAS AN
OFFICER DURING THOSE TIMES THEY
WERE BUILT WITH SECURITY IN MIND
NOTHING ELSE.
YOU GOT YOUR EDUCATION CLASSES A
FEW VOCATIONAL CLASSES AND
THAT'S IT.
NOW SOME OF OUR OLDER PRISONS
THEY WERE BUILT WITH
REHABILITATION IN MIND LIKE ARE
SAYING CLINTON'S ARE CHINOS ARE
NOR BECAUSE THAT WAS A TIME WHEN
THE DEPARTMENT REALLY BELIEVE IN
REHABILITATION.
WE DIDN'T WE WE FORGET ABOUT
THOSE DAYS BUT I'M TRYING TO
REMIND THE AGENCY AND THE STAFF
THAT THOSE DAYS ARE STILL HERE
BUT WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
SPACE.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE ARE LEADING
INMATES OUT AT NIGHT BEYOND
TRADITIONAL TIMES WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO SECURE FUNDING TO HIRE
ADDITIONAL STAFF TO FACILITATE
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS IN AREAS
WHERE I DON'T HAVE STAFFING IN
THE EVENING.
SO WE CAN FACILITATE THESE
PROGRAMS.
SO IS IT JUST A SCHEDULING THING
IS A RESOURCES I MEAN ASIDE FROM
THE CLASSROOMS BUT I'M JUST
SAYING FOR THE FILLING OF THE
VACANCIES. FOR TEACHERS AND AND
WHAT ARE NOT DIRECTOR SAYS THE
CAN SPEAK ON THE TEACHERS BUT I
DO KNOW THAT -- ON THE
VOCATIONAL TRADES THE VOCATIONAL
TRADE WE DO STRUGGLE AND HIRING
SOME OF THOSE -- INSTRUCTORS
BECAUSE OF FORTUNATE ENOUGH --
THE STATE WHAT WERE THOSE ROBUST
BUILDING GOING ON SO THAT
INSTRUCTORS WHO USED TO
TRADITIONALLY COMING TO WORK ON
OUR PRISONS.
THE GORE CONSTRUCTION OUTSIDE
THE MAY MAKE MORE MONEY IS MORE
FLEXIBLE -- DURING THE DOWNTURN
WE HAD STAFFING.
BECAUSE THE THERE WASN'T A WHOLE
LOT OF BUILDING FOR THE
AGGRESSIVE APPROACH IN THE
DIRECTION I GAVE THE R. P. IS
THE RECRUITMENT EFFORTS NEED TO
BE NONTRADITIONAL GOING IN THE
AREAS THAT WE WOULDN'T THINK OF
GOING HITTING.
SCHOOLS DIRECTLY HITTING
VOCATIONAL SCHOOL DIRECTLY AND
SO THE MARKETS THAT I HAVE PUT
ON DEAR PETE TO COME UP WITH
NUMBERS.
THEY NEED TO BE THINKING AND AND
AND GOING INTO AREAS THAT THEY
TRADITIONALLY WOULD GO.
AND ALSO HIRING FORMERLY
INCARCERATED NO.
OUR DEVELOP AN OPERATIONAL FOR
REPORTS WAS TO CREATE WEEKLY AND
MONTHLY REPORTS FOR NOT ONLY TO
SEE THE TREATMENT OF OCCASIONAL
INSTRUCTORS ACADEMIC INSTRUCTOR
SO WE CAN -- ROOF QUICKLY SEE
WHERE VACANCIES EXIST AND REACT
TO THOSE VACANCIES AND JUST LIKE
SECRETARY D. AS MENTIONED WE ARE
DOING EVERYTHING CREATED WE CAN
FROM GOING TO EMPLOYMENT FAIRS.
TO WORKING WITH LOCAL
INSTITUTIONS TO HELP THEM THE
JOB PROCESS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE HAVING THOSE DISCUSSIONS
OFTENTIMES ESPECIALLY IN OUR
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
IT CAN SEEM VERY DRAMATIC IN
TERMS OF VACANCIES BUT THERE
MIGHT BE ONLY FOR POSITIONS
THERE AND SOMEONE HAS LAUGHTER
TO PEOPLE HAVE LEFT -- AND IF
THEY'RE IN A HARD TO FILL AREA
THAT COULD LOOK LIKE A 50%
VACANCY FOR OCCUR TECHNICAL
PROGRAMS THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE
SHOULDN'T BE REACTING THAT
DOESN'T MEAN WE SHOULD BE
AGGRESSIVE IN.
AND RECRUITING IT JUST MEANS
THAT THOSE VIEWS ARE OUT THERE
AND CAN IT CONTEXTUALIZED -- OUT
OF PLACE SO WE ARE PUTTING A
NUMBER OF PROCESSES IN PLACE AND
HAVE HAD THEM IN PLACE FOR OVER
A YEAR NOW TO REALLY TRY AND
FOCUS ON THOSE AREAS WITH
PROBLEMS AND MAKE SURE THEY WERE
DOING HIRING.
REVIEWING THINGS -- ON OUR C. B.
T. SIDE TO MAKE SURE THAT --
HOURLY WAGES ARE APPROPRIATE ARE
WORKING WITH OUR VENDORS WHO
HAVE BEEN REALLY AMAZING IN
TERMS OF BRAINSTORMING WITH US
ON HOW THEY CAN BEST GET PEOPLE
INTO -- INTO THIS YOU KNOW THE
PROGRAMS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE LEADING THIS TREATMENT
PROGRAMS LEADING THOSE ACADEMIC
AREAS SO THE WORK CONTINUES BUT
WE ABSOLUTELY -- HAVE EVERYTHING
IN PLACE TO REALLY MONITOR IT
NOW AND REALLY REACT TO THE
SITUATION QUICKLY AND TRYING TO
HELP I WHERE WE CAN.
CUT IT NOW ARE THERE -- A LACK
OF FOR FILLING VACANCIES IN THE
C. B. E. T.'S.
SIDE -- OR IS IT BECAUSE THOSE
ARE CONTRACTED OUT THOSE ARE
USUALLY FILLED WE'RE REALLY
TALKING ABOUT LIKE THE LOCATED
EVERYTHING ELSE.
THE VACANCIES RIGHT NOW OUR
AROUND THEY RANGED IN REALLY AND
AND 12214% -- WE STILL WANT TO
DO BETTER ON THAT THE SAME WITH --
OUR ACADEMIC PROGRAMS OR
ACADEMIC TEACHERS ARE ACTUALLY
COVERING RIGHT AROUND I THINK
10% BUT WE WANT THEM TO CONTINUE
COMING DOWN.
ON THE WHERE WE'VE REALLY HAD I
THINK SOME HISTORICAL STRUGGLES
WITH C. B. T..
MASSIVELY OLLED OUT AND
1-516-161-7718 AND WE DID
ADDITIONAL EXPANSIONS THERE SO
WHEN YOU ADD HUNDREDS OF
TREATMENT COUNSELORS INTO A
SYSTEM THAT ONLY HAS SIX OR
SEVEN HUNDRED YOU'RE EXPANDING
YOUR WORKFORCE FOR THIRTY OR 40%.
IT DOES TAKE SOME TIME TO GET
THAT HIRING DONE -- AND I KNOW
OUR PROVIDERS WILL BE ON THE
THIRD PANEL TO TO POTENTIALLY
DISCUSS SOME OF THE STRUGGLES IN
TERMS OF HIRING BUT THEY'VE DONE
AN AMAZING JOB A REALLY GOOD IT
WAS PEOPLE IN THE SAME THING
WITH OUR VOCATIONAL INSTRUCTORS.
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS WE'VE
EXPANDED NEARLY 10% IN OUR
CAREER TECHNICAL PROGRAMS AND SO
THERE IS SOME GAPS THERE IN
TERMS OF HIRING BUT THAT'S
BECAUSE WE'VE EXPANDED SO MUCH
AND WE CAN STILL CONTINUE TO DO
THE HIRING WE HAVE -- SO THERE'S
SOME GROWTH TO DO THERE BUT
EVERYTHING IS IS RANGING IN A
REASONABLE RATE BUT WE HAVE
TARGETED INSTITUTIONS SECRETARY
D. AS MENTIONED LOCATION
SOMETIMES PLACES LIKE R. J. D.
THEY CAN MAKE MORE MONEY IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR -- WORKING IN SAN
DIEGO THAN WORKING IN OUR PRISON
ENVIRONMENT AND SO THAT IT CAN
BE DIFFICULT BUT JUST LIKE
SECRETARY IDEA SAID WE ARE
TASKED WITH GETTING IT DONE IT'S
ABOUT SOLUTIONS -- AND SO WE ARE
DOING CREATIVE -- YOU KNOW
REALLY KIND OF TRYING TO FIND
CREATIVE WAYS TO FIGURE OUT
HIRING FOR THEM OR HELP THEM OUT
ANYWAY THAT WE CAN SO THAT THOSE
BODIES CAN GET IN THERE AND
START TEACHING. NINE AS A
STAFFING GOALS MENTIONED AS ONE
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
AUDITOR'S REPORT SO.
IT'S SAFE TO SAY THAN IN SIX
MONTHS YOU HAVE A PLAN TO HELP
FULFILL OR AT LEAST ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE NEED TO THEN AS WE GO
BACK INTO SUBCOMMITTEE IN BUDGET
THOSE ARE.
ISSUES THAT WE CAN DISCUSS.
YES ABSOLUTELY YES.
I KNOW MISTER JONES SAWYER HAS A
COUPLE QUESTIONS PLEASE AND THEN --
MISTER DE AS I JUST WANT YOU TO
KNOW -- THEIR THEIR COUPLE OF US --
BUT TRY TO MEET EVERY WEDNESDAY
FOR BIBLE STUDY.
AND WE DO BELIEVE IN RELIGIOUS
PROGRAMS AND WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THIS SPACE AND WE DO BELIEVE.
THERE'S A RETURN ON INVESTMENT
SO -- WHICH IS I KNOW YOU.
YOU IT STATED THAT YOU WEREN'T
SURE YOU COULD GET EVIDENCE
BASED OUT OF THAT BUT TO SO AS I
BELIEVE IN THE POWER OF PRAYER.
EVIDENCE OF THOSE SAME BIBLE
STUDIES AND IF THAT'S AN INVITE
ALL ATTEND.
SO I THINK PART OF MY AFTER
LISTENING TO MR SO SO SO I THINK
I CLEARLY UNDERSTANDING PART OF
MY FRUSTRATION -- AS YOU WERE.
KIND OF GOING OVER AND OVER THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHERE I CALL
WIDGETS GOING IN.
THE NUMBER PEOPLE THERE PROP
FIFTY SEVEN A NUMBER PEOPLE
THEY'RE GETTING CREDITS YOU NAME
IT ALL THESE HOURS TO GET REDUCE
TIME -- THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN
THIS TRAINING GROUP -- AND THEY
GET TIME OFF. EIGHT YOU NEED TO
REALIZE. FOR SOME PEOPLE THAT
COULD BE A PROBLEM THAT YOU'RE
NOT MEASURING HOW SUCCESSFUL
THESE PROGRAMS ARE.
AND YOU JUST LETTING PEOPLE OUT
AND FOR SOME PEOPLE THAT COULD
BE VERY VERY PROBLEMATIC AND OUT
OF I MEAN IT THE BEST PROBABLY
EXAMPLE I CAN.
I CAN GIVE YOU IS THERE'S A
THERE'S A COMPANY.
THAT BASICALLY -- DOING VERY
WELL [inaudible]
AND BUILDING PLANES AND I COME
TO YOU BOEING TWO PLANES GO DOWN.
THE WHOLE COMPANY ALMOST WENT
DOWN AND WE'RE STILL NOT SURE IF
OVER HIM OUT YOU KNOW.
BETTER THAN ANYBODY ELSE IF JUST
ONE OR TWO INMATES.
THAT WE RELEASE WITHOUT GOING TO
A PROGRAM THAT.
THAT WE'RE PRETTY SURE IS
WORKING.
IT COULD HAVE DRAMATIC THE
DEVASTATION OF IMPACT ON WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO.
AND SO.
IT'S NICE TO KNOW YOU'RE YOU'RE
HELPING A LOT OF PEOPLE.
BUT IT DOES JUST ANOTHER
PARADIGM SHIFT IS ANOTHER GEAR
YOU'VE GOT TO GET INTO.
WHERE YOU'RE ACTUALLY MEASURING
HOW SUCCESSFUL THESE PROGRAMS
ARE?
ON THE BACK WHEN THE BACK IN AS
THEY LEAVE.
BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW DAY LEAVING.
AND I AS I WAS TRYING TO TELL
YOU PART OF FRUSTRATING THING
ABOUT GETTING INFORMATION FROM
YOU DEPARTMENT.
I GOT ALL THESE WIDGETS IN AND
OUT GIVE ME TO PULL WHAT LITTLE
HAIR I HAD OUT BECAUSE THAT'S
NOT WHAT I ASKED.
FOR AND IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE THE DEPARTMENT IS
JUST SO NARROWLY FOCUSED.
ON HOW MANY.
HOW MANY HAND YOU CAN TOUCH HOW
MANY PEOPLE YOU CAN GET INTO
PROGRAMS?
THAT EITHER YOU NEED ADDITIONAL --
YOUR TO FOCUS SOME OF YOUR
RESOURCE ARE HAVE INTO DOING.
SOME MEASUREMENTS SO THAT YOU
CAN GET THE THE PROVEN ANALYTICS
TO SHOW THAT THE THE PROGRAMS
ARE WORKING [inaudible]
OR OUT OF YOU BE HONEST WITH ME
NOW BUT I GET THIS YEAR.
I'M INTERESTED TO THE OBVIOUS.
I HAVE NO.
NO REAL PROOF BY I GET ALMOST A
SPEAR THAT.
THAT PARTY APARTMENT DON'T WANT
TO SHOW WHERE THINGS MAY NOT BE
WORKING.
BECAUSE YOU MAY HAVE.
TO REASSIGN.
OR RE ASIDE SOME PEOPLE OUT OF
DEPARTMENT BECAUSE THEY JUST
DON'T FIT I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT
IS ABOUT.
THIS RETICENCE TO SHOW HOW.
SUCCESSFUL THESE PROGRAMS ARE.
AND THE MORE MORE I ASKED FOR IT
THE MORE MORE I GET NO
DISRESPECT MISSUS SOSA THE MORE
MORE I GET THIS WIDGET IN THING.
IT DRIVES ME NUTS BECAUSE THAT'S
NOT WHAT I RECENTLY ASKED FOR
THE AUDIT.
THAT'S NOT WHAT I ASKED FOR WHEN
I MET WITH YOU.
AND I'M STILL NOT GETTING.
IT AND IT IS JUST.
I JUST NEED TO KNOW WHAT WHAT.
IS IT I MEAN WHAT WHAT IS WHAT
DO YOU IS IT.
IS A RE DIRECTING EXISTING FUNDS
SO CHU YOUR YOU DO THAT YOU NEED
LEGISLATION TO DO THAT WHAT DO
YOU NEED TO BE ABLE TO GET THIS
DONE BECAUSE THIS SEEMS TO ME
COULD BE.
FAIRLY SIMPLE. SIX GET THIS.
DONE.
I THINK I THINK TO BEGIN TO
RESPOND -- I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD AND I
THINK THE CONVERSATIONS FOR ME
THE TAKE AWAY I HAD.
AS A WE WERE SPEAKING THE SAME
THING BUT JUST SAYING IT
DIFFERENTLY.
AND MAYBE THAT'S THAT THAT I'LL
CALL OWN THAT AND THAT WE WE ARE
JUST SO INGRAINED THAT THIS IS
THE YOU KNOW THE MEASURE IT IN
THE FORMAL RESPONSE.
BUT WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR IS
LIKE I SAID HOW DO YOU MEASURE
THE SUCCESS -- AND ONE OF THE
ANALYTICS ON A PARTICULAR
PROGRAM TO SHOW THAT THEY DIDN'T
COME BACK TO PRISON IN THIS
SAVINGS FROM THAT AND THROUGH
THAT SAME IS NOW WE CAN RELOCATE
THESE FUNDS OVER HERE.
CORRECT BUT ALSO IF THEY'RE
WORKING.
THE NOT RAPING PILLAGING SO
ROBBING BASED BASICALLY ON
OFFENSE IS EITHER.
SO BASED ON OUR CONVERSATION I
DID MEET.
AND WE'D I DID HAVE THAT FRANK
DISCUSSION THAT WE TO DO WE TEND
TO GET VERY BUREAUCRATIC.
AND OTHER ONE USED TO BE WERE
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT WE TEND TO GET
VERY BUREAUCRATIC AND I THINK
IT'S MAYBE JUST OUT OF OUT OF
FEAR CONCERN THAT WE'RE GONNA
SAY THE WRONG THINGS.
AND AND THAT'S THAT THAT'S JUST.
MY STANCE SOLD MET WITH THE TEAM
WE HAVE TO COME UP WITH A BETTER
WAY TO EXPLAIN.
WHY WERE SUCCESSFUL AND IF WE'RE
SUCCESSFUL THE SAVINGS OF THE
COST BENEFIT FROM THAT?
WHERE WE GONNA SAY WE COULD USE
IN OTHER PLACES TO ASK CAN WE
USE A SOMEWHERE ELSE BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL HERE?
AND THE FEAR MAYBE WHILE THEY'RE
GOING TO TAKE THE FUNDS THAT'S
NOT OUR FAIR ANYMORE.
I FOR IS THAT WE HAVE TO SHOW
WERE SUCCESSFUL IS NOT ABOUT THE
FUNDS BUT THE PERSON.
THE IMPACT THE LESS VICTIM.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LOOKING.
FOR SO FOR ME IT'S READING.
I'LL RE READ NHà REORGANIZING
OUR THOUGHT PROCESS ON HOW TO
RESPOND TO THESE THINGS NOW
THEY'RE GONNA BE TIMES WHEN WE
WILL GET THE BUREAUCRATIC
RESPONSE BECAUSE THAT'S YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHAT'S REQUIRED AT THE
TIME BUT I I TAKE OUR
CONVERSATION.
THE THE WILL HAVE TO RE CRAFT --
RESPOND TO THAT AND WE CAN'T BE
AFRAID TO SAY THIS JUST IN WORK.
AND IT'S NOT WORKING WE CAN BE
AFRAID BECAUSE AT LEAST WE TRIED.
AND WHAT I CAN AS SHE GAVE ME A
LITTLE GLIMPSE AND SO I I
PROBABLY NEED TO BE SITTING
WHERE YOU'RE SITTING AND LOOKING
BACK AND REMEMBER WHAT THAT.
WAS LIKE ESPECIALLY DURING HARD
ECONOMIC TIMES BECAUSE YOU DID
REAL WELL.
AND YOU SAVE.
MONEY ANY DEPARTMENT.
THAT THE STANDARD OPERATING
PROCEDURES TO SAY YOU NEED LESS
MONEY IN YOUR BUDGET NEXT YEAR
INSTEAD OF RE TOOLING THAT MONEY
BACK YOU DEPARTMENTS YOU COULD
SAY MORE TO COULD DO MORE AND BE
MORE EFFICIENT.
AND THAT JUST DADS.
THAT'S BEEN A TIME HONORED.
THING THAT'S BEEN DONE SO AT
LEAST FROM OF AB SET YOUR
POSITION BEING AHEAD OF A
DIVISION THAT WORRIED THAT --
PEOPLE WOULD CUT.
BODIES IN AND RESOURCES OUT OF
MY DIVISION AND SO.
I I DID DID TO BE A CREDIT TO
STEPS SO THAT HI HI I COULD KEEP
PEOPLE ALSO.
AT LEAST THAT HELP THAT HELPS --
MAYBE IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
COULD LEGISLATE WITH THE BUDGET
AS BEST WE CAN SAVE YOU.
IF YOU DO HAVE SAVINGS THAT SOME
OF IT NEEDS TO GO BACK INTO
CONTINUING DOING THAT'S WHY I'M
TRYING YOU TO RETURN THE RETURN
ON INVESTMENT.
BECAUSE IN BUSINESS THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT IF YOU PA
MORE MONEY.
INTO A SUCCESSFUL.
CAR LINE THEN YOU'LL MAKE MORE
MONEY AND YOU'LL BE MORE
SUCCESSFUL YOU CAN YOU CAN --
HIRE MORE PEOPLE.
THAT IS NOT THE GOVERNMENT AWAY
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT SO THAT
AT LEAST NOW YOU'VE GIVEN ME --
A GLIMPSE OF WHAT WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING A MAYBE EVEN THE FEAR.
A WHAT'S GOING ON AND MAYBE
THAT'S SOMETHING WE NEED TO TO
WORK ON THAT WE'RE NOT GOING.
TO IF YOU HAVE SIGNIFICANT
SAVINGS WERE NOT GOING TO
DECIMATED APARTMENT.
BECAUSE YOU DID THE RIGHT THING.
AND THE AND THE IT'S THE SAME
VOTE TO SWITCH SPACE -- WE'VE
ELIMINATED.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE OUT OF CDC
ARE.
AND WE'RE BEING TOLD.
WE STILL NEED ALL THIS SPACE --
IN MY MIND WHEN I USED TO DO
REAL STATED -- BUT THE MISSED
MORE LIKE AND I'VE HAD SOME
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THAT -- YOU
WOULD CONSOLIDATE RIGHT AND IF
YOU DIDN'T NEED A BUILDING YOU
COULD ACCESS ALL OUR OPERATIONS
YOU WOULD DO THAT -- AND THAT
THAT'S SCARY BECAUSE THEN YOU
LOSE A BUILDING IN.
AND YOU LOSE EVEN MORE PEOPLE
AND SO.
THERE I BELIEVE THERE'S ENOUGH
SPACE.
THERE WE JUST HAVE.
TO HAVE PEOPLE THAT KNOW HOW. TO
RECONFIGURE.
SPACE ALLOCATIONS AND YOU HIGHER
IS GIVE GROUPS THAT DO THAT ALL
THE TIME.
THEY DID IT WHEN I WAS THE CITY
OF LA HE PROBABLY DID IT WHEN
MISTER MOORE LOCK WHICH AT THE
COUNTY SO YOU CAN LOOK AT YOUR
SPACE ALLOCATION AND MAKE.
SOME -- TO ME DECISIONS ARE
SMART DECISIONS SO YOU CAN DO
THAT SO THAT'S MY SECOND.
FRUSTRATION OF HOW CAN WE WOULD
GET YOU SIGNATURE CLASSROOM
SEEING.
ULTIMATELY GET PEOPLE DOING THAT
I KNOW THE PROJECT WAS CHOMPING
TO SAY SOMETHING YEAH I WANT TO
SAY THAT I COMPLETELY CONCUR
WITH YOU UNDERSTAND -- NOW
ESPECIALLY WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT IN TERMS OF THAT YOU KNOW
WE ARE WHAT WE PUT THESE MINUTE
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS IN
BECAUSE WE WANTED TO KNOW AT THE
END OF THE DAY WE ARE STILL.
IMPLEMENTING THE BEST PROGRAMS
WE COULD BUT I ABSOLUTELY
UNDERSTAND -- SAYING THE ONE
FEAR THAT WE'VE HAD INTERNALLY
IS WHEN YOU DO A RESEARCH
ANALYSIS ON SOMEBODY THAT HAD
SAY TWENTY YEARS INCARCERATED
AND THEY'VE TAKEN THIRTY
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS.
THAT THAT RECIDIVISM ANALYSIS
ARE WE GOING TO PINPOINT THAT
ONE PROGRAM IS A THAT WAS IT OR
PINPOINT ACADEMIC AND SAY THAT
WAS IT THAT'S WHY WE WANTED TO
CALL IN A RESEARCHER TO SAY.
A REAL REGRESSION ANALYSIS HAS
TO BE DONE HERE TO PICK OUT THE
RIGHT PIECES SO THAT WE'RE NOT
GIVING YOUR RECIDIVISM FACT
ABOUT SOMEBODY.
THAT WAS ACTUALLY TIED TO
SOMETHING ELSE THAT DONE SO
THAT'S PART OF THE RESEARCH
PROJECTS THAT WE WANT.
TO BE CONTRACTED IN AND HAVE
THEM LOOK AT IS JUST OUR FEAR IN
MAKING THE WRONG IS --
ASSESSMENT BY LOOKING AT
RECIDIVISM TIED TO MAYBE ONE
THING WHEN THEY'VE DONE TWENTY
TWO DIFFERENT THINGS OVER THE
COURSE OF DECADES WHETHER
INCARCERATED SO I THINK THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE COMING FROM A LITTLE
BIT IN TERMS OF HESITANCY.
BUT WE ARE ABSOLUTELY
BRAINSTORMING EVERY DAY BECAUSE
I RECOGNIZE WHAT YOU WANT I
THINK THERE'S A WAY TO GET THERE --
WE HAVE THE RECIDIVISM DATA WE
HAVE THE DOJ DATA IT'S JUST
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
NOT.
RESPONSIBLE ONE TAGGING IT TO
ONE CERTAIN FACTOR CORRECTION I
THINK WE WOULD BE COGNIZANT OF
THAT AND ACTUALLY LOOK FOR THE
TRENDS.
RIGHT BECAUSE USUALLY MOST
INMATES ARE INVOLVED IN SEVERAL
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND NOT JUST
ONE BUT I THINK FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE WE'RE JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHICH ONES ARE TRULY
ARE WORKING I HAVE THE BETTER
TRENDS BECAUSE YOU'LL BE ABLE.
TO TO TEASE THAT DATE.
THAT DATA OUT.
SO THE MIST MORE OR MISTER MOORE
LIKE HAD A QUESTION CENTER
TOMORROW THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US SURE.
THANK YOU.
MISTER VICE CHAIR FOR MENTIONING
MY NAME THREE TIMES A YEAR WITH.
THREE FIVE BUT I'D LIKE TO CLOSE
IN PRAYER [inaudible]
NOT.
THIS IS PROBABLY MY BUSIEST YEAR
UP HERE -- BECAUSE THIS YEAR
I'VE BEEN MOVED FROM BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW SUB ONE EDUCATION
TO SUB FIVE CORRECTIONS PUBLIC
SAFETY AND JUDICIARY SO.
THERE'S THIS LEARNING CURVE IS
YOU KNOW JUST.
UNBELIEVABLE AND I APOLOGIZE
I'VE HAD.
QUITE A FEW MEET -- COMMITTEE
MEETINGS AND BILL PRESENTATIONS
AYE AYE AYE I HAVE BEEN HERE FOR
THE WHOLE TIME BUT I I JUST WAS
SITTING TO DRENCH THE COUNTY I
AT THE COUNTY YOU YOU FILE --
YOU KNOW YOUR APPLICATION FOR A
JOB AND AND THERE'S A FORM AT
THE VERY BOTTOM.
DO YOU HAVE A CRIMINAL RECORD
RIGHT IN THAT'S REMOVED AND AND
THAT'S NEVER PROVIDED TO ME AS A
DEPARTMENT HEAD.
SO I DON'T KNOW.
BUT HR WILL COME TO ME AND SAY.
YOU KNOW YOU ACCEPTED THIS
INDIVIDUAL AND WE HAVE MORE LET
YOU KNOW THAT.
THEY HAVE THE FOLLOWING
BACKGROUND AND AND I'M SAYING
WELL I WAS THE TREASURER THE
COUNTY AND I FUNCTION WITH MONEY.
AND I'VE GOT TO BE REAL CAREFUL.
INSIDE TWO OF THESE INSTANCES IN
SO [inaudible]
I DECIDED.
ON THESE -- TWO WITH MIKE SENIOR
MANAGEMENT SELECT HIRAM LET'S
STAY WITH THEM LET'S HELP --
DESERT THEY WANT IT DIRECTOR
GETTING BACK IN THE SYSTEM
THEY'RE YOUNG AND THEY YOU KNOW
IT'S TIME FOR GRACE.
SORRY I I'M HERE TO SAY THAT.
ONE OF THEM DID WELL
[inaudible]
AND MIKE.
YOU KNOW STAFF SAYS MIKE'S USE
IN THE COUNTY.
VAN WE DON'T KNOW WHAT HE'S
DOING IT WITH IT AT THE LUNCH
HOUR PRETTY.
AND THEN WE SAY WELL LET'S.
SEE WE CAN VISIT MIKE'S HOME AND
WE FIND.
PROPERTY CHECK PAYMENTS IN THIS
IN HIS HOUSE AND SO WE HAVE TO
REST MY SO.
I SAY THAT IT ONLY BE TRIVIAL
BUT I HAVE A 50% RECIDIVISM RATE.
YOU KNOW JUST ON TRYING IT BUT
YOU CAN'T REALLY SCARED.
BECAUSE WHEN THE THIRD PERSON
SHOWED UP.
THEY INFORMED ME THAT.
SHE HAD A A RECORD IT WAS LIKE I
DON'T WANT TO GO DOWN THAT ROAD
RUNNING AND I DON'T WANT.
TO BUY A FIFTY FIFTY SHOT.
SO I I SIDE BUT I'M I'M.
I'M SAYING YOUR NUMBERS MAYBE
FOR PRETTY ACCURATE BASED ON MY
LIFE EXPERIENCE [inaudible]
BUT I'M.
I CAN I WANT TO ASK A COUPLE
QUESTIONS OF MISTER SUSE IF I
COULD NOT ONE IN YOUR MARRIAGE
EVEN MATT MAY HAVE BEEN ASKED
BUT I JUST WANT TO KNOW.
WHAT IT WHAT IS YOUR EDUCATIONAL
BACKGROUND -- I HAVE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE FROM CSU
STANISLAUS AND A LAW DEGREE FROM
FORESTRY ONE SCHOOL OF LAW AND
STOCKTON [inaudible]
AND THEN.
WHAT IS WHAT IS YOUR CAREER PATH
BEEN WHAT WHAT YOUR HISTORY -- I
ORIGINALLY STARTED IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS IN THE
BUDGET MANAGEMENT BRANCH
OVERSEEING FISCAL OPERATIONS FOR
THE DIVISION HEALTH CARE
SERVICES -- WHEN DOES SPLIT HAD
REALLY OCCURRED THEN I WENT TO
WORK AT VALLEY STATE PRISON FOR
WOMEN AT THE TIME -- AS A
CONTRACT ANALYSTS THE BUDGET
ANALYST I DID SOME ACTING ROLES
AT THE A LOCAL INSTITUTION THERE
AND THEN CAME BACK UP TO
HEADQUARTERS AND WORKED IN THE
BUDGET MANAGER BRANCH OVERSEEING --
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT THINGS IN
THERE INCLUDING I HEALTH CARE
AGAIN I TECHNICAL OPERATIONS AND
OVERSEEING THE BUDGET FIELD
OPERATIONS -- THROUGH THE
MANAGER ROLES AND CHIEF -- AND
THE BUDGET FIELD OPERATIONS
INCLUDED THE DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS ALL INSTITUTIONAL
BUDGETS -- THAT DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE CONTACT BEDS IN
IT REALLY GAVE ME SOME GREAT
INSIGHT INTO POLICY EXPERIENCE
AND I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND WITH
THIS COMMITTEES COMING FROM
BECAUSE IT HAS TO MAKE.
DOLLARS AND SENSE TO ME AND
THAT'S WHY WE'VE TRIED TO
IMPLEMENT EVERYTHING WE CAN AS
SOON AS I WENT DOWN INTO DRP
FOLLOWING MY BUDGET STAND.
IT IS REALLY TO ME AT HAS TO
MATHEMATICALLY WORK OUT AS WELL
AND SO I COME FROM THAT
BACKGROUND IN TERMS OF POLICY
BUDGETS AND BUDGETING -- IN
MAKING SURE THAT IT'S IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO BE DOING FOR THE
TAX DOLLARS THAT WE'RE SPENDING
ON THESE PROGRAMS AND SO I COME
FROM THAT BACKGROUND A LITTLE
BIT AND C. C. R..
SO WHY WOULD A LAW SCHOOL
GRADUATE.
BE A BUDGET DIRECTOR WIRED TO A
CPA WHY DID YOU GO DOWN THE
RIGHT COURSE.
AND I'M GETTING NERVOUS.
TALKING ABOUT.
IS ONE OF MY KEEP LATER.
ACTUALLY OCCURRED WHILE I WAS IN
THE BUDGET MANAGEMENT BRANCH I
WAS GOING TO SCHOOL AT NIGHT.
I'M IN DOING THAT THIS INTO YOUR
P. TRULY THAT IS NOT A
REQUIREMENT FOR ME IT'S A
PASSION BECAUSE OF THE THINGS
THAT WERE IMPLEMENTING -- IT'S A
PASSION BECAUSE OF THE WAY THAT
I SEE THE PRESENT CULTURE
CHANGING WITH THE PROGRAMS THAT
WE ARE PROVIDING JUST IN MY TIME
IN C. C. R. IT'S A PASSION FOR
ME TO MAKE THE DOLLARS AND CENTS
WORK.
I'M PROUD TO BE IN THE DIVISION --
AND LEADING A TEAM OF PEOPLE
THAT CAN PUT CDC ON THE BLACK
AND SO FOR ME THIS CREATES --
SOMETHING IN TERMS OF
SUSTAINABILITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT BUT I THINK WE'VE
NEVER DONE BEFORE AND WE HAVE
HEARINGS LIKE THIS AND AUDITS
LIKE THIS BECAUSE THE DATA
COLLECTION AND AND NORMALLY THE
DEPARTMENTS CAN OFTEN GO.
IN COLLECTED A LOT OF THIS IS A
RESULT OF US GOING NO WE'RE
GONNA COLLECTED BECAUSE WE WANT
TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON BECAUSE
WE WANT TO MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISIONS.
SO I'M HERE TRULY -- BECAUSE I
BELIEVE IN WHAT WE'RE DOING IN
THE DEPARTMENT AND THE CHANGES
THAT WERE MADE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE ARE
APPRECIATE YOUR PASSION I THINK
YOUR BOSS IS LUCKY TO HAVE YOU.
YES I AM.
I'M NOT TALKING TO YOU.
MR SOUSA -- YOU YOU YOU YOU GAVE
SOME COMMENTS ABOUT CONCURRENT
SINCE SOME THOUGHTS ABOUT
REMEDIES -- WOW HOW DO YOU
ASSURE US OF ACCOUNTABILITY THAT
YOU'RE GONNA FALL THROUGH THAT.
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO MEET THE
BENCHMARKS AND THAT -- YOU'RE
GONNA MAKE A MISTER DE IS REALLY
PROUD.
YOU KNOW SOME OF THE STUFF IS
REALLY MAKING DATA DRIVEN
DECISIONS AND PLANNING AND SO
WHAT WE'VE DONE OVER THE LAST
YEAR IS TRYING TO FOLLOW UP ON
THOSE WEEKLY MONTHLY QUARTERLY.
REPORTS WE HAVE DETAILED -- DATA
DASHBOARDS THAT COME OUT NOW
EVERY SINGLE MONTH AND GO TO
EVERY PRINCIPLE EVERY WARDEN
EVERY ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR THAT'S
OVER THE DIVISION OF A DAHLE
INSTITUTIONS.
SO THAT IF SOMEBODY'S NOT
COMPLETING WE KNOW DOWN TO THAT
PERSON WHY THEY'RE NOT
COMPLETING A PROGRAM -- WE HAVE
WORK GROUPS THAT HAVE DEVELOPED
UNDER MISTER IDEAS IS DIRECTION
ABOUT TRANSFERRING INMATES WE
RECOGNIZE THAT TO BE A PROBLEM
IN TERMS OF COMPLETIONS SO WE'RE
TRYING TO SEE AN BACK INTO THE
REASONS.
OF WHY THAT TRANSFER HAS SO WE
CAN START MITIGATING THESE
THINGS CORRECTIONS LIVES IN AN
ENVIRONMENT THAT THEY ARE VERY
REAL PROBLEMS AND VERY COMPLEX
PROBLEMS BUT THERE ARE SOLUTIONS
TOMB IF WE KNOW WHAT THOSE
PROBLEMS ARE.
AND OFTENTIMES WITHOUT DATA YOU
GO IN BLIND AND YOU MAKE
DECISIONS THAT ACTUALLY AREN'T
REAL ON THAT AREN'T BASED ON A
REAL ACCOUNTABILITY SO IN TERMS
OF POWER HOW MY GONNA DISPLAY IT.
I'M GOING TO DO IT EXACTLY HOW
WE'VE BEEN DOING IT WHICH IS
DEVELOPER PORTS PUBLICLY TALK
ABOUT IT AND TALK ABOUT THE
THINGS THEY WERE DOING.
I THINK -- IN TERMS OF
COLLABORATION EVEN WITH THAT THE
STATE AUDITOR THEY KNOW THAT I
AND AS TRANSPARENT I THINK IT'S
CAN BE.
CALIFORNIA REHABILITATION
OVERSIGHT BOARD I'M HAPPY TO
GIVE THEM ANY INFORMATION WE'VE
BEEN DEVELOPING HOW WE WANT
THOSE BOARD MEETINGS TO LOOK
BECAUSE THE MORE THAT WE DISPLAY
AT THE MORE THAT IT'S IMPORTANT.
THE MORE THE CALIFORNIA
RECOGNIZES REHABILITATION IS
HERE TO STAY THE HIGHER IMPACTS
THAT WILL HAVE IN THE
INSTITUTIONAL -- AND AND SEE THE
STARS THE WHOLE SO IT'S REALLY
FOR ME ABOUT COLLECTING DATA AND
MAKING SURE THAT ITS OPERATION
AVAILABLE AND HAVING ALL OF MY
STAFF -- AND EVERYONE IN THE
DEPARTMENT BE SOLUTION BASED
IT'S NOT ABOUT A PROBLEM WE CAN
OVERCOME IT'S ABOUT HOW DO WE
MEDICAID THAT PROBLEM SO THE
PEOPLE ARE GETTING
REHABILITATION.
STUFF THE STUFF WORKS YOU KNOW
IT WORKS NATIONALLY -- IT WORKS
OF IMPLEMENTED CORRECTLY IT
WORKS IF THEY HAVE THE COMMUNITY
RESOURCES THAT THEY'RE TIED TO
WE SEE IT WORKING WE'VE PULLED
TO HIGH LEVEL DATA POINTS JUST
THIS YEAR.
IN TERMS OF ACADEMIC EDUCATION I
MENTIONED IN ONE HEARING WE SEE
THAT I CONVICTIONS IN IN ONE
YEAR OF RELEASE IT'S NOT A LOT
OF DATA YET BECAUSE
LONGITUDINALLY WE DON'T HAVE A
LOT.
BUT WE SEE CONVICTIONS -- THAT
ARE NORMALLY AT NINE EIGHTEEN
POINT 5% ARE DOWN TO NINE POINT
5% FOR THOSE THAT ACHIEVING GT
YOUR HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA PRESS
RELEASE THOSE ARE HUGE NUMBERS
THAT WE SAY.
THESE HAVE SUBSTANTIAL IMPACTS
SO -- THAT'S THE YOU KNOW OUR M.
C. R. PEAS OUR MEAL COMMUNITY
REENTRY PROGRAMS WHICH THE I
THINK WILL BE DISCUSSED TODAY OF
IT.
WE SEE RECIDIVISM IMPACTS
SOMETIMES OFFER PEOPLE STAYING
LONGER THAN SIX MONTHS OUT THOSE
PROGRAMMES UPWARDS OF 30% THERE
ARE.
OUR TIME WE'RE SHOWING YOU WERE
A LITTLE MORE PASSIONATE.
SORRY AND TIME I NEED A TIMER --
SO THERE'S THINGS ABOUT PUBLICLY
DISPLAYING DATA AND AND REALLY I
I SEE THOSE TO COULD YOU IN
FIFTY WORDS OR LESS.
JUST GIVE ME AN ASSESSMENT OF
YOUR REACTION TO THIS AUDIT WAS
IT A FAIR AUDIT WAS IT ACCURATE.
WERE THERE SOME AREAS THAT CAN
BE BROUGH.
I THINK THERE'S ALWAYS GOING TO
BE DIFFERENCES AND HOW.
DATA IS REPRESENTED BUT I AGREE
AND CONCUR WITH THE THE AUDIT
FINDINGS THE THE DISAPPOINTING
PART FOR ME IS -- WE HAVE LED
THE DIVISION IN THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS TO REALLY TRY AND PUT
THE THINGS AND FOUNDATIONAL ANY
SO THAT WE KNOW WHEN WE'RE
GIVING YOU RESEARCH FIGURES ARE
WE ARE CONTRACTING WITH
RESEARCHERS. FIFTY FIVE FIFTY
SIX AREA THAT THAT DATA SALAS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
FOR THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
YOUR DS FOR LET ME PICK ON YOUR
LITTLE THEIR CAN I HAVE A LITTLE
FUN RIGHT -- NO THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT OF THE COMMENTS
ABOUT BEING DATA DRIVEN BUT I
DID WANT TO ASK JUST SO THAT YOU
CAN RESPOND BECAUSE EARLIER WAS
TALKED ABOUT HOW.
VENDORS INTENDED THE
INSTITUTIONS TO NOT USE EVIDENCE
BASED PROGRAMS FOR THE CURRICULA.
RIGHT AND YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF DATE AS
OF YOU CAN JUST KINDA.
TALK ABOUT THAT A Y. EIGHT THOSE
INSTITUTIONS ARE DOING THAT OR
WHAT'S THE HOLD UP FOR THAT TO
ACTUALLY HAPPEN -- I'D
APPRECIATE THAT.
SO -- IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WE SORT OF WORK WITH YOU WHICH
REALLY OPENED THE DOOR UP. TO
BEING IN THE QUEUE RESULTS FIRST
CLEARING HOUSE AS EVIDENCE BASED
ON RESEARCH AND SO WE COLLECTED
ALL OF THIS CURRICULUM
INFORMATION FROM OUR PROVIDERS --
AND ASSESS WHETHER IT WAS IN THE
CLEARING HOUSE AND THAT IS KIND
OF THE ROLE THAT WE'VE BEEN
TAKING AT THIS POINT THAT IT BE.
IN THE RESULTS FIRST CLEARING
HOUSE OF THE INTERVENTION OUR
CURRICULUM LEVEL.
FOLLOWING THAT ASSESSMENT AND
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING IN THE AUDIT
IS WE BEGAN WE PUT IN A CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM WE SAID YOU
HAVE TO START TELLING US ALL THE
CURRICULUM THAT'S HAPPENING.
DOWN TO THE PERSON TAKING A
CERTAIN ASPECT OF A CURRICULUM
AND WHAT TABLE OF CONTENTS
THAT'S RELATED TO HIM SO VERY
DETAILED INFORMATION BECAUSE WE
KNOW IT'S GONNA BE USEFUL FOR
RESEARCH.
AND SO THERE'S BEEN THIS
CATEGORIZATION OF EVERYTHING HAS
TO BE IN THE RESULTS FIRST
CLEARING HOUSE.
AT THE INTERVENTION A CURRICULUM
LEVEL AND WE HAVE PROVIDERS IN
OUR CONTRACTS TO SAY THAT IT
MUST BE EVIDENCE BASED WHEN WE
DID A REVIEW OF SANSA.
THEY SAID JUST BECAUSE IT'S NOT
IN THIS CLEARING HOUSE DOES NOT
MEAN IT'S EVIDENCE BASE JUST
MEANS NOT RESEARCHED AND PUT IN
THIS CLEARING HOUSE.
SO WE WERE TRYING TO BE --
COGNIZANT OF NOT APPROACHING
THAT TOO AGGRESSIVELY TO SAY
BECAUSE NOT EVERYTHING'S IN THE
CLEARING HOUSE OUR PROVIDERS
SOME OF THE 20% THAT'S
REFERENCED IN HERE.
HAVE DECADES OF CURRICULUM THAT
THEY'VE BEEN USING IN PRISON
THAT HAS HAD RESEARCH STUDIES
BEHIND IT THAT SHOW THAT IT --
RESULTS AND EFFECTIVE RECIDIVISM
SO WE TRIED NOT TO BE SOMEWHAT
BY THE DISCONNECT IN THE
AUDITOR'S ACTUALLY SAYING IT'S
NOT EVIDENCE BASED THE AUDITOR'S
REVIEWED THE RESULTS FIRST
CLEARING HOUSE NOT THAT'S THE
STANDARD THAT WE'VE PUT FORWARD
AT THIS POINT SO.
THEY'RE REVIEWING IT AS IS IT
INCLUDED IN THERE AND OUT THAT
THEY CAN CORRECT ME IS INCLUDED
IN THE RESULTS FIRST CLEARING
HOUSE -- AND THAT'S WHAT THAT'S
WHAT THEY WERE REVIEWING THE
CURRICULUM AGAINST [inaudible]
GOT IT [inaudible]
RIGHT -- WHAT A ONE LAST
QUESTION BECAUSE MISTER DE AS
YET CHAIRED A STORY EARLIER --
BUT THE INDIVIDUAL THAT WORKED
AT THE RAM STADIUM NOW.
AND I WAS JUST WONDERING.
WHAT CDC ARE DOING FOR THOSE
FOLKS WE HAVE THESE PROGRAMS IN
CORRECTIONS?
YOU SHARED A SUCCESS STORY OF
SOMEONE THAT ONE OUT BUT HOW ARE
WE CONNECTING THOSE SO THAT
STORY IS MULTIPLIED YOU KNOW A
HUNDRED FOLD -- DOES CDC OUR
WORK WITH INDUSTRIES YOU KNOW
I'LL DECIDE THE SYSTEM SO THAT
PARTNER THOSE AND REALLY BUILD
BRIDGES RIGHT.
CDC ARE ALONG WITH PIAA BOTH
ASIAN OR BOTH AGENCIES WE DO
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT BOARD EDT LABOR.
AND WE HAVE BEEN -- BUILDING
BUILDING COMMUNICATIONS AND
PATHWAYS -- TO SO THE INMATE CAN
UTILIZE A CERTIFICATE BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE GETTING IN WITH THE UNION
HALLS RIGHT NOW THROUGH PIAA AND
WITH THE CDC ALSO WE ARE.
INDIVIDUALS ARE ABLE TO TAKE
EXAMINATIONS IN PRISON WE GET
THEM CONNECTED WITH UNION ALSO
UPON RELEASE THAT -- PRIOR TO
THEM EVEN LEAVING P. I. A S.
PAYING UNION WAIT.
UNION DUES PART OF THEM BEING
RELEASED SO WHEN THEY DO GET OUT.
THEY'RE ABLE TO GO TO THE UNION
HALL AND UTILIZE A CERTIFICATE.
SO IT'S JUST THROUGH OUR PRISON
EMPLOYMENT WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD AND WORKING WITH THEM --
YOU KNOW JUST WORKING WITH OUR
NEWLY ESTABLISHED PRISON
EMPLOYMENT.
OKAY THANK YOU WHEN WE ASK
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS HEARING
NONE THANK YOU WILL LOOK FORWARD
TO THE SIX MONTH REPORT -- WITH
A LOT OF THESE HOPEFULLY THAT
WILL SEE MORE -- PROGRESS ON THE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WITH THAT
LET'S GO TO MOVE TO OUR NEXT
PANEL IT'S ITEM NUMBER FOUR
COMMENTS ON REHABILITATION AND
REENTRY PROGRAMS WE HAVE SEASON
CHAMPION.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH STANFORD
LAW SCHOOL THREE STRIKES PROJECT
DOUG BONTA CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER WITH.
AMITY FOUNDATION JOHN JENKINS
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT WITH LESS
CARE FOUNDATION THANK YOU GUYS
FOR JOINING US AND HEARINGS
GOING A LITTLE BIT LONGER THANK
YOU. FOR FOR BEING WITH US THIS
ENTIRE TIME.
SO FIVE YOU CARE TO BEGIN.
WE'LL GO AN AGENDA OR PERFECT
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU SUSAN
CHAMPION WITH THE THREE STRIKES
PROJECT AT STANFORD LAW SCHOOL --
HI I'M HERE PRIMARILY TO TELL
YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
EXPERIENCE OF AN INMATE WHO IS
RETURNING TO HIS OR HER
COMMUNITY AFTER SERVING.
A PRISON SENTENCE -- HAVE THE
THREE STRIKES PROJECT WE
INITIATED THE THREE STRIKES
REFORM ACT WHICH MEANT THAT AT A
CERTAIN POINT IN TIME.
BETWEEN THREE AND FOUR THOUSAND
LIFE INMATES WERE RETURNING TO
THEIR COMMUNITIES AFTER HAVING
BEEN FACING A LIFE SENTENCE.
MANY OF THEM HAD BEEN IN PRISON
FOR TEN TO SEVENTEEN TWENTY
YEARS AT THIS POINT -- AND WE
KNEW THAT THE SUCCESS OF THIS
REFORM THE SUCCESS OF SENTENCING
REFORM.
CHANGED IN LARGE PART ON THE
SUCCESS OF THE INDIVIDUALS OR
GETTING OUT.
AND BECAUSE WE ARE BECAUSE WE
WORK WITH MULTIPLE COUNTIES --
WE HAVE SEEN A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS
A LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS IN WHICH
RE ENTRY HAS BEEN DONE -- OUR
BIGGEST CONCERN FOR OUR CLIENT'S
WAS THAT THEY HAVE A BAD
[inaudible]
AND FOOD.
AND BASIC NECESSITIES IN A SAFE
AND SOBRE ENVIRONMENT.
THAT WAS WHAT WE THAT WAS WHAT
WE FELT WAS AT THE BARE MINIMUM
WHAT THEY NEEDED.
AND IN MOST CASES THAT WAS A
VERY DIFFICULT TO FIND WE
SCOURED THE STATE GOING FROM
COUNTY TO COUNTY TRYING TO FIND
PROGRAMS WE HAD STANFORD LAW
SCHOOL INTERNS.
GOING THROUGH BOOKS TRYING TO
FIND PLACES WHERE WE CAN SAFELY
HOUSE OUR CLIENTS IT WAS VERY
VERY DIFFICULT.
WE EVENTUALLY FOUND A COUPLE OF
PROGRAMS THAT WE REALLY BELIEVED
IN THAT WE KNEW WERE GOING TO BE
HELPFUL.
EVEN THEN THERE WERE HUGE
BARRIERS TO GETTING OUR CLIENTS
IN THERE IF THEY WERE COMING
FROM THE COUNTY IN WHICH A
PROGRAM DIDN'T.
THE PROGRAM DIDN'T EXIST WE
WOULD HAVE TROUBLE EITHER
GETTING THEIR PROBATION
TRANSFERRED TO THE WE WOULD SAY
LOOK WE HAVE A BED FOR THIS
PERSON IN A PROGRAM THEY'RE
GONNA FEED THIS PERSON THEY'RE
GONNA HELP THIS PERSON GET THE
SERVICES THEY NEED.
AND GIVE THIS PERSON CBT
PROGRAMMING AND HELP THEM RETURN
TO THE COMMUNITIES AND WE'LL BE
TOLD NO WE'RE NOT GONNA ALLOW
THIS PERSON'S -- PROBATION TO BE
TRANSFERRED OR WE'RE NOT GOING
TO ALLOW THIS PERSON'S PAROLE TO
BE TRANSFERRED BECAUSE THAT'S
JUST NOT THE WAY WE DO THINGS.
THIS MEANS THAT A CLIENT COMES
OUT OF PRISON WITH TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
GOES TO A BUS STOP.
AND TAKES THAT BUS WHEREVER
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO GO AND
INSTRUCTIONS TO REPORT TO A
PAROLE OFFICE -- INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE COMING OUT OF PRISON HAVE A
THIRD THIRTEEN X. GREATER CHANCE
OF DYING WITHIN THE FIRST TWO
WEEKS OF RELEASE.
THE NUMBER ONE CAUSE OF DEATH IS
OVERDOSE THE SECOND LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH IS A HEART ATTACK
WHICH IS GENERALLY RELATED TO
OVERDOSE.
IT IS INCREDIBLY STRESSFUL AND
INCREDIBLY UNSTABLE TIME AND I
WOULD ARGUE THAT WE SEND PEOPLE
TO PRISON.
FOR LONG PERIODS OF TIME TEN
YEARS AND MORE.
WHEN THEY COME BACK AND?
THEY'RE NOT THE SAME PERSON THEY
WORE AND SEVERAL PEOPLE HAVE
MENTIONED THAT AND THEY NEED A
SAFE PLACE AND WHICH TO READJUST.
IN ORDER TO BE GOOD MEMBERS OF
THEIR COMMUNITY -- IT'S AN
INCREDIBLE BURDEN ON FAMILY
MEMBERS TO SUDDENLY HAVE SOMEONE
I KNOW I PERSONALLY FEEL
BURDENED WHEN MY PARENTS STAY
WITH ME FOR A WEEK EVEN IF
THEY'RE LIVING IN A DIFFERENT.
PLACE -- THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT
ARE COMING TO FREQUENTLY -- THE
SAME HOME IN WHICH THEY HAD
COMMITTED THEIR CRIMES OF THEIR
RETURN TO THEIR FAMILIES THEY
MAY BE GOING TO THE SAME PLACE
THEY WERE BEFORE.
THEY WERE COMMITTED TO PRESENT --
THEIR FOOT ON THE COMING TO
PLACES IN WHICH THERE ARE FEW
FINANCIAL RESOURCES.
AND THEY'RE SUDDENLY PUT IN A
POSITION WHERE THEY'RE RELYING
ON FAMILY MEMBERS TO FEED THEM
TO HOUSE THEM TO CLOSE THEM --
TO TAKE THEM TO THEIR
APPOINTMENTS THEIR HUGE HUGE
NEEDS SOME PEOPLE NEED REGULAR
DIALYSIS APPOINTMENTS SOME
PEOPLE NEED MENTAL HEALTH
MEDICATIONS SOME PEOPLE NEED. TO
BE CONNECTED WITH SERVICES
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY AND WITHOUT
THE SUPPORT REENTRY SUPPORT.
THEY'RE REALLY NOT EQUIPPED TO
DO THAT AND IT'S INCREDIBLE
BURDEN ON THEIR FAMILIES WHO
FREQUENTLY ARE ALSO NOT EQUIPPED
TO DO THAT -- MY EXPERIENCE
WORKING WITH THIS POPULATION
OVER THE PAST SEVEN YEARS HAS
CONVINCED ME THAT HAVING HAD AN
INDIVIDUAL HAS BEEN INCARCERATED
RETURN TO THEIR COMMUNITIES TO
PROFESSIONAL.
WRAPAROUND REENTRY PROGRAMS IS
KEY. TO REDUCING RECIDIVISM AND
TO PRODUCING THE KIND OF
OUTCOMES THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
IN TERMS OF KEEPING OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE.
AND REALLY.
I FEEL WE HAVE A BIT OF A MORAL
OBLIGATION EVER GOING TO SEND
PEOPLE TO PRISON FOR SUCH LONG
PERIODS OF TIME.
WE CAN'T JUST PUT THEM OUT ON
THE STREET AND EXPECT THEM TO
SUCCEED I THINK THERE ARE A LOT
OF BARRIERS.
RIGHT NOW THAT EXIST
BUREAUCRATIC BARRIERS THAT
PREVENT PEOPLE ACCESS TO THE
ACTUAL PROGRAMMING THAT IS THERE
FOR THEM BUT MAYBE IT'S IN THE
WRONG COUNTY.
AND THERE'S ALSO I THINK A REAL
DEARTH.
OF REALLY GOOD SOLID PROGRAMS
OUT THERE.
DISPERSED AMONG ALL OF THE
COUNTIES AND OUT OF A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT
ARE INCARCERATED TODAY THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THEM.
ARE COMING BACK TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND IF WE WANT TO
COMMUTERS TO BE SAFE WE NEED TO
PROVIDE THEM.
AND INVESTED IN THE SUPPORT OF
SERVICES THAT THEY'RE GONNA NEED
IN ORDER TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
I'M.
JUST A QUICK NOTE ON SOME OF THE
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS THAT
ARE OFFERED I THINK THESE ARE
ALSO VERY VALUABLE THEY PROVIDE.
A LINK FREQUENTLY.
BETWEEN INMATES INSIDE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES OUTSIDE AND IN THOSE
PROGRAMS THEY ARE THEN ABLE TO
TAKE THOSE EXPERIENCES AND THOSE
SKILLS.
AND BRING THEM INTO THE
COMMUNITY THAT WAS THERE TO
SERVE THEM IN PRISON SO IF I I
HAVE A GREAT.
RESPECT FOR AT PROGRAMS LIKE
THAT -- PRISONERS DRAMATIC THEY
COME OUT THEY'RE TRAUMATIZED
THEY HAVE LOTS OF NEEDS AND I
THINK.
WE NEED TO BE THERE FOR THEM TO
PROVIDE FOR THAT.
IN A LETTER THESE DOWN AND TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE PROGRAMS THAT
DO DO THAT PLEASE THANK YOU.
SUSAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE IN ASSEMBLY -- PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DOUG
BONHAM CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER
FOR AMITY FOUNDATION WERE --
FIVE OH ONE C. THREE NON PROFIT
THAT OPERATES IN ARIZONA
CALIFORNIA NEW MEXICO I COULD
TELL YOU OF ALL THE THREE STATES
THAT WE OPERATE IN CALIFORNIA IS
BY FAR THE MOST PROGRESSIVE --
IN TERMS OF PROVIDING SERVICES
WE PROVIDE TREATMENT EMPLOYMENT
HEALTH AND WELLNESS VOCATIONAL
TRAINING CASE MANAGEMENT CARE
COORDINATION.
HOUSING SERVICES AND THEN WE
ALSO PROVIDE HIGH UTILIZE OR
OUTCOMES BASED SERVICES ARE
PERFORMANCE SPACE CONTRACTING AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
MENTION ONE OF THE PROGRAMS.
THAT WE DESIGNED IS ACTUALLY IN
LOS ANGELES IT'S A PAPER SUCCESS
OR SOCIAL IMPACT BOND PROGRAM
THAT'S ENTIRELY DRIVEN BY
PERFORMANCE PRIVATELY FINANCE EN
ROUTE AND FUNDED THROUGH THE
COUNTY -- BASED ON OUR
PERFORMANCE OUTCOMES.
I WON'T SPEAK ABOUT WIDGETS AND
I APPRECIATE SOME OF THE
COMMENTS MENTION HERE TODAY --
BY EVERYONE AND SO I I WILL SAY
THAT WE SERVE.
ALL THAT REPRESENT ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND CHILDREN IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND SO ONE THING THAT ISN'T
MENTION IS INDIRECT IMPACT OF
INCARCERATION BASED ON THE
FAMILIES AND THE COMMUNITIES.
AND WE'RE CURRENTLY IN
DEVELOPMENT OF FIVE HUNDRED
UNITS A PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IN SOUTH LA THOSE UNITS
WILL BE.
BUILT WITH MEN AND WOMEN THAT
ARE FORMALLY INCARCERATED AS
VOCATIONAL TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES AND ALSO WORK TO
HOUSE MEN AND WOMEN THAT ARE
HOMELESS IN THE COMMUNITY.
AS CEO OF AMITY FOUNDATION I'M
RESPONSIBLE FOR INSURING WE'RE
PROVIDING MORE PATHWAYS FOR MEN
WOMEN AND FAMILIES TO HEAL.
AND I'LL SAY THAT MY
INTRODUCTION AMITY FOUNDATION
WAS NOT IS CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER IS ACTUALLY AS A CHILD
THAT WAS AND IT DOES OVER A
DOZEN FOSTER HOMES GROWING UP --
I SPEND A LOT OF MY CHILDHOOD
VISITING MY PARENTS IN PRISON
YARDS AND BEHIND GLASS.
AND ACTUALLY KNOW A LOT OF THE
IMPACT OF INCARCERATION ON MY
FAMILY AND TO OTHER FAMILIES IN
THE COMMUNITY.
I'VE LOST SEVERAL CLOSE FAMILY
MEMBERS DUE TO INCARCERATION AND
DRUG ADDICTION.
AND I'LL SAY THAT -- THE I WAS
PART OF A PILOT PROGRAM THAT WAS
NOT EVIDENCE BASED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE TO HELP REUNITE MY
FOR ME WITH MY FAMILY -- WAS
UNTIL TEN YEARS LATER THAT THAT
PROGRAM WAS EVIDENCE BASE IN
TERMS OF HAVING ME STAY WITH MY
FATHER AFTER HE WAS INCARCERATED
WHILE HE WENT THROUGH --
TREATMENT AT AMITY FOUNDATION --
THE TODAY THAT PROGRAM IS
ACTUALLY A REPLICATED ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES AND ACROSS THE
WORLD.
THE INTERVENTIONAL ALLOWED ME TO
REUNITE WITH MY PARENTS SO THEY
COULD BOTH RECEIVE SERVICES
AFTER THEY WERE RELEASED FROM
PRISON AMITY FOUNDATIONS ALSO
HELP ME TO BREAK THE CYCLE OF
INCARCERATION AND HELP TO ENSURE
THAT AS A FATHER MY DAUGHTER
WILL NEVER SEE.
A WHAT IT'S LIKE TO VISIT A
PRISON VISITING ROOM OR NEVER
SEE WHAT IT'S LIKE TO SIX SEE ME
BEHIND GLASS OR READ LETTERS ON
A BIRTHDAY -- WHILE YOU'RE IN A
FOSTER HOME WHERE ORPHANAGE.
EXCUSE ME I'M SORRY -- THE SAME
INTERVENTIONS WHY STAND HERE
BEFORE YOU TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
PROGRAMS TO HELP MEN AND WOMEN
RETURN HOME SAFELY WITH SERVICES
A LEAN THEY NEED MY STORY IS
ABSOLUTELY NOT UNIQUE.
THERE'S MANY CHILDREN THAT
REPRESENT IN THE COMMUNITY MANY
FAMILY MEMBERS THAT ARE
REPRESENT IN THE COMMUNITY.
THAT ARE IMPACTED IN A VERY LONG
TERM AND SUCCESSFUL WAY BY
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS.
IN THE LATE NINETEEN NINETIES
UCLA AND NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
DRUG ADDICTION DID A FIVE YEAR
ROBUST EVALUATION OF CDC OUR
PROGRAMS.
AND WAS ACTUALLY AT ONE OF THE
MD FOUNDATION PROGRAMS AND
SHOWED A 40% REDUCTION OF
RECIDIVISM. FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT
COMPLETED IN PRISON AND
COMMUNITY BASED TREATMENT I
CAN'T STRESS THE IMPORTANCE OF
BOTH IN PRISON AND COMMUNITY
BASED TREATMENT.
THE IMPRISONED TREATMENT A
COMPREHENSIVE AFTER CARE
INCLUSIVE A LONG TERM
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES AND PLAYED PLACEMENT
AND PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
IS ESSENTIAL FOR A THREE PRONGED
APPROACH TO OUR SUCCESSFUL RE
ENTRY.
WE HAVE WORKED IN COLLABORATION
WITH CDC ARE TO IMPROVE AND
ENHANCE SERVICES FOR THOSE
RETURNING HOME FOR MY CAR
SERRATION.
AND FEEL THE SUCCESSFUL REENTRY
MUST BE A COLLABORATIVE IN
COMMUNITY APPROACH.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ARE ESSENTIAL TO SUCCESSFUL
REENTRY PUBLIC SAFETY AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION.
AS MANY MENTION HERE TODAY POST
REALIGNMENT WE'RE SERVING MORE
SERIOUS VIOLENT OFFENDERS IN THE
PRISON SYSTEM THAT HAVE
TYPICALLY DONE LONGER STAYS IN
THE PRISON.
IN PRISON AND NEED MORE
INTENSIVE SERVICES ALL ONE OF
THE OTHER THINGS THAT WAS A
MENTION HERE TODAY.
IS A DIRECT CORRELATION BETWEEN
LENGTH OF STAY IN TREATMENT AND
SUCCESSFUL OUTCOMES.
WE WORK IN COLLABORATION WITH
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES AND I'M
HERE WITH TODAY STANFORD LAW
WEST CARE AND AND DOZENS OF
OTHER COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS.
AND WE ALONE COULD NOT PROVIDE
THESE SERVICES WITHOUT A
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH IN THE
COMMUNITY AND MANY OTHER
PROVIDERS.
IMPRISONING COMMUNITY AFTER CARE
MUST BE LOOKED AT AS ONE
TREATMENT EPISODE THAT TAKES
PLACE IN TWO LOCATIONS THE FIRST
TAKING PLACE INSIDE THE PRISON
BUT IT MUST TRANSITION IN THE
COMMUNITY FOR SUCCESSFUL AFTER
CARE SERVICES.
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH CDC ARE IN
THEIR LEADERSHIP OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS I'VE WORK WITH THE
PREVIOUS SECRETARY IN THE
CURRENT SECRETARY AND EUROPEAN I
FEEL THAT THEY'RE MAKING GREAT
STEPS TO WORK TO LISTEN. TO
PROVIDERS TO INCORPORATE WHAT WE
KNOW IS BEST PRACTICES EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES AND MANY OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
OURS SUCH AS THE DOG PROGRAM.
IN ARTS AND CORRECTION ARE NOT
DIRECTLY INVOLVED WITH OURS BUT
I'VE SEEN THE IMPACT TO THE
SUCCESS OF OUR PROGRAMS.
WE SUPPORT THE NEED FOR MORE
RESEARCH AND OUTCOMES DRIVEN
SERVICE MODELS IN A WORKING IN
COLLABORATION WITH CDC OUR
COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS AND
OTHER STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES DEVELOP A COLLABORATOR
SERVICE MODEL NECESSARY. FOR
THOSE RETURNING HOME TO RECEIVE
ALL OF THE ESSENTIAL SERVICES
SUCH A SUDDEN SOME USE.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PRIMARY CARE
SERVICES EDUCATION VOCATIONAL
TRAINING EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
FAMILY SUPPORT SERVICES IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSING JUST TO NAME
A FEW.
THE LINKAGES BETWEEN AND CUSTODY
SERVICES AS I MENTIONED IN
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR SUCCESSFUL
RECIDIVISM REDUCTION AND WE HOPE
TO SEE MORE SUPPORT FOR THE
SERVICES IN THE FUTURE.
IF I WAS GOING TO SHARE THIS OR
NOT I WENT BACK AND FORTH ON IT
BUT I WANT TO SHARE ONE MORE
STORY -- THERE'S A SEVEN YEAR
OLD GIRL WHO LOST HER MOTHER AND
GRANDMOTHER LAST YEAR TO A
HEROIN OVERDOSE IN A FATHER
WHOSE ONLY SEEN A FEW MONTHS IN
OUR LIFE.
HIGHS BEEN INCARCERATED FIVE
TIMES NOW.
SHE'S INTELLIGENT YOUNG LOVING
BEAUTIFUL YOUNG GIRL AND
UNFORTUNATELY SHE LIVES IN A
STATE WHERE THESE KIND OF
SERVICES ARE SIMPLY JUST NOT
AVAILABLE BOTH FOR HER MOTHER
AND FOR HER FATHER -- THAT THE
YOUNG LADY IS MY NIECE I'M IN
THE PROCESS OF WORKING ON THE
ADOPTION RIGHT NOW WITH MY WIFE
AND DAUGHTER BRINGING HER HERE
TO CALIFORNIA.
I WANT TO MENTION THAT BECAUSE
EVERYTHING WE DISCUSS HERE HAS A
VERY HUMAN AND HAPPEN TO IT -- I
IN I DID SHARE THAT STORY NOT
JUST TO SHOW -- THE HUMAN ASPECT
OF IT BUT JUST TO REMIND THAT
CALIFORNIA IS TAKING PROGRESSIVE
STEPS WE LOOK AT SO MANY
EVIDENCE BASED MODELS THAT ARE
IN OTHER STATES.
CALIFORNIA TRULY SHOULD BE AN
EVIDENCE BASED MODEL WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE NEEDS TO BE EVALUATED
AND IT DOES NEED TO BE THE
EVIDENCE BASED MODEL MANY OF THE
THINGS WE TALKED ABOUT AND I'VE
HEARD TODAY.
ARE MODELS THAT ARE REPLICATED
FROM OTHER STATES AND I'D REALLY
LIKE TO SEE CALIFORNIA BECOME
THE LEADER IN TERMS OF
RECIDIVISM REDUCTION.
IN THE UNITED STATES.
JUST A FEW PROGRAMS THAT I THINK
WERE MENTIONED HERE EARLIER
TODAY'S M. C. R. P. PROGRAMMER
THE MEN'S COMMUNITY RANCHER
PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS PEOPLE TO
STAY THE LAST YEAR THERE SENS ON
AN ANKLE MONITOR IN THE
COMMUNITY.
AND THOSE PROGRAMS ARE SEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL RESULTS WE COUPLED
WITH -- THE LIFE FOR PROGRAMS
WERE LIFERS ARE ACTUALLY SERVING
AS MENTORS THEY'RE RECEIVING
SOME OF THE SERVICES THEY NEED.
AND WE'RE ACTUALLY ABLE TO HIRE
A LARGE AMOUNT OF OUR WORK FORCE
IT'S FORMALLY INCARCERATED I
THINK THE STATE SHOULD ALSO LOOK
AT PROVIDERS THAT EMPLOYEE MEN
AND WOMEN THAT ARE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED.
AND SHOULD PROVIDE PATHWAYS OF
EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE NONPROFITS A
COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS ARE A
LARGE EMPLOYER IN THE COMMUNITY
AS WELL.
JUST A LITTLE BIT OF A DATA
POINT HERE AND ONE THING THAT
OFTEN GETS LEFT OUT IS YOUR
SEVEN TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE RE
INCARCERATED A RETURN TO PRISON
IF YOU'RE HOMELESS.
THERE'S A HUGE DISCONNECT IN
TERMS OF THE SERVICES THAT ARE
PROVIDED HERE AND ACCESS TO
PERMANENT AFFORDABLE AND SAFE
HOUSING -- I TRULY DO BELIEVE.
IN THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
DISCUSSION ON RETURN ON
INVESTMENT I BELIEVE THAT IF
WE'RE GIVEN THE ELEMENTS FOR
SUCCESSFUL REENTRY SERVICES WE
SHOULD ABSOLUTELY BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE TO THOSE STANDARDS.
THEN THERE SHOULD BE A DIRECT
RETURN ON THAT INVESTMENT --
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT IN TERMS
OF BEST PRACTICES IN EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES ARE A LOT OF AT
BEST PRACTICES THAT COMPLEMENT
OUR EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES OF
NO **** OFF ABSOLUTELY BE
INCLUDED.
SOME OF THE WORK FORCE AS I
MENTION IS ESSENTIAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT EMPLOYMENT AND WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A 85% PLACEMENT
RATE INTO EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
ENDED SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENT.
WHEN THEY'RE IN OUR COMMUNITY
BASED PROGRAMS AND I'LL JUST AND
ON THE NOTE THAT AGAIN I REALLY
EMPLOYEE DID LOOK AT THE LENGTH
OF STAY IN TREATMENT IT IS NOT
SIMPLY JUST PUTTING PEOPLE IN
SLOTS AND FILLING PROGRAMS?
AND CYCLING THEM THROUGH AND
SHORT TERM STAYS WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING THAT'S LONG TERM AND
COMPREHENSIVE AND THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING THESE.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT AND I
THINK THAT'S WE WERE MENTIONING
UP HERE'S THE HUMANITY AND ALL
OF THIS AND NOT.
MISTER JONES SAWYER SAID WIDGETS.
AND SO PUSH IT THAT PLEASE
CONTINUE.
WHAT WHAT IS START OUT WITH WITH
GOOD AFTERNOON IS NOW GOOD
EVENING -- SIR CHAIRED THAT THE
NUMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
JOHN JENKINS SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT -- FOR FOR WEST CARE
AND WERE ALSO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDES
SERVICES TO THE MOST --
CRITICALLY NEEDED -- POPULATION
ARE INDIGENT POPULATION AND IN
THE COMMUNITY WE PROVIDE
SERVICES SUCH AS CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SERVICES TREATMENT AND
REHABILITATION MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELLNESS -- VETERANS SERVICES
AND EDUCATION PREVENTION AS WELL
AS HOUSING SERVICES.
WE ALSO PROVIDE SERVICES THAT
SEVEN OF THE LOCATION SEVEN OF
THE IN PRISON LOCATIONS THAT THE
RP -- HAS WE ALSO PROVIDE -- TO
SERVICES AT TWO COMMUNITY -- TO
CUSTODY TO COMMUNITY
TRANSITIONAL REENTRY PROGRAMS
WHICH IS THE SISTER PROGRAM TO
THE M. C. R. P. IT'S CALLED C.
C. TRP IT'S FOR FOR FOR WOMEN IN
WHERE WOMEN CAN BE -- COME INTO --
COMMUNITY SETTING.
AND FINISH THE REST OF THEIR
SENTENCE -- WE ALSO PROVIDE
SERVICES AND WHAT'S CALLED STOP
IS SPECIALIZED TREATMENT FOR
OPTIMIZED PROGRAMMING THERE'S
THAT'S THE AFTER CARE NETWORK
FOR IMPRISONED TREATMENT
PROGRAMS -- I HAVE TO AGREE WITH
MY COLLEAGUE BEFORE ME THAT WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT TREATMENT INSIDE.
COUPLED WITH THE COMMUNITY AS
ONE EPISODE.
AND THAT EPISODE NEEDS TO NOT BE
BROKEN -- YOU DON'T BREAK A
CYCLE OF TREATMENT SO IF YOU IF
YOU'RE PROVIDING TREATMENT IN
THE INSTITUTION IT NEEDS TO GO
FROM THE INSTITUTION TO THE
COMMUNITY.
NOT FROM TREATMENT BACK TO
GENERAL POPULATION.
AND THEN LATER TO BE IN THE
INSTITUTE IN THE COMMUNITY SO IT
NEEDS TO BE ONE PROGRESSIVE --
EPISODE -- I'D LIKE.
TO YOU KNOW REALLY TALK ABOUT
THE COMMUNITY TO CUSTODY REENTRY
PROGRAM -- ALSO KNOWN AS C. C.
T. R. P. WESKER OPERATES TO
THESE PROGRAMS ONES AND SAN
DIEGO IS A HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
BAD PROGRAM AND THE OTHER ONE IN
STOCKTON CALIFORNIA WAS JUST A
FIFTY PROGRAM.
THESE ARE PROGRAMS -- FOR WOMEN
WHO ARE SERVING THE REMAINDER OF
THEIR SENTENCE IN THE COMMUNITY
AND A COMMUNITY PROGRAM.
LIKE THE M. C. R. PEAS A ALL
HAVE -- ANKLE MONITORS ON THEY
CAN COME THERE THEY HAVE A
LITTLE BIT LONGER STAY SO THEY
CAN COME WITH A MINIMUM OF FORTY
FIVE DAYS LEFT ON THEIR SENTENCE.
UP TO TWO YEARS LEFT ON THEIR
SENS WHILE THEY'RE THERE THEY
CAN RECEIVE -- DRUG AND ALCOHOL
EDUCATION BUDGETING --
EDUCATIONAL THINGS THAT AT A
CERTAIN POINT THEY CAN GO OUT
AND START GOING BACK TO SCHOOL
GET A JOB SAVE MONEY IT'S NOT
UNCOMMON WE HAD A LADY THAT --
CLEATED COMPLETED THE PROGRAM
NOT TOO LONG AGO THAT LEFT --
WHILE PAYING HER RESTITUTION AND
ALL THINGS FOR A REQUIRED LEFT
WITH NINETEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
SAVED TO RE INTEGRATE BACK INTO
THE INTO THE COMMUNITY.
AND I THINK THAT THESE PROGRAMS
SHOULD BE SOMETHING THAT ARE
LOOKED AT TO BE REPLICATED
BECAUSE THEY ALLOW THAT SLOWER --
REINTEGRATION BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY OF THEY ALLOW THAT
TIME AND I THINK THEY ARE
SUCCESSFUL -- I DON'T HAVE ANY
LONG TERM DATE ON IT BUT I CAN
TELL YOU OUT OF THE TWO PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE -- STARTING JUST
FROM JULY TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
UP UNTIL MARCH OF THIS YEAR WE
HAD -- FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FIVE WOMEN DOES CHARGE THE
PROGRAM.
OF THAT FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY
WERE SUCCESSFULLY DISCHARGED --
ON A PAROLE AND SO THAT'S A
SEVENTY NINE POINT 2% SUCCESS
RATE AND THESE ARE ALL VOLUNTEER
PROGRAMS SO -- THEIR WOMEN THE
VOLUNTEER FOR THE PROGRAM COME
THERE AND IF THEY DON'T WANT TO
BE IN THE PROGRAM THEY CAN ASK
TO BE.
SENT BACK -- THE OTHER PROGRAM
I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT IS THE
SPECIALIZED TREATMENT FOR
OPTIMIZE PROGRAMMING THE STOP
PROGRAM AND THAT'S THE AFTER
CARE.
NOW WORK FOR OUR IN PRISON
TREATMENT PROGRAMS -- THIS
RELIES ON COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS IN EACH COUNTY -- TO BE
THE RE ENTRY -- LOCATION FOR
PEOPLE COMING OUT IT'S
PRIORITIZE FOR PEOPLE WITHIN THE
FIRST YEAR OF RELEASE HE EITHER
UPON RELEASE OF THE FIRST YEAR
OF RELEASE.
BUT ANYBODY ON PAROLES ELIGIBLE --
THIS PROGRAM I THINK IS IS
SUCCESSFUL IT RELIES ON GOOD
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS THAT
ARE THAT ARE IN EACH COMMUNITY
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES THEY CAN
PROVIDE RESIDENTIAL.
OUTPATIENT AND SOBER LIVING IN
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING SERVICES --
I THINK THAT THE PROGRAM COULD
USE SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING
BECAUSE THERE IS NOT WALT WHILE
THE R. P. I THINK ALLOCATES ALL
FUNDING THAT THEY HAVE TOWARDS
IT -- THERE IS A GREATER NEED OF
PEOPLE COME IN -- PER ALL COMING
TO US FOR PLACEMENTS THEN WE
HAVE THE THE ABILITY TO PLAY
SINCE AWAITING LESSER ARE --
HAPPENING BECAUSE OF THAT WITHIN
THE STOP NETWORK WE ARE WORKING
WITH THE R. P. TO LEVERAGE MEDI
CAL THROUGH THE ORGANIZED
DELIVERY SYSTEM.
AND I KNOW THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT
HOW DO WE LEVERAGE OTHER FUNDING --
BUT I THINK THE KEY THING IS TO
REALIZE HAT NUMBER ONE IT.
AND SOME COUNTIES DIDN'T OFTEN.
PERIOD SO IT'S NOT AVAILABLE IN
EVERY COUNTY SO WE ARE WORKING
WITH THEM TO ROLL THIS OUT AND
USE THAT TO TO LEVERAGE THE
FUNDS -- I THINK THAT -- WHEN I
WHEN I LOOK AT THIS I LOOK AT
WE TALK ABOUT EVIDENCE BASED
PROGRAMMING SOMETIMES EVIDENCE
BASED PROGRAM IS A LITTLE TRICKY.
BECAUSE YOU TALK ABOUT EVIDENCE
BASED PROGRAMMING PRACTICES.
WELL THESE PROGRAMS A LOT OF
TIMES WHEN THEY GET ON THESE ON
THESE LISTS WERE DONE.
IN A REALLY.
HEIGHTENED CONTROLLED
ENVIRONMENT WHETHER SPECIFIC
POPULATION WITH SPECIFIC FUNDING
LEVELS -- FOR A SPECIFIC PERSON
AND IT'S NOT ALWAYS REP OF
GLOBAL EXACTLY -- SO WE HAVE TO
WATCH APPLES FOR APPLES IS THAT
REALLY THE SAME POPULATION IS IT
REALLY THE SAME CONDITIONS IS IT
REALLY.
IS EVERYTHING THE SAME SO IF YOU
WANT TO DO THE STATS THEN YOU
REALLY HAVE TO COMPARE APPLES TO
APPLES -- YOU CAN'T SAY WELL
THIS POPULATION GOT TO GO
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM --
SPECIFICALLY WITH NO
INTERRUPTIONS IN THIS POPULATION
WELL YEAH THEY HAD.
HALF THE TIME THEY WERE IN THERE
THEY GOT LOCKED DOWN AND BECAUSE
OF OTHER THINGS THAT HAPPENED.
AND SO HOW DO YOU COMPARE THE
TWO JUST BECAUSE YOU HAVE THE
SAME CURRICULUM DOESN'T MAKE A
COMPARISON OF THE TWO I THINK
CDC ARE WORKS.
OUT REALLY GOOD AND WE'VE HAD
GOOD CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM
ABOUT THE RIGHT PERSON.
IN THE RIGHT PROGRAM AT THE
RIGHT TIME.
SO I THINK THAT IF YOU DO THAT
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE THE BEST
OUTCOMES -- I THINK THAT WE NEED
TO LOOK AT UGH.
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT -- CDC ARE
NEED SOME FLEXIBILITY IN THERE
AND SOME OF THEIR CONTRACTING TO
ADAPT TO CHANGES THAT HAPPEN.
CHANGES IN THE ENVIRONMENT
CHANGES AND SO WE HAVE A
CONTRACT THAT COMES ALONG AND
NOW ALL THE SUDDEN YOU HAVE WILL
JUST GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE THE
ORGANIZED DELIVERY SYSTEM AND
NOW -- MEDICAID MEDICARE WAS
PAYING FOR RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
WILL WHAT USED TO BE A LEVEL OF
REIMBURSEMENT WILL SAY IS EIGHTY
ONE DOLLARS A DAY IS NOW GONE UP
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE DOLLARS
A DAY IN YOUR BE ABLE TO HIRE
STAFF.
AT HIGHER SALARIES AND THINGS
LIKE THIS AND SO THE MARKET
CHANGES AND IF YOU'RE STUCK IN
CONTRACTS FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND
YOU CAN'T ADAPT TO THOSE MARKET
CHANGES.
THAT MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT TO
HIRE STAFF RETAIN STAFF AND DO
THOSE THINGS AND WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT -- ALSO -- WHAT THEY'RE
WHAT THE STAFFING YOU KNOW
[inaudible]
VACANCIES ARE.
UNLESS YOU KNOW STAFF MEMBERS
GONNA DO SOME.
STRANGE THAT'S GET OUT GET THEM
FIRED ARE THERE GOING TO GO LOOK
FOR A JOB AND THEY TELL USE
SEVERAL TIMES MONTHS IN ADVANCE.
IF SOMEBODY JUST LEAVES ARE AS
REMOVED FROM A PROGRAM.
IT'S TIME ONE TO ADVERTISE TO TO
GET A BACKGROUND CLARENCE DONE.
THREE TO DO YOU KNOW DO YOUR
INTERVIEWING AND ALL THAT.
YOUR YOUR PHYSICAL YOUR YOUR
DRUG TEST BACKGROUND TO SO IT
TAKES TIME SO IT'S VIRTUALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO KEEP THESE
PROGRAMS FAILED STAFFING WISE A
100% OF THE TIME -- IT JUST IS --
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE DON'T
STRIVE FOR IT BUT IS IT IS TOUGH --
I THIS REMINDS ME OF A OF A
QUOTE THAT -- HARRY TRUMAN'S
THAT IT SAYS IT'S AMAZING WHAT
YOU CAN DO WHEN YOU ACCOMPLISH.
IT'S AMAZING WHAT YOU CAN
ACCOMPLISH IF YOU DON'T CARE WHO
GETS THE CREDIT.
I THINK THAT ALSO NEEDS TO LOOK
AT WHO TAKES THE BLAME.
AND I THINK WE HAVE A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE WITH CDC
ARE IN THE RP I THINK WE ALL
TAKE THE BLAME FOR SOME OF THE
RESULTS -- SOME OTHER THINGS --
THAT AND I APPLAUD THEIR
OPENNESS TO LISTEN DASS
PROVIDERS AS VENDORS IN TO SAY
HEY THIS DOESNT WORK -- THIS
DOESN'T WORK IF -- WE NEED TO
MAKE A CHANGE HERE THIS ISN'T
GONNA GIVE US A SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOME AND I THINK THAT THEY
ARE LISTENING.
AND THEY ARE WILLING TO TO MAKE
THE CHANGE AND MAYBE THE AUDIT
DIDN'T SHOW THAT BUT I COULD
TELL YOU OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
THEM SHOWS ADAPTABILITY AND AND
BEING WILLING TO CHANGE -- BUT I
THINK IT TAKES A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME YEAH AND I THINK THAT'S
WHERE EVERYONE'S EXPERIENCE OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR A LONG TIME.
CAN HELP INFORM THE DISCUSSION
ARE ACTUALLY LOOKING AT THE
OUTCOME SO IT'S NOT IT'S LOOKING
AT THE DATA BUT LOOKING THROUGH
IT WITH THE LANDS OF ONE
COMPARING APPLES APPLES.
MAYBE YOU'RE COMPARING YOU KNOW
A LEVEL TWO IN MAY TO A LEVEL
TWO IN MAY BUT WHAT FACILITY AND
SEE WHAT THOSE TRENDS ARE.
BECAUSE YOU CAN YOU KNOW LOOK AT
ONE FACILITY AND MAYBE IT WAS A
LOCK DOWN A LOT MORE OFTEN THAN
ANOTHER FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS.
BUT SEEING WHAT THOSE OUTCOMES
ARE.
AND I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT IS -- WHAT ARE THOSE
BEST OUTCOMES AND THAT'S WHY WE
KEEP?
ASKING FOR THE ANALYTICS I THINK
THE AUDITOR'S REPORT IS ASKING
FOR THOSE.
NOT TO SAY SOMEONE'S DOING
SOMETHING WRONG.
BUT TO REALLY INFORM THE
DISCUSSION ON HOW DO WE KEEP
DOING IT RIGHT.
HOW MUCH OF THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
DOING IT RIGHT AND HOW DO WE
MAXIMIZE ON THAT?
I APPRECIATE YOUR GUISES
TESTIMONY BECAUSE I DO THINK AND
IT NEEDS TO BE A WRAPAROUND
SERVICES THINK -- THAT'S WHAT --
MISS CHAMPION WAS TALKING ABOUT.
IT AND ALL OF YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT HOW DO WE DO IT DIGEST.
NCDC ARW BUT WHEN THEY COME OUT
AND I KNOW I'VE BEEN PRIVY TO
SEE SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS -- IN
MY OWN BACKYARD WHERE.
IF NAY MAY TRULY WANTS TO NOT GO
BACK IN THE SYSTEM IS HOW DO WE
CONNECT THEM WITH THE SERVICES.
TO GIVE THEM THE MAXIMUM.
CHANCE AT AT SUCCESS.
AT HOLDING DOWN A JOB AT
CONNECTING WITH SERVICES IF THE
NEED SERVICES SPECIALLY IF THEY
HAVE CHILDREN AND LOVED ONES.
RIGHT IN THAT AS A MOTIVATION TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE THEM FORWARD
SOME JUST ASK A GENERAL QUESTION
OF ALL OF YOU AND THAT'S JUST --
YOU KNOW WHAT MORE WOULD YOU
GUYS NEED FROM SAY EITHER CDC
ARE THE STATE TO ACTUALLY HELP
WITH THESE OUTCOMES BECAUSE I
THINK WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME PAGE
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE WANT TO
ACHIEVE.
SO IS THERE SOMETHING THAT
YOU'VE IDENTIFIED. TO HELP WITH
THAT LOVE TO HEAR YOUR RESPONSES.
THIS BIG GENERALLY ALLEYS OUR
PROGRAM HAS A RE ENTRY PROGRAM
THAT WE DESIGNED WITH FORMER
INMATES.
THROUGH THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION WE HAVE FORMER FORMER
INMATES PICK UP.
FROM THE PRISON GATES THEY ARE
IN A POSITION TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND THEM.
THAT PROGRAM WAS PICKED UP BY
THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE AND SO WE
STARTED DOING THAT FOR FEDERAL
CLEMENCY RECIPIENTS SO WE WOULD
HAVE OUR TEAM OF FORMERLY
INCARCERATED GO MEET THEM.
PICK THEM UP THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THESE FEDERAL INMATES WOULD
GO ON TO WHAT'S CALLED OF
RESIDENTIAL REENTRY CENTER RC.
TWO IF YOU'RE A FEDERAL INMATE
WE FOUND IT AMAZING TO KNOW THAT.
OUR CLIENTS WERE ACTUALLY GOING
SOME PLACE WHERE THEY WOULD HAVE
SECURITY WHERE THEY WOULD HAVE.
SOME STRUCTURE WHERE THEY
WOULDN'T BE A BURDEN ON THEIR
FAMILIES WHERE THEY HAVE ACCESS
TO SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
PROGRAMMING WHERE THEY WOULD
HAVE THE ABILITY TO GET THEIR
DRIVER'S LICENSE OR SOCIAL
SECURITY CARD IN THERE IS THAT
ALL THE PAPERWORK THAT THEY NEED.
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO SOME
VOCATIONAL TRAINING AND TO WORK
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY.
I'M WE FOUND THAT MODEL.
WELL SOMEWHAT -- UNEVENLY
ADMINISTERED EVERY STATE HAD
THERE ARE SEASON EVERYBODY HAD
ACCESS TO THE R. C. ANYBODY WAS
COMING OUT COULD GO AND MOST DID
GO TO THE R. C..
AND WE FELT THAT THAT REALLY WAS.
AN INCREDIBLE.
VALUE AND A RELIEF TO THEM TO
KNOW THAT THEY HAD A PLACE TO GO.
AND THAT THAT PLACE WAS GOING TO
SUPPORT THEM IN THEIR SOBRIETY
GOALS IN THEIR LOCATION UNCLES
IN THEIR BEHAVIOR REHABILITATION
GOALS.
SO THAT I THINK.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IS AN IDEAL
MODEL HAVING SOMETHING LIKE THAT
IN EVERY COUNTY THAT HAD
CAPACITY BECAUSE I BELIEVE IT'S
BEEN -- SORT OF INTIMATED THAT
THERE'S A GREAT.
NEED FOR MORE OF THESE THAT
THESE SERVICES AND FOR LONGER
PERIODS OF TIME.
KNOW WHAT'S ONE OF THE MODELS
WHERE WE CAN ACTUALLY LOOK TO
WHERE THIS IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING.
THE CZ TRP THEN THE M. C. R.
PAYS THAT WAY THEY HAVE THEY
ALREADY DO IT AND I THINK THAT.
I THINK YOU KNOW ONE OF THE AND
NOW THIS GETS WILL.
WILL.
OUT THERE A LITTLE BIT BUT IF WE
BECAUSE THEY'RE INMATES WHEN
THEY WHEN THEY'RE IN THESE
PROGRAMS.
THEN THEY'RE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDICAL SERVICES SO I THINK THAT
IF THERE WAS A WAY YOU TALK
ABOUT LEGISLATIVELY HOW COULD
YOU DO SOMETHING.
IF THERE WAS A DIFFERENT
DESIGNATION -- AND THEY WEREN'T
NECESSARILY INMATES NUMBER ONE
THEIR HEALTHCARE COSTS WOULD GET
PAID FOR THROUGH MEDICARE ALL
INSTEAD OF CDC ARE -- YOU CAN
ALSO IT WOULDN'T BE A PANACEA SO
WOULDN'T COVER EVERY PLACE BUT
YOU COULD LEVERAGE MEDI CAL FOR
TREATMENT SERVICES IN CERTAIN
LOCATIONS -- THAT COULD REDUCE
SOME COST I THINK ALSO THERE WAS --
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT AND AND I
THINK IT WAS ALREADY SPOKE ABOUT
WITH?
THE S. A. T. F. WHEN YOU'RE IN
YOU'RE IN CUSTODY PROGRAMS IF
YOU CAN HOUSE PEOPLE IN THE
PROGRAM TOGETHER -- AND HOUSE
THEM TOGETHER WHEN THEY'RE IN
THE PROGRAM TO KEEP THEM HOUSE
TOGETHER.
AND IF THEY AND IF THEY IF THEY
PAROLE FROM THAT PROGRAM BECAUSE
ONE YOU HAVE TO YOU HAVE TO
THINK OF IT KIND OF JUST.
TEN IN GENERAL TERMS IF YOU ARE.
IF.
IF YOU HAVE AN ALCOHOLIC AND HE
GOES TO TREATMENT DO YOU WANT
THAT ALCOHOLIC TO GO FROM
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT BACK TO AN
ALCOHOLIC HOME.
EVERY NIGHT.
NO YOU DON'T THAT'S NOT THE BEST
CASE SCENARIO -- FOR CAN THEY
MAKE IT.
CERTAINLY THERE'S BEEN PEOPLE
THAT HAVE DONE IT.
BUT DOES THE STATE STATISTICS
SAY THAT IT'S A LOT MORE
DIFFICULT YES IT IS AND SO IF WE
IF WE TAKE SOMEBODY THAT'S IN A
PROGRAM.
AND THEN YOU PUT HIM BACKINTO A
MIXED HOUSING UNIT WORK NOW I
HAVE TO ACT THIS WAY SO I GOT A
PROTECT MYSELF HERE.
AND THEN I'M SUPPOSED TO GO AND
FLIPPED THE LIGHT SWITCH WHEN I
GO BACK TO PROGRAM.
IT MAKES IT DIFFICULT AND
THEY'RE ALREADY HAVING A
DIFFICULT TIME.
AND SO THEN.
SO THEN TO WHAT I TALKED ABOUT
THE THE SEAMLESS EPISODE THEN TO
TAKE THEM INCOMPLETE THAT
PROGRAM AND THEIR SENTENCE NOT
BE DONE YET. TO PUT THEM BACK IN
THE GENERAL POPULATION YOU'VE
KIND OF SUCK THAT.
EVERYTHING BACK OUT OF THEM --
AND IT AND IT'S HARD CAN THEY
STILL MAKE IT YES THERE'S A
GIVEN THE BEST RESULTS NO I
DON'T THINK SO -- AND I THINK
THAT WE'VE TALKED WITH THE RP
ABOUT I THINK THAT THEY AGREE
WITH US.
AND I THINK THAT THEY'RE LOOKING
AT HOW CAN HOW CAN THEY DO THAT
HOW CAN THEY MAKE THOSE
ADJUSTMENTS.
BUT I DO THINK THAT THE YOU KNOW
THE STOP ARE A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
PROGRAMS THAT ARE SUCCESSFUL THE
THE M. C. R. PEAS IN THE C. C.
T. R. PEAS.
ARE REALLY GOOD EXAMPLES OF
WHERE YOU CAN TAKE THE IN THE
SOMEBODY SENTENCE AND RE
INTEGRATE THEM BACK AND SAY
FULLY WITH THAT SUPPORTS.
AND THEY CAN GET A JOB THEY CAN
CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION.
AND GET THE SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED AT THE SAME TIME.
SO FROM BOCES IN AND SEAN BOTH
EXPRESSED THINGS THAT I WOULD
SUPPORT FULLY AND I WOULD JUST
ADD TO THAT -- THE CERTAINLY
RIGHT NOW THE PROCESS SHOULD BE
WHERE WE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
DOING THE RESEARCH SO ON OUR
FEDERAL GRANTS THERE'S ACTUALLY
A RESEARCH COMPONENT THAT'S
FUNDED BY SAM SO THAT WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR DOING THE
RESEARCH ON OUR OWN PROGRAMS.
THROUGH A THIRD PARTY IN
PROVIDING THAT TO OUR FUNDING
SOURCES -- THAT'S THAN THE
REQUEST FOR QUALIFICATION
PROCESS AND ACTUALLY PUTS A
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE PROVIDER
TO DO SOMETHING IN TERMS OF
SOLVING FOR THE SOLUTION OF
RECIDIVISM REDUCTION -- THERE'S
A BARRIER SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS
WITH EMPLOYMENT SERVICES THAT'S
VERY -- DRIVEN BY WIDGET SO IF
YOU'RE ITS PLACEMENT DRIVEN SO
YOU'RE INCENTIVIZE FOR THE
NUMBER PLACE AND SAID OUR
POPULATIONS CONSIDERED A HIGH
BARRIER POPULATION TO SERVE SO
THE PRISON TO EMPLOYMENT
INITIATIVE EXPANDING ON THAT
BECAUSE THAT WAS ONE OF THE
FIRST.
INITIATIVES THAT SAID YOU WILL
SERVICE HIGH BARRIER POPULATION --
AND FUND EMPLOYMENT SERVICES FOR
THAT AND I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
HOUSING MORE HOUSING SO WHAT
WERE YOUR WHAT SEAN'S ALREADY
TALKED ABOUT THIS IS AN AND A
LOT OF THE PROGRAMS ARE ALREADY
FUNDING IN THE PRISON IN THE
COMMUNITY.
BUT IF PEOPLE CANNOT GET INTO A
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AT THE END OF
ALL THIS YOU MADE A LARGE
INVESTMENT WITH THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT SOMEBODY WILL RETURN BACK
TO CAR INCARCERATIONS.
I JUST WANT TO ADD ONE THING TOO
IS THAT NOT EVERYBODY WHO COMES
OUT OF CDC OUR CUSTODY IS ON
PAROLE.
AND IN MANY CASES IF YOU'RE NOT
ON PAROLE OR IF THAT THERE'S A
PROGRAM THAT'S DESIGNATED FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE ON PAROLE.
THAT'S A HUGE BARRIER TO A LARGE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO JUST LEFT
PRISON BUT THEY DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THESE PROGRAMS BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT IN THE RIGHT
DESIGNATION AND OPENING THOSE
SERVICES UP. TO ANYONE WHO'S
LEFT PRISON BUT ALSO I THINK BE
A HUGE -- POSITIVE.
WHICH I THINK IS -- WOULD ADD TO
THAT JUST SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO BE TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION
BECAUSE YOU HAVE EVERY COUNTY
DOING SOMETHING DIFFERENT IN
TERMS OF RE ENTRY SERVICES.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE PAROLE
SYSTEM PROVIDING COMPREHENSIVE
ROBUST COMMUNITY SERVICES IN A
CERTAIN DESIGN WAY.
THANK YOU ONE METER FOR MISTER
JONES SAWYER.
AND SO I I KIND OF ONE OF FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DO DO PROGRAMS ON THE
OUTSIDE INSIDE HOW TO BLEND AND
WE PUT THEM WE REALLY DO
PROBABLY NEED TO SIT.
AND HAVE THAT DISCUSSION -- AS
MR SALAS WHAT WILL TELL YOU.
AN INSTA VOEPEL THERE'S THERE
BEEN EVEN TIMES WERE REACH SAID.
LOOK SOMEONE'S EIGHTY YEARS OLD
THEY'RE IN PRISON.
THE ONE LEG A DIABETIC THAT'S ON
DIALYSIS AND WE HAVE MEMBERS ARE
SAFE LET THEM STAY.
BECAUSE THEY'RE DANGEROUS.
AND BUT WE CAN GET HIM OUT.
AND THEN MAKE WE CAN PUT HIM ON
THE FEDERAL -- TAXPAYERS IS IT --
DOLLAR TOLL.
BUT NO WE'RE NOT GONNA LET THEM
OUT AND SO -- WHAT?
I DON'T KNOW IF WE NEED TO TALK
TO YOU ABOUT WHAT KIND OF SAFE
ENVIRONMENT.
CAN WE KEEP THE ONE LADY
DIABETIC.
THAT'S ON DIALYSIS WHAT KIND OUR
GROUP HOME OR WORKING WE PUT IN
WHERE PEOPLE FEEL SAFE THAT DOES
INDIVIDUAL.
WON'T ROB A BANK THE NEXT DAY SO
MAYBE WE NEED TO WORK TOGETHER
TO FIGURE THAT OUT.
BECAUSE I'M PRETTY SURE --
SECRETARY DS WOULD LOVE TO GET
SOME MALES EXPENSES OFF OF HIS
MEDICAL SIDE -- COULD BE IT
COULD HELP A LOT AND SO WE LET'S.
MAYBE WE CAN WORK TOGETHER. TO
TO FIGURE THAT OUT SO THAT WE
CAN LEGISLATE TO DONOVAN AND
THERE WERE -- FORMER LIFERS THAT
BECAUSE OF BEING PARDON OR
WHATEVER THEY'RE NOW OUT.
THEY'RE GOING BACK IN
[inaudible] TO DONOVAN ARE KIND
OF THEIR OWN PRO IS JUST KINDA
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION I JUST.
SOME SPORADIC PROGRAM IS SO
PAGES PLEASE LIFERS ARE GOING IN.
WITH THE WITH THE UNDERSTANDING
FROM THE WARDEN TO DATE THEY'VE
WORKED IT OUT THEY WERE DOES
SECURITY CONCERNS OBVIOUSLY.
AND AND I'VE HEARD THESE LIFERS.
SAY IT'S PROBABLY ONE THE BEST
THING THAT'S EVER HAPPENED.
AND AND THEN BEING NAIVE I'VE
I'VE SAID THINGS LIKE WHAT TELL
YOU SAME THING ABOUT YOU KNOW
YOU NEED TO STAY IN SCHOOL.
LEARN A TRADE AND ALL THAT AND
THEY'LL GIVE IT A YEAH BUT
YOU'RE NEVER LIFE.
FOR YOU KNOW WHEN WHEN WHEN THEY
PUSH BACK ON ME I YOU KNOW I I
CAN'T I DON'T KNOW IT'S LIKE I
DON'T KNOW WHY THEY GOT TO THAT.
POINT I DON'T KNOW HOW I DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO SAY TO GET SOMEONE
OUT THESE GUYS.
TO AND A RESPECTED AND SO HOW DO
WE GROW THAT PROGRAM WERE FORMER
LIFERS CAN COME IN.
AND ACTUALLY START TALKING TO
INDIVIDUAL ABOUT WHAT IS WHAT DO
THEY NEED. TO GO OUT AND SOMEONE
JUST SAID.
HE'D.
HE JUST SAID THE RIGHT THING.
HE KNEW HE COULD FEEL MY PAIN HE
COULD HE UNDERSTOOD MY TRAUMA
WHEN I WAS YOUNGER.
WE MET FACT WE HAVE THE SAME
PROBLEM AND WE WENT TO THE SAME
TERRIBLE PATH.
AND NOW WHEN HE SAYS YOU NEED TO
DO THIS THIS THIS THIS AND THAT
TO GET OUT OF HERE IT MAKES
SENSE TO ME BECAUSE HE DID IT.
IF I TOLD SAME THING.
YOU KNOW SELECT YOUR CHILDREN IN
TERMS OF AN OVER OVER AGAIN AND
THEN.
SIR FROM STEP ONE IS TO HEAR
FROM SOMEBODY ELSE LIKE MR
SOLACE THEY ALL YEAH IS A GREAT
IDEA AND SO -- IF WE COULD
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO MORE THOSE
WROTE ROBUST PROGRAMS AND AND
YOU CAN COMMENT ON THAT TOO AND
THEN THE LAST.
THE LAST THING.
I READ THAT THE FIRST LADY OF
NEW YORK.
IS WORKING WITH FEMALE INMATES
TO CONNECTING WITH THEIR
CHILDREN.
AND FAMILIES AND SO I STE I
STARTED LEGISLATION THAT WAS
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR SO THAT --
WHEN WE JUST HAD CHILDREN COULD
STILL BREASTFEED?
BECAUSE IT IS IN MY OPINION --
WHETHER GOING ON DRUGS WHETHER
YOU'RE FOLLOWING SOME
CRIMINALITY WHETHER WHATEVER
YOU'RE DOING THAT'S BAD.
I STILL THINK.
THIS THIS INSTINCT TO BE A
MOTHER.
WELL OVERCOME A LOT OF THAT AND
WE NEED OF STAR FOSTER IN AT AND
SO I THINK.
THE THE NEW YORK.
IN REIKERS THEY ACTUALLY ARE
CONNECTING.
THE CHILDREN I DON'T KNOW HOW
IT'S DONE IT'S GOT TO BE SOME
OUTSIDE INSIDE THING -- SO THAT
OUR INTER FUNNY THAT THESE THESE
WOMEN WHO ARE INCARCERATED.
ARE GOING OUT OF THEIR WAY. TO
GET THESE PROGRAMS TO CUT DOWN
THERE THE THIRD TIME THE CREDIT
TIME AND ALL OF THAT SO YOU CAN
GET OUT AND GET RECONNECTED TO
HER FAMILY.
BECAUSE ONCE YOU'RE DISCONNECTED
FROM YOUR FAMILY YOU'RE.
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE IN THAT.
YOU'RE CUTTING THAT PRISON
POPULATION MENTALITY YOU DON'T
WANT TO GET OUT AND SO HOW DO WE
HOW DO WE FIGURE THAT OUT.
SO WE CAN MAYBE IT'S TO DO THAT
AND CDC ARE -- SO SOON IN IN THE
WOMEN'S FACILITIES -- AND I
THINK WE COULD GET SOME AMAZING --
RESULTS FROM THAT IF WE WERE.
TO HAVE WOMEN -- STAY CONNECTED
TO THEIR CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
SO PICK ONE ANYONE OR JUST.
IN GENERAL START WITH THE FIRST
THE FIRST ONE IN TERMS AYE
UTILIZES OF HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS
I THINK THAT IS THE APPROPRIATE
APPROACH IS TO WORK WITH LOCAL
RESOURCES IN TERMS OF COUNTY AS
WE WORK ON THIS PROGRAM IN LOS
ANGELES.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT HEALTH
SERVICES SO INDIVIDUALS LIKE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT
SHOULDN'T BE IN THE PRISON
SYSTEM AND ARE BETTER SERVED IN
A COMMUNITY BASED SETTING WITH
WRAPAROUND.
COMPREHENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TIED TO
THEM IS A MUCH BETTER APPROACH
AND WERE SEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
RESULTS IN THAT LOS ANGELES I'D
BE HAPPY.
TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU IN TERMS
OF THE LIFERS WORK WITH A OR C.
ON THAT PROGRAM AND SUPPORT THEM
THERE ARE A A WONDERFUL
ORGANIZATION I CAN'T SAY ENOUGH
ABOUT LIFERS WE ACTUALLY HIRE.
A NUMBER OF FORMER LIFERS AN
ORGANIZATION WE HAVE A FACILITY
THAT'S ENTIRELY DEDICATED TO
FORMER LIFERS THERE WE JUST OPEN
IT THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
WHAT WORKED WITH US ON ABOUT SIX
MONTHS AGO.
AND THAT'S A WONDERFUL PROGRAM
AS YOU HEARD SECRETARY IDEAS SAY
THE RETURN RATE FOR LIFERS IS
ABOUT 3% BUT THE MARGIN OF ERROR.
WITH SERVING LIFERS IS EVEN LESS
THAN THAT SO WE HAVE TO BE
CAREFUL IN TERMS OF PROVIDING
THOSE SERVICES IN THE COMMUNITY.
BUT THEY'RE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
PART OF OUR WORK FORCE IN THEIR
EIGHT EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL IN
TERMS OF MENTORING A YOUNGER
GENERATION OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
COMING THROUGH THE SYSTEM NOW.
ANY THAT SUPPORT AND THEN I'LL
JUST SAY FINALLY BECAUSE OF
COURSE I WAS IMPACTED BY
PROGRAMS LIKE THAT.
I CAN'T SAY ENOUGH ABOUT FAMILY
REUNIFICATION PROGRAMS I BELIEVE
THERE'S A VERY SMALL ONE THAT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ALLOWS
FOR UP TO FIVE YEARS I BELIEVE --
WHILE THEY'RE STILL INCARCERATED
I CAN'T THINK OF THE ACRONYM FOR
RIGHT NOW YOU CAN FIND IT OUT
LET ME KNOW AND THAT OUT AND I
BELIEVE THERE'S ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY BEDS -- IN LA COUNTY
I BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE OPERATING
WITH ACTUALLY ALLOW WOMEN TO
REUNITE WITH THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS BUT WOULD LOVE TO SEE
MORE OF THOSE KIND OF PROGRAMS
AND THEY HAVE PROGRAMS LIKE
PHOTO.
THAT ACTUALLY ALLOW WOMEN.
TO I'M OUT ON ALTERNATIVE
CUSTODY ANKLE MONITORS AND
REUNITE WE ACTUALLY FUND THOSE
PROGRAMS THERE ARE STOP SERVICES
AND SHAUN DOES AS WELL.
IN THE COST OF THAT IS
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS THAN BEING
INCARCERATE YES AND THE IMPACT
IS IMMEASURABLE IN SOME CASES
LIKE I MENTIONED YOU KNOW THAT
NOBODY EVER TRACKS WHAT THE TRUE
COST IS TO A FAMILY.
WITH THE TRUE IMPACT IS TO THE
CHILDREN THAT ARE ACTUALLY
BROUGHT THROUGH THOSE SERVICES
AND WE ALWAYS FOCUS ON THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT'S INCARCERATED
WHICH IS GOOD.
BUT THERE'S SO MANY -- INDIRECT
RIPPLE EFFECTS OF IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING THOSE SERVICES
SUCCESSFULLY IN THE COMMUNITY.
CAN I MAKE THAT YOUR DAD ON TO
THE TO LIVE FOR PEACE THERE
THOSE ARE THE MOST -- MOTIVATED
INDIVIDUALS YOU'LL SEE THEY THEY
KNOW THEY GOT THEIR ONE CHANCE
THIS IS MY ONE SHOT AND I'M NOT
GONNA MESS THIS UP THAT'S WHY
THERE'S ALL.
THE LOW RECIDIVISM RATE THAN
THEIR SERIOUS -- THEY KNOW WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO AND I THINK THE
OUR PEACE BEEN VERY GOOD ABOUT
ALLOWING LIFERS TO BE HIRED AND
AND PUT INTO THE PROGRAM AND SO.
THAT HAS BEEN SOMETHING THAT'S
BEEN A CHANGE IN THE IN THE NEW
REGIME AND THEY'VE REALLY LOOKED
AT THAT AND SAID.
HEY WE CAN SEE THE SUCCESSFUL
ELEMENT WE KNOW THAT THAT --
HAVE IN A MIXTURE OF PEOPLE WITH
LIFE EXPERIENCE AND EDUCATION
AND AND YOU BILL AND THOSE TWO
TOGETHER YOU CAN GET SOME REALLY
GOOD RESULTS.
THE OTHER THING ON YOUR ON YOUR
OTHER POPULATION THE ONLY I
THINK THAT YOU'RE RIGHT THERE IS
A PLACE FOR THEM AND IT CAN
HAPPEN IN THE COMMUNITY WE JUST
HAVE TO BE CAREFUL AND I SAY.
THE RIGHT PROGRAM FOR THE RIGHT
PERSON AT THE RIGHT TIME.
BECAUSE WE CAN'T WELL WE DON'T
WANT TO DO IS WE DON'T WANT TO
JUST SAY.
WELL WE'RE GONNA PUT THIS PERSON
THAT'S ELDERLY THAT'S DIABETIC
THAT'S YOU KNOW DYING INTO A
REHABILITATION PROGRAM FOR DRUG
AND ALCOHOL JUST SO WE CAN GET
HIM OUT THERE BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT BUILT FOR THAT THEY'RE NOT
THEY'RE NOT A SKILLED MILLER
NURSING FACILITY THEY DON'T HAVE
THE STAFFING FOR THAT.
THEY THEY CAN'T -- MANAGED THAT
POPULATION THERE THERE FOR
MANAGING DIFFERENT POPULATION SO
WE JUST HAVE TO LOOK FOR THE
RIGHT PROGRAMS -- THAT FIT THAT
POPULATION AND HOW DO WE HOW DO
WE DO THOSE.
THANK YOU.
HI THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT
IF THERE IS ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
I'M I'M HELEN ROTH DELTON FROM
SEIU LOCAL ONE THOUSAND WE
REPRESENT THE WORKERS -- IN THE
STATE FACILITIES THE TEACHERS IN
THERE SOME OF THEM WITH ME.
WHO'VE LISTEN TODAY AND I'M I'M
PASSING OUT SOME RECOMMENDATIONS.
THEY'RE NOT IT'S NOT JUST THE
EVIDENCE BASED BUT THAT YOU NEED
TO LOOK AT SOME OF THE PROGRAM
COMPONENTS THAT ARE GOING INTO
THAT.
WE SUPPORT EVIDENCE BASED
PROGRAMS OBVIOUSLY AND WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET WE ALSO
SUGGEST YOU LOOK AT ZERO WHICH
PUTS OUT WROTE THESE REPORTS ON
A LOT OF WHAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR
IS ALREADY BEING DONE BY THE
STATE AND SO WE WOULD WANT.
TO USE RESOURCES WHEN THEY'RE
ALREADY HERE AND SO LET ME TURN
IT OVER BRIEFLY. TO THIS
GENTLEMAN THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON COULD START WITH
YOUR NAME AND MY NAME IS CHARLES
THOMPSON I AM AN EDUCATOR AT
PELICAN BAY STATE PRISON.
AND I WAS LISTENING TO THE
EVALUATIONS AND EVERYTHING TODAY.
AND KIND OF CAME UP TO STAND UP
FOR THE CREDENTIAL TEACHERS THAT
ARE THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- OUR
CHALLENGES ARE UNIQUE AND I WAS
SITTING THERE THINKING IF I WAS
AN INMATE.
AND YOU GAVE ME AN OPPORTUNITY
TO GOLD LISTEN TO ME TEACH
HISTORY OR GET INTO A PROGRAM
THAT'S PAYING ME A DOLLAR AN
HOUR.
AND GIVEN ME A TRADE.
I'D BE TICKED.
IF YOU WERE SITTING IN MY CLASS
WHEREAS I'D BE EXCITED. TO BE
LIKE IN A P. I. A PROGRAM.
AND THE REASON I I KIND OF SAY
THAT LIKE FOR EXAMPLE RIGHT NOW --
I AM THE TUTOR FOR THE
ELECTRONICS TEACHER.
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T HAVE THE TIME
TO TEACH MATH AND SCIENCE AT THE
SAME TIME TEACHING ELECTRONIC SO
AS A VOCATIONAL TEACHER.
MUST MY SCHEDULES A LITTLE BIT
MORE FLEXIBLE SO I CAN GO OVER
THERE AND HELP TEACH THE MAD
HELP KEEP THE SCIENCE.
AND WHAT HAVE YOU.
BUT IT ISN'T BECAUSE THE
ACADEMIC TEACHERS -- DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES OR WHAT HAVE YOU
IT'S JUST THAT THERE'S A SLIGHT
DISCONNECT FOR EXAMPLE.
THIS YOUNG MAN THAT I'M TEACHING
IN THIS -- VOCATIONAL CLASS OR
IN THE ELECTRONICS CLASS
SHOULDN'T EVER BEEN CLASSIFIED
TO BE IN THAT CLASS.
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
SO THERE'S A SLIGHT DISCONNECT
BUT AT THE SAME TIME BE
ACADEMICS ARE DOING I THINK A
BANG UP JOB FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS I'M SURE THAT THE
NEW DIRECTOR IS.
SENDING US THE RESOURCES THAT WE
NEED BUT AT THE SAME TIME I
THINK THAT MAY BE.
WHEN THEY DID THEIR OF STUDY
WHATEVER I'D LIKE I'D I'D BE
CURIOUS TO KNOW WHO THEY TALK?
TO I REALLY WOULD BECAUSE I
COULD HEAR.
MISSISSAUGA ASKING OKAY.
WHAT I GET THE WAGES I GET THAT
THIS BUT HOW ARE YOU HELPING
THESE GUYS WHAT ARE YOU DOING
BEYOND THE WAGES?
I THINK THE ACADEMIC OUTAGES AT
PELICAN BAY ARE DOING THAT.
AGAIN THERE'S SOME DISCONNECTS
IN THERE AND EVERYTHING RIGHT
THERE BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
PROGRAMS LIKE P. I. E. AND THE
OTHER THINGS THAT THEY'RE
WORKING WITH IT'S LIKE COMPARING
APPLES AND ORANGES.
I'M NOT SIT IN THE CLASS.
MAKING NO MONEY.
OR I CAN GO SIT OVER IN THIS
CLASS.
MAKE A DOLLAR AN HOUR.
AND THEN I HEARD THEM SAY A 7%
RECIDIVISM RATE.
WHERE YOU GET THAT NUMBER IT?
IS THIS SELF REPORTED.
BECAUSE IF CDC ARE GAVE OUR
RECIDIVISM RATES.
MAYBE OUR NUMBERS WOULD LOOK
PRETTY GOOD.
TO SO NO OFFENSE TO ANYBODY ELSE
BUT I THINK THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS IS DOING A HELL OF A
JOB.
AND THE ACADEMIC TEACHERS THAT
ARE ASSIGNED TO THESE PRISONS
ARE DOING THE BEST WE CAN WITH
WHAT WE HAVE.
YEAH THANK YOU THANK YOU.
PLEASE.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS ROBERT
HOLTZ -- I AM A CREDENTIALED CT
INSTRUCTOR AT THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTION. FOR MEN I'VE BEEN A
DEPARTMENT EMPLOYEE FOR THE PAST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS I'VE WORKED
UNDER.
NUMEROUS SECRETARIES AND I'M
PRETTY MUCH ALL STRUCK.
BY LISTENING TO OUR CURRENT --
SECRETARY AT IN THE PLANS THAT
THEY HAVE IN PLACE AT THE
OPPORTUNITY MEDIUM.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO AT A
CORRECTIONAL EDUCATION
ASSOCIATION.
CONFERENCE WHERE HE SPOKE AS A
KEYNOTE SPEAKER IN THIS MAN'S
DEDICATED TO I THINK MAKING THE
CHANGES THAT KERN AND AND I SAW --
SECRETARY KATE WAS IN HERE
EARLIER -- SEE THEM YOU KNOW
REALLY.
PUT FORTH THE EFFORT THAT I
HADN'T SEEN PREVIOUSLY IN MY
CAREER.
I I HAVE AN S. YEAH YOU ONE
THOUSAND DOES ANY BARGAINING
UNIT.
FOR A REPRESENTATIVE FOR UNIT
THREE ON THE SEXUAL EDUCATION
ASSOCIATION.
REGION SEVEN DIRECTOR IT'S AN
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION.
CALIFORNIA AND MY RESPONSIBILITY
INCOME SAYS CALIFORNIA ARIZONA
NEVADA UTAH HAWAII IN THE
COUNTRY A MESS MEXICO.
I'VE BEEN A WASP VISITING CHAIR
NINE TIMES -- THEY DID REPORT
THAT THE IN THE FINDINGS IN THIS
REPORT THAT THEY DID LOOK AT
THAT STATE THAT WE'RE ALL WHAT'S
ACCREDITED SCHOOLS AND THAT'S A
BIG DEAL -- I'VE BEEN A MEMBER
SIX TIMES SO I I VISITED AND
THESE HAVE BEEN IN PUBLIC.
SCHOOL SUCH AS WHEN A YEAR OR LA
HABRA AND AND SOME ORANGE COUNTY
SCHOOLS AND AN INCLUDING PRISON
SCHOOLS.
I COORDINATED THREE WAST VISITS
SAID THREE PRISONS IN MY CAREER.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT'S REALLY FUNNY
I A REPAIR I ONLY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THIS
REPORT LAST NIGHT BECAUSE I WAS
ON MY WAY HOME.
AND ASKED ME TO STAY.
AND MY MARGINS ARE FILLED WITH
SO MANY COMMENTS IT WOULD TAKE
SO LONG TO ADDRESS SOME BUT THE
STAKEHOLDERS ARE IN A ROOM. FOR
THIS FOR A WHAT'S ACCREDITATION
PROCESS OR CORRECTIONAL
EDUCATION ACCREDITATION PROCESS
WHETHER THERE IS C. B. T.
PROGRAM OR OR WHETHER.
I'VE SEEN SOME REALLY GOOD
SCHOOLS.
IN THE COMMUNITY TAKE ON THEIR
VOLUNTEER PROGRAMS TAKE ON SOME
OF THESE CONTRACTED AND ENGAGE
THEM IN THE PROCESS OF LOOKING
AT HOLISTICALLY HOW ARE WE DOING.
DELIVER IN A YOU KNOW AN
EDUCATIONAL PRODUCT -- NO IT'S
IT'S IT'S I SEE IT AS A A METHOD
BY WHICH YOU'RE LOOKING TO SEE.
OUR WE'VE BEEN EFFECTIVE WELL.
THESE WALLS CAN SEE A CREDIT
PROCESSES ARE ARE PEOPLE THAT
ARE SEPARATE FROM.
THE ORGANIZATION AND AND AND AND
LOOK AT IT FROM.
A SPECIFIC POINT OF VIEW AND
THEN.
LASTLY -- YOU KNOW THERE'S
PLENTY OF REPORTS OUT THERE FROM
THE RAND -- INSTITUTE THAT WORK
WITH CRACKS LEDGE CATIONS
ASSOCIATION OF THE NUMBER YEARS
START IN TWO THOUSAND ONE SAYING.
THAT CORRECTION EDUCATION WORKS
AND JUST TOUCHING.
JUST ONE OF US TOUCH IN A HAS A
A THE FACT OF REDUCE IT BY 43%
SO.
APPRECIATE YOU CAN CAN CONTINUED
COMMITMENT. TO WHAT WE DO AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU.
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT.
HI MY NAME IS JOHN ROBIN I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF PROGRAMS FOR POTS
FOR LIFE.
WE PROVIDE DAY IN PRISON
PROGRAMMING AND SERVICE DOGS FOR
MILITARY VETERANS.
THIS IS MOST HE WAS TRAINED IN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON LOS
ANGELES COUNTY HE'S GOING TO A
MILITARY VETERAN WITHIN A MONTH --
AS A DIRECTOR OF PROGRAMS I HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY GO BACK INSIDE
GO BACK INSIDE AND I WORK IN
THREE DIFFERENT PRISONS.
IN THREE DAYS I WILL OF SAVE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA EIGHTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
I WAS FORMERLY INCARCERATED WITH
SIX LIFE SENTENCES CONSECUTIVE
TO FORTY YEARS I HAD A HUNDRED
NINETY TO LIVE.
I WAS SENTENCED TO DIE IN THE
PRISON SYSTEM.
AND BECAUSE OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT COME INSIDE
THE PRISON SYSTEM AND PROVIDE
PROGRAMMING.
I WAS ABLE TO BECOME THE FIRST
EVER PRISONER OF TO RECEIVE A
RECALL OF COMMITMENT UNDER
ELEVEN SEVENTY D..
AND NOW I DEDICATE MY LIFE TO
GOING BACK IN INSIDE.
ALONG WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS.
THE ISSUE IS THAT THE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT WORK WITHIN CDC ARE.
ARE ONLY ALLOTTED FOR MILLION
DOLLARS FOR MORE THAN A HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS.
THESE ARE THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE.
PROVIDING TRAUMA INFORMED.
PROGRAMMING. FOR GUYS THAT ARE
SERVING LIFE AND LONG TERMS.
THERE'S THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS GOING INTO THE C. B.
TEAS AND FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
GOING TO THE CBO THIS.
THE CBO'S EDGE AS AS YOU HEARD
YOURSELF THESE LIFERS ARE GOING
BACK IN WITH A THREE AND A HALF
PERCENT RECIDIVISM RATE.
THE THERE'S THE MODEL FOR
SUCCESS THE MODEL FOR SUCCESS IS
RIGHT IN FRONT OF US.
SOMEBODY THAT'S FORMALLY
INCARCERATED SHOULD BE SITTING
ON THIS PANEL SO THAT YOU CAN
HEAR WHAT WORKED WHAT WHAT WORK
FOR THESE GUYS THAT ARE THAT ARE
NOT RECEIVING RIGHT.
SO -- I JUST WANT TO OFFER MY
SUPPORT TO THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT CAME IN AND
CHANGE MY LIFE.
IN THAT ALLOWED ME TO STAND HERE
ALLOWED ME TO GO BACK IN AND
WORK WITH THESE PROGRAMS.
AND ALLOWED ME TO PROVIDE A
MILITARY VETERAN WITH SERVICE
STOCK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU COULD YOU
TALK TO MY STAFF FOR YOUR YOUR
YOUR YOUR INFORMATION THE
CALIFORNIA SCIENCE CENTER WHAT'S
THE HIGHLIGHT.
D. YOU'RE A PAUSE PROGRAM AT THE
SIGN SAID I HAVE A DISH CALLED
DOGS LIFE AND THEY DO ALL
DIFFERENT.
TYPES OF DOGS THEY ASKED ME
ABOUT YOUR PROGRAM ANYONE IS A
HIGHLIGHTED. FOR ALL TO SEE --
IN EXPOSITION PARK IN LOS
ANGELES SO IF YOU.
GIVE HER SOME INFORMATION THAT
WOULD BE GREAT ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS EARL SMITH
I'M RETIRED CHAPLAIN
FROM THE SAN QUENTIN PRISON
WORKED THERE FOR TWENTY THREE
YEARS I STARTED IN -- NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE WHEN I STARTED THE
PRISON WAS LOCKED DOWN.
AND I REALIZE THAT PROGRAMS ARE
THE ONLY WAY THAT WE WOULD.
BE ABLE TO TURN AROUND -- FAST
FORD I STARTED THE PAINT SENATE
WITH BASEBALL PROGRAM.
THE REASON I START THEIR PROGRAM
WAS BECAUSE I WANTED TO FIND A
WAY TO TAKE ME IN.
THAT WERE FROM DIFFERENT RACES
DIFFERENT GANGS AND BRING THEM
TOGETHER WITH SOMETHING IN
COMMON.
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME AS A
PROTESTANT CHAPLAIN.
I STARTED SOMETHING CALLED
INCARCERATED MEAN PUTTING AWAY
CHILDISH THINGS WHICH TOOK ME.
FROM THE PROTESTANT CHAPEL THE
MUSLIM CHAPEL THE JEWISH CHAPEL
TO BUDDHIST CHAPEL THE NATIVE
AMERICAN CHAPEL WE BROUGHT THEM
ALL TOGETHER INTO A PROGRAM IS
THAT WHAT WE HAVE IN COMMON.
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT.
GOVERNOR GRAY DAVIS THE FIRST
LIVE FOR THAT GOT OUT UNDER HIM.
WAS A GUY THAT WAS IN OUR
PROGRAM.
THE GUYS THAT I HAD FIND THAT
PROFOUND THE PROGRAM WITH.
THEY WERE ALL LIFERS THEY'RE ALL
OUT THERE ALL ALL PAROLES FOR
THEIR SAVE THE STATE A LOT OF
MONEY BECAUSE NOW THEY'RE
HOMEOWNERS.
OF THE REASON I STAND UP HERE IS
BECAUSE I KNOW THE VALUE.
OF COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WE SAY THE VOLUNTEERS BUT YET IN
REALITY THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT
ARE HAVING FUNDING IN ORDER TO
BE ABLE TO SEND PEOPLE ON TRIPS
OR WHATEVER THEY HAVE TO GO INTO
THE PRISON.
SOME OF THESE PLACES A FOUR WAY
THEY'RE NOT ALL LIKE SAN QUENTIN
THE BAY AREA.
AND IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT THEY NEED THE FUNDING AND
THAT'S WITH A REALLY HERE FOR
AND A CLOSE AND I LIKE TO SAY
THIS.
I HAVE A HOUSE FOR LIFERS I HAVE
A HELL'S MY WIFE AND I WE HAVE
AN ACRE WE HAVE SIXTEEN BED
FACILITY.
AND IS CENTERED AROUND THE
PREMISE THAT GUY SHOULDN'T JUST
GET OUT AND GO BACK TO SOMEPLACE.
THEY SHOULD BE PREPARED TO GO
BACK.
AND IN DOING THAT WE'VE HAD
SEVENTY EIGHT GUYS FROM
DIFFERENT WHETHER THEY'RE LIFERS
A LONG TERM RATES GET OUT.
AND MY DAUGHTER JUST TEXT ME
SOMETHING TO SAY FOR WHICH IT
THING OKAY. SIXTY ONE OF THE
GUYS GRADUATED SOME OF THEM WENT
OTHER PLACES BUT THE REASON I'M
SAYING THAT IS.
I HEAR THIS THING WE TEACH
PROGRAMS AND SET IN THE PRISONS
RIGHT NOW
ALSO LIKE A VOLUNTEER NOW THAT
I'M RETIRED I TEACH THE PROGRAMS
AND THERE NEEDS TO BE A
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE GUYS WERE
TEACHING IN THE PRISON.
AND HOUSING IN PREPARING THEM.
TO STAY IN THE COMMUNITY WITHOUT
THAT THERE'S A DISCONNECT AND I
BELIEVE THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE WHERE THAT
CONNECTION COMES WE HAVE THE
HOUSING WE DO ALL OF THAT BUT
SOME OF THESE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS I COULD TELL YOU
AS A CHAPLAIN.
WITHOUT THEM I WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YEAH I'M I THINK
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
A HOLISTIC APPROACH.
POLICE OFFICIAL PUBLIC COMMENT
HI -- MY NAME IS AN ALONG ON
WITH THE W. HAYWOOD BURNS
INSTITUTE AND REALLY INTERESTING
HEARING TODAY I JUST WANTED TO
BUILD ON WHAT ON THE TWO
GENTLEMAN BEFORE ME SAID BUT
JOHN -- POINTED OUT SO THE NEED
FOR FINDING AND I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT AS YOU KNOW THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF TALK TODAY ABOUT THE NEED
FOR BETTER EVALUATION MORE
EXPANSIVE EVALUATION THAT.
GOES BE ON C. B. T. AND ON YOU
KNOW LOOKS AT OTHER MEASURES
BESIDES RECIDIVISM BUT ALSO THAT
THAT TAKES TIME IN YOUR LIFE YOU
KNOW ALL THE DEPARTMENTS LOOKING
FOR RESEARCH PARTNERS AND SO.
AS YOU'RE BUILDING THAT
EVALUATION DESIGN AND TRYING TO
DISTINGUISH WHICH CBO'S ARE
ACTUALLY CAUSING YOU KNOW A
BETTER REDUCTION IN RECIDIVISM
AND BETTER OUTCOMES.
THAT THERE IS A NEED.
TO INCREASE THE FUNDING THROUGH
THE CDC OUR INNOVATION GRANTS
THE WISHES OF FUNDS THAT THAT
FIND A LOT OF THE COMMUNITIES
BASED PROGRAMS.
SO THAT THEY ARE ACTUALLY
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS LEFT.
TO EVALUATE BECAUSE FOUR MILLION
IN FUNDING YOU KNOW IS A
REDUCTION IN WHAT THEY WERE
GETTING AND SO I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN AN ASKED. TO FOR TEN
MILLION ADD ON AND YOU KNOW I
THINK THAT IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
TO FIND SO IN ALSO THERE
PROGRAMS LEFT OF VALUE -- EIGHT
AND I THINK ALSO ENGAGING THE
CBO'S IN THAT PROCESS AGAIN TO
ASK THEM WHAT SHOULD BE MEASURED
TO GET THEIR THINKING TO GET.
PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN INSIDE AND
DIRECTLY IMPACTED TO GET THEIR
THINKING ON WHAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT IN CAUSING
TRANSFORMATION AND SO IT ISN'T
JUST YOU KNOW FROM THE IVORY
TOWER AND SMART PEOPLE WHO HAVE
NO DIRECT EXPERIENCE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT.
I HI MY NAME'S AMANDA BURGER ON
THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR WITH THE
INSIDE CORDON PROGRAM AND WE
WORK IN. NINE PRISONS IN
CALIFORNIA TO JUVENILE
FACILITIES IN INDIANA AND WE'RE
ALSO WORKING AT EACH CLOSE WHICH
IS A YOUTH FACILITY.
IN STOCKTON OUR WORK IS SPENDING
EVERYTHING FROM WOMEN'S
FACILITIES TO HEALTH FACILITIES
WE'RE WORKING WITH LIFE FAIRS.
I PERSONALLY OF MANAGE THE
PROGRAM ON EACH UNIT FOR THE
LAST THREE AND A HALF YEARS AT
SAN QUENTIN AND IN THAT CASE
WE'RE WORKING WITH MEN WHO HAVE
DETERMINATE SENTENCES.
ON ALTHOUGH MANY PEOPLE THINK OF
US AS A GARDENING PROGRAM WE
ACTUALLY HAVING ECO LITERACY
CURRICULUM WHERE MINDFULNESS
BASED.
WE CO DESIGN AND PLANT
PERMACULTURE GARDENS AND WE DO
RE ENTRY BRIDGING THIRTY OF THE
MAN THAT WE WORK WITH ITS HAND
CLINTON HAVE BEEN HIRED BY
PLANTING JUSTICE WHICH IS A
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAM IN
OAKLAND.
AND WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
INCREASE OUR WORK IN IDENTIFYING
WITH PEOPLE'S NEEDS ARE PRE
RELEASE.
BEFORE THEY GO HOME AND THEN
CONNECTING THEM WITH TRUSTED
PEOPLE IN COUNTIES WHERE WE HAVE.
ALLIES AND I THERE'S JUST A FEW
THINGS I WANTED TO SAY TODAY
WE'RE ALSO A FOUNDING MEMBER OF
THE TRANSFORMATIVE PRISON IN
PRISON WORKING GROUP TEA PW.
WHICH REPRESENTS THIRTY FIVE
GROUPS THAT OFFER TRANSFORMATIVE
PROGRAMMING IN PRISONS.
AND JUST TO REITERATE WHAT
SEVERAL OTHER PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
SAYING WE ARE ADVOCATING FOR TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO BE ALLOCATED
TO OUR WORK.
IN THIS BUDGET SESSION ON THE
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS WAS A FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR REDUCTION FROM
TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN YOU
DO THE MATH IT'S EASY TO SEE
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS ACROSS
THIRTY SIX PRISONS.
IS VIRTUALLY IT'S JUST ENOUGH
MONEY TO KEEP US ALIVE BUT NOT
IN ANY KIND OF SUSTAINED WAY.
AND I I REALLY DO WANT TO SAY TO
YOU THE AUDITOR USED THE WORD
VOLUNTEER OVER AND OVER AGAIN IN
HER REPORT WE ARE NOT VOLUNTEER
PROGRAMS WERE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
PROFESSIONALLY STAFFED.
WHO THEN PARTNER WITH VOLUNTEERS
IN THE COMMUNITY MANY OF US ALSO
HIGHER FORMALLY INCARCERATED
PEOPLE WITH YEARS AND YEARS AND
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE AND PEOPLE
NAY LIVING WAGES SO I JUST?
I REALLY WANT TO ELIMINATE THAT
TERM VOLUNTEER.
FROM EVERYONE'S VOCABULARY ON
THE LAST THING I WANTED TO SAY I
APPRECIATED ALL THE DISCUSSION
ABOUT EVIDENCE BASED RESEARCH
TODAY.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY AGAIN WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THIS FROM A
SYSTEMS APPROACH NOT ALL PRISONS
OR PRISON YARDS ARE CREATED
EQUALLY.
AND SO I THINK WHILE WE'RE ALSO
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE SUCCESS OF
THE PROGRAMS WE ALSO NEED TO
REALLY HAVE A FOCUS ON WHAT ARE
THE CONDITIONS FOR SUCCESS ON
THE YARD.
ARMED AVENAL STATE PRISON IS A
PRISON WE'RE WORKING AT TWO
YARDS THERE THE WORKING CAME UP
THROUGH EDUCATION -- CUSTODY
SHE'S BEEN PHENOMENALLY
SUPPORTIVE TO US AS A PROGRAM
PROVIDER WE'RE ABLE TO GET.
EMAIL RESPONSES CUSTODY ON THE
YARD ARE VERY OPEN TO WORKING
WITH US SO I JUST WANT TO
ENCOURAGE YOU WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT SUCCESS. TO REALLY THINK
BROADLY AROUND WHAT DOES
DISTRICT DOES SUCCESS MEAN HOW
DO YOU DEFINE SUCCESS IN NOT
ONLY WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING FOR IN
OUR PROGRAMS.
BUT WHAT ARE THE CONDITIONS THAT
NEED TO EXIST ON A YARD IN
WITHIN A PRISON. FOR ALL OF US
TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND FINALLY THE
LAST THING I'LL SAY -- I DON'T
KNOW WHETHER YOU SAW ON SIXTY
MINUTES BUT THEY JUST.
POSTED A VIDEO ON THE VERY
INSTITUTE HAS A PROJECT CALLED
HUMANIZING PRISONS THEY SPENT A
LOT OF TIME GOING TO GERMANY AND
STUDYING THE WAY THE PRISON
SYSTEM IS FUNCTIONING THERE.
AND THEY'VE NOW GOTTEN SOME
FUNDING AND THEY'VE BEEN DOING
WORKING CONNECTICUT IN REALLY
TRANSFORMING THE CULTURE ON THE
YARD AND FRANKLY THEY'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT WHAT WE'RE DOING IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE TO THE CDC
OURS CREDIT WE'VE INNOVATED WITH
A LOT OF WORK HERE.
SO AGAIN I I JUST REALLY WANT TO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO REALLY TH. TO
KEEP ASKING THIS QUESTION WHAT
DOES SUCCESS MEAN AND WHAT ARE
ALL THE DIFFERENT INGREDIENTS
THAT ARE GOING TO NEED TO COME
TOGETHER.
IN ORDER FOR THERE TO BE A
REALLY SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION AND
FOR PEOPLE TO GO HOME HEALTHY
AND WHOLE.
SO I WANT TO REALLY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND APPRECIATED
ALL THE NEW ONES CONVERSATION
TODAY AND I KNOW IT'S LATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THIS WILL PUBLIC COMMENT HOW YOU
GUYS DOING MY NAME'S GERALD THE
SAMA FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUAL WHO JUST COMPLETED
HALF OF HIS LIFE AND CITY C. R..
SO I KNOW THE SYSTEM FROM.
VOTE FOR IT AS AS A PART AS A
PERSON YOU GUYS ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE PEOPLE YOU GUYS ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
I SERVED IN -- I'M ALSO A CO
FOUNDER OF OF AN ORGANIZATION
CALLED SELF AWARENESS AND
RECOVERY WAS STARTING TWO
THOUSAND FIVE IN PRISON. TO
ADDRESS TRAUMA TRAUMA THAT
WASN'T BEING UP.
ADDRESSED IN IN THE SYSTEM.
YOU HAD MENTAL HOW YOU HAD THESE
LITTLE GROUPS THAT WE REALLY.
HITTING THE COR YOU KNOW WE M.
AND I AND AND I'VE SEEN HOW
WE'VE WASTED A LOT OF MONEY IN
THE DEPARTMENT.
OF PROGRAMS THAT ARE JUST LIKE
MAN IT'S A COOKIE CUTTER NUMBER
STATE A COOKIE CUTTER EVIDENCE
BASED HOME.
AND THEN THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
BUSTING OUR **** BECAUSE MY
LANGUAGE ARE YOU IN THE
COMMUNITY -- THEY THE GOAL
WINNER THAT THERE REALLY ARE
MAKING A CONNECTION THERE COMING
FROM A NON BIASED PERSPECTIVE
THEY'RE COMING FROM AN
EMPATHETIC PERSPECTIVE ARE
CONNECTED WITH THE PEOPLE
DOESN'T MAKE IN ARE THE PEOPLE
THAT MAKING PROFOUND CHANGES.
I PARTICIPATED IN OVER EASY
ABOUT FORTY DIFFERENT.
PROGRAMS FROM THE COMMUNITY.
AND AND AND I SEEM THEIR
STRUGGLES ICE IN THE CHALLENGES
THAT THEY'D HAVE TO GO THROUGH
GOING TO CLEAR TO GOING TO THE
PRISON SYSTEM.
THEY WENT TO A LOT I ALSO SERVED
ON THE MAN'S ADVISORY COUNCIL
FOR A LOT OF YEARS.
IN THERE YOU KNOW SOMETHING THAT
WAS ESTABLISHED BY LEGISLATOR TO
TO TO MEDIATE BETWEEN OFFICERS
AND IN THE IN THE POPULATION OF
ENCOUNTER A LOT OF RETALIATION
AND FROM WHAT I WENT THROUGH.
AND AND SERVING IN THERE BUT I
HAVE I WOULD WITH OUR MINISTRY
IS THERE ARE OUR WARDENS AND WE
MADE A LOT OF POSITIVE --
CHANGES.
A BIT INCOME WITH A LOT WHICH
STRUGGLES IN SEOUL YOU KNOW I
REALLY WANT WANT WANT US TO HAVE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE AT
THE TABLE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
HOW HOW WE'RE GONNA PUSH THIS
THIS THIS THE?
THIS PROBLEM THAT WE'RE
ENCOUNTERING AND HOW HOW AND HOW
WE HOW TO INVEST MONEY IN THE
RIGHT PLACES NOW WHERE IS JUST
THE COOKIE CUTTER MODEL AND IT
AND IF YOU'RE NOT EVEN IS BASED
IN.
THE THEN YOU HAD A LOOK BECAUSE
I SEE A LOT OF GREAT PEOPLE THAT
ARE ARE COMING FROM THE
COMMUNITY. TO HELP OUT THAT THE
THE COMMUNITY INSIDE OF CITRIX
PEOPLE FROM THE HOOD.
BY THE HOOD TO HELP PEOPLE FROM
THE HOOD.
HERE I MEAN IN AND IF IF IT
BELOW THAT THE SUPPORT.
YOU KNOW IT MAKES IT VERY
DIFFICULT TO REALLY REACH OUT
THE POPULATION THAT COMES FROM
TRAUMA FROM ABUSE FROM THEY
COLLECT FROM DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
THESE SOME OF THE MOST HURT.
INDIVIDUALS IN SEOUL THEY THEY
NEED APPROACHES THAT THAT THAT
THAT COME FROM A PLACE OF
COMPASSION LOVE HEALING AND
EMPATHY.
AND ALSO WE NEED ASSISTANCE ON
HOW TO LOVE AT THAT THAT DATA
YOU KNOW -- TO THE SIDE WITH
THERE'D BE TWO SOUNDS TO THEIR
SYSTEM THAT THEY HAVE YOU KNOW
WHAT WE GIVE EACH ILL TAG GROUP
OR EACH ORGAN.
ORGANIZATION THAT GOES ENTERED
EVERYBODY'S AT A SUMMIT SERVICE
A PRE AND POST SURVEY YOU GET
THAT DATA AND YOU SEE THE
DIFFERENCE OVER TIME.
AND AND WE CREATE A SYSTEM
STARLOG IN THE DATA FOR FOR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
YOU KNOW SOUL -- I I I I I HAVE
KIND OF MIXED FEELINGS ABOUT
ABOUT THIS WHOLE TOPIC BECAUSE I
FEEL LIKE WE'RE WE'RE INVESTING
TOO MUCH MONEY.
AND THE RIGHT AND THE WRONG
AREAS AND I DIDN'T IN THE RIGHT
AREAS SO WHAT I'M I'M I'M
BASICALLY JUST A REQUEST IN THIS
THAT.
WE PROVIDE MORE SUPPORT FOR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
NOVICE SOME SOME FUNDING THERE --
SO THAT OUR PEOPLE THAT COME
FROM FROM FROM THE STREETS THAT
ARE CONNECTING AND MAKE AN
IMPACT IN THE CHANGES THAT THERE
ARE PEOPLE IN THERE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED.
IN PEOPLE THAT COME FROM THAT
BACKGROUND.
CAN'T CAN SUPPORT THEM WHO
BETTER TO TELL A PERSON ABOUT RE
ENTRY THAT THAN A PERSONAL CAME
OUT AND WENT PLEASE REENTRY
BUSES AND WENT ALL THE HURDLES.
AND AND KNOWS THE THE REAL FROM
THE FAKE OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
THAT OFFER SERVICES FOR US YOU
KNOW BECAUSE THAT'S HAVE.
PEOPLE COME INTERNET TELL US
WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU A B. C. AND
D. AND WHEN YOU GET OUT OKAY
WITH THERE'S A LOT OF GRAY AREAS
WILL ONLY FUND IS BUT YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE TO FALL INTO THIS QUITE
TURN IT GETS ALL CUT COMPLICATED.
THIS I WHAT WHAT YOU SHOULD TELL
ME THAT'S NOT BEFORE I GOT OUT
OF BEFORE I PUT ALL MY EGGS IN
ONE BASKET THE LINE ON YOUR
GUISES PROGRAM TO ASSIST.
SO YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
GRAY AREAS THERE THAT THAT
DEFINITELY BE WORKED OUT AND
HOPEFULLY WE WE WE CAN ALL WORK
TOGETHER I'M NOT HERE TO BASH ON
THE DEPARTMENT.
YOU KNOW BECAUSE IN THAT
DEPARTMENT IT WAS WHAT I GOT
THREE THREE THREE THREE
VOCATIONAL TRADES I GOT. TO TWO
COLLEGE DEGREES IN THERE YOU
KNOW I AND A LOT OF WISDOM AND
INSIGHT AND AND EXPANDED OUR
PROGRAM IN OUR TOTAL NUMEROUS
PUT -- PRISONS WITH NO FUNDING
ON ILL TAG IT MAY LEISURE
ACTIVITY FUNDING ACTUALLY THAT
THAT THAT THAT IS THAT THAT
THERE IS WILL SOME FUNNY SO WHAT
LIVE VERY LIMITED FUNDING.
SO I KNOW WE CAN DO A LOT FOR A
POPULATION IF WE PUT THOSE
DOLLARS IT AND IN THE RIGHT
HANDS WITH THE RIGHT PEOPLE THAT
ARE ACTUALLY DOING THE WORK
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR JUST ONE ALEX
THANK EVERYBODY.
FOR ACTUALLY SAYING WITH US.
SAYS -- SIX THIRTY THREE BUT I
DO WANT TO THANK AB ALL THE THE
MEMBERS I CAME IN TODAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER OUT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON BEAR QUE
HAN COM LONGER DA VOEPEL AND
SENATOR MORLOCK.
AND WITH THAT LET ME JUST ASK.
THIRTY OF CLOSING COMMENTS NO
TIME AGO.
GREAT CLOSING COMMENT AT THAT --
WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
SIX MONTH MARK -- THE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND KIND OF THE
PROGRESS OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
BEING MADE I THINK COLLECTIVELY
WE ALL WANT TO DO WHAT'S BEST
FOR SOCIETY AND ACTUALLY.
GIVING REINTEGRATING FOLKS BACK
INTO SOCIETY TO BE SUCCESSFUL
AND WHAT THAT WILL GO AHEAD AND
CONCLUDE THIS JOINT HEARING IS
SIX THIRTY FOUR PM AND THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE [inaudible]
YEAH --
ONE ALRIGHT [inaudible]
THANK YOU
PUBLIC COMMENT.
IN TWO PARTS PART ONE WILL BE
AFTER ISSUE NUMBER ONE SO THAT
WE CAN HEAR PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ALL ISSUES INCLUDING ADVOCACY
PROPOSALS.
RELATED TO CONTINUE WITH CARE
REFORM.
PART TWO WILL BE AFTER WE HEAR
THE PANELS ON SHOES TO THROUGH
NINE OR THE BALANCE OF THE
DISCUSSION PORTION OF THE AGENDA.
WILL ALSO ASK FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THE NON DISCUSSION ISSUES
THAT ARE INCLUDED AT THE END OF
THE AGENDA.
ALL PANELISTS ARE ASKED TO
MAINTAIN REMARKS TWO UNDER THREE
MINUTES PLEASE.
PUBLIC COMMENT TO WILL BE
RESTRICTED TO ONE MINUTE EACH
AND OUR STAFF WILL HOLD UP A
GENTLE REMINDER WHEN.
IT'S YOUR TIME TO CLOSE.
WITH THAT LET'S BEGIN WITH ISSUE
NUMBER ONE WELCOME COLLEAGUES
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
ON THE IMPLEMENTATION AND
FUNDING UPDATE RELATED TO THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM EFFORTS.
ALSO CALLED THE C. C. R..
PLEASE ALSO COVER THE B. C. P.
USE THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH C.
C. R. [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF FEATURE
BINGO WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR THERE -- I WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND THANK YOUR STAFF THEY
DID A VERY THOROUGH MULTI PAGE
JOB DESCRIBING THE C. C. R. I'M
GONNA RUN THROUGH IT VERY
QUICKLY FOR REFERENCE WITH SOME
HIGH LEVEL COMMENTS BUT I DON'T
WANT TO TAKE.
THE TIME TO READ IT BACK TO YOU
EITHER.
WONDERFUL -- THE C. C. R. THANK
YOU FOR DEFINING THE ACRONYM --
RESULTED FROM LEGISLATION A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO THAT LED TO
A MULTI YEAR ENGAGEMENT WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM.
THAT EFFORT CULMINATED IN A
JANUARY TWENTY FIFTEEN REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE ACCOMPANIED WITH
A JANUARY -- BUDGET PROPOSAL --
FROM FROM THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION HAD A MULTI YOUR
VIEW ON A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
NEEDED TO BE DONE TO IMPROVE THE
OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN AND FAMILY --
IN CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY
AROUND CHILD WELFARE OF COURSE --
THE THERE WERE A VARIETY OF OF
GOALS OF THE OF THAT WITHIN THAT
BUT PRIMARILY AROUND THE
REDUCING THE USE OF CONGREGATE
CARE -- WE WE FOUND THAT WHILE
OF COURSE THERE ARE GOOD
CONGREGATE CARE PROVIDERS TO
PRODUCE GOOD OUTCOMES BY AND
LARGE THE ASSOCIATIONS THAT A
DEMOGRAPHIC LEVEL -- ARE BETTER
FOR USE WHEN THEY ARE IN HOME
BASED FAMILY CARE SITUATIONS
WITH IT WITH A A MORE LIMITED --
GROUP GROUP AROUND THEM -- THAT
THEY CAN BE CARED FOR YOU
OBVIOUSLY CAN'T JUST TAKE KIDS
OUT OF A GROUP HOME YOU HAVE TO
HAVE SOME PLACE TO PUT THEM.
SO THAT WAS THE REFLECTION IN
THE INITIAL INVESTMENTS MADE IN
THE C. C. R. IN TERMS OF FAMILY --
RECRUITMENT RETENTION AND
SUPPORT.
IN -- RE RE CASTING THE
EXPECTATIONS OF THE VARIOUS
FACILITY TYPES THAT WE HAVE.
A MAKING SETTING THE EXPECTATION
THAT GROUP HOMES WOULD BE PHASED
OUT IN THE CHILD WELFARE ARENA
IN FAVOR OF SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS --
I DON'T WANT TO USE THE WORD
CRISIS STABILIZATION BUT THEY
WERE ENVISIONED AS SIX MONTHS
MAXIMUM PLACEMENTS AND LAST
THOSE STRENGTHS AND NEEDS OF THE
CHILD AND YOUTH INDICATED A
LONGER PERIOD OF TIME WAS NEEDED.
AND THAT REALLY THE FOCUS OF OUR
EFFORT WAS TO GET HOME BASE
FAMILY KERR -- WE HAVE GONE TO
SINCE JANUARY TWENTY FIFTEEN
THROUGH SEVERAL YEARS OF POLICY
DEVELOPMENT AND GUIDANCE A LOT
OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE -- WITH
COUNTIES WITH PROVIDERS IN THE
SYSTEM AND WE'VE BEEN MOVE NOW
BEYOND THE JUST THE POLICY
DEVELOPMENT AND INTO THE
IMPLEMENTATION PHASE AND MORE
NOW A COUPLE YEARS INTO THAT.
AND YOU'LL SEE THAT REFLECTED IN
THE IN THE FUNDING -- THAT THAT --
IS IS PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET AND
HAS BEEN PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET --
IN ADDITION TO EFFORTS TO A
RETAIN AND RECRUIT FAMILIES AND
TO CHANGE THE THE MIX OF
PROVIDER TYPES AND OUR SERVICE
EXPECTATIONS OF THOSE PROVIDERS.
A CHILD AND FAMILY TEAMING
CONCEPTS WERE A MAJOR FEATURE OF
THIS IT'S IMPORTANT.
I THINK IT'S NO SECRET TO
ANYBODY THAT WHEN PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING TO
THEM AND THEY FEEL LIKE THEY'VE
HAD A VOICE AND BEEN ABLE TO BE
HEARD THEY HAVE MORE BY INTO
WHAT'S HAPPENING TO THEM.
AND SO CHILD AND FAMILY TEAMING
AROUND DECISIONS ABOUT PLACEMENT
ABOUT SERVICE NEEDS -- ABOUT
DURATION OF CARING OVERALL CASE
MANAGEMENT AND WHAT'S IN A COURT
REPORT THOSE ARE ALL FEATURES OF
CHILD AND FAMILY TEAMING.
EXCUSE ME SACRAMENTO ALLERGIES --
THE OTHER MAJOR FEATURE -- WELL
IT WAS A DEVELOPMENT OF A NEW
RATE SYSTEM FOR ABOUT TWENTY
YEARS PRIOR TO THIS -- WE'VE HAD
AN AGE BASED SYSTEM WHERE AS A
CHILD GOT OLDER RATE RATES
CHANGED -- WE'VE DOW IMPLEMENTED
A RATE SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S BASED ON THE SS STRENGTHS
AND NEEDS OF THE CHILD.
AND INTENDED TO BETTER SUPPORT
FAMILIES -- ROUGHLY A HUNDRED
AND TEN HUNDRED TWENTY DOLLAR A
MONTH INCREASE IN THE AMOUNT
GIVEN TO FAMILIES.
A CHANGE IN THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT WE PROVIDE FOR SERVICES AND
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT TO FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCIES -- AND OTHER
CHANGES -- TO FOR EXAMPLE THEY
THE PHASE OUT OF THE GROUP HOME
RATES AND REPLACEMENT WITH A
SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
PROGRAM I'M GONNA TRY NOT TO
CALL THEM S. T. R. T. P. S. --
AS DESCRIBED IN YOUR AGENDA THEY
HAVE NEW RATES AS WELL -- THOSE
THOSE ARE REALLY THE HIGHLIGHTS
I WANTED TO HIT FOR YOU THERE
WAS MAYBE ONE OTHER ON PAGE
THIRTEEN THERE'S A MENTION OF
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AND THAT'S BEEN A HUGE FOCUS FOR
MANY YEARS IN CALIFORNIA EVEN
DATING BEFORE THE C. C. R..
WE KNEW IT AS KATIE A LITIGATION
KATIE.
A WAS THE THE NAME OF THE YOUTH --
IN THAT LITIGATION -- AND WE'VE
DONE AND MADE GREAT STRIDES IN
CALIFORNIA INCREASING THE
ABILITY OF CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN
CARE TO ACCESS NECESSARY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
AS I MENTIONED WHEN WE RE CAST
THE EXPECTATIONS OF OUR SERVICE
PROVIDERS MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FEATURES PROMINENTLY AND NOT.
AND THE SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS
THAT I MENTIONED EARLIER HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH CONTRACTS AS A AS
A PRIMARY FOCUS OF THEIR SERVICE
PREVENTION.
IN TERMS OF FINDING YOUR CHART
ON PAGE.
SIXTEEN OF AT THE TOP THERE ARE
LATE LAYS OUT THAT THE THE
RECENT HISTORY AND A PROPOSAL --
FOR FOR C. C. R. YOU WILL NOTICE
THE TOP FOUR LINES ALIGNED WITH
THE MAJOR THEMES THAT I TALKED
ABOUT THE THE THE RATE CARE --
PAYMENTS THE CHILD AND FAMILY
TEAMS THE THE SUPPORT FOR FOSTER
PARENT CARE GIVERS AND RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL WHAT WE USED TO
CALL A FOSTER FAMILY HOME IS NOW
KNOWN AS A RESOURCE -- FAMILY --
SO THAT'S A TERMINOLOGY CHANGE
BUT THE CONCEPT IS THE SAME
THOSE ARE THAT THE HOME BASED
FAMILY KERR -- PROVIDERS CARE
GIVERS THAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE DISCUSSED
IN YOUR AGENDA -- THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF CHANGE MANAGEMENT THAT'S
BEEN DIFFICULT UNDERSTANDING
ROLES AND EXPECTATIONS THE THE
TRANSFER OF OF FAMILIES FROM A
FOSTER FAMILY DESIGNATION TO A
RESOURCE FAMILY DESIGNATION.
HAS BEEN SLOWER N
EVERYBODY ANTICIPATED -- THERE'S
BEEN SOME INVESTMENTS AND BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND AND THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION IN THE CURRENT
BUDGET TO GET -- THROUGH A
BACKLOG TO APPROVE THOSE MORE
TIMELY -- BUT THERE WAS A
FUNDING AUGMENTATION MADE A
COUPLE YEARS NOW -- THAT WE USED
TO PAY -- FAMILY CARE GIVER WHEN
THE CHILD I AM SORRY WHEN THEY
HOME WAS APPROVED AS A PLACEMENT.
BUT VERY OFTEN WE FIND PLACEMENT
PRIOR TO APPROVAL AND SO THERE
WAS A PERIOD OF TIME WHERE
FAMILIES DIDN'T HAVE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT THAT MAYBE WOULD HAVE
HELPED THEM.
EITHER BE A BETTER CARE GIVER OR
BE WILLING TO ACCEPT A CHILD IN
THE FIRST PLACE SO THAT'S A
MAJOR INVESTMENT THE LEVEL OF
CARE PROTOCOL TOOL HELPS US TO
SIGN THE NEEDS BASE RATE TO A
CHILD.
CANS THE CHILD ASSESSMENT OF
NEEDS AND STRENGTHS IS THE
FUNCTIONAL ASSESSMENT WE'RE
USING TO IDENTIFY THE NEEDSAND
STRENGTHS OF THE YOUTH.
AND THEN THERE ARE THE OTHER
BUCKET WHICH I WON'T DESCRIBE
BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY MANY
THINGS LUMPED INTO THAT -- ON
PAGE SEVENTEEN THERE'S A MENTION
OF A COUPLE BCP'S.
A BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS -- AT
THE BOTTOM OF SEVENTEEN AND ON
TO EIGHTEEN OTHER WAS RECENT
LEGISLATION PASSED LAST YEAR --
AB TWENTY EIGHTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY -- THAT
TALKED ABOUT INTEGRATED SYSTEMS
OF CARE -- AND AND HOW WE GET
EVERYBODY WHO NEEDS TO BE
INVOLVED IN THE CARE OF A KID
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY CROSSOVER A
FOSTER YOUTH ISN'T JUST A FOSTER
YOUTH THEY'RE ATTENDING SCHOOL
THEY MAY HAVE.
INVOLVEMENT WITH THE DISABILITY
SYSTEM MENTAL HEALTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH -- WE HAVE YOU THROUGH OR
DO ONLY INVOLVED WITH PROBATION
SO MAKING SURE THAT EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS WHAT'S EXPECTED OF
THEM AND MEETING THE NEEDS OF
THE USE.
IT WE'RE ASKING FOR STATE
POSITIONS TO TO WORK ON THAT.
AND THE SECOND ITEM ON THE TOP
OF PAGE -- EIGHTEEN IS -- C. C.
R. WAS CUT TITLE COMPLIANCE
WORKLOAD BUT THESE THIRTY FOUR
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN THE CORE OF OUR
CC OUR IMPLEMENTATION TEAM AT
THE DEPARTMENT WE'RE ASKING
THEIR RENT -- IT RENEW ALL AN
EXTENSION -- HERE THROUGH TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO RECOGNIZING THE
PACE OF CCR HASN'T BEEN WHAT IT
IS THESE ARE OUR RESIDENT
EXPERTS PROVIDING ASSISTANCE AND
MAKING SURE THAT THE WORK
ACTUALLY GETS DONE.
I WON'T DISCUSS THE ADVOCACY
PROPOSALS BECAUSE WERE ARE
OBVIOUSLY GOING TO GO THROUGH
THEM IN THE NEXT COUPLE AGENDA
ITEMS -- AND THERE'S A FEW PAGES
STARTING ON PAGE TWENTY WHERE
THE LA -- GOES THROUGH A NUMBER
OF COMMENTS WE FOUND WHAT THE LA --
HAD TO SAY ABOUT CC ARE AT THIS
POINT WAS VERY THOUGHTFUL AND
FOCUSED ON WHAT IT TAKES TO BE
SUCCESSFUL -- WE LARGELY AGREE
WITH THE COMMENTS OF THE LA --
AND WILL HAVE SOME COMMENTS
ABOUT LEVEL OF CARE IN RESPONSE
TO QUESTIONS THAT WERE PROVIDED
TO US IN THE AGENDA AHEAD OF
TIME.
A WITHOUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS OR I CAN -- TURN IT TO
MY COLLEAGUE -- GREG ROSE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF OUR CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES DIVISION TO GO
THROUGH THE QUESTIONS IN THE
AGENDA.
THANKS MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
GREG ROSE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
AND COUPLE OF THINGS I WANTED TO
MENTION BEFORE ANSWER THE THE
FIRST QUESTION.
YEP YOU DIRECTOR TRIPPING CAN
MENTION SOME OF THE THE THE THE
SUCCESSES AND THE CHALLENGES OF
OF C. C. R. I DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE A COUPLE OF
THINGS AS WELL. ONE AND WE'RE
SEEING A DECLINE OF OVER A
THOUSAND YOUNG PEOPLE IN
CONGREGATE CARE OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS -- THAT THEY'RE THE
NUMBER OF CHILD AND FAMILY TEAMS
IS INCREASING SIGNIFICANTLY BOTH
ON CHILD WELFARE AND ON
PROBATION MANAGE CASES WE'RE
SEEING SOME SOMBER SOLID
PARTNERSHIPS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THAT I THINK WILL BE --
THAT WILL BE FOUNDATIONAL TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE THE THE SYSTEM
FORWARD.
AND AND THERE'S A LOT OF UPSTATE
COLLABORATION WITH LOOK WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ON THIS CASE
SPECIFIC SITUATIONS -- SO THAT
WE CAN BETTER CERTAIN THE WEEK
WE CAN LEARN AND WE CAN ALSO
BETTER SERVE YOUNG PEOPLE -- AND
HELP THEM GET THE NEEDS THE THE
THE THINGS THEY NEED.
I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE A A
COUPLE OF AREAS THAT WE I THINK
ARE IMPORTANT WE FOCUS ON IN
THIS -- THIS COMING YEAR AS WE
DO IMPLEMENTATION ONE OF THOSE
IS THERE'S THERE'S A AROUND
EIGHT HUNDRED YOUNG PEOPLE IN --
CONGREGATE CARE FACILITIES THAT --
ON MAY NOT OR ARE SOME MAY NOT
AND SOME HAVE TOLD US THEY WILL
NOT BE TRANSITIONING -- THE THE
DAY THE COUNTIES ASSESSMENT OF
THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE IN CARE IS
ABOUT SEVENTY SOME ODD PERCENT
72% OF THEM WE DON'T MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS -- FOR FOR A SHORT
TERM RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC
PROGRAM AND SO IT TO THOSE YOUNG
PEOPLE I THINK THAT WE WE WE AS
A AS A AS A GROUP OF COLLEAGUES
NEED TO FOCUS ON CLEARLY WE NEED.
TO CONTINUE WORKING ON THE
BACKLOG OF THE RFA APPLICATIONS
AND THEIR AND AND I THINK THE
THE THE KEY AS I THINK IS
MENTIONED ACTUALLY IN THE AGENDA
ONE OF THE CORNERSTONES OF THE
AT OF THE OF THE INITIATIVE.
IS HIGH QUALITY CHILD AND FAMILY
TEAMS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE AND THEIR
AND PEOPLE WHO CARE ABOUT THEM
HAVE BOYS AND CHOICE AND WE ARE
SEAT WE'RE SEEING THE THE AS I
MENTIONED WE'RE SEEING THE
INCREASE OF THOSE -- WE ALSO ARE
WANTING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CONTINUE WITH HIGH HIGH QUALITY
AND WITH HIGH FIDELITY WITH THAT
SAID I'M HAPPY -- TO TRANSITION
INTO ACT ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
THAT WERE POSED INTO THE AGENDA.
THE THE FIRST TWO QUESTIONS ARE
ARE ARE SIMILAR IN NATURE AND
AND DEPUTY DIRECTOR JAMAICA
MENTIONED THAT -- THERE HAD BEEN
SOME INVESTMENTS IN THESE AREAS
OF THE THE SPECIFICALLY IS A
QUESTION ABOUT -- ABOUT THE
ELIMINATION AND I WOULD SAY THAT
THE A COUPLE OF POINTS ONE THE
THE COUNTIES HAVE HAD TO HAVE A
PRIOR TO TO REALIGNMENT AND AND
HAVE HAD SOME RESPONSIBILITY. TO
DO -- APPROVALS AND THEY'VE HAD
SOME RESPONSIBILITY FOR
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION.
THE ADMINISTRATION CLEARLY KNEW
GET GIVEN THE THE THAT HEAVY
LEFT IN FRONT OF US.
AND THE INTENT AND THE AND THE
LEVEL OF INTENSITY NEEDED -- FOR
TO TO DO RECRUITMENT RETENTION
AND SUPPORT -- CREATED TO IN
ESSENCE A THREE YEAR -- THAT A
THREE THREE YEAR FUNDING TO
PROVIDE -- THAT UP FRONT
INVESTMENT IN IN THESE
ACTIVITIES SO THE THE REDUCTION
HAS BEEN THE REDUCTION IN THESE
FUNDS IT HAS BEEN AT WHAT'S
PLANNED -- WHEN WE HAVE FROM THE
FIRST YEAR -- OF THAT ADDITIONAL --
ROLLOUT OF THE IMPLEMENTATION --
AND SO BOTH WITH THAT BOTH WITH
THE THE SO CALLED SHIPPERS FUNDS
THAT FOSTER PARENT RECRUITMENT
RETENTION PONDS AND AND THE OUR
FATE DOLLARS WERE INTENDED TO
PROVIDE -- A SURGE OF ACTIVITY
TO TO ALSO IDEA I I IDENTIFY
AREAS THE OF IN FOR INNOVATION
AT AND FUTURE -- REINVESTMENT
BYE BYE COUNTIES -- WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO GO THROUGH ALL THE
QUESTIONS OR YOU WANT US WOULD
YOU LIKE ME TO STOP AFTER EACH.
ONE DID YOU HAVE A COMMENT
ISRAEL OKAY.
I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT BEFORE WE
CONTINUE -- YOU -- INDICATED
THAT THERE IS A BACKLOG IN OUR
FAVOR APPROVAL CAN YOU TELL ME
WHAT THE BACKLOG IS OR HOW LONG
IT'S TAKING I KNOW THERE WAS A
DISCUSSION LAST YEAR AND WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS TO
ADD. TO THE BACKLOG IS DECLINE
IS DECLINING -- THE SPECIFIC
NUMBERS I A CAN HAVE FOR YOU
BEFORE THE END OF THE HEARING I
DON'T HAVE THEM IT IN IN FRONT
OF ME AT THE MO THEY'VE BEEN
DEBT THERE'D.
THEY'VE DECLINED BY -- AS I
RECALL THE TWENTY SOME ODD
PERCENT THE TIME TO APPROVAL IS
STILL OPEN BUT IT'S STILL OVER
NINETY DAYS SIGNIFICANTLY OVER
NINETY DAYS.
THE THE THE THE TREND IS THAT
THE THE BACKLOG IS TRENDING DOWN
AND THE NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS
IS TRENDING UP.
SO -- DEAD.
SO AT THAT THE US THAT TIME FOR
APPROVAL IS IS DECLINING BUT
IT'S STILL IT'S STILL IN
EXISTENCE I KNOW AND I IF I
RECALL CORRECTLY LAST YEAR WE
HAD THIS CONVERSATION ABOUT --
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
APPLICATIONS WERE APPROVED IT
WITHIN THE NINETY DAYS AND WE
HAD ASSURANCES LAST YEAR THAT --
THIS IS GOING TO HAPPEN AND SO
THAT'S WHY I WANT TO KNOW
SPECIFICALLY WHAT THE THE YOU
KNOW HOW LONG IT'S TAKING AND
WHY.
SINCE LAST YEAR WE HAD THE
DISCUSSION WHY HAS ANY CHANGE
RIGHT AFTER THE PROMISES SO THAT
SOME AT THE THERE ARE. FOUR ON
THE PLACEMENTS PRIOR TO APPROVAL
SO THESE WERE THE YOUNG PEOPLE
IN RELATIVE CARE -- THE THE
THEIR OF THE THE BACKLOG THE
LAST I CHECKED WITH ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED AND SET AND AND SIXTY
SEVEN CASES.
THE THEY ARE AND AND 61% OF
THOSE CASES THAT ARE AT THAT ARE
THAT ARE GOING ON BEYOND THE
NINETY DAYS ARE -- ARE -- HAVE
BEEN GRANTED GOOD COSTS OF THEIR
THINGS THAT THE THE BOTH THE
COUNTY AND THE CHECK AND THAT
AND FAMILY ARE OF WITHOUT
WITHOUT THEIR CONTROL SOME OF
THEM HAPPENED TO DO WITH.
THE LENGTH OF TIME RIGHT WHAT IT
COST ME GOOD CAUSE MEANS THAT
THAT THERE IS A THERE IS A A
REASONABLE THERE'S ARE A
REASONABLE REASON. FOR THAT FOR
THAT FOR THAT THE THE TIME TO GO
BEYOND NINETY DAYS SO FOR
EXAMPLE SOME OF THOSE THINGS
HAPPEN TO BE THE TIME IT TAKES
TO GET A CRIMINAL BACKGROUND
CHECK COMPLETED.
SOME OF THEM HAVE TO HAVE TO DO
WITH SOME OF THAT WHICH IS THE
THAT THAT ONE OF THE LARGER ONES
AND SOME OF THEM HAVE TO DO WITH
SOME -- PHYSICAL PLANT THINGS IN
THE HOME.
EXAMPLES ARE SOMETIMES IT HAS TO
DO WITH -- SOMETIMES IT HAS TO
DO WITH OF UP APPROPRIATE
FENCING OR SOMETIMES IT HAS TO
DO WITH -- WITH -- SMOKE
DETECTORS AND OTHER KINDS OF
THINGS BUT BUT IT'S IT'S IT'S
IT'S IT'S THOSE KINDS OF
PHYSICAL PLANT THINGS BY BUT AND
YOU KNOW Y. ALLEY I THINK WE
WERE HERE LAST YEAR WHEN WE HAD
THESE CONVERSATIONS -- SMOKE
DETECTORS ARE.
TRIVIAL IN MY OPINION SEARCH LE
IT'S LARGER THAT THAT THE THE
THE THE WHOLE I DON'T HAVE MY
LIST TO AND FROM THE I DO
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
THE THE THE THEY TEND TO IT THAT
THAT HOME.
THINGS HAPPEN TO BE THEY THEY'RE
OFTEN.
SO THEY'RE THEY'RE FLAUNTING
WHAT THEY'RE ALSO THEY'RE ALSO
SITUATIONS WHERE A FAMILY MOVED.
TO SEND SOMEBODY TO GET THOSE
LISTS FOR YOU SURE IN THE
MEANTIME WHILE WE'RE HAVING THIS
COME I EAT I WILL HI I HAVE SOME
OF THE INFORMATION -- IN MY
BACKPACK I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
THERE ARE THERE ARE SITUATIONS
IN WHICH FAMILIES WILL MOVE --
LIKE AT AT B. TIP TO HAVE TO
FIND ANOTHER TO AS THEY'VE TAKEN
ON THE YOUNG PERSON.
AT MICH THROUGH THE APPROVAL AND
THAT REQUIRES ANOTHER HOME AND
GROUNDS INSPECTION SO THERE'S A
NUMBER OF THERE'S A FEW THINGS
LIKE THAT THAT THAT -- ARE AT
THAT -- HAVE THAT THE CURRENT
THERE'S A NUMBER SIX AS I SAID
61% OF THESE -- OF THE BACK OF
THAT.
TIME TO APPROVAL PAST NINETY
DAYS EVENTS ALL ITS ON THE
MEANTIME I'M SORRY TO INTERRUPT
AT CHURCH TRYING TO HAVE A
DIALOGUE HAD A FEW -- IN THE
MEANTIME WHAT HAPPENS TO THOSE
KIDS THOSE KIDS ARE IN
PLACEMENTS WITH THEIR RELATIVE.
AT AT THAT POINT THERE THE
RELATIVES ARE BEING REIMBURSED
FOR THAT FOR THAT THERE OKAY SO
WITH THAT WAS THAT THAT BIGELOW
A DISCUSSION I ONE RELATED
DISCUSSION INSTEAD OF AN
ARGUMENT LAST YEAR.
ABOUT HOW LONG IT WAS TAKING FOR
THE OUR PAY. FOR THE FOR THE
FAMILIES TO RECEIVE PAYMENT NOW
SO THE FOLLOW UP QUESTION IS IS
THERE A BACKLOG IN PAIN THOSE
FAMILIES.
NOT THAT WE'RE AWARE OF OUR
KNOWLEDGE OKAY.
ARE INEVITABLY I'M SURE THAT
SOMEBODY COULD FIND A
SITUATIONAL SOMEBODY I'M.
SOMEBODY IS ONE THING BUT THE
LIGHT IN GENERAL AS HE IS CLEAR
THAT WE CAN PAY UP TO A YEAR OF
PLACEMENT PRIOR TO APPROVAL OKAY
SOLD MIKE IN SEOUL JUST TO BE
CLEAR.
SO FAMILIES ARE BEING PAID
CREATES ARE IN THE HOMES IN THE
MEAN AROUND IT'S JUST THE
OFFICIAL APPROVAL HASN'T BEEN
GRANTED CORRECT PLACEMENT
PENDING APPROVAL.
THE IMPROVE AS AN IMPORTANT STEP
IN OUR OPINION BUT IT'S NOT
DELAYING THE WELL BEING AND CARE
OF THE CASE IS THAT ONCE AGAIN
WHICH IS OUR FOR MISTER THAT
WORKERS HERE THAT THAT WAS BOB
BIG.
DISCUSSION LAST YEAR OKAY AND
THEN -- YOU SAID THERE'S SIX
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN CASES.
OF A CAN YOU ELABORATE ON THAT.
THAT'S THE THE BACKLOG OF THE OF
THE ROUTE THAT THE OF THE BEYOND
THE NINETY DAYS SO THE MORE THE
RELATIVE AND SIXTY SEVEN CASES.
GIVE OR TAKE A FEW BRIGHT AND
THE MAKE THE THE BAR. 99% OF
THESE ARE OUR CHILDREN THAT ARE
PLACED.
CORRECT THE OF THAT THAT NUMBER
I PROVIDE THEY'RE ALL PLACE
THERE THAT THEY'RE ALL THEY ALL
OUR RELATIVES WITH THAT ARE AT
THAT HAVE CHILDREN IN THEIR CARE
WHO ARE BEING COMPENSATED WHO
GET THE STIPEND THE FOSTER CARE
STIPEND FOR WHILE THAT WHILE THE
WORK IS GOING THAT'S GREAT.
NEWS BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS A
BIG A TOPIC OF DISCUSSION AFTER
A LOT OF THE FOLKS WERE HERE AND
INDICATING THAT THERE WAS NO --
PAYMENT FOR THEM FOR IT RIGHT
YOU TO FOUR MONTHS AND YOU KNOW
SO THAT HAS BEEN COMPLETELY THAT
ALL THAT PART HAS BEEN SOLVED
BASED AS THE THE THE THE ACTUAL
APPROVAL TIME.
IS TAKING THE SOMETIME AT THE
BASE AND THE FINAL CORRECT.
OKAY CORRECTS OF FOLKS GET YOUR
THAT WORKS ARE BEING SUPPORTED
OKAY -- BUT STILL FOR THAT OKAY
WERE YOU HAVING UP ARE VERY.
THIS IS MY LEASE -- BUT NO I'M
I'M REALLY THANKFUL THEN BECAUSE
IT FEELS NOW THAT YOU ARE
LISTENING -- WE HAD A BIG HUGE
DISCUSSION LAST YEAR AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK
BECAUSE AGAIN I THESE ARE KIDS
THAT THAT NEED OUR SUPPORT AND
FAMILIES IN NEED OUR SUPPORT SO
IF YOU'RE GUARANTEEING ME THAT
THIS IS HAPPENING.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT IF YOU
CAN JUST YOU KNOW GIVE ME THE A
DVD OF THE DATA TO SUPPORT THAT
I WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE IT
ABSOLUTELY WE CAN DO THAT --
WERE REPORTING ON C. C. R.
IMPLEMENTATION PURSUANT TO SOME
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WAS JUST
LAST MONTH WE GOT TOGETHER WITH
YOUR STAFF AND WE PROVIDE A
TWENTY SOME ODD PAGE REPORT THAT
INCLUDES A CHART WITH THAT
INFORMATION.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
IF YOU WOULD LIKE IT AS HE
EXPLAINED -- THERE'S BEEN A
DRAMATIC INCREASE IN THE VOLUME
OF PEOPLE WANTING TO BE CARE
GIVERS AND NEEDING TO MOVE
THROUGH THE PIPELINE AT THE SAME
TIME THAT'S HAPPENED.
WE'VE MANAGED TO BRING THE
BACKLOG DOWN AND I WHEN I SAY WE
I MEAN US WITH OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS -- TO BRING THAT THAT
BACKLOG DOWN IT IS MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION IN TIME TO
APPROVAL IS MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT ALL OF THAT SAID
AGAIN.
CHILDREN ARE GETTING THE CARE
THAT THEY NEED.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THE AVERAGE
IT'S PROBABLY IN THE WRITTEN
WORD IS HUNDRED NINETY DAYS SITE.
IT'S ABOUT SAY NOT BY.
WILL DO NOW IS THAT WE'LL WHEN
WE HEAR FROM.
MEDINA -- FRANK JUSTIN RYAN --
AND THEN.
PERHAPS HAVE SOME OF THE OTHER
QUESTIONS YOUR ANSWERS ARE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
THE DEAN OF COCOA.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES GOOD AFTERNOON --
SPECIFICALLY I AM I'M.
GOING TO BE ADDRESSING QUESTIONS
FOUR AND FIVE AROUND SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES --
QUESTION NUMBER FOUR HOW DO THE
DEPARTMENTS TRACK WHETHER MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
ARE BEING PROVIDED TO CHILDREN
WHO NEED THOSE SERVICES WHETHER
OR NOT IN AN S. T. R. T. PEER
GROUP HOME -- AND THE TWO
DEPARTMENTS -- DO PRODUCE
QUARTERLY REPORTS THAT TRACK --
FOSTER CARE CHILDREN CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE WHO MAY NEED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND WHETHER OR
NOT THEY ARE GETTING THOSE
SERVICES.
THE CHILD WELFARE IS REQUIRED --
TO SCREEN AND ALL CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE AND THEN MAKE A
REFERRAL -- TO COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH -- IF THE CHILD SCREENS
POSITIVE AND THEN THAT IS
DOCUMENTED IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM AND THEN THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
TAKES THAT DATA -- FROM THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM AND MATCHES
IT TO OUR DATA TO DETERMINE WHAT
SERVICES THE CHILDREN ARE
GETTING -- IF IN FACT THEY'RE
GETTING THE SERVICES.
SO -- WE WE DO THAT MATCH WE DO
IT QUARTERLY TO ENSURE THAT THE
CHILDREN ARE GETTING THE SERVICE
WE CONTINUE TO MONITOR AND TRACK
THAT DATA.
AND CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES --
TO EXAMINE AND REFINED THAT DATA
[inaudible]
NUMBER.
FOUR AND BEFORE WE GET THE FIVE
WHAT IS TODAY TO TELL ME ABOUT
THE DELIVERY -- IT TELLS US THAT
THE CHILDREN THAT ARE ACTUALLY
MAKING IT INTO -- THE COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM MOST OF
THOSE CHILDREN ARE RECIEVING
SPECIAL TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
WHEN YOU SEE THOSE WHO MAKE IT
YEAH?
IT DOESN'T HELP OF MY MY MY
MICROPHONE IS OFF FOR THOSE WHO
WHO.
YOU SAY FOR THOSE WHO MAKE AT
THE END.
WHAT DETERMINES OUR WHAT IS WHAT
IS THE HOLD BACK FOR THOSE SO --
THERE IS SOME DATA COLLECTION
AND I THINK SOME DATA
IMPROVEMENT ISSUES -- THAT NEED
TO HAPPEN WE ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH SIDE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES -- CAN ONLY
TRACK ONCE THE CHILD HAS MADE IT
INTO THE COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM AND SEE IF THEY HAVE
SERVICES SO PERHAPS I WILL.
ASK THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO SPEAK TO ON YOUR
QUESTION.
OKAY SURE REGRETS AGAIN FOR THE
DEPARTMENT THE THE EIGHTY
LIMITED THAT. EIGHTY POINT 3% OF
THE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO SCREEN
POSITIVE GET REFERRED -- TO GET
REFERRED OVER TO THE OVER TO TO
THE MENTAL HEALTH ACT HIM SORRY.
8083% OF THOSE WHO HAVE HAVE
HAVE SCREENED -- GET IT GET A
REFER SCREEN POSITIVE GET A
REFERRAL INTO THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND THERE AND THERE'S A
MEDICAL NECESSITY REQUIRE EVAN
OUT OF MEDICAL NECESSITY
ASSESSMENT THAT'S DONE.
ON THE MENTAL HEALTH SIDE SO --
THE THE THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT SCREEN
POSITIVE -- OUT SO THERE'S A
SCREENING AND THEN THERE'S AN
ASSESSMENT TO THE CHILD WELFARE
WORKER DOES A IN ESSENCE A ROUGH
SAFETY IF YOU WILL THAT THE
CHILD MEET CERTAIN CRITERIA --
HAD CERTAIN EXPERIENCES THEN
THEY WILL -- THEY WILL BE
REFERRED OVER TO THAT SPENT TO
THE MENTAL HEALTH -- SPECIAL NOW
PROGRAM SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM AT THAT POINT DOES A
MORE CLINICAL ASSESSMENT TO SEE
IF THE CHILD MEETS THE CRITERIA
FOR MEDICAL NECESSITY.
AND IT'S A THEN WENT THEN --
FOLKS WILL THEN THE SERVICES
BEGAN BEYOND THAT SHOULD NOTE
THAT THERE ARE YOU KNOW -- SOME
SOME SOME FOLKS THAT HAVE
SCREENED POSITIVE WILL NOT MEET
THE MEDICAL NECESSITY
REQUIREMENTS SO THAT STE THE THE
ONLY SERVICE THEY WILL GET WILL
BE AN ASSESSMENT.
BECAUSE THEY THEY DON'T MEET THE
CRITERIA FOR FURTHER -- FOR
FURTHER SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH.
WHEN WE HAVE FRANK MEGA I HAD A
GERMAN JUST MAKE ONE COMMENT ON
THIS PARTICULAR POINT IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH -- THAT WHAT
WE DO KNOW FROM DATA AT THE H.
C. S. IS THAT A ROUGHLY THREE IN
TEN KIDS IN OUT OF HOME CARE.
MEET THE ENGAGEMENT RATE WHICH
IS A STATE THE TERM RATE -- THAT
IS THE SORT OF THE METRIC OF
MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT IN THE
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
AND THAT MEANS FIVE CONTACTS IN
A YEAR -- AND SO SEVEN IN TEN
ARE NOT AND THAT'S IN PART
BECAUSE AS MR ROSE SAID THAT.
THE MEDICAL NECESSITY DEFINITION.
AS IT'S APPLIED SCREENS SOME
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF KIDS IN
OUT OF HOME CARE OUT OF THE
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
AND TO SOME EXTENT IT'S GOOD FOR
KIDS NOT GETTING SICK AND TO THE
SCREENING IN THE FIRST PLACE BUT
NOT TO HAVE THE MENTAL HEALTH
CONVERSATION HERE BECAUSE THE
BANK COMMITTEES.
YOUR COMMITTEES HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AT SOME LENGTH ALL YEAR BUT THIS
QUESTION OF WHAT IS MEDICAL
NECESSITY.
AND HOW IS IT HELPING ARE NOT
HELPING KIDS TO EXPERIENCE THE
TRAUMA OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT AND
A REMOVAL -- I THINK IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT ONE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE IT SEEMS
COUNTERINTUITIVE AN INCONSISTENT
WITH WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT KIDS IN
FOSTER CARE OF EXPERIENCED.
THAT THINK THAT SEVEN OUT OF TEN
OF THEM WOULD NOT.
NEED ANY SUPPORT FROM OUR
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
MEANINGFUL SUPPORT FROM OUR
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
AND THE ISSUE THERE IS THE
DEFINITION OF MEDICAL NECESSITY.
IS THAT SOMETHING THEM I HOPE WE
CAN WORK ON ON THAT.
YES WONDERFUL AND CLEAN UP --
MISS COOK OFFS -- COULD YOU
ADDRESS QUESTION NUMBER FIVE
BEFORE WE MOVE ON SURE HAPPY TO
SO QUESTION NUMBER -- FIVE
REGARDING THE PROVISION OF
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AND HOW IT IS PROGRESSING -- AND
AREAS PERHAPS NEEDING ATTENTION --
WITHIN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS OR OR
YEAR AND A THE PROVISION
ESPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WE ARE SEEING IS
PROGRESSING -- IT MAY VERY BY S.
T. R. A. T. P. -- BUT BUT IT IS
PROGRESSING -- AREAS OF WHERE --
I THINK THERE MIGHT BE SOME
ATTENTION NEEDED IS PERHAPS ON
THE LOWER LEVEL GROUP HOMES --
WHO ARE TRANSITIONING TO S. T.
R. T. PEAS -- IN THAT THEY MAY
HAVE NOT OR HAVE NOT DEALT WITH
ON CHILDREN AND YOUTH -- WITH
THESE INTENSIVE -- NEEDS AND
ALSO -- MAY NOT BE FAMILIAR WITH
THE SPECIAL TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND REQUIREMENTS AND
THE WAY THAT -- SERVICES ARE
EXPECTED TO BE PROVIDED -- AND
SO IT'S A STEEP LEARNING CURVE
ON FOR THEMSO I WOULD SAY THAT --
YOU KNOW THE DEPARTMENTS
CONTINUE -- TO BRAINSTORM ON HOW
WE CAN ASSIST SUPPORT -- THAT
LEARNING CURVE WHAT IS IT YOU
NEED. TO BE ABLE TO SHOW -- THE
S. TRT PEAS.
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO?
IS SIX A STEEP LEARNING CURVE
WHAT WHAT IS IT THEY NEED.
I FOUND WHAT IS IT WE'RE GOING
TO DO TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE IT.
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE SO THAT.
WE DON'T LEAVE ANYBODY BEHIND --
I APPRECIATE THAT QUESTION --
THERE HAS BEEN A NUMBER OF
EFFORTS STARTING FROM --
TRAINING -- A REGIONAL TRAININGS
THAT HAPPENED SOME AT A HIGHER
LEVEL BUT TO TRY TO INFORM IT'S
BEEN GOING ON REGIONAL COOKIES
BROUGHT THE LAST TWO YEARS TO
EDUCATE -- S. T. R. T. PEAS OR
GROUP -- GROUP HOMES LOOKING TO
CONVERT THERE IS --
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS THAT
HAPPENED BETWEEN THE TWO
DEPARTMENTS WHERE WILL ACTUALLY
NEED -- WORK WITH -- GROUP HOMES
THAT HAVE QUESTIONS -- I THERE
IT IS COLLABORATIVE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL IT NEEDS TO HAPPEN WITH
THE PLACE IN AGENCIES AND THE
MENTAL HEALTH PLAN SO I THINK
THERE'S A NUMBER OF SUPPORTS.
THE AT VARIOUS LEVELS THAT CAN
HELP WITH THAT LEARNING CURVE.
CLEARLY IT'S SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
IN THE NEXT MONTH OR MONTHS AS%
OPPOSED TO IN THE NEXT YEAR OR
YEARS -- IS THERE A PLAN IS
THEIR SPECIFIC PLAN TO TO DEAL
WITH THIS [inaudible]
TRANSITION PERIOD.
I KNOW THAT YOU SAY THAT FOR TWO
YEARS THERE'S BEEN SOME
BRAINSTORMING BUT VERY
SPECIFICALLY AND YOU FOR TRYING
TO GET FROM POINT A TO POINT B..
IS THERE A PLAN SO THAT WE GET
THERE.
THE THE THE THE WAY THE THE LEAD
THAT.
THERE IS A PLAN THE PLAN THE IS
BASED PARTLY BASED ON THE THE
THE THE LEGISLATION WHICH COURT
REQUIRES THIS KIND OF LINEAR
PROCESS FIRST.
FIRST YOU GET LICENSE TO IT WITH
THE NEW UNDER THE NEW CRITERIA
AND ADMITTEDLY ARE -- SCRUTON T.
OF THE LICENSING PROCESS IN THE
LICENSING DOCUMENT IS IS IS VERY
HIGH FOR TWO REASONS ONE IS WE
ARE LOOKING AT MAKING SURE THAT
RATHER THAN -- IN OUR OLD WAY OF
THE AUDITING WHERE WE KIND OF
COUNTED ACCOUNTED THINGS AND
ONLY LOOK AT MONEY WE WERE
ACTUALLY TRYING TO ASSESS
QUALITY AND SO PART OF WHAT WE
ARE DOING IS.
BEING CLEAR THAT.
WE WOULD HOLD THE THE WE WOULD
ASSESS THE THAT PROVIDERS OF
QUALITY BASED ON WHAT THEY SAID
THEY WERE.
WHAT THE PROGRAM WAS GOING TO DO
WHAT IS YOUR PROGRAM GOING TO BE
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO FOCUS ON
ON THAT THE HEALING THE TRAUMA
HOW ARE THEY CONNECTED HOW ARE
THEY HOW WILL THE IN?
HOW WILL THE IMPLEMENTED PROVIDE
THAT THE INTEGRATED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES SO OUR OWN
PROCESS TAKE IT IT TAKES A WHILE
IT IT'S AN INTERNET PROCESS?
ONLY THEN ONCE THEY'RE LICENSED
CAN THEY GO OVER AND GET THE
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM APPROVAL
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES IS DOING -- AND
SOME COUNTIES ARE DOING AS WELL
AND THEN ONCE THEY HAVE HAVE
GONE AND GOTTEN THAT PROGRAM
APPROVAL THEN THEY'RE ABLE TO
ENGAGE WITH LOCAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS. TO ACTUALLY GET
A CON GET CERTIFIED TO GET A
CONTRACT SO IT'S A LINEAR
PROCESS THAT IT TAKES A WHILE
OUR PLAN TO GET PEOPLE -- FROM
ONE PLACE TO ANOTHER HE HAS BEEN
A NUMBER OF REGIONAL CONVENING
AND INCLUDING JUST RECENTLY A
NUMBER OF OF OF WEBINARS AND
OTHER ENGAGEMENT WHERE.
SOME OF THAT THAT THE THE
PROVIDERS THAT HAVE ALREADY GONE
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND AND AND
WE'RE AND TURNED THE CORNER MORE
QUICKLY ARE ARE PROVIDING.
HERE KIND OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE BE IN ADDITION TO
WHAT THE TWO DEPARTMENTS AND
LOCAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IS DOING
SOME COUNTIES ARE ALSO --
PARTNERING LOCALLY TOOK TO HELP
SUPPORT -- THAT THAT THE
PROVIDERS WHO HAVE YET WHO HAVE
HISTORICALLY HAD A MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM TO UNDERSTAND WHAT WHAT
DOES THAT LOOK LIKE AND HOW DO
YOU PREPARE.
SO THAT YOU CAN ACTUALLY --
ACHIEVE THE PROGRAM APPROVAL SO
THERE'S A NUMBER OF OF OF OF OF
EFFORTS GOING -- BUT THE PROCESS
IS IN FACT A LINEAR AND THEN AT
THE END OF IT THE EVEN THE THE
CONTRACTING PROCESS THAT LOCAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH HAVE SELECTIVE
CONTRACTING AND THEY THEY THEY
CAN CHOOSE TO CONTRACT OR NOT TO
CONTRACT WITH ANY GIVEN PROVIDER.
IF IF I MAY MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE PITCHER FRANK AGAIN.
I I WOULD JUST ADD ON TO THIS IS
AN AREA WHERE I WANT TO BE SURE
THAT WE DON'T UNDER STATE THE
AMOUNT OF EFFORT GOING INTO THE
WORK HERE -- THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF FACILITIES
TRYING TO TRANSITION THE MALL IT
IS A REALLY DIFFICULT
UNDERTAKING -- WE ARE FOCUSED
WITH OUR COUNTIES -- OUR STAFF
AND AND SOME OF THE THIRTY FOUR
IN THE B. C. P. THAT I
REFERENCED EARLIER OR ENGAGE
pCOLLEAGUES IN OUR COUNTY
COLLEAGUES WE DO FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY INDIVIDUAL CALLS WITH
THOSE COUNTIES.
WE'RE WORKING THROUGH THE ISSUES
THAT THEY'RE SEEING SPECIFICALLY
COUNTY BY COUNTY ON THE GROUND
WE'RE ALSO PRIORITIZING OUR
EFFORT -- TO TO IDENTIFY WHERE
WE NEED CAPACITY TO I'M KEY FOR
YOU HOW MANY -- YOU SAID YOU YOU
MAKE CALLS ARE YOU HAVE --
CALDERON COUNTIES HOW OFTEN --
SOME OF THOSE ARE WEEKLY
DEPENDING ON THE COUNTY THAT
OFTEN YEAH.
A LARGE AMOUNT IS ARE OBVIOUSLY
MORE OFTEN BECAUSE THEY HAVE
MORE CASES TO WORK THROUGH MORE
SITUATIONS TO WORK THROUGH THANK
YOU YEAH ABSOLUTELY.
SO I DON'T WANT TO LEAVE YOU
WITH THE IMPRESSION THERE SOME
VAGUE PLANNERS ACTIVE WORK
THAT'S VERY DIFFICULT WORK
THAT'S GOING ON ON A VERY
INDIVIDUAL BASIS HERE AND MISTER
MAC OF PERHAPS OR OTHERS MIGHT
WANT TO WEIGH IN.
WITH COMMENTS THERE THAT SAID
THERE IS MORE THAT COULD BE DONE.
YEAH.
I JUST TOOK MY REMARKS OKAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FRANK MAKE
WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION -- A
COLLEAGUE OF MINE AT SEATED BDA
WHO'S HERE COLE WROTE THE REPORT.
THAT GAVE RISE TO THE C. C. R.
LEGISLATION WITH WITH MISTER
ROSEN SO -- WE'RE FULLY
COMMITTED TO ITS IMPLEMENTATION
AND CONTINUE TO BELIEVE IT'S THE
RIGHT WAY TO DO CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES.
I POINT OUT THAT THAT CCR ISN'T
ONE REFORM CC ARE IS NO FEWER
THAN FIVE MAJOR REFORMS THAT ARE
ALL BEING UNDERTAKEN AT THE SAME
TIME.
WE'RE CHANGING THE WAY WE DO
SOCIAL WORK WERE CHANGING THE
NATURE OF RESIDENTIAL.
CARE INTO INTO SHORT TERM
TREATMENT WE'RE CHANGING THE WAY
WE APPROVED FAMILIES WERE
CHANGING THE LIGHT THE THE RATE
SYSTEM FOR FAMILIES WERE
CHANGING THE WAY AND THE NATURE --
BUT TWO OF THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
AND CHILD WELFARE AND ALL OF
THIS IS HAPPENING AT THE SAME
TIME.
AND SO I WOULD JUST UNDERSCORE
WHAT MR JOVANKA SAID THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK HAPPENING.
ALL THAT BEING SAID I DO THINK
IT MAKES SENSE TO TAKE SOME
STOCK AND HOW IT'S GOING WE MADE
SOME BIG ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT.
WITH C. C. R. WOULD BE ABLE TO
PRODUCE AND BY WHEN AND I DO
THINK THAT IT'S FAIR TO SAY.
SERVE HOW THE GOING AND AS AS
YOU MIGHT IMAGINE AND AS WE
SHOULD PROBABLY EXPECT THERE ARE
SOME THINGS THAT ARE GOING WELL.
AND THERE ARE SOME AREAS THAT
ARE STILL VERY MUCH A WORK IN
PROGRESS AND PROBABLY GIVE RISE
TO SOME REASON FOR SOME MID
COURSE THINKING -- AND SO WE
SORT OF A LINE WITH MR ROSE A
SENSE OF OF WHAT'S WHAT'S
WORKING THE REDUCTION IN THE
NUMBER OF KIDS IN CONGREGATE
CARE BOTH PROBATION AND CHILD
WELFARE KIDS.
CHILD AND FAMILY TEAMING IS A
MUCH BETTER WAY OF DOING SOCIAL
WORK FOR EVERYBODY INVOLVED AND
THAT'S WELL UNDER WAY THE
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL PROCESS.
AS ARGUE WITH HIM LABOR
INTENSIVE AS IT IS AND AT GET IT
SO MUCH MORE WORK THAN WE
ANTICIPATED TO GET THE EXISTING
CASES SORT OF THROUGH THE
PIPELINE.
IT IS A MUCH BETTER WAY. TO
APPROVE AND SUPPORT FAMILIES
BECAUSE YOU DO A ROBUST HOME
ASSESSMENT.
AND SO CARE GIVERS.
ARE BETTER ABLE TO CARE FOR
CHILDREN WHERE BET BETTER ABLE
TO DETERMINE IF IT'S A RIGHT
MATCH SO I DON'T WANNA GET LOST
IN THE DISCUSSION ABOUT OUR A
FAIT.
THE VALUE OF OF IT -- AS A
DIFFERENT AND BETTER WAY OF
APPROVING RELATIVES -- AND MANY
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES ARE NOW
STARTING TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF INTENSIVE SERVICES FOSTER
CARE FAMILIES.
THIS IS ONE OF TWO MAJOR
CATEGORIES OF FAMILY BASED
PLACEMENTS THAT CC ARE ASSUMED
WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR KIDS WHO
WERE IN LOWER LEVEL GROUP COMES
BUT SHOULDN'T BE LIVING THERE.
THEY DON'T THEY DON'T NEED
TREATMENT BUT THEY SHOULD BE
WITH FAMILIES AND WE MADE SOME
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT.
BUILDING OUT INTENSIVE SERVICES
FOSTER CARE AND TREATMENT FOSTER
CARE WHAT WAS WHICH WAS ACTUALLY
A REQUIREMENT OF THE KD ES
SETTLEMENT.
AN INTENSIVE SERVICES FOSTER
CARE WE'RE STARTING TO SEE SORT
OF TAKE OFF.
THE AREAS THAT WE BELIEVE ARE
STILL VERY MUCH A WORK AND AND
AND PROCESS AND THERE ARE SOME
AREAS OF CONCERN.
ARE ONES THAT YOU'VE HIGHLIGHTED
ALREADY ONE IS.
THE RELATIVELY SLOW RATE OF
CONVERSION OF GROUP HOMES --
INTO -- S. T. R. TEEPEES.
ABOUT HALF OF THE KIDS WHO ARE
IN CONGREGATE CARE ARE IN FILL
IN FACILITIES RIGHT NOW THAT
HAVE AN S. T. R. T. P. LICENSE.
YOU PROVIDED THE AUTHORITY FOR
US TO BE ABLE TO ALLOW THOSE
FACILITIES TO CARE FOR THOSE
CHILDREN.
UNTIL THE END OF THIS YEAR
BECAUSE OF THAT.
SORT OF THAT THAT SLOWER RATE OF
CONVERSION -- AND WE DO THINK
THAT FOR MANY OF THOSE
FACILITIES THEY'RE SMALLER
FACILITIES THERE COMMUNITY BASED
FACILITIES.
MAY.
THEY ARE QUALITY AND THEY COULD
BE VERY THERAPEUTIC PLACES FOR
YOU FOR YOU.
BUT THE STEPS TO BE CALM
APPROVED ARE NOT INSIGNIFICANT
MISTER ROSE.
OUTLINED SORT OF THE THREE THE
THREE STEPS AND SO THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF WORK TO TRY TO HELP
THOSE FACILITIES.
ALONG THE PROCESS OF LICENSING
AND APPROVAL AND THEN
CONTRACTING.
BUT I DO THINK IT IT'S TIME AND
WE ARE BEGINNING TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. TO THINK ABOUT
PERHAPS WHETHER WE NEED SOME
MORE INTENSE SEVEN MORE
INTENTIONAL.
SORT OF SPECIFIC TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR THOSE.
IN A FACILITY THAT WE REALLY
BELIEVE ARE IMPORTANT PARTS OF
THE CARE NETWORK AND WE INTEND
TO TALK TO THE ADMINISTRATION
ABOUT.
IDEAS -- IDEAS FOR DOING JUST
THAT -- THAT CONTRACTING -- THE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH CONTRACTING
ISSUE I THINK IT'S ONE THAT THAT
BEARS KEEPING OUR EYE ON THERE'S
ONLY NINETEEN S. T. R. T. PEAS
IN THE STATE HAVE HAVE PASSED
ALL THREE STEPS -- AND SO.
THERE'S ABOUT NINE HUNDRED
CONGREGATE CARE FACILITIES IN
THE STATE BUT I SHOULD QUALIFY
THAT BY SAYING THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY TO SAY.
THAT WE BELIEVE THERE OUGHT TO
BE NINE HUNDRED BUT BUT NINETEEN
IS A LOW NUMBER -- AND BOB AS WE
GET S. T. R. T. PEAS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT.
THROUGH THE LICENSING PHASE I
THINK WE HAVE TO WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO PROBLEM SOLVE.
ABOUT HOW THOSE FACILITIES GET
MENTAL HEALTH CONTRACTS FROM
COUNTY MENTAL COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH PLANS AND THAT'S AN AREA
I THINK THE BEARS.
ARE OUR INTENTIONALITY AND YOUR
AND AND YOUR OVERSIGHT -- AND
THEN THE LAST THING I'LL SAY IS
THEM AJ BUT THEY'RE PEDIC FOSTER
CARE.
WAS OF AN OUTCOME OF THE KD ES
SETTLEMENT THE KATIE A LAWSUIT
WITH THE LAWSUIT THAT THE STATE
LOST -- THAT -- FOUND THAT THE
STATE WAS NOT IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE FEDERAL EPA STT LAW.
AND PART OF COMING INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH WITH THE PST TO
THE COURT REQUIRED WITH REST
THAT DEVELOP TREATMENT FOSTER
CARE.
AND THAT'S BEEN VERY SLOW TO GET
OFF THE GROUND AND AND I DON'T
THINK THAT'S BECAUSE ANYONE'S
BEEN DRAGGING THEIR FEET -- BUT
WE MADE ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT TREATMENT FOSTER
CARE WOULD BE A VIABLE.
APPROACH -- TO TO SERVE SOME
CHILDREN WHO SEE SEE OUR SAYS
GET OUT OF THE GROUP HOPES.
BOMB AND I THINK WE NEED TO WORK
ON EITHER DEVELOPING TREATMENT
FOSTER CARE WITH INTENTIONALITY
OR COMING UP WITH A CONTINGENCY
PLAN IF IT TURNS OUT THE
TREATMENT FOSTER CARE TO IT.
IT IS PERHAPS NOT VIABLE IN THE
WAY THAT THAT KATIE A COURT --
THOUGHT IT WAS -- THE LAST AND
LAST THING I WOULD SAY IS THAT --
THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS IT'S
TAKEN MORE TIME.
THAN PERHAPS SOME ORIGINALLY
IMAGINED I SHOULD SAY PROBABLY
NOT MORE TIME THAN MY MEMBERS
IMAGINE -- BUT WE WERE
INCREDIBLY AUDACIOUS IN SCOPE AN
AMBITIOUS AND TIME FRAME.
AND SO WE'LL TALK LATER ON IN
THE PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENT BUT
OUR MEMBERS EXTREMELY ORRIED
ABOUT PULLING OUT THE RUG.
PULLING THE RUG OUT FROM UNDER
THOSE UP FROM UP FROM UP FRONT
INVESTMENTS LIKE RFA AND THE
FAMILY STABILITY FUND BECAUSE
THE FAMILY.
ARE THE ALTERNATIVE -- TO
GROUPON PLACEMENTS AND WE ALL
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH OF THEM AND IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT I THINK THAT WE
NOT.
BECAUSE OF AN UNREALISTIC TIME
FRAME THAT WE SET OUT AT THE
BEGINNING BECAUSE WE WERE REALLY
AUDACIOUS AN AMBITIOUS.
THAT WE NOT PULLED THE RUG OUT
FROM UNDER THE REFORM IN MID
STREAM.
WE'RE GOING TO BE SHARING THE
CHAIR SHIP -- WE BOTH HAVE BILLS
WE'RE PRESENTING.
SO WE SINCERELY APPRECIATE YOUR
UNDERSTANDING IN THAT REGARD --
ALL RIGHT.
BEFORE THE FIFTY ABSOLUTELY YEAH
SO SO BEFORE WE CONTINUE OUT WE
TALKED ABOUT THE NINE HOT.
NINE HUNDRED OF FACILITIES IN
NINETEEN HAVE PASSED ALL THREE
STEPS SOUL CAN YOU ELABORATE
JUST A LITTLE BIT NOT TOO MUCH
BUT I JUST WANT TO KNOW.
IF THERE'S ONLY NINETEEN PASS
DOES THAT MEAN THAT SOME KIDS
ARE CURRENTLY IN THOSE
FACILITIES.
AND IF THERE IS ONLY NINETEEN
AND HAVING FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
WHAT WHAT HAPPENS TO THE?
THE I'M OF LET'S JUST ASSUME
JUST FOR MY PURPOSES THAT
THERE'S NOW IN NINETEEN COUNTY
THAT ACTUALLY HAVE ONE RIGHT
WHAT HAPPENS.
TO THOSE OTHER COUNTIES OR THAT
DON'T HAVE THOSE FACILITIES
AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO THOSE KIDS SO OF
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION IN TWO
PARTS THE FIRST PART OF YOUR
QUESTION -- THE MENTAL HEALTH
CONTRACT -- IS NOT A
PREREQUISITE AT THIS MOMENT FOR
A FACILITY TO CARE FOR A CHILD.
THEY EITHER HAVE TO HAVE A
CONTRACT TO DELIVER BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES OR THEY HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR RANGING FOR
ALL NECESSARY.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IT'S NOT
THE OPTIMAL SORT OF STATE OF CCR
OCT OPERATIONS BUT IT BUT IT IS
ALLOWED -- BUT AS WE TO TEAR
SECOND PARTY YOUR QUESTION --
THAT CC ARE INTENTIONALLY
ENVISIONED REDUCING THE NUMBER
OF CONGREGATE CARE FACILITIES.
AND YOUR QUESTION HITS TO A
CONCERN THAT WE HAVE ONCE WE GET
TO THE POINT WHERE.
ALL THE FACILITIES QUALITY
FACILITIES THAT CAN MEET THE
TEST OF C. C. R. EXIST ARE THEY
WHERE THE KIDS ARE.
AND SO THERE ARE SOME REALLY
EXCELLENT AS T. R. T. P. TH --
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU'RE NOT I MEAN IF YOU'RE
NOT IN VENTURA COUNTY YOUR YOUR
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S IT'S YOUR
AUTO COUNTY IF YOU'RE GONNA GO
TO VICTOR.
SO -- WE ARE LOOKING AT THIS
QUESTION BUT I I DON'T I DON'T
KNOW THAT.
I CAN SIT HERE RIGHT NOW AND SAY
WE'RE SURE THAT THERE'S GOING TO
BE A SUFFICIENT GEOGRAPHIC.
SORT OF AVAILABILITY.
OF TREATMENT PROGRAMS WHERE THE
WHERE THE CHILDREN ARE RESIDING
AND I KNOW WHAT'S ONE THING THAT
THE DEPARTMENT IS CROSS MAPPING.
BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
TO ACTIVELY MANAGE BYE BYE ON
FOLLOW UP ON THE THE NOT SO
THESE.
NINETEEN HUNDRED FACILITIES THAT
ARE POTENTIALLY GOING TO BE --
QUALIFIED ARE THE SEEN CHILDREN
RIGHT NOW SOLE SO I GUESS MY MY
QUESTION IS ARE THEIR KIDS
CURRENTLY BEING SEEN.
OKAY SO THAT THAT MAKES MORE
SENSE THEY'RE NOT.
EMPTY AND JUST WAITING FOR THE
APPROVAL PART PROCESS ARE STILL
SEEING CHILDREN BUT YOU HAVE A
RACK SO.
ALL OF THOSE FACILITIES HAVE --
HAVE YOUNG PEOPLE IN THEM SOME
SOME ARE STILL MAINTAINING THEIR
GROUP HOME LICENSE AND FOOD AND
AND MEETING THOSE OUGHT THAT
LEVEL OF CARE OBLIGATION.
SOME ARE LICENSED AS AS SHORT
TERM RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
PROGRAMS BUT DON'T YET HAVE A
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM SO THEY'RE
AT THEIR MEETING THAT THAT THE
HIGHER ACUITY NEEDS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE BYE BYE -- BY ARRANGING
FOR OR ARE PARTNERING WITH LOCAL
MENTAL HEALTH TO ARRANGE FOR
THAT THE SERVICES AND THEN
NINETEEN ARE FULLY INTEGRATED ON
THIS POINT.
SO THERE THERE ARE YOUNG PEOPLE
IS BEING SERVED IN THOSE THERE
ARE A GROUP THE GROUP I
MENTIONED EARLIER THE EIGHT
HUNDRED OR SO THAT -- THAT WON'T
MEET S. T. R. T. P. REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE IN SOME OF THAT --
BECAUSE THE CURRENT CONGREGATE
CARE FACILITIES THAT MAKE THAT
HAVE TOLD US EITHER THEY'RE NOT
GONNA TRANSITION OR IT SEEMS
UNLIKELY THEY WILL ARE THE THAT
GROUP OF YOUNG PEOPLE ARE THE
THE THE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT WE AND
THE DEPARTMENT ARE WORKING WITH
OUR COUNTY COLLEAGUES.
ON AT IMMEDIATELY TO LOCATE --
FAMILIES ARE ALL OF THAT CAN
CARE FOR THEM IF IN JUST I AGREE
WITH EVERYTHING THAT MR ROSE
SAID -- WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE IS
THAT GOING FORWARD THOSE
FACILITIES THAT ARE RECEIVING
AND CARING FOR CHILDREN NOW WHO
AREN'T FULLY LICENSED -- AT SOME
POINT THEY HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION RIGHT TO CONTINUE IN
THE LIMBO PERIOD OR DECIDE THIS
IS NOT -- A SERVICE THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO MEET.
AND FOR THOSE THAT EITHER CAN'T
OR DON'T WANT TO CONTINUE TO TO
BE AN S. T. R. T. P..
IT'S IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT THEY
NOT BECOME PART OF THE THE S. T.
R. T. PEMEX BUT FOR THOSE.
THAT CAN AND ARE NECESSARY AND
COULD BE GOOD PROVIDERS WHAT WE
DON'T WANT IS FOR THEM. TO GIVE
UP AND SAID THIS IS THIS IS WAY
TOO MANY HURDLES FOR US WE'RE
OUT.
AND AND IT'S IT'S THAT.
I MEAN IN THE SHORT RUN THEY'RE
THEY'RE CARING FOR AND SOME OF
THEM ARE CARING FOR KIDS BUT AT
SOME POINT.
THEY HAVE TO DECIDE ARE WE GONNA
CONTINUE IN THIS IT TO TO TRY TO
DELIVER THE SERVICE ON BEHALF OF
STATIC CALIFORNIA OR DO WE HAVE
TO BACK OUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IT ENDS IN DECEMBER.
IS THAT CORRECT WHAT ENDS IN
DEATH WHAT ENDS IN DECEMBER IS
THE PERIOD AFTER DECEMBER ANY
CHILD THAT IS IN -- A CONGREGATE
CARE FACILITY THAT DOES NOT HAVE
ITS S. T. R. T. P. LICENSE.
IS NO LONGER ELIGIBLE FOR STATE
REIMBURSEMENT.
SO IN FACT GIVEN THE GIVEN THE
COST IT IT SORT OF MEANS THAT
THAT PLACEMENT BECOMES.
NOT A VIABLE PLACEMENT AND YOU
EXTENDED.
FROM THE YEAR BEFORE BACK TO
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST -- WITH
CONDITIONS THAT I COUNTY COULD
ASK FOR AN EXTENSION IF IT
PROVED TO THE STATE.
EXCUSE ME THAT IT WAS TAKING.
APPROPRIATE STEPS TO TRY -- TO
GET FAMILIES AND TO GET S. T. R.
TO HELP GET US YOUR TEEPEES
APPROVED.
THE QUESTION THAT THAT OUR
MEMBERS BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE TO
ANSWER WITH YOU AND WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION BEFORE THIS
BUDGET AND IS DO WE THINK
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF
NINETEEN CONTINUES TO BE A
REASONABLE DATE.
AND I BELIEVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS
WILL START PROBABLY TOMORROW
MORNING AROUND EIGHT O'CLOCK.
CLEARLY THAT WOULD BE THE NEXT
BEST A PARTY BUT NUMBER SAID SHE
IS A BAR IT IS HARD TO IMAGINE
THAT IT'S GOING TO BED THAT.
ALL THE FACILITIES THAT THAT WE
WANT BECAUSE THEY DELIVER GOOD
CARE AND THEY CAN REALLY -- NEED
A CHILD'S NEEDS TO HEAL -- IT'S
HARD TO IMAGINE THAT ALL OF THEM
WILL WILL GET PAST THE FINISH
LINE BY DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
SO IT SOUNDS LIKE IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE REASONABLE TO EXPECT IT TO
HAPPEN BY DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
IT IS IT YOUR INTENTION THAN TO
ASK FOR AN EXTENSION. TO ANY TO
BEGIN THAT PROCESS.
THE DISCUSSIONS THAT WERE ABOUT
TO HAVE WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
IS TO SORT OF IDENTIFY WHETHER
OR NOT WE HAVE A SORT OF A
COMMON ASSESSMENT OF THE
LIKELIHOOD OF DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST BEING REASONABLE OR NOT
AND AND IF IT TURNS OUT THAT MY
SUPPOSITION HERE TODAY -- IS
BORNE OUT IN THE ADMINISTRATION
CAN KERR'S WE WOULD NEED A
STATUTORY CHANGE TO ALLOW -- FOR
EXCEPTIONS AND I ASSUME THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD WOULD WANT
TO SIMILARLY.
ENSURE THAT -- ANNEKE.
IN THOSE CASES WERE EXTENSIONS
OCCUR DUE DILIGENCE AS BEING
MATT.
AND TERMS OF FINDING FAMILIES
AND AND BECAUSE IT'S NO ONE'S
INTENT. TO HAVE AN INDEFINITE
PERIOD OF YOU KNOW OF OF OF
FACILITIES THAT ARE CONVERTED TO
AS CHAIR TEEPEES DICK TO BE
CONTINUED TO CARE FOR KIDS.
BUT IF WE ONLY HAVE NINETEEN OF
FIVE MILLION.
NINE HUNDRED THAT'S WHAT THERE
ARE.
OTHER THERE ARE WORTH IT I'M
SORRY EACH OF THOSE.
HOMES EACH OF THOSE FACILITIES
HAVE OUR YOUTH.
THEY'VE GOT TO GO SOMEWHERE AND
IF THERE ISN'T A FAMILY
[inaudible]
WE CAN'T PUT HIM ON THE STREET
IT'S ABOUT HALF OF THE KIDS --
IN IN CONGREGATE CARE RIGHT NOW
ARE IN A FACILITY THAT DOESN'T
HAVE AN S. T. R. T. P. LICENSE.
AS CHAIR TO BE LICENSE IS THE
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST THAT --
DEADLINE AND SO IT'S THE THE
TEST WOULD BE FINDING FAMILIES
FOR FOR THOSE CHILDREN OR END.
OR BY GETTING THOSE FACILITIES
TO THE POINT WHERE THEY ARE
LICENSED AS S. T. R. T. PEAS.
SO YOU CAN YOU ADDRESS YOU
TACKLE THE PROBLEM FROM TWO
DIRECTIONS FINDING FAMILIES IN
TRYING TO HELP PUT FACILITIES.
GET LICENSED AND WE'RE GONNA BE
DOING BOTH AND THE QUESTION IS.
OUR OUR MUTUAL EFFORTS IN THIS
INVOLVES HELP FROM THE STATE.
BOTH STATE AGENCIES AND OTHER
COUNTY PARTNERS WELL OUR EFFORTS
YIELD ENOUGH RESULTS SUCH THAT
WE WOULD NOT NEED AN EXTENSION
PAST TWELVE THIRTY ONE NINETEEN
AND IT'S HARD FOR US TO IMAGINE.
THAT THAT WOULD BE THE CASE THIS
REVIEW YES.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO FIND --
FOUGHT THE PARENTS BUT I MAY BE
OFF ON THIS BUT IF YOU LOOK BACK
ON PAGE SIXTEEN THE I CC ARE
SPENDING UNDER TWENTY NINETEEN
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE FOSTER PARENT
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION AND
SUPPORT IS DECLINED.
WITH ACTUALLY ZERO SO HOW ARE WE
GOING TO FIND THESE FAMILIES
WHEN.
IT INDICATES THAT WE HAVE. ZERO
MONEY TO FOR RECRUITMENT I IT
JUST DOESN'T MAKE ANY.
UNLESS I'M WE ARE WE THINK THAT
FUND IS REALLY IMPORTANT THE DIP
THE DEPARTMENT IS IS.
BRINGING CONTRACTORS LIKE
DANNY'S GOODMAN TO HELP US WITH
TECHNOLOGIES TO FIND FAMILIES
BUT IT'S EXPENSIVE LABOR
INTENSIVE ACTIVITY.
AND SO FROM FROM THE VERY STRONG
VIEWPOINT TO THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
IT IS PREMATURE TO REDUCE
FUNDING FOR THE FAMILY STABILITY
FUND FORMALLY KNOWN AS FIFTY
SOUGHT NOT JUST PAYMENT CHAIR
IT'S I'M IT'S CLEARLY GOING IT
HUNTER PRODUCTIVE ABSOLUTELY
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE SAYING THAT IN
ORDER TO COMPLY.
WE ARE TO HELP THESE KIDS OUT OF
CC ARE ARE OUT OF THE I'M SORRY
THE THE HOMES WE NEED FAMILIES
BUT WE ARE NOT RECRUITING
FAMILIES THERE WERE JUST.
WE'RE GOING TO BE SPINNING OUR
WHEELS ON DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
IT'S WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE.
AND UP.
IT'S AN ADDITIONAL COMMENT BY SO
WE HAVE TO HOW CAN WE FIX THIS
OR IS VERY PLAN.
SINCE THE MONEY IS.
ARE.
NOT AVAILABLE FOR THE
RECRUITMENT AND HOW CAN WE HELP.
AND WE WE WE BROUGHT THE ISSUE
TO FOR YOUR DISCUSSION HERE
TODAY WE WE DEFINITELY INTEND TO
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
TRY TO GET TO OF A PLACE WHERE
WE ALL AGREE.
IS THE RIGHT PLACE AND IT WOULD
RESULT IT IT IT.
ASSUMING A STATUTORY CHANGES
NEEDED WE ABSOLUTELY INTEND TO
BRING IT TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEES -- FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU TESTIMONY FROM THE
NEXT WITNESS [inaudible]
JUSTIN.
IT.
DOESN'T REDUCE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- A IS THERE A SPECIFIC
QUESTION THAT YOU WOULD LIKE ME
TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE ON WHAT --
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR JAMAICA
AND TO BE DIRECTOR ROSE HAVE
EXPENDED ON FOR ME THE MOST.
BUT NUMBER AND THE MANY THAT'S
BEEN REDUCE I MEAN IS IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT HAS EVEN BEEN
DISCUSSED -- I UNDERSTAND IT'S A
NEW ADMINISTRATION BY THIS IS A
PRESSING ISSUE AND FOR VARYING
OUT THE RECRUITMENT MONEY HAS
THERE BEEN ANY DISCUSSION AS TO
REINSTATING SOME OF THAT MONEY
OR HOW WE'RE GOING TO HELP --
THE THE COUNTIES IN THE
RECRUITMENT [inaudible]
THROUGH A WHAT I CAN SEE IS THAT
THE THE ADMIN AT THE KERN
ADMINISTRATION AND MAINTAIN THE
SAME PROPOSAL THAT DAY THAT.
WAS ORIGINALLY AGREED UPON BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND AND THE PAST
RESTORATION WHEN -- CCR WAS
ENVISIONED SO -- WHICH I THINK A
CLEAR DISTINCTION HERE'S MAKE IS
THAT THERE'S NOT A REDUCTION AND
AT WHAT WE WE'VE BEEN REFERRING
TO AS VAPERS OUR FOSTER PARENT
RECRUITMENT RETENTION SUPPORT
FUNDING -- RECRUITMENT PROCESS
SO IT ENDS UP BECOMING A COUNTY
RESPONSIBILITY IN AS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR ROSE SAID COMMENTED ON
EARLIER.
THE THE DISCUSSION OF OF CCR AND
RECOGNIZING THAT WE NEEDED TO
MOVE THE SITE AT THE GROUP HOME
POPULATION FROM THE CONGREGATE
CARE. TO THE HOME BASED SETTING
I WAS LOOK AT THAT THERE IS IT'S
AN INITIAL INVESTMENTS -- SO ACT
AS YOU READ THIS TIME THE
ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T HAVE A
PROPOSAL BEYOND'S MAINTAINING
THAT SARAH THAT ORIGINAL INITIAL
UP FRONT INVESTMENT NOW TO THE
EXTENT.
THAT A THIS IS A LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITY -- AS USUAL WERE VERY
HAPPY.
TO CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS AND
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
WERE RECOUNT ON THAT'S BUT WHAT
KNOWN BUT LET ME JUST STOP YOU
RIGHT THERE BECAUSE WHAT YOU'RE
WHAT I'M WHAT I'M HEARING IS
THAT THERE IS AN INITIAL
INVESTMENT BUT ACCORDING TO THIS
CHART IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE
INITIAL INVESTMENT WAS -- TWENTY
ONE THOUSAND IT'S TWENTY ONE SIX
THIRTY BOB BUT THERE IS NO THE
MAIN.
MAINTAINING THAT ORIGINAL
INVESTMENT BECAUSE IT'S IT'S THE
IF YOU LOOK ABOUT CHARLIE YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE CORRECT WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING IS PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
IS -- FOR THE CURRENT YEAR THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
MAINTAINING -- THE THE TWENTY
ONE MILLION GENERAL FUND AND
THEN PROPOSED FOR THE GOVERNOR
AND THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
THERE IS NOT A PROPOSAL.
TO MAINTAIN OR AT ANY ENTITLED
THAT THAT IS NOT MAINTAINING THE
ORIGINAL INVESTMENT IT'S AS WELL
AS WHERE I'M GETTING HUNG UP ON
BECAUSE HE SAID THAT THERE IS AN
INTENT TO MAINTAIN THE ORIGINAL
INVESTMENT.
AND BUYS HEARING IT OUT IS NOT
MAINTAINING IN MY UNDERSTANDING
IT.
UNDERSTANDING IT NO I UNDERSTAND
YOUR YOUR YOUR QUESTION AND THE
ORIGINAL INVESTMENTS WAS THIS
THREE YEAR PERIOD OF TIME --
AGAIN JUST A TO RESET AGAIN ADD
TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS IS A
PRIORITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
WE'RE HAPPY TO HELP.
ALSO IN THAT CONVERSATION IS IS
TO SHOULDN'T IT BE ARE ALSO A
PRIORITY OF THE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION I MEAN I THINK WE
YOU KNOW THE SO I APPRECIATE.
THAT YOU'RE HERE BY BUT IF THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT IS A PRIORITY
FOR ALL OF US WHICH WAS
INDICATED BY MAINTAINING THE
ORIGINAL INVESTMENT THAN.
THAT THE ORIGINAL INVESTMENT
INDICATED TO ME THAT THERE WAS A
PRIORITY FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
I I I KNOW WE'RE GONNA BE GOING
BACK AND FORTH BUT THE POINT
BEING.
THAT YOU'RE PUTTING IT BACK ON
US I WHICH I CAN APPRECIATE
HOWEVER THE THE THE ORIGINAL
INVESTMENT INDICATED THAT THERE
WERE SOME WILLINGNESS FROM THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION TO CONTINUE
WITH THIS.
CELL. EIGHT I DON'T SEE THE I'M.
THE INTENT.
I GUESS FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
TO CONTINUE YOUR YOU KEEP
INDICATING THAT IF THERE'S AN
INTENT FROM THE LEGISLATURE.
THAN THAN -- THAN THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL COMPLY BUT
THE NICHOLS CAUGHT UP BACK TO
WHAT YOU ORIGINALLY SAID THAT.
THEY WERE MAINTAINING THE
ORIGINAL INVESTMENT THE IN IT
JUST THERE THERE'S NO INTENT
ISN'T WHAT MY QUESTION IS ARE MY
POINT IS.
BY THE NINE INVESTMENT THIS TIME.
AND MADAME CHAIRS -- THE FROM
THIS FROM THIS THAT FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF THE COUNTIES THAT
ARE THAT ARE IMPLEMENTING THIS
REFORM ON YOUR BEHALF WE ASSUMED
A LOT OF THINGS THREE YEARS AGO.
SO IT MAY BE TRUE THAT THREE
YEARS AGO WE ASSUMED THAT WE
WOULD HAVE ALL THE FAMILIES WE
NEEDED -- WE ASSUMED THAT ALL
THE S. T. R. T. PIECE WOULD HAVE
CONVERTED.
THE KD ES COURT ASSUME WE HAVE
TREATMENT FOSTER CARE WE ASSUMED
A LOT OF THINGS SOME OF THEM
HAPPENED AND SOME OF THEM DID
NOT AND SO.
IT SEEMS I WOULD ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT INHERITED CC
ARE FROM THE PRIOR%
ADMINISTRATION TO UNDERSTAND
THAT -- WE'RE ALL IN GOOD FAITH
MAKING MID COURSE CORRECTIONS
AND WORKING AS HARD AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN TO IMPLEMENT THIS
REFORM SOME THINGS ARE GOING AS
PLANNED AND SOME THINGS AREN'T.
SO TO SAY WELL THREE YEARS AGO
WE THOUGHT IT WAS ALL GOING TO
BE DONE AND IT'S NOT SO IF YOU
WANT TO DO IT AFTER THREE YEARS
IT'S ON YOU BUT THAT'S NOT OUR
PRIORITY.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT IS AN
APPROPRIATE WAY TO VIEW OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO IMPLEMENT
CURRENT LAW BECAUSE CCAR'S
CURRENT LAW.
AND IF WE'RE ALL TOGETHER MAKING
A GOOD FAITH MID COURSE
CORRECTIONS AND ASSESSMENT OF
HOW WELL WE'RE DOING.
THEN WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THOSE SAME ADJUSTMENTS ON THE
FINANCING SIDE.
I THINK THAT THE THE BOTTOM LINE
IS.
ARE THESE REDUCTIONS GOING TO
HELP OR HURT C. C. R..
AND I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WILL
HURT IT I MEAN I ASSUME WE CAN
ALL AGREE THAT THE REDUCTIONS
WILL HURT IT.
I THINK THAT THE THE IF WE TALK
ABOUT PRIORITIES IT ISN'T
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITY ONLY I
THINK IT HAS TO BE A MUTUAL
PRIORITY.
AND I THINK IF WE VIEW IT THAT
WAY JUST AS YOU SAID WE'RE ALL
IN THIS TOGETHER.
ARE WE WE WE END.
WE HAVE TO AT TIMES TAKE A
REFRESHED LOOK.
AT ANY VALUATION AS OPPOSED TO
SAYING THIS IS WHAT WE DECIDED
ON AND THAT'S IT.
EVERY YEAR I THINK WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THIS AGAIN AND YOU'RE
RIGHT WE'RE ALL TRYING TO DO.
THE ABSOLUTE BEST THAT WE CAN
WILL HAVE DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
RESPONSIBILITY DIFFERENT LEVELS
OF EXPERTISE TO BE ABLE TO OFFER
MORE TO MAKE SURE THAT WHAT WE
DO IN THE END.
WILL HELP US TAKE CARE OF THAT
SUIT THE C. C. R..
IT HELPS TO TO REACH THE THE THE
GOALS THAT WE WANT FROM THE C.
C. OURS THIS WAS ONE OF ONE
ADDITIONAL COMMENT MISTER FOR
THIS -- I SAT HERE FIVE FOR TWO
YEARS UNDER ALL GOVERNOR BROWN
AND I KEEP GETTING -- THE SAME
KIND OF STANDARD ANSWERS -- FROM
YOU KNOW THAT ADMINISTRATION
ABOUT YOU KNOW WILL HELP YOU
WITH TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
ALL OF THAT WHICH IS REALLY
FRUSTRATING AND I SAW THIS
GOVERNOR.
OUT WITHOUT A FRESH NEW LOOK
WITH HOPE WITH -- MORE
ENCOURAGEMENT THAT WE WERE GOING
TO TRULY BE PARTNERS IN THIS AND
SOLD IF YOU.
I DON'T MEAN TO I AM BE BRASH.
ABOUT THIS BUT I THOUGHT WE WERE
PARTNERS IN THIS AND AND AGAIN
FOR ME IT WAS HOPEFUL TO HEAR
THE GOVERNOR INDICATE THAT WE
WERE ALL GOING TO BE IN THIS
TOGETHER AND SOUL.
SOUL I'M DON'T WANNA SEEM
FRUSTRATED BUT I'M GOING TO GET
FRUSTRATED WHEN I KEEP HEARING
THE SAME YOU KNOW WHAT OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND WHICH
IS REALLY DOESN'T DO ANYTHING I
DON'T WANT TO START OUR
RELATIONSHIP -- THAT WAY I WANT
US TO REALLY SIT DOWN AND TALK
ABOUT SOLUTIONS AND RATHER THAN
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND YOU
KNOW ALL THE RHETORIC.
FRANKLY THAT I GOT FOR THE LAST
TWO YEARS FROM THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION I WAS REALLY
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN GET
DIFFERENT ANSWERS BECAUSE THIS
IS CHILDREN THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND SO I WILL LEAVE IT AT
THAT BUT PLEASE.
YOU KNOW FROM NOW ON THAT'S WHAT
I'M LOOKING FOR THE I GOT THE
LIP SERVICE ALREADY FROM THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION AND I
DON'T WANT.
TO GET IT HERE.
THESE ARE TWO CRITICAL --
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH TO GET THE SAME LIP
SERVICE AND I AGAIN MY HOPE IS
THAT THIS NEW ADMINISTRATION WE
CAN GET ANSWERS AND IT'S NOT
PUNITIVE IN ANY MEANS I JUST
WANT SOME -- WILLINGNESS TO TO
SIT DOWN AND REALLY BE PARTNERS
IN THIS INSTEAD OF YOU KNOW
GETTING THE LIP SERVICE SO I
WOULD APPRECIATE IT THAT IT IN
THE FUTURE.
I I WE CAN WE LIMIT THE YOU KNOW
TECHNICAL ASSISTANT.
RESPONSES BECAUSE THAT'S NOT
HELPFUL WE NEED ACTUAL --
ANSWERS THAT ARE GOING TO HELP
US IN DECEMBER YOU KNOW BY
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TO MAKE
THIS A SOLUTION I'M NOT HERE --
TO BATTLE WE'RE HERE.
TO I HAVE SOLUTIONS AND CREATE
PATHWAYS SO THAT WE CAN ASSIST
THE COUNTIES AND ASSIST THESE
CHILDREN AND AND AND THE
SERVICES THAT WE IN OUR
PROMISING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO I I I DON'T THINK THAT THE
THE APPROACH OF THE MINISTRATION
IS TO TO TAKE THIS AS YOU SAID
THIS COMBAT EVER NOT BE
SUPPORTIVE I THINK THAT'S WHEN
THE BEAUTIES OF THIS BUDGET
PROCESS RIGHT IN THE IN THE
HEARINGS THAT WE GO THROUGH IS.
THE ADMINISTRATION PUTS ON ITS
BUDGET PROPOSAL IN AND AND THERE
IS LISTED THE PRIORITIES AT THE
TIME AND WE HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY HERE SO I'M
DEFINITELY HERE ON ON YOUR
CONCERN ON ON THE THE COMMENTS
AND DONATED THINK THAT IT'S
ANYTHING LIKE THAT OF OF A OF A
LIP.
SERVICE IT'S IT DOES COME FROM A
GENUINE -- RESPONSE OF IF THIS
IS A PRIOR TO THE TIME WHEN I OR
INTO BEING ONE WERE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THE TECHNICAL
ASPECTS OF IT CREDITS DISTANCE --
BECAUSE TAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE HERE TO SIT FOR AN A
LIST AND YOU'RE RIGHT IT'S ALSO
HERE.
YOUR PRIORITIES SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND BUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MS RUBIO --
RYAN THE LAND IS HELLO.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARED MEMBERS
MILLINERS ILIO -- SO WE WOULD
JUST LIKE TO REITERATE SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE RAISED IN OUR
HUMAN SERVICES BUDGET
PUBLICATION -- RECENTLY -- TWO
PRIMARY ISSUES -- ONE BEING.
THE RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
IMPLEMENTATION AS HAS BEEN
ALREADY NOTED -- THIS IS
CRITICAL FOR THE BECAUSE OF THE
SUCCESS OF THE GOALS OF CCAR
SPONSORED THE GUIDE TO MAKING
SURE THAT MORE.
CHILDREN ARE IN HOME BASE FAMILY
CARE SETTINGS -- AND AS AS ALSO
PREVIOUSLY NOTED -- YOU KNOW
THERE ARE THE REMAIN CHALLENGES
RELATED -- TO THE APPLICATION
APPROVAL TIME.
A TIME FRAMES THAT -- FAMILIES
HAVE TO GO THROUGH -- INCLUDING --
FOR CAREGIVERS WITH THE
PLACEMENT PRIOR TO APPROVAL --
OVER NINETY DAYS AS REQUIRED --
BY LAW.
AND SO GIVEN THESE CHALLENGES
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THERE HAS
BEEN SOME MODERATE --
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE WAIT TIMES.
WE WOULD RECOMMEND NOT ONLY THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CONTINUE TO
CLOSELY MONITOR -- THIS
PARTICULAR COMPONENT OF CCIR BUT
CONSIDER EXTENDING.
THE FINANCIAL SUPPORT THAT IT
HAS BEEN GIVING TO COUNTIES. TO
HELP THEM.
IMPLEMENT THIS CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF CCAR -- A AND AND
BRING THOSE WAIT TIMES DOWN.
AS WELL TO CONSIDER -- EXTENDING
THE FUNDING FOR THESE PARTICULAR
CARE GIVERS WITH THE PLACEMENT
PRIOR TO APPROVAL -- OR HAVING
THEIR WELL A APPROVAL WAIT TIMES.
GREATER THAN NINETY DAYS -- IN
ORDER TO INSURE THAT THESE ARE
FAMILIES PLACEMENT SETTINGS ARE
REMAIN STABLE AND THAT CHILDREN
DON'T HAVE -- TO AND UP.
OF CHANGING -- THERE CARE GIVERS
OF THE OTHER -- IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT -- IS READ THE
CARD TO THE LEVEL OF CARE --
TOOL AND RATE STRUCTURE -- THERE
REMAIN SEVERAL OUTSTANDING
QUESTIONS RATHER REGARDING THIS
COMPONENT OF CCIR -- THAT IS
ALSO EXPERIENCED -- SIGNIFICANT
DELAYS -- ONE BEING -- WHAT THE?
KIND OF THE LATEST ITERATION OF
THAT TO LOOKS LIKE -- AND WHAT
CHANGES HAVE BEEN MADE.
OVER THE PAST FEW MONTHS --
INCORPORATING THE INPUT FROM THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN WORKING
WITH -- WITH GARDEN THIS TOOL
AND WHAT.
ANY OUTSTANDING UNCERTAINTIES.
REMAIN -- AS THE TOOL -- IS
ROLLED OUT TO OTHER.
POPULATIONS THAT ARE SUBJECT TO
THE STRUCTURE -- WE WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT -- IT'S IMPORTANT TO
GET A BOOK FROM VERY SPECIFIC
DETAIL TIMELINE FOR THE ROLL OUT
OF THE RATE STRUCTURE -- TO
DIFFERENT -- CAREGIVERS OUTSIDE
OF THE THE NEW -- FFA -- CARE
GIVERS.
AND THE DETAILS ON THE PLANNED
VALIDITY TEST.
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION PLANS --
TO CONDUCT ON THE TOOL AS IT'S
ROLLED OUT AND HOW IT PLANS TO
INCORPORATE -- ANY FINDINGS FROM
THAT A TEST -- TO LATER
ITERATIONS OF THE TOOL -- AND
FINALLY TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE --
IT YOU WE THINK IT WOULD BE A
WORTHY IF OF THE NEGOTIATION
COULD -- OF PROVIDE A KIND OF AN
ASSESSMENT OF THE COMBINED THAT
FINANCIAL IMPACT THAT -- FOSTER
FAMILY HOMES -- WOULD HAVE
WHAT'S THE NEW RATE STRUCTURE IS
IMPLEMENTED -- COMBINED WITH THE
NEW -- SUPPLEMENTAL CARE
INCLEMENT PLANS AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL TO DETERMINE.
WHETHER OR NOT THERE MIGHT MAYBE
SOME FAMILIES THAT ON THAT HAVE
A HIGHER OR LOWER -- RATE OF OF
GRANTS COMPARED -- TO THEIR X.
WHAT THEY WORKS WOULD HAVE BEEN
EXPERIENCING UNDER THE THE OLDER
AGE BASED RATE STRUCTURE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE LA -- BEFORE
REMOVED TO THE NEXT.
ISSUE.
ALRIGHT THEN I'D LIKE TO ASK
THAT -- JENNIFER REX ROAD --
COME JOIN US PLEASE.
AND WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
THIS REYES.
MR FRAZIER HAS AN EXCUSED
ABSENCE MISTER MATHIS.
MISTER PATTERSON.
MISTER RAMOS MISS RUBIO.
MEET DOCTOR WOULD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME --
GENEREX READ WHAT CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CARE GIVERS.
AND EXCITE IT'S EXCITING TO BE A
PAIR WITH I AM SUCH A HOT ISSUE
THAT -- YOU'VE EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN.
AND I'D DEFINITELY WE FEEL THAT
AND THIS IS NOT THE TIME.
TO PULL THE RUG OUT -- FROM
UNDERNEATH RETENTION AND
RECRUITMENT ACTIVITIES.
SO MANY COUNTIES HAVE DEVELOPED.
I'M REALLY IMPORTANT AND
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS -- INCLUDING
AND FAMILY FINDING ACTIVITIES
AND CAMPAIGNS -- THERE ARE A LOT
OF SUPPORT GROUP AT TANGIBLE
SUPPORT AT PROGRAMS FOR CARE
GIVERS INCLUDING.
A MENTORING PROGRAMS -- FOSTER
PARENT LIAISONS -- RESPITE
PROGRAMS AND OTHER TANGIBLE
SERVICES THAT MAKE -- PLACEMENTS
POSSIBLE WHERE THEY WOULDN'T
HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE BEFORE
INCLUDING -- SIBLING SETS AND OR
LARGER SIBLING FATS AND AND
OTHER YOUTH WHO ARE STEPPING
DOWN FROM CONGREGATE CARE.
SO WE REALLY FEEL LIKE -- THE
TIME THAT THAT FIT BIRDS WAS
IMPLEMENTED KIND OF GOT SOME OF
THESE PROGRAMS OFF THE GROUND.
UNFORTUNATELY SOME OF THAT MONEY
WAS DIVERTED -- THROUGH THE
WHOLE RFA CRISIS WHICH WAS
IMPORTANT BUT NOT REALLY.
THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE
FUNDING SO SOME OF THE COUNTY IS
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THE
RETENTION AND RECRUITMENT
PROGRAMS THEM THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE -- HAD THEY OTHERWISE NOT
HAD TO DETER FOR DIVERT THE
FUNDING.
SO AB AND WE WOULD LOVE TO SEE
AN COUNTY IS BE ABLE TO BUILD ON
THE SUCCESS -- OF THESE PROGRAMS
AND OTHER COUNTIES YOU KNOW
START.
THE SIXTH START DOING SUCCESSFUL
ACTIVITIES ARE ACTIVITIES THAT
SHOWED -- PROMISE OUR SUCCESS.
AND AND SO WE CAN REALLY MEET
THAT DEMAND FOR HOMES BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY WE CAN'T STEP KIDS
DOWN.
UNLESS WE HAVE FAMILY HOME
SETTINGS TO PUT THAT MEANT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU -- REACTION PLEASE
FROM -- FEEDBACK FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION -- DEAL F. AND
ALEJO.
WELL I THINK REALLY BRIEFLY A
MEMBER TALKED ABOUT RECRUITMENT
IN THE END IN THE PRIOR
CONVERSATION WE JUST HAD I MEAN
I I WOULD SAY. TO I MEAN IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW TO AS YOUR
AGENDA DESCRIBED IN THE
BACKGROUND WE DIDN'T GO THROUGH
ABOUT THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
THAT SIGNIFICANT FUNDING FOR
CHILD WELFARE WAS REALIGNED IN
TWO THOUSAND AND ELEVEN AND
ALONG WITH THAT CAME THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR FAMILY
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION.
THAT SAID WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
CHANGE IS HARD CHANGES DIFFICULT
WE NEED MORE FAMILIES THAT'S WHY
THE STATE INVESTED IN THE SYSTEM
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
WE'RE HAPPY AS MS RACKS ROAD AND
MISTER MAC OF BEFORE HER -- AND
YOUR OWN REQUEST FOR
CONVERSATION WE'RE HAPPY TO
ENGAGE IN THAT CONVERSATION ME
WHAT I DIDN'T JUMP IN AND SAY AT
THE TIME.
JANUARY TEN WAS RIGHT AFTER
JANUARY SIX AND THERE WHILE THE
GOVERNOR WEIGHED IN ON
PRIORITIES HE DIDN'T HAVE
PRIORITIES ON EVERY ISSUE IN THE
BUDGET RIGHT.
AND SO I'M GONNA.
SAY WITHOUT SAYING WHAT I JUST
SAID.
AND YOU KNOW WE'RE HAPPY TO
ENGAGE IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND YOU KNOW -- WONDERFUL THANK
YOU.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE.
I THINK MAYBE THE IF I MAY THE
ONLY OTHER THING THAT I WOULD
ADD TO THIS IS THAT -- AS WE'VE
SEEN WITH OTHER INVESTMENTS LIKE
THE RFA BACKLOG REDUCTION.
WHEN WE PUT MONEY INTO SOMETHING
BECAUSE WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
WE SHOULD ALSO BE CLEAR ABOUT
WHAT WE EXPECT TO GET OUT OF
THAT INVESTMENT OR WHAT THE
PROGRESS OR MILESTONES ARE THAT
WE'RE EXPECTING AND SO I WOULD
JUST ADD THAT TO THE
CONVERSATION?
THIS ISSUE AGAIN DOESN'T HAPPEN
IN ISOLATION MR ROSE TESTIFIED
WE'D ALREADY REDUCED A THOUSAND
KIDS OUT OF CONGREGATE CARE.
MEANING THOSE OF ALREADY GONE
SOME PLACE WE HAVE AN RFA --
BACKLOG IN A DELAY IN APPROVALS.
ADDRESSING THAT CAN CREATE MORE
HOME BASED CARE PLACEMENTS AND
FURTHER REDUCING THE NEED FOR
SOME OF THE FACILITIES THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT.
IT'S A LOT OF WORK A LOT OF
DIFFERENT MOVING PARTS AND
PIECES WERE HAPPY TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION SO FOR SHEER
INDULGENCE.
AND JUST IN CASE MY BRAIN IT'S
AN AND JUST TO ADD ON WITH THE
TO BE DIRECTOR TO MAKE IT SAID
THE THE THE GOVERNOR HAS MADE
SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENTS IN ITS
FIRST BUDGET IN HHS SO -- BEGIN
TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS IS A
PRIORITY -- WILL HAPPEN GAUGING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND JUST
RECOGNIZE.
THAT YOU KNOW ALL OF ALL OF
THESE SERVERS AS WE TAKE FROM
ONE TO ANOTHER THOSE ARE SOME
THINGS THAT WE ALSO WANT TO
CONSIDER AS WELL.
THANK YOU -- THAT WE HAVE HEARD
ABOUT POTENTIAL UNSPENT FUNDS.
A AND F. P. R. R. S..
CAN THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
COUNTIES IN THE ADVOCATES SPEAK
TO THIS.
AND HOW IT RELATES TO THE
PROPOSAL.
I THINK I THINK THERE ARE AND IN
SOME CASES SOME OF THE CONTRACTS
AND SERVICES WERE DELAYED IN THE
BEGINNING I WAS ABLE.
THERE WAS SOME LAG TIME -- IN
SETTING OUT PROGRAMS AND GETTING
THE CONTRACTS IN PLACE.
AND I THINK WHAT I'VE SEEN AS
THAT AND BECAUSE COUNTIES NEIL
THAT THE PROGRAM -- OR THE
FUNDING WAS ENDING THEY STARTED
THEY SUCH AN SOME COUNTY IT'S A
STARTED TO SCALE BACK -- THE
PROGRAMS AND FUNDING -- SO.
THAT'S THE BEST I CAN.
OFFER.
GREG MAY KNOW MORE.
LAUREN HUNTER.
RIGHT SO I JUST I WITHOUT GREAT
RISK IN THE DEPARTMENT I'D ALSO
NOTE THAT PREVIOUS YEARS OF
UNSPENT FUNDS HAVE BEEN ROLLED
OVER AND AVAILABLE THIS YEAR AS
WELL SO THE THE THE THE
INVESTMENT THE THREE YEAR
INVESTMENT THAT WE TALKED SO
MUCH ABOUT EARLIER.
HE HAS HAS CARRIED THROUGH YOU
KNOW IT SO IT HAS IT HAS BEEN
AVAILABLE -- AND SO I WANT YOU.
TO SO WOULD YOU ASKED ABOUT THE
AND YOU KNOW UNSPENT FUNDS THEY
THEY ARE THEY ARE AVAILABLE THIS
YEAR [inaudible]
AND I'LL ADD ONE MORE AND PEACE
TO THAT I KNOW OF A PROGRAM AND
FOR LA PROBATION FOR EXAMPLE
THEY'RE USING.
AND A VERY -- HIGH QUALITY
EVIDENCE BASED MARKETING AND
RECRUITMENT -- PROGRAM AND
THEY'RE GETTING A LOT OF RESULTS
SO.
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I
THINK MAYBE TOOK A LITTLE WHILE
TO GET OFF THE GROUND BUT NOW
THEY HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
INTERESTED.
AND THEY HAVE KIND OF HAVE THIS
WAVE OF SUCCESS WHEREAS IF THE
PROGRAM.
IF THE IF THE FUNDING DOES THAT
CONTINUE YOU HAVE A LOT OF
INTERESTED.
PARTY IS AN A SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM
GOING BUT NO -- NO WAY TO
CONTINUE TO KIND OF CAPTURE AND
TRAIN AND AND UC'S FAMILY IS FOR
PROBATION YOUTH.
SO THAT MIGHT BE AN EXAMPLE OF
OF HOW THIS.
THIS INVESTMENT IF WE IF WE CUT
IT OFF RIGHT NOW WE'RE LOSING
YOU KNOW WHERE IT CAN A LOSING
THAT. THREE YEAR INVESTMENT.
CUTE BUT WHEN FINANCE
[inaudible]
NO COMMENT.
BUT I I THINK AGAIN JUST AND
REYES FINANCE I THINK WE'VE
WE'VE CONTINUED ON WITH THE
DISCUSSION AND IT'S AT RESPECT
FOR NOT PROVIDING THE SAME
RESPONSE -- JUST TO GET OUT ON
WITH THAT W. DIRECTOR ROSE SAID
WE'VE -- INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL WAS
LANGUAGE TO RE APPROPRIATE ANY
UNSPENT FUNDS THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF FLEXIBILITY.
TO PROVIDED TO COUNTIES FOR ANY
OF THOSE UNSPENT FUNDS TO GIVE
THEM A LONGER TO USE THOSE --
GOOD [inaudible]
HELLO.
COMMENTS VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU -- ADVOCACY PROPOSAL
THE FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM FERS.
CAN WE CALL UP CAN DEREK
[inaudible]
APRIL [inaudible]
GREAT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I CAN'T BEGIN TO TELL YOU HOW
HAPPY I AM TO BE HERE TODAY --
MY NAME'S KEN BERWICK I'M THE
FOUNDER AND CEO OF SENECA FAMILY
OF AGENCIES WHERE ONE OF THOSE
NINETEEN STI TEEPEES IN THE
STATE.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY WERE ONE OF
THE LARGEST WRAPAROUND PROVIDERS
IN THE STATE.
AND WE PROVIDE SERVICES ACROSS
CHILD WELFARE MENTAL HEALTH
JUVENILE JUSTICE AND EDUCATION
IN INTEGRATED SYSTEMS. TO THAT
END AND BECAUSE OF THAT WORK
WE'VE SEEN UP CLOSE.
THE IMPACTS OF SOME OF THE GAPS
IN OUR SERVICE SYSTEM FOR KIDS
AND FAMILIES.
AND SEEING THOSE GAPS THREE
YEARS AGO WE GOT A GRANT FROM
THE IRVINE FOUNDATION. TO BRING
LEADERS IN THE STATE TOGETHER TO
LOOK AT HI NEEDS YOU.
AND THE SAY ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT COULD BE MOST IMPACTFUL FOR
THOSE WHO.
AND AND THROUGH THAT PROCESS
WHAT WE SAW IS THAT YOUTH ARE
ENDING UP.
IN HOSPITALS.
IN JUVENILE HALLS.
AND HOMELESS.
THAT NEVER NEEDED TO BE.
AND THEY DIDN'T NEED TO BE
BECAUSE THERE ARE MOMENTS IN
THOSE WHOSE LIFE AND THEIR
FAMILIES LIVE.
WHERE WE CAN OPTIONALLY
INTERVENE USING A MOBILE CRISIS
RESPONSE SYSTEM THAT CAN CHANGE
THEIR TRAJECTORY?
THE TRUTH IS I DON'T THINK WE
KNOW HOW MANY S. T. R. T. P.
BETS WE NEED IN THE STATE.
I DON'T THINK WE KNOW HOW MANY
FOSTER VETS WE NEED IN THE STATE
BECAUSE UNTIL WE BUILD THAT ARE
OUR SYSTEM OF FOSTER CARE WE
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY US T. I. T.
PEOPLE AT TWENTY EIGHT AND UNTIL
WE BUILD OUTS THAT THINGS LIKE
MOBILE RESPONSE.
THAT DIVERT KIDS AN OPPORTUNITY
MOMENTS INTO AWAY FROM PLACES
LIKE HOSPITALS AND GROUP CARE
AND INTO MORE -- SUPPORTED HOME
BASED SERVICES THEN WE'LL KNOW
WHAT WE NEED FOR HIGHER AND
SERVICE.
WE'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
RUNNING FOR CONTRA COSTA AND SAN
FRANCISCO MOBILE RESPONSE TEAMS.
AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN I STARTED I
HAD WRITTEN DOWN HERE OF THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN 80% DIVERSION RATE
BUT OUR CLINICAL DIRECTOR IS
HERE TODAY AND SHE REMINDED ME
THAT WAS EIGHTY THREE POINT
SOMETHING PERCENT.
YOU CAN'T FORGET THE DECIMAL
POINT.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS MORE THAN
EIGHT OUT OF TEN KIDS DON'T END
UP IN A HOSPITAL WAITING ROOM
GOING TO PEOPLE WHO ARE SICK.
THEY DON'T END UP IN JUVENILE
HALL AND THEY DON'T USE A LOCAL
POLICE OFFICER AS THEIR CRISIS
COUNSELOR.
AND THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS IN OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM A YOUTH IS IN
CRISIS THE PARENT DOESN'T KNOW
WHO OR WHAT WHO TO CALL OR HOW
TO GET HELP.
IN THE END UP COMING INTO A
SYSTEM THAT WAS NEVER DESIGNED
TO MEET THEIR NEEDS AND TO KEEP
THEM OUT OF HIGHER AND SYSTEMS
AND PROVIDE SUPPORT.
WE'VE DONE SO MUCH IN THE STATE
BY PROVIDING WRAPAROUND SERVICES
ACROSS THE STATE BY CREATING
SYSTEMS TO INTERVENE AND SCHOOLS
BY CREATING SYSTEMS THAT CAN
INTERVENE EARLIER.
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF THE OF
THE IRVINE GRANT AND TALKING
WITH LEADERS AROUND THE STATE
ABOUT WHAT WE COULD DO
DIFFERENTLY I BELIEVE THERE IS
NOTHING WE CAN DO.
THAT WOULD BE MORE IMPORTANT AND
MORE IMPACTFUL THAN TO PROVIDE
STATEWIDE URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM
I'M HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AND
JOHANNA IS HERE TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS BECAUSE SHE ACTUALLY
KNOWS WHAT SHE'S TALKING ABOUT.
WE CALLED JOHANNA I THINK WE
SHOULD.
HI JOHANNA OF OUR BREATH MOBILE
RESPONSE TEAM SENECA.
AND I PARTICULARLY TRIED TO USE
ONLY TWO MINUTES THAT I'D LEAVE
YOU A MINUTE OR SO TO ASK
QUESTIONS.
DOMINANCE HOW MY PROGRAM.
SO WE'VE BEEN RUNNING OUR
PROGRAMS ARE IT WOULD YOU GAVE
YOU MADE IT FOR THE HARSH AS I
THOUGHT ARE COMING UP FOR ONE
MINUTE TO TELL US NUMBER.
SO WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN RUNNING A
PROGRAM FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS IN
OUR COUNTY -- WHICH IS REALLY
SIGNIFICANT A REALLY LONG TIME
TO BE RUNNING A PROGRAM HALF OF
OUR STAFF HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
US FOR MORE THAN FIVE YEARS
WHICH IS WHILE CONSIDERING THAT
IT'S MENTAL HEALTH IT'S
COMMUNITY BASED AND IT'S CRISIS
WORK -- I THINK THE BEAUTY OF
OUR PROGRAM IS THAT WE'RE JUST
REALLY ABLE TO SERVE.
FAMILIES AT A TIME THAT'S
CONVENIENT FOR THEM AT THEIR
HOME ADD IN A SPACE THAT'S
COMING UP FOR THEM IN THEIR
LANGUAGE -- IT'S REALLY MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS RESPONDING
MENTAL HEALTH CRISES -- REALLY
THERE TO ADVOCATE FOR THEM AND
REALLY SUPPORT THEM THROUGHOUT
THAT ENTIRE PROCESS WHAT WE DO
HAVE A GREAT DIVERSION RATE IT
WE DON'T ALWAYS GET TO DIVERT
BUT WE DO GET TO HELP -- CHANCE
FOR THEM TO THE HOSPITAL BE WITH
THEM THROUGHOUT THAT PROCESS AND
REALLY SUPPORT THEM AND PROVIDE
FOLLOW UP SERVICES IF THEY NEED
ANY -- SO THE CONFLICT OVERVIEW
OF WHAT WE DO -- HAPPY AND IF IF
I COULD JUST ADD TO THAT TIME
AND TIME AGAIN.
WE IN MOST OF OUR COUNTY STACK
PROVIDES PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
STATE.
AND MOST OF OUR CAN AS WE DON'T
HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF HAVING
LEVEL RESPONSE.
AND SO WHAT WE SEE IS A CYCLE
WHETHER WHERE EITHER POLICE OR
SOMETIMES MENTAL HEALTH AND
BEING.
A CHILD ENDS UP IN AN EMERGENCY
ROOM IN THE HOSPITAL USUALLY
THOSE WAIT TIMES WHEN SOMEBODY'S
IN THE KID PSYCHIATRIC CRISIS.
IS OUR FOUR SIX EIGHT AT THE
I'VE HEARD NIGHTMARE STORIES OF
MUCH LONGER YOU KNOW THE STORIES --
OFTEN ARE TEENAGERS SIMPLY WALK
OUT.
THEY DON'T EVEN WAIT TO GET HELP.
THAT'S BEST CASE SCENARIO.
WORST CASE SCENARIOS LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS CALLED.
THE SOMETHING HAPPENS THAT TAKES
THEM DOWN THAT TRAJECTORY AND
THEY'RE IN JUVENILE HALL AND
THEN IN RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT OR
IN A GROUP HOME.
OF AT AND AND SO MANY OF THOSE
SITUATIONS ARE UNNECESSARY.
SO MANY OF THE SITUATIONS WHEN
WE GET TENER BEING AT THE
OPTIMAL POINT.
CAN PROVIDE THE PIVOT POINT THAT
ALLOWS US TO KEEP KIDS AT HOME
OR IN A FOSTER HOME.
OR IN THE COMMUNITY AND IN THE
COMMUNITY -- I KNOW THAT THE SO
WE HAVE MANY SOCIAL WORKERS HERE
AT THE CAPITOL FOR THEIR LOBBY
DAY.
AND THEY HAVE SHARED THE TO WHAT
A NIGHTMARE FOR THEM IS TO PICK
UP THE PHONE AND TO HAVE A
PARENT SAY.
I'VE GIVEN UP ON GIVING MY CHILD
TWENTY FOUR HOURS TO GET OUT OF
HERE -- THE AFTER OUR CHILDREN
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE HAVE
ALREADY EXPERIENCES TRAUMA FROM.
TO BE PLACED INTO FOSTER CARE.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN THAT AND I THINK THAT
THIS FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM.
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT -- WE WE
NEED TO PRESERVE THE PLACEMENT.
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND NOT FOR
THE TRAUMATIZED THAT FOSTER
YOUTH.
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT AND I I
SINCERELY APPRECIATE -- THE COMP
YOUR COMMENTS ON THIS AS WELL --
TALKING ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
THAT WE HAVE LOTS OF FOSTER
YOUTH.
THERE WAS ONE INSTANCE WHERE
THEY WERE ALL HOLDING UP THEIR
SIGNS TO HOW MANY TIMES HAVE
BEEN PLACED [inaudible] FOURTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT THE THIS THIS IS WE
ALL LIKED WE ALL AGREE THIS IS
ALL.
UNACCEPTABLE HAVING A HOTLINE
HAVING DOING EVERYTHING THAT WE
HAVE TO DO. TO KEEP OUR CHILDREN.
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE ARE OUR
CHILDREN TO KEEP THEM FROM.
BEING FURTHER TRAUMATIZED AND TO
FIGURE OUT TO DATE DOING THE THE
TRIAGE. TO FIND OUT THE TO KEEP
THEM AWAY FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO KEEP THEM AWAY FROM HOSPITALS --
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
I KNOW THE DOCTOR ARAMBULA --
THIS HAS BEEN ONE OF HIS TOP
PRIORITIES AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE IT
A TOP PRIORITY. FOR FOR THIS FOR
THIS COMMITTEE -- I THINK
CREATING THIS NURTURING
ENVIRONMENT JUST AS YOU'VE
DESCRIBED IT NOW I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU HAVE A PRE PLACEMENT.
VISIT THE TO MAKE YOU DO WITH
THE PARENTS SO THAT THE PARENTS
THEN KNOW WHO CAN SUPPORT THEM
TELL US ABOUT THAT WE DO WE'VE
RECEIVER FARRELL'S FROM A
VARIETY OF PLACES WE HAVE A
PRETTY.
AWESOME RELATIONSHIP BUT OUR
LOCAL THANK EMERGENCY SERVICE
AND SO KIDS THAT GO THROUGH
THERE THAT AREN'T FULLY LINKED
ON WE GET ALL THEIR DISCHARGE
PAPERWORK AND WERE ABLE TO REACH
OUT TO THEM -- AND I WOULD SAY
ABOUT 20% OF OUR YOUTH ARE
FOSTER YOUTH RIGHT NOW BUT WE
GET TO CALL.
THE FAMILY SAY HEY WE
UNDERSTANDING JUST WENT THROUGH
THIS CRISIS CAN WE COME OUT
THERE INTRODUCED OUR SERVICE TO
YOU IF THIS WAS THE COME UP
AGAIN HOW CAN WE SUPPORT YOU
WHAT OTHER.
RESEARCH CAN PROVIDE FOR YOU WE
ALSO GET REFERRALS FROM TEACHERS
SOCIAL WORKERS -- LAW
ENFORCEMENT SOMETIMES LONG
PERSONAL WHAT THE HOUSE SEVERAL
TIMES AND THEY DON'T REALLY KNOW
WHAT TO DO AND SO THEY ACTUALLY
REFER TO US -- A FEW MONTHS AGO
THERE WAS A WOMAN.
WHO ARE HER SON WAS HAVING A
TANTRUM IN THE STORE AND ANOTHER
PARENT SAID TO HER HATE CALL
THESE PEOPLE THEY CAN HELP YOU
AND SO THAT'S MY MOST PROUDEST
REFERRAL THAT WE'VE GOT IN --
BUT WE DEFINITELY CAN THEN REACH
OUT TO THOSE FAMILIES AND SAY --
YOU KNOW WE WE HEARD ABOUT YOU
MIGHT BENEFIT FROM OUR SERVICES
CAN COME OUT AND INTRODUCE
OURSELVES -- WE FIND THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE THAT INITIAL
ASSESSMENT WERE ABLE -- TO IT'S
LIKE A WARM HAND OFF AND THEY'RE
MORE LIKELY TO UTILIZE US DURING
A CRISIS.
THANK YOU WERE PLAYING MUSICAL
CHAIRS.
ACTUALLY THE LAST TWO WEEKS HAVE
BEEN THAT WAY SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR OF FLEXIBILITY HERE -- SOUL
ANY REACTION OR FEEDBACK FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ARE ALEJO.
I'D SAY THE GREG ROSE AGAIN FOR
THE DEPARTMENT CERTAINLY WERE
AWARE OF THESE TYPES OF SERVICES --
AND PROGRAMS AND IN OTHER STATES
AND AND IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS
AND I THINK THAT THE KEY FOR US
IS THAT THE KEY FOR ME WHEN I
THINK ABOUT IS.
HOW WE GO ABOUT HOW
IMPLEMENTATION AGO ABOUT IT MANY
OF THE PLACES I'M AWARE IT ARE
RIGHT OUR SMALL SMALLER --
JURISDICTIONS AND DO WE DO HAVE.
URBAN AND RURAL AND DISTANCE AND
A NUMBER OF THINGS TO CONSIDER
BUT WE ARE IN FACT AWARE OF OF
OF THE UTILITY OF THESE KINDS OF
PROGRAMS AND WE'VE SEEN THEM IN
OTHER JURISDICTIONS.
AND IF I MAY THE ALLEN BEATS SO
WAS ONE OF THE ENGINEERS OF THE
NEW JERSEY SYSTEM WHICH IS
ACTUALLY A LARGER MORE SKILLED
SYSTEM AND HE WORKED.
WITH US ON SOME OF THE IDEAS
AROUND CONSTRUCTION OF THE
SYSTEM AND HOW IT CAN BE SCALED --
MOBILE RESPONSE ACTUALLY.
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH IS IN A
MORE COST EFFECTIVE PROGRAM AT
SCALE THE THE SMALLER IT IS THE
MORE DIFFICULT BECAUSE YOU HAVE
TO HAVE AVAILABILITY.
AND AN UNUSED AVAILABILITY IS
REALLY EXPENSIVE.
SO SO TO THE DEGREE THAT YOU CAN
HAVE DEPTH IN TEAMS TO RESPOND
TO A BROADER AREA YOU DO GET.
NOT JUST SMALL ECONOMIES OF
SCALE BUT BIG ECONOMIES OF SCALE
AROUND THE INITIAL RESPONSE
ESPECIALLY SO THERE ARE SOME
THINGS THAT REALLY WORK ABOUT A
STATEWIDE SYSTEM THAT ARE VERY
DIFFICULT IN THE SMALLER SYSTEMS
THAT WE'RE RUNNING.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT.
JUSTIN PRENTICE BERMAN FINANCE --
AS WITH ALL THE PROPOSALS ARE WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON ANY OF
THEM AT THIS TIME -- SO AGAIN.
TO THE EXTENT IT'S PRIORITY OF
THE LEGISLATURE WERE HAPPY.
TO ENGAGE WITH ON THE DON'T.
THANK YOU FOR THE LAST YOU HEAR
THAT [inaudible]
ELIA.
THANK YOU RIGHT WELL THANK YOU
AND THEN I'LL GOING TO COLLAPSE --
SUSAN AND IF [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND WE'LL BE DISCUSSING
CONTINUED EMERGENCY CARE GIVER
FUNDING AT THE TIME OF PLACEMENT.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION
EARLIER BETWEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO IN THE STATE -- US ALL OF
THE LA US COMMENTS HIM TO BE
TALKING A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THE FUNDING -- AS A STATE
MANSION LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION CAME TOGETHER HEN
THEY STAND A CRISIS.
AND YOUR FOR YOUR FUNNY AT THE
TIME A PLACEMENT HAS JUST BEEN A
LIFESAVER. FOR TEN THOUSAND THE
FAMILY TO ME JUST SO MANY FOLKS
ON WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
HOWEVER WE'RE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE COMING YEAR.
SO IN THE DEAL THAT WAS MADE
LAST YEAR WE THOUGHT WE WOULD BE
AT NINETY DAYS ISSUE NOTED THE
STATE THOUGHT WE WOULD BE THERE
AND SO.
IN THE LEGISLATION WE NOW CUT
OFF THAT FUNDING IT NINETY DAYS
STARTING ON JUNE THIRTIETH.
AND THERE'S ALSO NO GOOD BECAUSE
EXEMPTION ANYMORE SO ALL THE
PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE AND ALL
THIS GOOD NEWS THAT THE STATE
GAVE YOU.
ALL ENDS ON JUNE THIRTIETH.
SAYS ADVOCATES WERE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT WE WOULD
ASK THE LEGISLATURE TO REALLY
WHO WORK WITH US TO CONTINUE THE
AMAZING WORK THAT HAPPENED. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE EXTEND TO AT
LEAST A HUNDRED AND TWENTY OR A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY
DAYS.
BECAUSE A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS IS
THE CURRENT AVERAGE.
SAID ANYTHING BELOW THAT REALLY
IS GOING TO PUT FAMILIES AT RISK
WE ALSO REALLY ENCOURAGE THE
GOOD BECAUSE EXEMPTION WOULD
NEED THAT BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME
FAMILIES THAT.
FOR REASONS BEYOND THEIR CONTROL
IT GOES PAST THAT THEY CAN'T
JUST LOSE FUNDING OVER THINGS
THAT ARE NOT UNDER THEIR CONTROL.
IT HARMS NOT ONLY THESE FAMILIES
BUT ALSO THE CHILDREN IN THEIR
CARE.
THANK YOU FOR POINTING THAT OUT
BECAUSE I'M -- AS WE SPOKE
EARLIER -- I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE BY
NOW WE HAVE TO OBVIOUSLY
CONTINUE BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
TO LOSE THAT AGAIN PUTTING IN
DANGER THOSE FAMILIES.
THAT HAVE STEPPED UP TO SUPPORT
THOSE CHILDREN SOUL WHAT CAN WE
TOGETHER DO AND OUT WHAT
SPECIFIC -- SUGGESTIONS
RECOMMENDATIONS -- CAN YOU
PROVIDE SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
WITH THIS.
ABSOLUTELY AND APPRECIATE THE
EGG KNOWLEDGE MEN OF THEIR
EARLIER CONVERSATION I MEAN THIS
IS AN EXAMPLE OF AN AREA WHERE A
CONVERSATION AMONGST MULTIPLE
GROUPS GROUPS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AND COUNTIES IN
THE LEGISLATURE.
RESULTED IN A GOOD SOLUTION TO A
KNOWN PROBLEM THE WORLD'S
DYNAMIC -- AS WITH MANY THINGS
YOU'VE HEARD TODAY AND YOU KNOW --
IN THE THERE'S AN UNWRITTEN RULE
SOMEWHERE THAT IF IF I TOLD YOU --
THAT WE WERE LOOKING AT ISSUES
FROM REVISION -- THAT THAT WOULD
BE A FAUX PAS SO I'M NOT GONNA
TELL YOU THAT.
HELLO BUT I WOULD IN NO WAY TEN
I DIDN'T HEAR -- BUT YET BUT BUT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT TODAY -- AS
I MENTIONED THE GOVERNOR DIDN'T
WEIGH IN ON C. C. R. NOGEN TEN
PROPOSAL SO FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
WE NEED TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATION NOW THAT HE'S BEEN
IN OFFICE FOR A FEW MONTHS
PERHAPS IT'S A TIME.
FOR YOU KNOW FOR HIM TO TAKE A
BETTER LOOK AT WHAT'S I HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO DOUBT HE'D BE
INTERESTED IN THE CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU NO I APPRECIATE THAT
AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT
OUT BECAUSE AGAIN YOU KNOW AT WE
I WANT TO AGAIN COMPLIMENT.
YOU ON THE WORK THAT YOU HAVE
DONE BY CLEARLY THERE'S MORE
WORK TO BE DONE SO PLEASE DON'T
LET THIS FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS --
AT AT SOME POINT -- WE NEED TO
BE ENGAGED AS PARTNERS WITH
BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T BRING IT UP
AND WE DON'T BRING IT UP.
THERE AND THEN IT GOES BY THE
WAYSIDE SHELTER YOU WILL WERE
FALLING CONFIDENCE THANK YOU
DROPS I APPRECIATE AND I LOOK
FORWARD -- TO MAKING SURE THAT
WITH THESE CONVERSATIONS ARE HAD
AND AND FOR THE GOVERNOR TO NOT
LOOK AT THEM ME REVISION OR LOOK
AT IT WHATEVER IT IS THAT HE
WANTS TO DO BY THESE ARE --
IMPORTANT INVESTMENTS IF WE WANT
TO KEEP CALLING THEM THAT I
THINK IT'S AN INVESTMENT BUT FOR
ME IT'S LIFESAVING MEASURES FOR
SOME OF THESE THESE FAMILY SOLD
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
THEN WHAT TIME YOUR FAVORITE
OKAY -- THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS FROM FINANCE
HELLO YES IF I MAY I MEAN I I
BROKE A LITTLE BIT OF A ROLL
TALKING ABOUT THAT I DO I WANT
TO BE.
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR I DID
NOT COMMIT THAT THERE WAS
SOMETHING NOT MANY DIDN'T HEAR
ANYTHING THIS YEAR BUT I DON'T
NOT CREATION IS ABSOLUTELY PART
OF THE CONVERSATION AROUND IT'S
NO NO AND I AND AND I APPRECIATE
THAT -- BUT AGAIN YOU KNOW IF
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE WITH
THIS WORK WE NEED SOME SOME --
INDICATION THAT AT LEAST THE POT
IS IN THERE AND I THAT'S WHAT I
HEARD THAT THERE'S SOME THINKING
ABOUT IT I KNOW THAT YOU DIDN'T
MAKE A COMMITMENT BY IT BUT IT'S
REFRESHING. FOR ME TO TO HEAR
THAT THERE HAS BEEN SOME
THOUGHTS PUT INTO IT AND SO I'M
NOT COMMITTING YOU TO ANYTHING
YET -- BUT IT'S OUR PASSION A
COMMON APPLIES TO A NUMBER OF
THINGS C. C. R. AS A LIVE ANIMAL
AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY SO.
THANK YOU AND THEN -- FRANK --
WE ARE.
YOU ARE UP AGAIN TALKING ABOUT
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL AND
CANCER ASSESSMENT AND I KNOW WE
HAD SOME DISCUSSION ALREADY
ABOUT THE APPROVALS.
SO IF WE CAN -- THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR POP FRANK MACKESY WTA WE
HAVE INDEED MADE OUR CASE FOR
CONTINUING THE RFA FUNDING SO I
WON'T -- REITERATE THAT HERE AND
ON CANS IT'S A NEW FAMILY CHILD
ASSESSMENT TOOL WE'VE COME UP
WITH A PRELIMINARY ESTIMATE WITH
THE STATE OF HOW MUCH IT'S GOING
TO COST THE COUNTIES TO
IMPLEMENT IT.
WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR IS TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE FOR THE DEPARTMENT
TO WORK WITH US TO TRACK THE
ACTUAL COSTS SO GOING FORWARD WE
CAN RIGHT SIZE BUDGETS MOVING
FORWARD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE ALEJO
DEPARTMENT.
RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
AND TRANSPORTATION OKAY MORE
MOVING ON TO TRANSPORTATION TO
SCHOOL AND OR OR SCHOOL OF
ORIGIN AT TIME OF PLACEMENT --
KRISTIN POWER.
AND JORDAN SOSA THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KRISTIN
POWER FOR THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS I WE TRUE WE
APPRECIATE THE PREVIOUS
DISCUSSION OF FUNDING AT THE
TIME OF PLACEMENT.
AND THIS ITEM IS RELATED TO THAT --
THIS IS FUNDING FOR
TRANSPORTATION TO THE SCHOOL
BOARD CHEN. ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT RIGHT THE CHILD IN
FOSTER CARE HAS IS THE RIGHT TO
REMAIN IN THEIR SCHOOL OF ORIGIN.
AND TO BE SURE THAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY GET TO THAT SCHOOL AND
THE SCHOOL BOARD IN RIGHTS.
ARE IMPLEMENTED WE MUST HAVE
FUNDING REIMBURSEMENTS THE CARE
GIVER FOR TRANSPORTING THAT.
CHILD TO THE SCHOOL THE PROBLEM
THAT WE SEE EXISTING IS THE CARE
GIVERS ARE ONLY ENTITLED TO
REIMBURSEMENT FOR PROVIDING
TRANSPORTATION TO A SCHOOL BOARD
AND ONCE THEY'RE APPROVED AS A
RESOURCE FAMILY.
RELATIVES AN EXTENDED FAMILY
MEMBERS GENERALLY ACCEPT
PLACEMENT OF A CHILD BEFORE
THEY'VE BEEN APPROVED AS YOU
HAVE THAT PREVIOUS DISCUSSION
TODAY.
AND THE APPROVAL PROCESS IS
LENGTHY AND WE KNOW IT'S
AVERAGING AT LEAST A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DAYS CURRENTLY.
A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS IS AND CAN
BE THE MAJORITY OF THE SCHOOL
YEAR.
FAMILIES CAN'T WAIT THAT LONG TO
RECEIVE THE SUPPORT AND WITHOUT
FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO COVER THE
COST OF TRANSPORTATION IT'S
OFFICE UNTENABLE FOR THE
FAMILIES TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT.
AND TRANSPORT THAT CHILD AT THE
SCHOOL BOARD CHEN.
WHEN WE SPEAK -- TO HOW
IMPORTANT SCHOOL CONNECTIONS ARE
AND THIS FUNDING MAKES THAT
STABILITY A REALITY.
WE REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR A
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO ENSURE THAT
REIMBURSEMENT FOR TRANSPORTING A
CHILD THEIR SCHOOL OF ORIGIN IS
INITIATED AT THAT TIME OF
PLACEMENTS.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JORDAN SOSA I'M ALL OF
FORMER FOSTER YOU FROM LAST LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND I SERVE AT
THE STATE WHY POLICY COORDINATOR
FOR CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION.
OF BEFORE JUST PROVIDE THE
PROVIDING MATHIS MONEY I LIKE TO
THINK -- SHEA HOUSE AND MY
SISTER ANNA SOSA FOR OPENING MY
EYES TO THE TRIALS AND
TRIBULATIONS MANY YOUTH PHASE OF
UP FROM INSTABILITY WITHIN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE AND
CALIFORNIA'S TROUBLE FOR SYSTEM
EXPERIENCE BOTH PLACEMENT AND
EDUCATIONAL STABILITY AND IT'S
FAR TOO COMMON HEARING THE LACK
THE PERMANENCY OF OUR YOUTH
EXPERIENCE INSIDE AND OUTSIDE
THE CLASSROOM.
WE ALWAYS HEAR THE VICIOUS CYCLE
OF THE EDUCATIONAL.
OUTCOMES FOR OUR FOSTER YOUTH
50% GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL
10% PURSUE A COLLEGE EDUCATION
AND ONLY 3% OF GRADUATE FROM
HIGHER EDUCATION.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT RESEARCH
STATES THE EDUCATIONAL DISPARITY
BETWEEN FOSTER YOUTH AND THE
GENERAL POPULATION IS DUE TO THE
EDUCATIONAL INSTABILITY FOSTER
YOUTH EXPERIENCE AS A RESULT.
OF MULTIPLE PLACEMENT CHANGES
EVEN THOUGH I MOVED TO MULTIPLE
HOMES AND FAMILIES AND FOSTER
CARE I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO STAY
IN THE SAME HIGH SCHOOL.
HOWEVER THIS IS NOT THE SAME
STORY FOR MY THREE YOUNGER
SISTERS WHO ARE STILL LIVING IN
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
I HAVE TO WITNESS MY SISTERS
MOVED FROM ONE HOME TO ANOTHER
BECAUSE THE SYSTEMS LET THEM
DOWN.
ST I HAD THE WITNESS SAYING
THERE SEE AND SAYING THEIR
GOODBYES BECAUSE OF THE SEVEN
DAY NOTICE ACTING ALL THEIR
BELONGINGS AND SEVEN DAYS AND
QUESTIONING IF THEY WERE LOVED
OR WANTED WHICH IS THE QUESTION
THAT WILL LAST LONGER THAN SEVEN
DAYS.
WITH THIS WE REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
RAISE TO ENSURE THAT
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR
TRANSPORTATION A CHILD TO THEIR
SCHOOL OF ORIGIN IS INITIATED AT
THE TIME OF PLACEMENT SO THAT
OUR YOUTH CAN THRIVE.
AND HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BECOME PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY AND ONE HOME AND ONE
SCHOOL.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS WE'LL.
I THINK OUR PRIOR REMARKS ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF SUPPORTING
FAMILIES WHO MAY BE BEFORE AFTER
APPROVAL NEED SUPPORT -- SPEAKS
FOR ITSELF.
THANK YOU I'M DO.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THE ESTIMATE
FOR THE PROPOSAL -- AND LET ME
JUST KIND OF ELABORATE ON THAT
SO WE TALKED ABOUT AT LENGTH
EARLIER ABOUT THE THE GREAT.
JOB THAT WE'VE DONE AND
APPROVING THE FAMILIES -- IS
THERE ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO
ENTER IN THE INTERIM TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE ARE FAMILIES ARE
RECEIVING THE TRANSPORTATION
COSTS AND AGAIN DO YOU AGREE
WITH THE ESTIMATE.
SO I ARE ALIVE YOU SPEAK TO THE
ASPECT BECAUSE I HAVEN'T
PERSONALLY SEEN IT SO I I'M NOT
QUALIFIED PROBABLY TO TALK ABOUT
IT I WILL TELL YOU THAT SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING WAS
REALIGNED IN TWENTY ELEVEN TO
COUNTIES SO STATE VISIBILITY
INTO EXACTLY WHAT'S BEING SPENT
TODAY AND HOW.
MUCH A CASE COSTS IS SOMEWHAT
LIMITED.
JUST IMPRISONMENT FINANCE WHO I
BELIEVE -- THERE'S ALSO
COMPANION LEGISLATION THAT'S
RELATED TO THAT SO I THINK IT'S
A ASSEMBLY BILL -- THREE THREE
SEVEN AND AND FINANCES -- I
BELIEVE OUR ANALYSIS MIGHT BE
OUT I'M NOT SURE BUT I THERE
MIGHT BE SOME QUESTIONS WITH THE
THE ACTUAL LAST IMMINENT -- WE
HAVEN'T REALLY DUG DEEP INTO
EVERYTHING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THE CASELOAD IS AND BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF COMPONENTS THAT
GO INTO THIS SOME.
OF THE WAY THE PROGRAM WORKS --
FOR THOSE FAMILIES THAT ARE
APPROVED IN YOUR FUNDING AMOUNT
IS DEPENDENT UPON YOUR MILEAGE
FROM THE HOME.
OR IF -- IT'S A A MONTHLY BUS
STIPEND AND SO ON SO.
THE SIMPLE ANSWER FOR YOU IS --
WE'RE NOT SURE IF THAT'S THE
CORRECT ESTIMATE WE'RE NOT SURE
IF IT'S TO HIRE IF IT'S TOO LOW --
BUT THERE ARE BECAUSE THERE ARE
SOME VARIABLES TO LOOK INTO ON
THAT -- SO.
I I WON'T SAY WHAT YOU DON'T
WANT ME TO SAY -- BUT BUT WE I I
I CAN DOUBLE CHECK FOR YOU AND
FIND OUT OF OUR ANALYSIS IS
PUBLIC RIGHT AND AND AND HOW.
NOT ONLY -- IF THE ANALYSIS IS
CORRECT BUT HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
DETERMINE.
IF IT IS TOO HIGH OR TOO LOW --
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A A KIND OF
AN ACCOUNTING TYPE OF ISSUE WELL
IT'S JUST IT'S LIKE USUAL
EVERYTHING IS AN ESTIMATE FOR
ITS RIGHT BECAUSE YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT THE CASE THAT IS GOING TO
BE AWARE YOUTH MAY.
NOT BE PLACED -- GETS A ONE BY
ONE TIME A YOUTH COULD
POTENTIALLY BE PLACED. THREE
MILES FROM -- THEIR SCHOOL BOARD
CHEN AND THEN A NEW PLACE
SPENDING GREG IF YOU WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING.
THEY COULD BE PLACED SOMEWHERE
WHERE IT'S TEN MILES AWAY SO --
WE WE DO TAKE AND ALL THOSE
CONSIDERATIONS WITH WORKING WITH --
THE DEPARTMENT WHEN WE TRY TO
COME UP WITH THAT CEMENT SO
YOU'RE CORRECT THERE'S NO.
PERFECT POINT WE CAN SAY EXACTLY
WHAT IT IS BUT WE NEED TO TRY TO
DO OUR BEST TO TO GIVE AN
ACCURATE OR A BEST ESTIMATE FOR
THE LEGISLATURE WHEN WE MAKE OUR
ANALYSES.
REGRETS THE DEPARTMENT I JUST
SAY TO HISTORICALLY WHAT WE DO
WE OFTEN DO IS LOOK AT PREVIOUS
EXPENDITURES FOR A SIMILAR --
POPULATIONS OF THE FOR THOSE
APPROVED VERSES THE OF FOLKS
THAT ARE TO PROVE WE COULD LOOK
WE CAN LOOK AT THOSE PREVIOUS
EXPENDITURES.
AS AS AS MISTER SPEAKER JUST
SAID -- SOME OF THOSE BECAUSE OF
REALIGNMENT THAT THE PRECISION
OF THE OF KNOWING EXACTLY WHAT
WAS SPENT -- IS IS A LITTLE LESS
PRECISE THAN IT HAS HISTORICALLY
BEEN BUT THERE ARE SOME.
WAYS IN WHICH WE COULD PARTNER
WITH FINANCE AND THE ADVOCATES
TO KIND OF LOOK THROUGH TO ME I
WOULD HOPE SO.
THANK YOU.
IF YOU COULD YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT'S YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY AN
IMPORTANT PIECE TO THIS IF WE
CAN'T -- PROVIDE THE THE MONEY
IF WE DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH MONEY
WE'RE GOING TO NEED FOR IT SO.
THAT OUR FAMILY FOUNDER COUNTIES
TO BE HELPFUL AND COLLECTING
DATA OR SURVEY IN A COUPLE
SELECT COUNTIES FOR US TO HELP
ENABLE THOSE ESTIMATES.
THAT ALWAYS A GROUP EFFORT ALL
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE IT.
ALL OF YOUR PARTICIPATION AND
YOU KNOW I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
CONVERSATION TO HAVE -- PLEASE
EXPECT MORE CONVERSATIONS LIKE
THIS -- ALSO -- THERE'S ONE LAST
YOU SHOULD LIKE TO RAISE IN
REGARDS TO OVERSIGHT LANGUAGE
THAT WAS ORIGINALLY ADOPTED IN --
TWENTY SIXTEEN STAFF HAS
INFORMED ME THAT ARE AT WORK TO
UPDATE AND CODIFY THIS LANGUAGE
HAS BEEN INITIATED AND I AGREE
THAT IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD ADOPT THIS PART OF THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET -- THANK
YOU TO THE LA -- FOR GREEN TO
WORK WITH US ON THIS I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING A PRODUCT AND
THIS IS I BET.
ACTUAL PRODUCT THAT WE CAN TAKE
ACTION ON AS WE CLOSE OUT THE ME
REVISION HEARING AND SOMEONE
NEXT MONTH AND IT'S APRIL.
I'M FOR AYE IT HOW IT IS IT
APRIL TENTH IS.
CRAZY ENOUGH BY MAY IS RIGHT
AROUND THE CORNER WE'VE ONLY GOT
A COUPLE WEEKS I LOOK FORWARD --
TO MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
THESE CONVERSATIONS OBVIOUSLY
SOON BECAUSE YOU KNOW MADE JUNE
IS COMING UP RIGHT AFTER THAT
AND SO WORK.
I DON'T WANNA BE FOUND IN A
POSITION WHERE WE'RE NOT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME FOR THIS.
THANK YOU VERY.
OKAY.
SURE OKAY I'M VOCAL HAND AND
TAKE IT OUT PUBLIC COMMENT ON
EVERYTHING THAT ISSUE ONE PLEASE.
AND AGAIN WE WHICH ISSUE.
YES AND PLEASE IDENTIFY WHICH
ISSUES YOUR THINKING ON AND IF
WE CAN YOU KNOW WE HAVE QUITE A
FEW PEOPLE CAN LIMIT THE
COMMENTS I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT.
THANK YOU JESSICA BARTH UP ON
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY ON COMMENT ONE AA.
WITH REGARDS.
TO TO READ AT BRINGING FOSTER
YOUTH AND FINDING FAT AND
FAMILIES FOR THEM TO BE WITH A
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED IN SERVING
FAMILIES -- WITH -- YOUTH WHO
ARE IN -- WHO'VE GONE TO
JUVENILE HALL OR HAVE BEEN
ADJUDICATIVE OF CRIME WE'VE
IDENTIFIED AN ISSUE WITH -- WELL
FOR INSTITUTIONS CODE WHICH
ALLOWS FOR RESTITUTION TO BE
CHARGED TO A GUARDIAN.
AND AND THAT MEANS THAT WHEN.
YOU HAVE A YOUTH WITH A YOU WITH
AN EDUCATION.
THEIR FAMILIES EXTENDED FAMILIES --
OR FRIENDS ARE GOING TO BE LESS
LIKELY TO TAKE THEM INTO THEIR
HOME IF THEY THEN HAVE TO PAY
THE RESTITUTION OF THE YOUTH --
FOR THEIR DEDICATION AND SO THAT
THE LAW IS VERY OLD.
IT -- IT SAYS THAT FOSTER
PARENTS ARE EXEMPT AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT WAS SUPPOSED
TO ALSO EIGHT BE INCLUSIVE OF A
GUARDIAN TYPE PERSON A NON
PARENT -- AND SO WE WOULD WE
WOULD ASKED FOR SOME
CONSIDERATION OF CHANGE OF THAT
RULE WE'LL SEND YOU AN EMAIL AS
FOLLOW UP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
CNN FMI CHILDREN NOW HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ALL THE
ITEMS THERE ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR CHILDREN BUT PRIMARILY FOR
THE FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM.
AND THIS WILL JUST RADICALLY
ALTER HOW WE SUPPORT CHILDREN
YOUTH AND FAMILIES I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT CARE
GIVERS ARE RESPONDING TO THEIR
NEEDS.
THIS IS ALSO ABOUT YOUNG PEOPLE
HAVING SOMEONE THAT THEY CAN
CALL WHEN THEY'RE FRUSTRATED
ABOUT THE SITUATION THE HOME OR
DON'T KNOW WHERE TO GET HELP A
YOUNG PERSON CAN ALSO CALL THIS
LINE.
AND GET THEIR CONCERNS ADDRESSED
AND GET HELP FOR THEMSELVES SO
JUST WANTED TO KNOW THAT BUT
IT'S A GREAT WAY TO AVOID LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND ALL THE OTHER
THINGS YOU'VE HEARD AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
LET ME CENTERS ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA ONE ALIGN MYSELF WITH
EVERYTHING FRANK MAC ASIDE AS
ALWAYS PARTICULARLY IN RELATION
TO THE PRETTY PLEASE WITH SUGAR
ON TOP DO NOT THROW THE BABY OUT
WITH THE BATHWATER -- REGARDING
THE SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENT WE'VE
MADE ON WE NEED ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS WE NEED SOME
ADDITIONAL TINKERING AROUND THE
EDGES TO MAKE SURE WE CAN
CONTINUE TO DO WITH THE GARDEN
IMPORTANT WORK.
THAT WE'RE DOING -- BUT WE NEED
SOME TIME TO TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT -- WANT TO REGISTER OUR
STRONG SUPPORTER AND EXCITEMENT
ABOUT THE FIRST PROPOSAL ON ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT COMPONENTS
OF THAT THE OUTCOME THAT WERE
HOPEFULLY OPTIMISTIC I'VE.
IS MAKING SURE THAT KIDS IN
CRISIS WHEN THEIR FAMILIES CALL
OR WHEN THEY CALL THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO GET REMOVED FROM THE
HOME AT THAT TIME EVERY TIME A
CHILD IS REMOVED ADDITIONAL
TRAUMA.
IS INDUCED AND SO WE WANT TO
PREVENT THAT IN EVERY WAY
POSSIBLE ALL WHEN A REGISTER
SUPPORT -- FOR THE PROPOSAL TO
NOT REDUCE THE RFA ALLOCATION AS
OUTLINED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET BUDGET BY TWENTY FOUR
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
WE ARE DOING FABULOUS WORK IN
THAT ARENA TO PULL THE RUG OUT
FROM UNDER US -- AND SORRY.
SO PLEASE DON'T TAKE THAT MONEY
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I DANIEL SANCHEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS ON THE HEARING VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE FAMILY
STABILITY FUND WERE PLEASED TO
BE PART OF A COALITION -- WITH
MANY THE PARTNERS THAT YOU'VE
HEARD HERE TODAY AND SO WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION AROUND THE IMPORTANCE
OF THOSE FUNDS AND REALLY -- AS
A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT THAT
GOES A LONG WAY TO ENSURING THE
SUCCESS OF C. C. R. IN AND
ENSURING THAT WERE ABLE -- TO
BUILD OUT THE SUPPORTS AND
ALTERNATIVES ON THAT WE NEED IN
THIS REGARD SO WE ENCOURAGE IN
AND ASK FOR YOUR STRONG SUPPORT
OF THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JUSTIN GARRETT CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES -- IS
SUCCESSFUL. TO SEE OUR MEANS AN
IMPORTANT PARTY FOR COUNTIES IN
IMPROVING OUTCOMES FOR YOUTH --
AND SO WE REALLY ARE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THESE INVESTMENTS
WILL HELP COUNTIES BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO RECRUIT RETAIN
APPROVE SUPPORT FAMILIES HERE
CARING FOR CHILDREN.
I'M AS WELL AS BE READY TO
RESPOND IN THOSE EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY
VITAL SO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CAN LUIS MULTIPLE HATS TODAY I'M
ON BEHALF OF THE AT ITEM ONE BE
THE FIRST SYSTEM THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH IS IN
SUPPORT OF THAT.
AND THEN ON THE EMERGENCY CARE
GIVER AT TIME OF FUNDING AT TIME
OF PLACEMENT HAVE BOTH CITY WHY
AND A SPIRIT THAT WHICH IS ONE
OF THE FIRST I THINK ESTHER
TEEPEES.
AND THE STATE INSOFAR THAT
PROPOSALS WELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
KRISTIN PARA THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS ON BEHALF OF
CARE GIVERS AND THE CHILDREN IN
THEIR CARE SUPPORTING AT FAMILY
STABILITY FUND FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM IN THE CONTINUED
EMERGENCY CHARACTER FUNDING AT
THE TIME OF PLACEMENT.
THANK YOU.
JULIE MCCORMICK CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT OVER THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND YOUTH IN SACRAMENTO LOS
ANGELES AND PLASTER COUNTY.
ON BEHALF OF OUR CLIENTS SO MANY
OF THESE.
ISSUES -- BROUGHT UP IN ISSUE
ONE ARE IMPORTANT TO THEM AS
YOU'VE HEARD THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM WILL ADDRESS
YOUTH AS WELL NOT JUST CARE
GIVERS -- IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM OR
HOSPITALIZATION IS NOT THE ONLY
ALTERNATIVE FOR THESE YOUTH IN
TIME OF CRISIS.
THE CONTINUED EMERGENCY CARE
GIVER FUNDING IS ESSENTIAL WE
HAVE FOUND THESE YOUTH --
RELATIVE PLACEMENTS -- I THINK
SOMEONE JUST USE THE PHRASE TO
PULL THE RUG OUT FROM UNDER THEM
AT THIS POINT -- WOULD BE
EXTREMELY DETRIMENTAL WE ARE
ALSO -- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
TRANSPORTATION TO THE SCHOOL
VIRGIN AT THE TIME OF PLACEMENT.
PLACEMENTS ABILITY IS REALLY
IMPORTANT BUT SCHOOL STABILITY
THAT IS ANOTHER COMMUNITY THAT
THESE CHILDREN ARE LOSING IF
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE THIS
TYPE OF FUNDING THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FRANK MAKE
WITH C. TO BEGIN IN ADDITION TO
THE ITEMS THAT I SPOKE -- TO
EARLIER WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
OTHER ITEMS ALL THE OTHER ITEMS
IN THE SECTION IN PARTICULAR THE
FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM IS
A CRITICAL PART OF FORGET TO
DELIVER ON THE PROMISE OF CCR.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CHRISTY BALLOT I'M A SOCIAL
WORKER IN SAMBHAR TO DINO COUNTY
AND I'M HERE WITH SEIU.
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE FOR PACKED REFORM
PACKAGE I CAN SPEAK FIRST HAND
TO THE NEED OF OUR FAMILIES
THEY'RE NOT FEELING SUPPORT YET.
I CAN SPEAK TO THE NEED FOR THAT
FIRST RESPONSE TEAM WE HAVE A
MOBILE RESPONSE TEAM FOR CRISIS
BUT IT'S GENERALIZED IT'S NOT
SPECIFIC TO FOSTER YOUTH.
SOMETHING THAT'S ACTUALLY DRIVEN
FOR FOSTER YOUTH FAMILIES AND
NEEDS.
THAT WOULD BE SO HELPFUL AND
WOULD MAKE ALL THE DIFFERENCE
OUR FAMILIES DESERVE PERMANENT
SEEN OUR CHILDREN DUE.
TO THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS DON ENDS
ON WHILE I'M A PUBLIC HELPFUL AS
YOU ARE YOU SEVENTY ONE MEMBER
AND A PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE FROM
LOS ANGELES COUNTY CALIFORNIA.
OKAY I AM IN THE BRISTOL BOARD
OF THE FAMILY URGES RESPONSE
SYSTEM AS WELL AS RESTORING
FUNDING FOR OUR FACE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MARQUITA HERIS
SOME ALSO PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE
THE WORDS IN THE LA COUNTY AND
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE FURS AS
WELL AS THEY ARE A FACE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
HI I'M VANESSA JOHNSON PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSE INFORMED CORRIDOR.
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY I SUPPORT
THE FURS AN RFA.
HELLO MY NAME'S AMY LAMB LAMB
WITH JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR
YOUTH AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE FIVE THAT SET OF OUT BUDGET
PROPOSALS TO FULFILL THE PROMISE
OF US EASIER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR --
MEMBERS MARTHA CARRERA
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE FAMILY
STABILITY FUNDED THE CONTINUE TO
BRIDGE THE CARE GIVER FUNDING
THAT TIME A PLACEMENT.
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
TRANSPORTATION TO SCHOOL OF
ORIGIN AT TIME OF PLACEMENT
THESE ARE ALL IMPORTANT --
BUDGET -- SUPPORTS FOR THE
FOSTER FAMILIES IN THE
ADMINISTRATION SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE WITH THE PROMISES THAT
WE MADE THREE CC ARE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS -- MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CONNIE DELGADO
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION PLEASE TO BE IN
SUPPORT OF THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE.
THANK YOU.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF ALL OF THESE
PROPOSALS BUT I WANT A
ESPECIALLY EMPHASIZE SPURS AND
EMERGENCY CARE GIVER PROPOSAL
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KELLY MAC MILLAN
ON BEHALF THE CEMETERY -- COUNTY
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE FIRST
PROGRAM THINKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON JACK ALONG WITH
GRACE AND HELP ARE BEING
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE SUPPORT OF
THE FIRST THE PROPOSAL AS WELL
AS THE TRANSMISSION TO SCHOOL
WORK AND THANK YOU.
DAPHNE DESIGNEE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR YOUTH LAW WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THE MARGIN TO CARE GIVER FUNDING
AS WELL AS TRANSPORTATION TO
SCHOOL OF ART AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI JANE CHARTER WITH FIRST PLACE
FOR YOUTH HERE IN SUPPORT OF
FURS WE THINK THIS WILL BE
REALLY BENEFICIAL TO TRANSITION
AGE FRUSTRATING BECAUSE WELL
THANK YOU.
CHRIS STONER MERTZ CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES IN SUPPORT OF THE FIVE
ISSUES AND I WANNA.
PARTICULAR COLA THE FAMILY
URGENT RESPONSE IN THE
TRANSPORTATION TO SCHOOL OF
ORIGIN.
THANK YOU.
GENEREX READ WITH CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CARE GIVERS SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT FOR ALL OF ALL OF THE
FUNDING FOR ISSUE ONE THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON CARA MUDAH
SEKALI PUT FAMILIES WE WORK WITH
OVER A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
RELATIVE CARE GIVERS IN THIS
REGION AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF CONTINUING EMERGENCY CARE
GIVER FUNDING AT TIME OF
PLACEMENT AS WELL TRANSPORTATION
TO SCHOOL MARGIN.
A TOP PLACEMENT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ANY AGUILAR FROM
YOU COMMUNITY COLLEGE I'D LIKE
TO FIRST APOLOGIZE -- WE I'M
ACTUALLY HERE TO ADDRESS ITEM TO
I ACTUALLY BROUGHT SOME OF OUR
STUDENTS FROM CHICO CALIFORNIA
WE ARE SHORT ON TIME WE'VE BEEN
HERE SINCE EARLY THIS MORNING ON
A COUPLE OTHER BILLS.
IN IF YOU JUST ALLOW IT'S JUST A
MOMENT TO ADDRESS SUPPORT ON
ITEM. TO TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS
AMONG FORMER POSITIVE I'M IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'M CHARLES STEVENS I ARE
CURRENTLY BENEFITING FROM THE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PLACEMENT
PLUS FOSTER CARE PROGRAM.
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
NUMBER TWO ORCHARD USE
HOMELESSNESS THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MARCY WILLIAM FROM
BUTTE COLLEGE -- AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE TO REDUCING
HOMELESSNESS AMONG FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH.
ADVOCACY PROPOSAL -- WITHOUT T.
H. P. PROGRAM A PLUS PLUS I
PROBABLY WOULDN'T BE HERE TODAY
ARE PROBABLY ON THE STREETS AND
DOING SOME OTHER DIFFERENT
THINGS AND I APPRECIATE IT MAN.
PUSHED OUT FOR A DAY THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ELIZABETH MORE
AND I'M A STUDENT AT BIãU
COLLEGE TIME HERE IN SUPPORT OF
MORE TRANSITIONAL HOUSING.
FOR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DAVID V. D. I'M A
CHILD WHILE FOR SOCIAL WORKER
AND I'M HERE WITH SEIU.
SEVEN TWENTY ONE I AM IN SUPPORT
OF THE RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL.
IS WELL AS THE FIRST.
AND IT THE CONTINUUM OF CARE
REFORM PACKAGE THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARIO
PROMOTERS I'M WITH SEIU LOCAL
SEVEN TWO ONE I'M ALSO A CHILD
WELFARE SOCIAL WORKER WITH INTER
COUNTY.
AND I'M HERE ASKING FOR SUPPORT
WITH THE FURS AND ALSO THE
RESOURCE FAMILY PROFIL THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS VIRGINIA EARLIER I AM
A NAVY VETERAN AND I'M A SOCIAL
WORKER AT AS STANISLAUS COUNTY
COMMUNITY SERVICES AGENCY -- I'M
PART OF SEIU LOCAL PHONE FIVE
TWENTY ONE AND I'M HERE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE -- REFORMS CAM
SPECIFICALLY THE FIBERS AND THE
FURS AND THE RFA.
AS A SOCIAL WORKER I SEE THEIR
GREAT IMPORTANCE.
APART THEM [inaudible]
HI -- I'M JERRY CRIED -- LA
COUNTY SOCIAL WORKER -- HERE
FROM -- SEIU SEVEN TWO ONE
ATOMIZED TO SUPPORT THE FUNDING
FOR JUST A FUNDING.
FOR FIRST AT M. A. B..
TWELVE AN RV FOR THE I THANK YOU.
HELLO -- TONYA REELS FROM
COLLEGE AND AND TALKING ABOUT
ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO OF FULLY APPROVE OF IT -- AS
A FAST STUDIOS -- THAT CONTINUES
THE OF BE IN AND TEACH PEOPLE AS
WELL IN THIS CASE HOMELESSNESS --
LIKE OVER ALL THE PROGRAM HAS
REALLY HELPED NOT ONLY ME BUT A
LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE I KNOWING --
BALLS SCHOOL WISE AND OUTSIDE OF
SCHOOL SO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
I DO APOLOGIZE WE ARE ALSO
TRAVELING AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF ISSUE NUMBER TWO I HAVE A FEW
YOUTH BEHIND ME THEY WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD REVENUE NAM MY NAME IS
MARCUS CRAZINESS ON FROM THP
INFAMOUS ACCOUNTING.
HERE TO SUPPORT THE HOMELESS FOR
THE YOU THINK IF THANK YOU.
HI MERIAL RUBIO -- I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT ISSUE NUMBER -- TWO
TEACH BE PLUS I'VE BEEN A
PARTICIPANT FOR TWO YEARS AND
IT'S BEEN REALLY BENEFICIAL --
SO YEAH I SUPPORT IT THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS TERRENCE FLAG --
TWENTY YEARS OLD I'VE BEEN PART
OF THE CHIEF PLACE OR I'M BOUT
TO BEING PART OF THE TATE GHB
PLUS -- I'VE BEEN I AM TWENTY AT
THE MOMENT AND THIS PROGRAM IN
VERY.
VERY HELPFUL FOR ME TAUGHT ME
HOW TO GET HIM DEPEND SEE FOR
MYSELF AND THANKS FOR THEM I
HAVE A STEADY JOB THAT I LIKE TO
GO TO EVERY DAY AND IT MAKES ME
HAPPY WORKING THERE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ABBOTT THAT US AS
WITH OBLIVION WE SERVICES WE
PROVIDE SERVICES STATEWIDE IN --
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AND CHILD
WELFARE WERE IN SUPPORT OF ALL
THE ITEMS IN ISSUE.
ONE THANK YOU.
HOW YOU DOING AND YOU COME HERE
SIX IN -- I'M A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH AND I'M PART OF THAT --
TEACH BE PROGRAM.
AND WITH THE T. H. P. PROGRAM
IT'S ALLOWED ME TO GO TO SCHOOL
IN -- AND IT'S IT'S A GREAT
PROGRAM BECAUSE I'M NOT HOMELESS
OR ANYTHING.
SO I THINK IT'S GREAT AND I
THINK WE SHOULD KEEP ITS AREA.
THANK YOU.
I NEED A LOT FROM THE PLASTER
COUNTY TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PLUS
PROGRAM AND I'M JUST
REPRESENTING SOME OF THE YOUTH
THAT WEREN'T ABLE TO COME TODAY
BECAUSE THEY ARE.
WORKING AND GOING TO SCHOOL.
AND CAN'T BE HERE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUT WILL GO
AHEAD AND CONTINUE ON TO ISSUE
TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS AMONG
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH ADVOCACY
PROPOSAL I WOULD LIKE TO CALL UP --
DETAILS IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
FOSTER YOUTH AT AN IMMEDIATE
FAMILY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THAT JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES OF
THE VIEW [inaudible]
AND YEAH AND EVERYBODY ELSE'S
CURRENTLY THERE THANK YOU.
YES SHARE WITH ME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING THE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO.
TRAVELED FROM CHICO AND MERCED
AND ALL AROUND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THIS PROPOSAL OUT OF
ORDER.
IT MEANS A LOT TO THEM AND TO US
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS AMY LEVEL IAN AT THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH AND
I'M SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
HIS STATEWIDE COALITION.
OF OVER TWO WOULD ORGANIZATIONS
TO REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FORTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN THE STATE'S TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM.
KNOWN AS TEACH PEOPLE US.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
CREATED TEACH PEOPLE US IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE IN THE MOST RISK IT
RECENTLY COMPLETED FISCAL YEAR
IT PROVIDED SAFE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND COMPREHENSIVE
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
210-009-0040 SIX FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH AND THEIR FOUR HUNDRED AND
NINETY EIGHT CHILDREN.
WHEN CALIFORNIA EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE TO AGE TWENTY ONE IN?
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THE
POPULATION SERVED BY TEACH
PEOPLE PLUS CHANGED CONSIDERABLY.
INSTEAD OF LARGELY SERVING
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY ONE YEAR OLDS
THP PLUS NOW SERVES OLDER MORE
VULNERABLE FORMER FOSTER YOUTH.
THIS INCLUDES PRIMARILY
CUSTODIAL PARENTS AND YOUTH WITH
DISABILITIES.
TEACH PEOPLE ALSO SERVES AS A
VALUABLE SAFETY NET FOR A NOT
SMALL BUT LARGELY INVISIBLE
GROUP OF YOUNG PEOPLE THESE ARE
YOUNG PEOPLE AGED EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY ONE WHO DON'T QUALIFY FOR
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE.
THIS IS A GROUP THAT WE WE VERY
RARELY SPEAK OF AND UTILIZE
TEACH PEOPLE IT'S CONSIDERABLY.
THIS PROGRAM IS BEEN EVALUATED
EVERY YEAR SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND SIX A CONSISTENTLY
FOUND TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR
YOUTH NOTABLY IN AREAS OF
HOUSING STABILITY MONTHLY
EARNINGS AND EMPLOYMENT.
SO CLEARLY THIS IS A WELL
ESTABLISHED EFFECTIVE STATE
PROGRAM.
HOWEVER IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
THIS PROGRAM IS AT RISK.
THE STATE BUDGET FOR TEACH
PEOPLE PLUS HAS REMAINED
UNCHANGED SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN DURING THE
SAME SENSE THAT SAME PERIOD OF
TIME THE COST OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA.
HAS INCREASED BY 50%.
SO NOT SURPRISINGLY AS THE
DEMAND FOR HOUSING HAS
SKYROCKETED SO HAS DEMAND FOR
THIS VITAL SAFETY NET PROGRAM.
WE DID A MOMENT IN TIME SNAPSHOT
IN A AND IN OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THERE WERE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN ELIGIBLE
YOUTH WAITING TO ENTER TEACH
PEOPLE PLUS.
LOS ANGELES AND SAN DIEGO
COUNTIES EACH HAD A WAITING LIST
OF OUR FIFTY YOUNG PEOPLE AGAIN
OVER HALF OF WHO ARE CUSTODIAL
PARENTS.
THESE ARE FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
WHO WERE IN CARE UNTIL AGE.
EIGHTEEN WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
ACHIEVE PERMANENCE AND NOW FIND
THEMSELVES YOU DON'T.
SEVERAL YEARS AFTER HOMELESS.
SO THE CURRENT BUDGET PROPOSAL
IS AN EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT TEACH PEOPLE US.
THIS WOULD ALLOW THE EXPANSION
OF THIS VITAL SAFETY NET PROGRAM
IT WOULD ALSO SLIGHTLY MODIFIED
THE ELIGIBILITY FOR THE PROGRAM
REALLY IT'S CLOSING MORE OF A OF
A LOOPHOLE.
CURRENTLY TO BE IN THIS PROGRAM
YOU HAVE TO BE IN CARE AT AGE
EIGHTEEN IT WOULD SLIGHTLY
MODIFY THE PROGRAM SO THAT IF
YOU WERE IN CARE BETWEEN SIXTEEN
AND EIGHTEEN IF YOU LATER BECAME
HOMELESS YOU COULD.
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM THERE
ARE A LARGE NUMBER OF YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO CHEAT PERMITS DURING
THAT TWO YEAR WINDOW.
HOWEVER THESE YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE
LARGELY THE SAME EXPERIENCE OF
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO REMAINING CARE
TELL EIGHTEEN AND YET WE CUT OFF
ACCESS TO THIS VITAL PROGRAM.
AND WE ACTUALLY CREATE A
DISINCENTIVE FOR PERMANENCE.
SO THIS IS A VERY LONG STANDING
SUCCESSFUL STATE PROGRAM THAT IS
REALLY OFFERED A BETTER BRIGHTER
FUTURE FOR THOUSANDS OF FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE STRONGLY URGE FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS PROPOSAL AND
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
INTRODUCE J. T. WHO IS THE
CURRENT PARTICIPANTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON PHONE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S J. T. OF
TWENTY YEARS OF MY FRESHMAN YEAR.
SEXY COLLEGE ON A PARTICIPATING.
A DOUBLES TSC PLUS PROGRAM.
I'M HERE HERE TODAY REQUEST
SUPPORT FOR THE THE IN EIGHTEEN
FOR A BIT. EIGHT MILLION A
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE IN TWO
YEARS HE PLAYS.
I ENDED FOSTER AT THE AGE OF
FOUR REMAINED IN UNTIL A FEW
MONTHS BEFORE TURNING.
TWENTY ONE BEING IN FOSTER CARE
IS DIFFICULT WHO'S PRETTY STABLE
UNTIL THE AGE OF TWELVE WHEN I
MOVED FROM PLACEMENT A PLACEMENT
LIVING IN SOLANO COUNTY.
COUNTER CUSTER.
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY THESE MOVES
MADE A HARD FOR ME TO TRUST MANY
PEOPLE EXCEPT A LOT OF THINGS
WELL GONNA.
AT THE AGE OF TWENTY MY FOSTER
MOM WAS EVICTED FROM ROMAN --
QUOTE AND SHE TOLD ME THAT I
COULDN'T MOVE WITH HER I WAS
HOMELESS AND LIVING LIVING WITH
MY FRIENDS ON A COACH IS.
DURING THIS TIME OF I WAS
CALLING SHOULDERS AND OTHER
PROGRAMS FINALLY HAVE FOUND THE
PROGRAM.
ADOLFO.
SINCE ARRIVING AT A DOUBLE
THEY'VE HELPED ME.
PROACTIVELY.
MOVE ABOUT MOVING FORWARD WITH
MY LIFE AND NOW LIVING IN A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT AND CREATING A
POSITIVE FUTURE FOR MYSELF.
ALSO A DOVE LESS HELP ME GET A
JOB AS A TEACHER'S AIDE TO POUR
MY DREAM OF BEING AN ARTIST.
THEY'VE PROVIDED ME VOCATIONAL
GUIDANCE HELP WITH CERTAIN
CERTAIN THINGS IN OUR SUPPLIES
TRANSFERRED MY OUR DEFENSE WAS
Y. DISPLAYED MORE WORK AND SOLD
MY PAINTINGS.
CONNECTED ME WITH OTHER ARTISTS
AND MENTORS AND EMPOWER ME.
TO PURSUE MY PASSION MY THG PLUS
PROGRAM HAS HELPED ALSO HELP ME
ROLE IN THE SEXY.
WELL I'M STUDYING GRAPHIC
DESIGNING IN WORKING FOR MY
ASSOCIATES DEGREE.
ADULTS WILL HELP ME APPLY IN
COMPLETE MY FAST FOOD UNTIL -- A
MUCH FASTER MY FINANCIAL AID
OPTIONS IN CONNECT WITH OTHER
FOSTER YOUTH PROGRAMS EVEN PAID
FOR MY STUDENT FEES.
THEY'RE ALWAYS ENCOURAGING
SUPPORTIVE SUPPORTIVE AND HELPED
ME MAINTAIN MY PASS AND GOALS.
ALSO THEY'RE VERY PATIENT WHEN
THINGS GET HARD FOR ME IN THE
PAST I'VE HAD I'VE HAD STRUGGLED
BUT HAVING THEIR SUPPORT HAS
HELPED ME.
WELL BETTER THAN.
I'VE DONE BEFORE I HAVE ADHD
WHICH REQUIRED A LOT OF PATIENTS
THEY HAVE CONNECTING WITH GOOD
THERAPISTS AND OTHER COMMUNITY
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT.
THIS SUPPORT CAN BE DIFFICULT
AND ALSO ARE TO DEVELOP.
ESPECIALLY AS A FORMER FOSSIL
WHO HAS BEEN A SYSTEM FOR A LONG
TIME WITHOUT TEARS YOU PLUS I
PROBABLY HOMES.
AND I'D STILL BE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO
AND FOCUS ON HOME.
THEY'VE HELPED ME FOCUS ON WHAT
IT TAKES TO BE SUCCESS IN.
MORE OF FOSTER YOUTH IN.
CALIFORNIA NEED NEED THIS HELP
SO I STRONGLY AGREE THROUGH. TO
URGE THIS PROPOSAL.
IN THE STATE AS RUMORS HE BERMAN
LIKES A LOT TO TAKE IN BUT LIKE.
I REALLY THINK THAT LIKE THE
TEARS HE PLACES WITH IT'S A
REALLY IT'S A REALLY.
GOOD THING N. ANYTHING THAT'S
FOR ITS HELPFUL SO.
IN IS A LOT OF OTHER.
YOU'VE BETTER LIKE IN THE SAME
POSITION AS ME LIKE THEY MIGHT
NOT KNOW WHAT THEY WANT TO DO AT
SCHOOL AND STUFF BUT LIKE.
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS HELP LIKE A
HELP US GAIN AN IDEA -- SO.
ANY SUPPORT WOULD BE REALLY
GREAT SO I RECOMMENDED.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING YOUR TESTIMONY -- IT'S
ALWAYS IMPORTANT TO HEAR FROM
THE VERY PEOPLE WHO ARE AFFECTED.
GIVE ALL THE THE THE THE REST OF
US TALKING ABOUT AN ISSUE.
BUT WHEN SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN IN
THE SYSTEM HAS EXPERIENCED IT
THE GOOD AND THE BAD CAN COME IN
AND TALK TO US.
MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE A
CONGRATULATIONS ON BEING AT SAID --
SEX CITY.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THE
BEGINNING RIGHT YEAH THAT'S
RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT IN YOUR YOUR
SON.
EVEN A SON WITH YOU.
HOW DID YOU SAY YOU HAVE A SON
NO NO?
EVER BRING A PIECE OF HIS
ARTWORK BUT WE WERE IT WAS
APPROPRIATE TO BRING IT UP
[inaudible]
WE'RE NOT.
I THOUGHT I HEARD THAT.
ALL RIGHT WELL WONDERFUL I I DO
WANT TO HEAR FROM DSS AND THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THE ESTIMATES
OF THE PROPOSAL DO UNDERSTAND
THE PROPOSAL YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE PROPOSAL.
A JET GENERAL MARK THAT RIGHT SO --
SHE SHE WILL ALLUDED TO CHANGING
A LITTLE BIT THE ELIGIBILITY IN
A PROGRAM AS I'VE SAID A COUPLE
TIMES TODAY ALREADY THE CHILD
WELFARE WAS A REAL LINE PROGRAM
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE REALIGNED
PROGRAM FUNDING.
OUR AVAILABILITY OF DATA IS
SOMEWHAT LIMITED TO EVALUATE A
REQUEST.
IT'S NO SECRET IN CALIFORNIA THE
SUPPLY AND COST OF HOUSING IS A
MAJOR BARRIER FACED BY WHO --
MAYBE MORESO BY FOSTER YOUTH
AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH THAN ANY
OTHER POPULATION.
IN THE STATE A G. BEING AN
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE GENERALLY
MEANS PURSUIT OF WORK OR
EDUCATION BOTH OF WHICH ARE
WORTH SUPPORTING -- SO I DON'T
REALLY HAVE A WAY TO TELL YOU
EIGHT MILLION IS THE RIGHT
NUMBER FIVE MILLIONS OF RIGHT
NUMBER TEN MILLION SO RIGHT
NUMBER I DON'T THINK IT WE CAN
OFFER.
IN ON THAT BUT I THINK YOU YOU
AS YOU AS YOU YOURSELF JUST SAID
IT WE TALKED EARLIER YOU KNOW
THE USE VOICE TALKING ABOUT
THEIR LIFE YOU DON'T COMPETE
WITH THAT STORY AND SO WE
RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF THE
PROGRAM.
AND ITS IMPORTANCE TO THE YOUTH
PARTICIPATING IN IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE SPACE BAR FINANCE OF WHILE
YOU WERE JUGGLING YOUR MANY HATS
EARLIER -- JUST MADE A BLANKET
STATEMENT FOR FINANCE AND WE
DON'T HAVE ANY POSITION ON ANY
OF THE AFRICAN PROPOSALS AT THIS
TIME.
DOES THE NUMBER OF HERE CORRECT
TO YOU THOUGH.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
WITHOUT GIVING IT AN OPINION A
WAS TO WHETHER OR NOT IT'S GOOD
FOR OR NOT BUT TO PART OF THAT
WOULD BE WHY WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON IT -- THE ONLY THING
I CAN REITERATING AGAIN IS THE
SAME THING THAT THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR THANK YOU THAT THAT --
THE THE PROGRAM THAT IS
REQUESTING FUNDING FOR THIS IT
WAS REALIGNED AS A PART OFTHE
TWO THOUSAND AND REALIGNMENT SO --
TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS AND THAT
BEING -- PRIORITY ANY GENERAL
FUND -- ERR ANY WHETHER IT'S A
BUDGET PROPOSAL OR LEGISLATION
THERE ON THAT'S A GENERAL FUND --
RESOURCES WOULD BE NECESSARY.
WE DO KNOW THAT THERE IS SOME
PROPOSED LEGISLATION -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM WHO IS.
THE BUDGET CHAIR -- DOES HAVE A
BILL IN THIS IN THIS AREA.
WONDERFUL COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ON ISSUE.
THREE ALL RIGHT WE UNDERSTAND
THAT LIBERTY SONGES IS TAKING
KATHY'S PLACE.
AND YOUR CAR A CARSON.
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
MISTER CURRY HERE [inaudible]
YES OKAY.
ISSUE THREE PROMOTING HOUSING
STABILITY FOR TRANSITION AGE
YOUTH ADVOCACY PROPOSAL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS LIBBY SANCHEZ ON BEHALF
OF A C. R. U. CALIFORNIA ALSO
PRETENDING TO BE KATHY SUDDENLY
MCDONALD TODAY SAME CURLS
DIFFERENT COLOR -- SO AB TWELVE
IS ONE OF OUR PROUDEST
ACHIEVEMENTS THE LEGISLATURE'S --
OUR SOCIAL WORKERS -- COUNTY
PARTNERS AND ALL OF CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES PARTNERS AT A
SHINING MOMENT RATE OF OF
PROGRAM THAT REALLY REALLY WORKS
AND WE HAVE.
REALLY VERIFIABLE OUTCOME
MARKERS THAT WE CAN POINT TO WE
KNOW THAT AB TWELVE YOUTH --
PARTICIPANTS SEE BETTER
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES BETTER --
WORK OUTCOMES AND BETTER HEALTH
OUTCOMES OVERALL -- WHAT WE HAVE
ALSO NOTICED THAT TEN YEARS AND
TO THE PROGRAM IS THAT THERE ARE
SOME UNANTICIPATED THINGS THAT
LEAD US TO BE HERE TODAY TO ASK
FOR SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING?
ON WE DIDN'T REALIZE HOW GREAT
OF A TAKE OPERATE THERE WAS
GOING TO BE -- IN THIS PROGRAM
AND WHAT A NEED THAT WAS FOR
THIS PROGRAM FOR YOUTH.
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY ONE NOR DID
WE UNDERSTAND REALLY THE
INTRICACIES INVOLVED IN EACH
CASE -- THE WORKLOAD INVOLVED IN
EACH CASE AND THE NEEDS OF THESE
YOUTH MANY OF WHOM HAVE BEEN IN
CARE THEIR WHOLE LIVES -- HAVE
GONE FROM PLACEMENT TO PLACEMENT
AND SO THE VERY -- BASIC THINGS
THAT I THINK MANY OF US WHO ARE
PARENTS AND ARE TRANSITIONING
THEIR KIDS TO COLLEGE AGE -- ARE
ABLE TO HELP OUR KIDS WITH.
THESE KIDS NEED EXTRA CARE EXTRA
TIME -- EXTRA RESOURCES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE STABLE AND
SITUATED -- SO WE ARE ASKING FOR
A FEW THINGS THE FIRST OF WHICH
IS WERE ASKING FOR THIRTY TWO
POINT NINE MILLION ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS. FOR CASELOAD WE ARE
HAVING -- AS WE MENTIONED A HUGE
TAKE UP RATE FOR THIS PROGRAM
AND EACH CASE IS REALLY REALLY
LABOR INTENSIVE SO THE ABILITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE MORE
SOCIAL WORKERS.
I'M ABLE TO SPEND MORE TIME ON
ALL OF THESE CASES IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
AND THEN WE'RE ASKING FOR SOME
HOUSING TRANSITION DOLLARS WERE
ASKING FOR HOUSING NAVIGATORS ON
THOSE BUT WE YOU KNOW THERE'S
THIS HOUSING CRUNCH WE'RE ALL
AWARE OF AND REALLY REALLY HARD
WITH LIMITED RESOURCES.
AND NOT A LOT OF RESOURCES TO BE
ABLE TO NEGOTIATE TO BE ABLE TO
FIND AN APARTMENT AND THE
PLACEMENT AND SO WE'RE LOOKING
FOR FUNDING FOR THAT WERE ALSO
LOOKING FOR TWO MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THINGS LIKE FIRST AND LAST
MONTH'S RENT.
AND THEN AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS -- TO HELP
TRANSITION SO -- I WANTED TO FOR
THE REST OF MY TIME TO MR CARSON
WHO HAS SOME FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE WITH BEING AN A. B.
TWELVE TH THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HOW YOU DOING [inaudible]
THE GAP [inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS COREY
CARSON AND TODAY I WANT TO TELL
YOU ABOUT SOME OF MY EXPERIENCES
IN CHALLENGES I FACED ON A ROAD
TO INDEPENDENCE IN ADULTHOOD.
BEFORE I TURNED EIGHTEEN I
DECIDE TO GOING TO THE EXTENT OF
FOSTER CARE SO I CAN GET THE
SUPPORT AND I NEEDED TO REACH MY
FULL POTENTIAL.
I'VE BEEN A TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
THE FIRST PLACE FOR YOU FOR
THREE YEARS NOW THE FIRST WITH
YOU BY MY OWN APARTMENT THE
ROOMMATE WHO'S ALSO IN PROGRAM
AND HAVE A SUPPORT TEAM.
WHICH INVOLVES MY YOUTH ADVOCATE
IN MY EDUCATION AND EMPLOYMENT
SPECIALISTS.
GROWN UP ON NEW THERE WE WERE
AND ALWAYS WILL BE UPS AND DOWNS
AND FOR ME I'VE ENCOUNTERED SOME
CHALLENGES DURING MY TIME IN
PROGRAM.
THERE'S A TIME IN MY LIFE AND I
HAD GOT INVOLVED WITH THE WRONG
PEOPLE WHO WEREN'T SUCH A GOOD
INFLUENCE ON MY LIFE AND WE'RE
HELPING ME GROW.
I WAS LIVING IN OAKLEY IN FIRST
PLACE WITH YOU AND IT'S HOT AT
TIMES THE NEGATIVE SITUATIONS I
WAS INVOLVED WE GOT TO THE POINT
WHERE THE COPS HAD TO BE
INVOLVED.
AND I WAS EVEN AT RISK OF
GETTING KICKED OUT OF PROGRAM TO
BE AN OTTOMAN ON MY YOUTH
ADVOCATE DIDN'T GIVE UP ON SHE
PUSHED HARD FOR ME TO BE ABLE TO
STAND PROGRAM EVEN THERE HAVE
BEEN INCIDENTS WITH THE POLICE.
NOT ONLY DID SHE FIVE FOR ME SHE
ALSO WORK WITH ME HELP IDENTIFY
ROOT OF THE PROBLEM.
I MOVED TO AN APARTMENT ANY AXE
TO A FIRST PLACE FOR YOU.
AND I WAS WORKING REALLY HARD TO
GET MY LIFE ON A GOOD TRACK BUT
THAT WASN'T THE END OF MY
TROUBLES.
SOME OF THE GUYS I KNEW FROM
OAKLAND HAVE FOUND ME IN MY JOB
I FOUND OUT WHERE I LIVE IT WAS
THE DANGERS INCIDENT AND COULD
HAVE GONE REALLY BADLY.
I WASN'T SAFE IN IT WASN'T SAFE
FROM MY ROOMMATE BECAUSE THE
GUYS TO SHOW UP AT MY PLACE AT
ANY TIME MY WIFE A MY E. WANTED
TO MOVE ME TO ANOTHER PLACE TO
CONQUER FOR SAFETY.
BUT IT COULD BE READY RIGHT AWAY
THERE IS NO SHIRT SHORT TERM
PLACE TO GO BEING THAT I WAS AT
THE AGE OF UNDER.
TWENTY ONE THEY COULDN'T PUT A
MINOR IN A MOTEL ROOM SO I HAD
TO CALL AROUND TO FIND A FRIEND
WHO HAD A COUCH I COULD CRASH ON
LOCALLY I FOUND SOMEONE.
IS BUDGET REQUEST IS IMPORTANT
FOR YOUNG ADULTS UNDER TWENTY
ONE WHO NEEDS TEMPORARY SUPPORT
AND STABILITY.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THE SYSTEM
IS DESIGNED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE BUMPS ALONG THE WAY DON'T
BRING EVERYTHING AROUND IS
CRASHING DOWN AS WELL.
HIS BUDGET REQUEST WILL HELP
BECAUSE IT WILL GIVE US MORE
TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX TO HELP
SOLVE PROBLEMS AND GET ON A PATH
TO PROGRESS.
EVEN WHEN HARD TIMES COME UP I
THINK FOR HIM TODAY ACTION WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. FOR SHARING THAT IS
AS I SAID EARLIER IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AS WE DO OUR
EVALUATIONS.
I WOULD LIKE AGAIN THE REACTION
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION AND DEAL
WITH.
JUSTIN GREATEST BERMAN FINANCE
WHO -- THE TICKET SO GO FOR ALL
THE AT PROPOSALS ON BEING THAT
THEY'RE OUTSIDE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL WE ON
THE POSITION ON THEM AND WE
HAVEN'T DONE A AND AN ESTIMATES
ON THE NEED. TO REALLY CAN'T
COMMENT ON WHETHER OR NOT ANY OF
THE PROPOSED DOLLAR AMOUNTS ARE
ACCURATE OR NOT [inaudible]
HELLO.
WELL I MEAN COMPARING EARLIER
REMARKS AND HE PUT A VERY HUMAN
FACE ON EXACTLY THE PROBLEM THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE AND AT THE
SAME TIME I WOULDN'T BE DOING MY
JOB IF I DIDN'T TELL YOU THIS
WAS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF A REAL
LINE PROGRAMS THAT HAD.
RISKS AND ISSUES AND WE KNEW
THAT AT THE TIME WE REALIZED IT --
AND MOVED THERE'S A TRADE OFF
BETWEEN FINANCIAL DECISIONS AND
HUMAN DECISIONS ON THAT
SOMETHING WE WOULD HAVE TO
NEGOTIATE TOGETHER.
VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU BOTH FOR FOR
JOINING US.
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR ELIMINATING
BARRIERS TO ENTER AND REENTER
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE ADVOCACY.
YES.
MR GIVES.
YOU CAN PROGRAM.
WHERE IT'S A SEVERE ON?
AN ERRAND PHILOSOPHY OF SOMEBODY
[inaudible]
ANYWAY.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE MISTER
GIBSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I'M HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY TO
SPEAK ABOUT ELIMINATING BARRIERS
TO ENSURE THAT YOU.
IN NEED OF TRANSITIONAL SERVICES
ARE ABLE TO ENTER OR RE ENTER
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE.
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE BENEFITS
ARE CRITICAL AS A YOUTH
TRANSITION INTO ADULTHOOD.
THESE YOU FACE GREAT CHALLENGES
IN COMPLETING THEIR EDUCATION.
FINDING A STABLE EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING.
HOWEVER A NUMBER OF THE ISSUES
HAVE BEEN RAISED IN THE COURTS
THAT HAVE PREVENTED A VERY
NARROW.
GROUP OF FOSTER YOUTH FROM
RECEIVING BENEFITS THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE BE ELIGIBLE FOR
CURRENTLY FOSTER YOU. SIX TO
ACCESS EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
SERVICES EIGHT OUT NO ONE UNDER
SCORE AIDS OUT.
IF THEY'RE TURNED EIGHTEEN
BEFORE THEIR CASES ARE FULLY
DECIDED.
AND YOU THE ALSO PREVENTED FROM
ACCESSING INSTEAD OF FOSTER CARE
WITH THE GUARDIAN OR THE
ADOPTIVE PARENTS CONTINUES.
ARE TO RECEIVE BONDS EVEN THOUGH
THAT THE FAMILIES NO LONGER --
FINANCIALLY SUPPORT THE YOU THIS
BUDGET REQUEST SIX TO CLOSE THE
GAP FOR VULNERABLE TRANSITIONING
H. FOSTER YOU IN THESE VERY
NARROW NARROW NARROW SITUATIONS
BY ENSURING THAT WE DO ALL THE
WE CAN'T TO EQUIP.
ARE YOU WITH THE TOOLS TO
SUCCEED.
OF THE ADVOCATES AND I HAVE --
CONTINUE TO MEET WITH A D. S. S.
AND ALSO D. F. O. TO DETERMINE
AT ESTIMATE.
CASELOAD.
WE RECEIVED A REPORT FROM LA --
X. -- ECSTATIC SEEING --
ESTIMATING COSTS HOWEVER WE HAVE
YET TO REACH CONSENSUS -- ON
THIS PARTICULAR ITEM -- IT IS
OUR HOPE AND OUR DESIRE THEY D.
S. S. AND D. O. ELF CAN --
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH US TO
RESOLVE THE DIFFERENCES ON CASE
LOAD ESTIMATES SO THAT WE CAN
MOVE FORWARD AND CLOSE THE GAP.
OF FOR THESE VERY VULNERABLE BUT
NARROW YOUTH HERE IN OUR STATE.
I'M HERE WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONIES AS A
YOUNG PERSON -- WE'RE HAPPY THAT
WILL HAVE HERSELF INTRODUCED
HERSELF.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MORE
IT'S A STUDIO I AM A NON MINOR
DEPENDENT FROM CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY I'M HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL WHICH
WOULD REMOVE A BARRIER TO EXTEND
FOSTER CARE FOR YOUTH WHO.
ENTER CARE OR RETURNED TO KERR
AT AGE.
SEVENTEEN I KNOW FROM PROPOSED.
I KNOW FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
HOW IMPORTANT THE SERVICES AND
OPPORTUNITIES OF EXTENT FOSTER
CARE CAN BE AND HOW HARD IT IS.
TO ACCESS AFTER A CERTAIN AGE I
WAS RAISED BY MY GRANDPARENTS
STARTING ONE WHEN I WAS AN
INFANT MY FATHER'S DISABLED
THERE WAS NEVER ABLE TO CARE FOR
HIMSELF OR ME.
MY MOTHER COULD NOT CARE FOR ME
EITHER BECAUSE SHE STRUGGLED
WITH SERIOUS DRUG ADDICTION.
WHEN I WAS SIXTEEN BOTH OF MY
GRANDPARENTS DIED WITHIN A FEW
MONTHS OF EACH OTHER?
IT WASN'T LONG BEFORE I HAD NO
PLACE TO GO.
I STARTED COUCH SURFING A
REACHING OUT TO COMMUNITY
SERVICE PROVIDERS I WAS
SERIOUSLY DEPRESSED AFTER MY
GRANDPARENTS DIED IT WASN'T SURE
WHERE TO TURN.
BY THE TIME IS CFS SOCIAL WORKER
MET WITH ME AND ACTUALLY EXPLAIN
FOSTER CARE AND THE SERVICES
AVAILABLE I WAS ABOUT SEVENTEEN
AND A HALF.
THE SOCIAL WORKER TOLD ME THAT
BECAUSE I WAS SO CLOSE TO
EIGHTEEN THERE WASN'T ANYTHING
CFS WOULD DO FOR ME.
SHE TOLD ME THAT THEY WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO COMPLETE THINGS IN
COR IN TIME TO PROVIDE ME WITH
ANY LONG TERM HELP IN IT.
AND THAT IT DID NOT MAKE ANY
SENSE FOR TO ENTER FOSTER CARE
FOR JUST A SHORT TIME.
WITHOUT OTHER OPTIONS I KEPT
COUCHSURFING AND WORKING WITH
OTHER OTHER SERVICE PROVIDERS
THAT YOU SENT SHELTERS AND TO
COME UP WITH THE PLAN. ONE OF
THE SHELTER WORKERS REFERRED ME
TO A LAWYER WHO WAS FINALLY ABLE
TO ASSIST ME WITH ACCESSING
FOSTER CARE SERVICES.
MY LAWYER COULD NOT GET A CFS
CASE THE RECORD AND TIME EITHER
SHE WAS FOUND SHE FOUND IT ALL
TO SEE CASE AND HAD A CONVERTED
TO APPEND TITIAN NOT ALLOWED THE
COURT TO PLACE ME IN FOSTER CARE.
THE FACT IS I GOT LUCKY AT THE
LAST MINUTE.
WORKING WITH MY PROBATION
OFFICER WHO HAS BEEN REALLY
SUPPORTIVE I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
BENEFIT FROM TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING WAS FIRST PLACE FOR YOU.
I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO STAY IN
THEIR PAEAN KEEP WORKING THROUGH
THE LOSS OF MY GRANDPARENTS A
FEELING AND FEELINGS ABOUT MY
PARENTS.
I AM CLOSE TO FINISHING HIGH
SCHOOL AND I HAVE A JOB IN
TRYING TO SAVE SOME MONEY.
I AM WORKING WITH MY PROVIDERS
TO COMPLETE COLLEGE APPLICATIONS
AND BELIEVE COLLEGE IS A REAL
POSSIBILITY.
PERHAPS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
ABOUT EXTENDING FOSTER CARE FOR
ME IS I WAS ABLE TO FIND PEOPLE
WHO CARE ABOUT ME.
AND THIS HAS MADE ME ABLE TO
CARE ABOUT MYSELF AGAIN WITHOUT
THE SUPPORT I CURRENTLY HAVE I
BELIEVE THAT I WOULD BE LIVING
IN A CAR OR WORSE.
I WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
CONTINUE SCHOOL AND I KNOW I
WOULD HAVE LOST ALL MOTIVATION
TO WORK.
I AM SURE THAT COLLEGE WOULD NOT
EVEN BE ON MY MIND.
I AM ASKING THAT YOU SUPPORT
THIS BILL SO THAT CHILD WELFARE
AGENCIES ARE ABLE TO HELP YOUNG
PEOPLE LIKE ME SO THE OTHER
YOUNG PEOPLE DON'T LOSE
IMPORTANT AND LYFT.
LIFE CHANGING SUPPORT JUST
BECAUSE THE COURT CASE TAKES TOO
LONG TO COMPLETE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME THEIR INFLUX YES AND I'M
HERE FROM BAY AREA LEGAL AID
LARGELY TO SUPPORT THIS IDEA
WHO'S BEEN BRAVE ENOUGH TO COME
IN AND TESTIFY AND I'LL JUST
NOTE THAT WE DO BELIEVE THIS IS
A NARROW POPULATION OF YOUNG
PEOPLE.
I'M TO OF THE COMPONENTS WE
THINK ARE PRIMARILY TECHNICAL
FIXES FOR EXTENDED FOSTER CARE.
THE PORTION THAT WOULD ALLOW
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO COME IN AT AGE.
SEVENTEEN AND DO NOT COMPLETE
THEIR CASES IN TIME.
TO REMAIN AN EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
COURT NOT COMPLETING THE
JURISDICTIONAL OR DISPOSITIONAL
HEARINGS IN TIME.
SHOULD BE RELATIVELY SMALL WE'VE
ALWAYS MAINTAINED IT IS
RELATIVELY SMALL BUT THIS IS OUR
THIRD YEAR ATTEMPTING TO REACH
CONSENSUS ON THOSE NUMBER SO
WE'RE HOPING THIS YEAR THAT.
WE CAN FINALLY COME TO A A TRUE
COST ESTIMATE AND GET SOME SOME
HARD NUMBERS SINCE WE SHOULD BE
ABLE [inaudible]
TO EVALUATE THAT.
THANK YOU BEFORE I ASK THE
QUESTIONS I WOULD TELL YOU THAT
I I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY THAT YOU'RE FINISHING
HIGH SCHOOL.
NOW COLLEGES NEXT.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT.
THEY ALWAYS TALK ABOUT
STATISTICS FOR FOSTER YOU.
AND HOW FEW OF FOSTER YOU
ACTUALLY GET A BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
BECAUSE OF THAT STATISTIC THERE
ARE LOTS OF UNIVERSITIES THAT
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU.
THEY'D LOVE TO HAVE YOU BECAUSE
EVERYBODY WANTS TO PROVE THAT
THEY ARE THE UNIVERSITY THAT HAS
THE BETTER STATISTICS.
WHAT DO ONE STUDY?
I WANT TO WORK WITH ANIMALS I'M
NOT REALLY SURE PROBABLY IN --
MARINE BIOLOGIST OR SOMETHING.
VERY GOOD I I'M SURE THAT
THEY'LL FIND THE RIGHT
UNIVERSITY FOR YOU COULD BE SAN
DIEGO ONE OF THE OTHER
UNIVERSITIES ALONG THE COAST
[inaudible]
BUT LOTS OF OPPORTUNITIES WOULD
BE AVAILABLE TO YOU.
AND AS SOON AS YOU GET TO A
COUNSELOR TO BE SURE YOU TELL
THEM YOU WANT TO KNOW.
EVERYTHING THAT'S AVAILABLE TO
YOU.
THERE'S A LOT THAT'S AVAILABLE
AND THEY'VE LOTS OF PROGRAMS
WITH THE STARTED A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LIKE THIS SPEAKER JUST
BEFORE YOU OR YOU GO STRAIGHT TO
A FOUR YEAR COLLEGE.
LOTS OF OPPORTUNITIES.
INSIST THAT THEY TELL YOU ABOUT
EVERYTHING THAT'S AVAILABLE.
I DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS.
THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUE ABOUT TO
THE THIS CASE THE CASE LOAD
NUMBER.
WHAT'S THE EARLIEST THOSE
NUMBERS CAN BE PROVIDED.
FEATURING A WHAT THE DEPARTMENT --
I I THINK AS HAS BEEN POINTED
OUT THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
I I THOUGHT IT WAS TWO YEARS NOT
THREE UNDER DISCUSSION -- I
THINK THERE'S BEEN SOME BACK AND
FORTH THERE I'M NOT PERSONALLY
FAMILIAR WITH THAT SO I I'M NOT
SURE WHAT THE STATUS OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE.
THE STAFF IS YEAH GREG ROSE THE
DEPARTMENT WE'VE BEEN WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON STAFF AND OTHER
ADVOCATES -- WE GET THAT THE
NUMBERS THAT THE NUMBERS SHOULD
BE AVAILABLE RELATIVELY SOON IT
WE BUT WHAT WE'VE BEEN LOOKING
AT WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR SOME
ACTUAL LANGUAGE TOOK TOOK TAKE A
LOOK AT SO THAT WE CAN -- SEE IN
FACT IF THE IF THE THAT THAT
THAT THE NARROWNESS THAT THAT
HAS BEEN DESCRIBED AS
ARTICULATED THERE AS WELL -- ARE
ARE ARE.
CLEARLY WE AREN'T INTERESTED WE
ARE WE ARE INTERESTED IN NOT
HAVING YOUNG PEOPLE FALL THROUGH
THE CRACKS BECAUSE OF SOME KIND
OF YOU KNOW DELAY IN COURT OR
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS -- THE THE
NUMBER THAT WE HAVE BEEN GIVEN
AND BECAUSE WE DON'T A WE HAVE A
HARD TIME ACTUALLY VERIFYING
THEM -- ARE IN FACT VERY SMALL
SO -- I WE WE WERE WAITING ON
SOME LANGUAGE AND WE ARE GOING
TO FINISH CRUNCH IN SOME NUMBERS
AND AND AND PRIVATE PROVIDING
THAT BACK TO THE TO THE THE
ADVOCATES. TO THE THE EARLIEST
WE CAN GET THE UPDATED CASELOAD
NUMBERS.
RETHINKING A MONTH.
LESS -- LESS LESS THAN LESS THAN
A MONTH I MEAN WE'RE BASED ON
THAT THAT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THAT THEY'VE ASKED FOR WE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO ONCE WE HAVE THE THE
THE THE THAT THAT LANGUAGE BE
ABLE TO TO VERIFY IT TO TO COME
UP WITH SOME.
NUMBER -- AND THEN IT HAS TO BE
PART OF THE OVERALL BUDGET
PROCESS.
TO RECONCILE EVERYTHING BUT
CERTAINLY WE CAN DO THAT.
IT REALLY APPEARS LIKE A
BUREAUCRATIC ISSUE YES -- I I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE ARE
DAHLE SUPPORTING THIS.
BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT ONCE WE
HAVE THE NUMBERS AND PERHAPS
WILL BE ABLE TO MOVE.
IS THERE ANY REASON TO BELIEVE
THAT THE NUMBER.
IS LARGER THAN THE CASE THAT THE
CASELOAD THAT THE LA -- HAS
ESTIMATED.
I THINK THAT WE I DON'T I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY INFORMATION
THAT WOULD BE DIFFERENT THAN THE
LA -- TESTAMENT [inaudible]
THE END.
FINALLY I THINK THIS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IS
CONSIDERING.
THAT THIS IS A RELATIVELY SMALL
GROUP WAS THE SMALL NUMBER -- IN
DESPERATE CIRCUMSTANCES I THINK
THAT THAT IS CLEAR AND ALSO FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIBSON'S --
TESTIMONY OF THROUGH NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN.
THAT IS CLEAR -- ARE THERE ANY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT.
DO NEED TO BE ADDRESSED AS A
RESULT OF AS A RESULT OF THIS.
AGAIN I THINK IT WILL BE ONLY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE -- THAT I
COULD IMAGINE IS -- IS IF THERE
ARE SOME IF THE THE L<c.cyan>G THE</c>
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD -- THAT IS
BEING CLARIFIED SOMEHOW HAS A
HAS HAS AN OPENING IN IT THAT
WHERE THAT IS IS IN IS DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT HAS BEEN DESCRIBED
MADE BUT I'M WAITING TO ACTUALLY
SEE THE THE SPECIFIC THE THE
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE OTHERWISE.
ANY ENDED THE ONLY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES COULD BE DOES DOES
THAT IS THERE ANY KIND OF
PERVERSE INCENTIVE FOR FAMILIES
TO NOT DO THE RIGHT THING AND
HAVE THEIR YOUNG PEOPLE AND UP --
IT IN EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
THERE'S BEEN -- THERE HAVE BEEN
OTHER STATES WHO HAVE EXPERIENCE
THAT -- NOT IN THIS SPECIFIC
INCH IS INSTANCE BUT THAT WOULD
BE THE ONLY THING I WOULD SAY WE
HAVE TO GUARD WE WOULD WANT TO
GUARD AGAINST.
I HAVE NO INDICATION AT THIS
POINT THAT THERE WILL BE.
ON UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES BUT
AGAIN AND TELL WE ARE CAN
ACTUALLY SEE THE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE I THINK WE WON'T BE
ABLE TO BE AS DEFINITIVE THAT
YOU'D LIKE US TO BE AT THE
MOMENT.
AND SO THAT SO THAT I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU HAVE NOT SEEN THE
LANGUAGE I HAVEN'T SEEN THE
LANGUAGE FOR THAT THERE'S A
THERE'S A THERE'S A UP.
A BILL AND THAT BUDGET ASKED
TOGETHER AND WE HAVE SEEN -- WE
WE HAVE WE HAVE AYE AYE WE HAVE
BEEN TOLD THAT THERE IS UPDATED
LANGUAGE TO BE IT'S COMING
[inaudible]
THE GIPSON.
CAN WE GET THAT LANGUAGE TO THEM
IMMEDIATELY YES I'M.
LOOKING FOR MONTHS WE'VE WE'VE
ACTUALLY WE'VE WORKED ON THAT
LANGUAGE AND WE MET WITH A
VARIETY OF ADVOCATES VERY
RECENTLY WE'VE BEEN MEETING WITH
THEM FOR THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS
AND WE DID.
AND I ACTUALLY THANK.
MR ROSE HE HAD HE IS VERY
HELPFUL IN AND GETTING BACK TO
US WITH CONCERNS AND WE'VE TRIED
TO ADDRESS I THINK WHAT.
WE WERE LOOKING AT OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS SOME HOPEFUL
THAT THAT'S DONE THAT LANGUAGE
IS READY AND SHOULD BE AVAILABLE
FOR YOU TODAY.
BUT OKAY IT WILL THERE IT IS. TO
THE LANGUAGE WILL BE READY TODAY
AND THEN WITHIN A WEEK OR TWO
WE'LL GET THE THE THE UPDATED
NUMBERS.
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
MADAM CHAIR.
YES MY ROOM BY MAY I I THINK.
THIS IS A GREAT OPTION AND OF
THE TESTIMONY THAT WAS GIVEN --
IN AND PRIOR IT REALLY GOES TO A
PASSION -- THAT WE'VE SPOKEN
ABOUT ALSO WITH THE HOMELESS
YOUTH IN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BEING MORE PROACTIVE
IN MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S
RESOURCES THAT ARE THERE FOR
THEM.
SO IN LOOKING AT THAT AND
GETTING THAT FINAL LANGUAGE --
TO YOU WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT IT --
KEEP IN MIND THAT THIS IS A
PROACTIVE MEASURE -- TO KEEP A
BALANCE ON FINANCIAL RESOURCES
ARE BEING USED IN THE FUTURE
BECAUSE OF WERE ABLE TO BE
PROACTIVE GET THOSE RESOURCES
NOW THAT WE HAVE THAT GREATER
IMPACT ON THE HOMELESS YOUTH
POPULATION THAT WERE SEEN.
IN IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
GEN SEEN THOSE THINGS MOVE
FORWARD.
WE WE WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS MOVING FORWARD BUT WHEN YOU
SAID LOOK AT IT PLEASE KEEP IN
MIND THAT ASPECT OF IT IN THE
SAVINGS THAT WILL HAPPEN DOWN
THE ROAD.
BECAUSE THE MONEY WE'RE SPENDING
NOW THANK YOU.
AND AS HAS BEEN NOTED THESE ARE
SEVENTEEN AND A HALF YEAR OLDS.
INCOMPLETE PERIL.
THE THE THE WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING I MR GIPSON YOU'VE
ALWAYS BEEN A CHAMPION FOR
FOSTER YOUTH.
I THANK YOU FOR THAT TO YOU YOU
HAVE BEEN.
YOUR HEART HAS ALWAYS BEEN THERE
AND YOU PUSH THE REST OF US AND
YOU MAKE US ALL UNDERSTAND WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE SO THAT WERE
ALWAYS ON BOARD WITH YOU I THANK
YOU FOR FOR ALL THAT ADVOCACY.
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- LA -- OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LET'S GO TO ISSUE.
FIVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON
YOU'RE STAYING RIGHT WITH US
SOUNDS THEIR ANNA JOHNSON.
AND JUSTIN VERY THIS IF WE CAN
BRING YOU BACK.
THANK YOU AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I'M HERE -- BEFORE YOU
TODAY TO SPEAK ABOUT REDUCING
THE FREQUENCY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
INVOLVEMENT AND DELINQUENCY
PETITION FOR FOSTER CHILDREN IN
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES.
THIS IS -- THIS ONE TIME
INVESTMENT OF NINE MILLION
DOLLARS WOULD PROVIDE FUNDING TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS WE
WANT PROVIDE TRAUMA INFORMED
TRAINING AND PROFESSIONAL
INTERACTION.
WITH BARBEL YOU.
AND EXPAND IT DIVERSION PROGRAMS
AND DEVELOPMENT TO A PRIEST --
APPROPRIATIONS APPROPRIATE
SERVICES TO YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS STATEWIDE.
THE GOAL.
OF THIS PROPOSAL IS TO FIND A
COMMUNITY BASED INFRASTRUCTURE
UP TO DIVERT FOSTER YOU AWAY
FROM THE JUVENILE SYSTEM IN WAYS
THAT IS BOTH SOCIALLY AND
FISCALLY.
RESPONSIBLE NOT ONLY DO WE SAVE
MONEY BY PREVENTING -- THESE
YOUTH FROM CROSSING OVER INTO
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM --
WE REVITALIZED COMMUNITIES BY
HELPING THEM BECOME PRODUCTIVE
CITIZENS.
WHO ARE YOU -- EMOTIONALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY STABLE WITH ME TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING A TESTIMONY
FOR THIS BUDGET REQUEST IS MADE
ON A JOHNSON UP FROM THE
NATIONAL CENTER OF YOUTH AND LAW.
WHO?
THAT ORGANIZATIONS ALSO A
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
WONDERFUL JOHNSON THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING AT CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS ANNA JOHNSON SENIOR
POLICY ASSOCIATE AT THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW AND I AM
HERE TO SPEAK -- IN SUPPORT OF
THIS ONE TIME BUDGET ALLOCATION
OF NINE MILLION TO AUGMENT THE
FOSTERING SUCCESS FUND.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN FACILITIES
LOCATED IN NINETEEN CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES MADE EXCESSIVE CALLS TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT ON YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE.
THESE FACILITIES AVERAGE CALLS
EVERY SINGLE DAY SOME AVERAGE
FOUR TIMES A DAY TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT SOME SEVEN TIMES A
CALLING
THEIR CARE -- YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE IN THESE FACILITIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY CRIMINALIZE
FOR NORMAL CHILDHOOD BEHAVIOURS
BEHAVIORS THAT ARE RELATED TO
TRAUMA OR BEHAVIORS THAT ARE
GENDER NON CONFORMING.
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTING
LGBT Q. YOUTH AND YOUTH WITH
DISABILITIES DISPROPORTIONATE
NIGHTLY IMPACTING USE OF COLOR
PARTICULARLY NATIVE YOUTH.
MOST PARENTS WOULD NOT CALL THE
COPS ON THEIR OWN CHILDREN ABOUT
A THROWN GLASS OF WATER A POKE
OF A SIBLING WITH A CANDY CANE
ON A HOLIDAY OR RUNNING IN THE
HOUSE.
BUT FOR USE IN THESE FACILITIES
SPECIFICALLY THE THIS IS WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND THIS IS NOT JUST A
SIMPLE ENCOUNTER WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS MANY OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HEARD IN THE
SPECIAL YOU'RE HEARING YESTERDAY
ON AB THREE NINETY TWO THIS IS A
COMPLEX.
RELATIONSHIP THAT THEY'RE
DEALING WITH AND IT'S A FEARFUL
RELATIONSHIP THAT THAT THAT
THERE MAY BE -- THIS IS ACTUALLY
THE BEGINNING OF FOSTER CARE TO
PRISON PIPELINE.
AS AS THE MEMBER MENTIONED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON MENTIONED
WHAT THIS FUND WILL DO YOU -- SO
I WILL SKIP OVER THOSE POINTS
THERE BUT CALIFORNIA'S ACTUALLY
ALREADY BEGUN TO MOVE TOWARDS
THIS HEALTH BASED APPROACH TO
DEALING WITH YOUTH AND CONFLICT
OF THE WITH THE LAW.
INCLUDING INVESTING IN DIVERSION
PROGRAMS AND TRAUMA INFORMED
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES FOR
YOUTH.
IN -- TWENTY EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA
MADE AT THE FIRST FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET ALLOCATION TO
ESTABLISH THE FUND INSISTS BEGIN
TO DEFER EAT DIVERT YOUTH IN
STATE CARE AWAY FROM THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THE DISTRIBUTION OF THESE
INITIAL FUNDS IS WELL ON ITS WAY
WITH CDS WITH THE APARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES RELEASING THE
REQUEST FOR INFORMATION.
AND TO DISTRIBUTE THOSE FUNDS
CONDUCTED THROUGH A WEAPON ARE
WHERE THERE WERE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY PARTICIPANTS
ACROSS THE STATE THAT TURNED OUT
FOR THAT WEAPON ARE AND ARE
INTERESTED IN DELIVERING THE
SERVICES IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT INITIAL
ALLOCATION WILL ONLY COVER ABOUT
THREE TO FOUR COUNTIES OF THOSE
NINETEEN WAS STATED NEED -- IF
THE COUNTIES REPRESENTED ON THIS
COMMITTEE ALONE WOULD EXCEED THE
AMOUNT COVERED BY LAST YEAR'S
ONE TIME AUGMENTATION ARE
ALLOCATION.
AND ARE FURTHER MORE THEY'RE
COMPARING THE TWENTY SIXTEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT CALLS TO THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
BECAUSE THERE IS A 10% INCREASE
IN THE TOTAL NUMBER OF CALLS TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
SO WE'VE SEEN AN INCREASING
TREND SO WE KNOW THAT THIS ONE
TIME ALLOCATION IS -- WOULD BE
VERY WELCOME IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
BUT CHILDREN IN THE SYSTEM AS
YOU KNOW HAVE EXPERIENCED THIS
ABUSE NEGLECT AND TRAUMA.
AND THOSE IN GROUP CARE ARE
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE TO
CROSSING OVER AND RELYING ON
POLICE TO DEAL WITH YOUTHFUL
BEHAVIOR PUSHES CHILDREN INTO
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM WHEN THEY
ACTUALLY NEED.
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE IN THEIR
HOME COMMUNITY -- YOU
DEVELOPMENT A DIVERSION PROGRAM
IMPROVES YES BEHAVIOR AND
OUTCOMES IMPROVES PUBLIC SAFETY
AND IS A SMARTER INVESTMENT --
AND THIS I'M JUST GOING TO KIND
OF BE QUICK HERE WITH A SKIP
OVER SOME STUFF SINCE I KNOW YOU
ALL KNOW THAT SO -- BY REDUCING
OUR OVERLOOKED AND RELIANCE ON
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND PRIORITIZING
COMMUNITY BASED TIME IN FORCE
FROM INFORMED CARE CALIFORNIA
WILL IMPROVE LIFE OUTCOMES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH.
BETTER UTILIZE SCARCE LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES AND
IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
AND I URGE YOUR IPHONE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY FEEDBACK FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION.
A PICTURE RECORD FROM THE
DEPARTMENT I REALLY DON'T HAVE
MUCH TO ADD WE WORK CLOSELY
TOGETHER AND YOU KNOW I COULD
HAVE ON THE LAST ITEM THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ADVOCACY AS WELL IN NON
DISCUSSION PORTION OF THE AGENDA --
THERE ARE SEVERAL PROPOSALS FROM
OUR OFFICE OF THE FOSTER CARE
OMBUDSMAN AND A LOT OF WORK AND
ON ON THE BILL OF RIGHTS AS WELL
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
ISSUE FORWARD.
OBVIOUSLY REDUCING THE
CRIMINALIZATION OF YOUTH AND
THEIR BEHAVIORS IS A GOOD THING
WE WENT ALL SUPPORT THAT -- I I
WOULD SAY IT'S PROBABLY TOO
EARLY TO TELL WHETHER THE MONEY
THAT WAS IN THE CURRENT YEAR
BUDGET IS HAVING AN IMPACT OR
THE IMPACT THAT WAS INTENDED OF
IT.
THE COMMENT THAT I'VE MADE
PREVIOUSLY ABOUT YOU KNOW WHEN
WE MAKE AN INVESTMENT WHAT ARE
WE GETTING FOR IT WHAT WE EXPECT
TO SEE FOR IT.
PER SHARE THE CLARIFICATION THIS
IS A ONE TIME REQUEST.
THAT COMES ALONG WITH SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT STARTING
SOMETHING AND THEN STOPPING
SOMETHING OR WHAT COMES NEXT AS
THE NEXT STOP FOR THESE
PROVIDERS AS THEY EXPAND THE
CAPACITY.
UP SO AGAIN COMING BACK TO THE
HOW DO WE PROVE THAT IT WORKS SO
THAT WE KNOW WHETHER WE WANT TO
CONTINUE IN THE FUTURE OR NOT.
SO THOSE WOULD BE SOME KINDS OF
THE QUESTIONS I WOULD
ADDITIONALLY NOTE -- AND COULD
PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE DONE IT
EARLIER THERE'S A LOT OF OVERLAP
IN THE ADDRESSING OF THE ISSUES
BETWEEN THE VARIOUS PROPOSALS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY.
YOU HEARD THP PLUS TALK ABOUT
BAD CAPACITY AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF BEDS AVAILABLE.
THEN WE HEARD A PROPOSAL ABOUT --
AT ADVOCATING FOR NAVIGATORS TO
HELP PEOPLE FIND PLACES TO STAY
HERE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
HELPING THEM ACHIEVE PERMANENCY
WHEN THEY'RE ALREADY IN A
CONGREGATE CARE SITUATION.
AND DIVERTING THEM FROM CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SO THERE'S A CERTAIN
PIECE TO THAT WE WOULD LIKE A
PART IN THE CONVERSATION NOT
JUST WHAT ARE WE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE IN ARE WE GETTING AT BUT
ALSO HOW DO THESE THINGS
INTERACT WITH EACH OTHER SO IT'S
A MORE COMPLICATED CONVERSATION.
VALID ISSUE AND AGAIN FIRST
THING I SAID REDUCING THE
CRIMINALIZATION OF YOUTH AND
THEIR BEHAVIORS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT HUMAN THING TO BE
DOING.
BERMAN FINANCE -- ARE JUST
INTEREST FROM FINANCE ANSWERED
LIKE THAT ON THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS TAKEN SOME APPROACHES ON
THIS I BELIEVE -- REGULATIONS
WERE JUST FINALIZED IN OCTOBER
OF LAST YEAR TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE
IN AND IT WITH -- A LOT OF THESE
FACILITIES ON ADDRESS SCENE --
PICTURED COULD END IN AN EFFORT
TO LIMIT THE NEED FOR CALLING
LAW ENFORCEMENT SO I JUST WANT
TO ADD THAT ON THERE.
THANK YOU AND I THINK YOU'RE
CORRECTIVE PARENTS AREN'T GOING
TO CALL.
POLICE LAW ENFORCEMENT TO COME
AND HELP THEM.
OUT.
SOLVE ISSUES THAT YOU'RE RIGHT
THIS THE USER TEENS AND THEY'RE
ACTING OUT AND BUT ONCE THEY'RE
CRIMINALIZE ONCE THEY ARE PUT
INTO THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THEN IT'S SO HARD TO GET THEM
OUT BECAUSE THAT REMAINS WITH
THEM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS TO US.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER.
SIX THAT'S NOT.
THAT'S NOT YET [inaudible]
DAVID DEMOING [inaudible]
SHE ISSUE NUMBER SIX ADDRESSING
THE IMPACT OF MANDATED STATE
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE. FOR
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES.
ADVOCACY PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO TO
BE HERE.
MY NAME AGAIN IS DAVID DOWN WHEN
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY THAT PROVIDES A
ADOPTIONS AND FOSTER CARE
SERVICES.
AT LEAST FOR OUR AGENCY IN ANY
GIVEN YEAR WE SERVE ABOUT A
THOUSAND FOSTER CHILDREN.
ARE PRIMARILY CHILDREN OF COLOR
AND MINORITIES.
I I WANT TO FIRST SAY THAT WE
APPLIED.
THE COMMITMENT FROM THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR. TO
INCREASE THE WAGES AWFUL WORKERS
BY RAISING THE MINIMUM WAGE I
THINK THAT'S A POSITIVE.
FOR ALL THE WORKERS SEEN IN
CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TO OUR BUDGET REQUEST THAT DEALS
WITH THE IMPACT.
THAT THE MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES
ON THE ABILITY OF THE NONPROFIT
SUCH AS THE ONE THAT I WORKED
WITH. TO PAY OUR SOCIAL WORKERS.
THE STATE SAID IF A FAIR RATES
FOR SOCIAL WORKERS HAVE BEEN
FROZEN SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
ONE AND WERE CUT 10% IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINE WE SAW A
SLIGHT INCREASE OUR THREE YEARS
AGO.
BUT NOTHING CLOSE ENOUGH TO
COVER THE COST OF INCREASING
SOCIAL WORKER SALARIES.
I THINK YOU KNOW WE ALL AGREE
THAT SOCIAL WORKERS ARE GREAT
ADVOCATES AND MENTORS WERE OUR
FOSTER CHILDREN.
IN THE SYSTEM.
MAKING MATTERS WORSE FOR IF A
FACE.
THE STATE LAW REQUIRES THE EXAM
PROFESSIONAL EMPLOYEES BE PAID
DOUBLE THE MINIMUM WAGE.
WHILE THE MINIMUM WAGE ACT
MANDATES ANNUAL INCREASES TO THE
STATE'S MINIMUM WEIGHT.
FFA RAID DID NOT COVER THE COST
OF PAYING OUR SOCIAL WORKERS
DOUBLE THAT MINIMUM WAGE.
NOT SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO DO
WE DO WITH AGAIN BECAUSE OF THE
FUNDING SOURCES.
AND WE DON'T SEE ANY RATE
INCREASES.
IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
I THERE'S ONLY TWO STATE SET
FOSTER RATES AT THE NOT REESE
WHO RECEIVE A MANUAL ADJUSTMENT.
ONE IS THE FAA RATE AND SADLY
THE OTHER ONE NEEDS FOR INFANT
CARE SUPPLEMENT. TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE WITH THE LAW.
WE'RE ASKING THAT THE BUDGET
ALLOCATION OF TWENTY SIX MILLION
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND
554-200-0192.
THOUSAND TWENTY ANY FURTHER
INCREASE OF FFA RATES AT THE
BEGINNING OF EACH SUBSEQUENT
CALENDAR YEAR.
AT THE LESSER OF THREE POINT
FIVE OF THE CHANGE IN THE US
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX.
AS YOU KNOW IF IT FOR YOU
PROVIDE CARE SUPPORT AND
SERVICES FOR NEARLY THIRTEEN
THOUSAND CHILDREN.
SOME 25% OF THOSE KIDS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE IN FOSTER CARE.
IF A FACE ARE CRITICAL TO
SUCCESS WILL IMPLEMENT THE
STATE'S CONTIENEN WITH CARE
REFORM.
THAT SIGNATURE HOME BASE FAMILY
CARE FOR EVERY CHILD IN FOSTER
CARE.
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
BRING IN FFA SOCIAL WORKER
SALARIES INTO COMPLIANCE.
WITH THE NEW STATE MINIMUM WAGE
LAW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WITH THIS
SOUNDS LIKE A TOTALLY LOGICAL --
REQUEST.
ALMOST SEEMS LIKE -- IT MAY HAVE
BEEN OVERLOOKED FOR WHATEVER
REASON.
IS A FOR INCREASING THE MINIMUM
WAGE WE HAVE TO PROVIDE THE
FUNDING -- THAT GOES WITH THAT.
OF IT ANY THAT IS THE DSS SERGIO
OUT HAVE [inaudible]
COMMENTS.
YEAH I THINK YOU HEARD ME SAY
THAT ARE ANXIOUS AS HEARING THE
GOOD OUTCOMES FOR THE PEOPLE
WERE CARRYING FOUR DEPENDS IN
PART ON A STABLE AND THUS
PROPERLY COMPENSATED WORK FORCE --
AND THIS IS ONE OF THE RATES
SAYS AS MENTIONED THAT DOESN'T
AUTO ADJUST FOR CHANGES IN
MINIMUM WAGE THE DEFINITION OF
IT IS AS HE DESCRIBED IF IF
YOU'RE A PROFESSIONAL BY WAGE
ORDER NUMBER FOR YOUR YOUR WAIT
A YEAR WAGE MUST BE DOUBLE THE
THE MINIMUM WAGE.
AND AND WHILE WE ARE WHERE WE'RE
AT TODAY WERE ALSO ON A PASSED
TO TO FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR --
AT A FUTURE POINT IN TIME --
SOME FFA IS ARE ABLE TO MEET
THAT STANDARD TODAY UNDER THEIR
RATE -- OTHERS ARE NOT WE
UNDERSTAND THE RANGE OF WAGES IS
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TWENTY THREE
AND THIRTY DOLLARS AN HOUR FOR
THESE FOLKS THESE ARE PEOPLE
WITH MASTERS DEGREES AND SOCIAL
WORK -- AND SO YOU KNOW THAT
SHOULD THAT SHOULD WEIGH IN
THEIR AT THE END OF THE DAY.
AND IF WE CONTINUE TO CLASSIFY
THEM AS A PROFESSIONAL WHICH
WHICH IS THE MOST PEOPLE WOULD
AGREE THAT THEY ARE -- THEN THE
WAGE ORDER IS IS PRETTY CLEAR
THAT THERE WHICH NEEDS TO BE
DOUBLE MINIMUM WAGE.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU [inaudible]
BERMAN FINANCE [inaudible]
HELLO.
I I DO WANT TO JUST COMMENT THAT --
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SOCIAL
WORKERS THERE ARE.
OBVIOUSLY MANY HERE YESTERDAY
AND TODAY AND THEIR WORK IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
THIS FIELD AND SO MANY OTHER
FEELS AND I I THANK YOU -- BY MY
SISTER REMINDS ME THAT IT'S SHE
HAS A DOCTOR AND SOCIAL WORK
THIS REMINDS ME THAT SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE REALLY THE ONES WHO
DO THE WORK YEAH.
THAT THE REST OF US JUST TALK
ABOUT IT BUT THE SOCIAL WORKERS
TO IT.
SO IN HONOR OF MY SISTER ROSA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THAT CONCLUDES SOME
ISSUE NUMBER SIX WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER.
SEVEN CHILD WELFARE PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSING.
EARLY INTERVENTION PILOT PROGRAM
[inaudible]
MARQUITA [inaudible]
HERIS [inaudible]
YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MARQUITA HARRIS FOR THE
LAST NINE YEARS I HAVE WORKED AS
A PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE SERVING
CHILDREN EVERY IS.
PLACED INTO FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY I'M HERE
TO ASK FOR FUNDING IN THE AMOUNT
OF EIGHT POINT TWO FIVE MILLION
FOR THE STATE GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS WHICH WE BELIEVE WILL BE
MATCHED BY EQUAL OR MORE FEDERAL.
TITLED NINETEEN FUNDING THOUSAND
IS COUNTY IS THE HOME OF THE
LARGEST CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA AS TO AS CHALLENGE
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES WE
SERVE MILLIONS.
AT RISK DETAINED THE TENSION
FAMILIES WHO TYPICALLY SHOULDER
A HIGHER BURDEN OF CHRONIC AND
PREVENTABLE DISEASES AND
COMMUNITIES EXPERIENCE IN
EPIDEMICS OF DIABETES AS MOBY
CITY.
ARTISANS EXTRACTING AN INFANTS
WHO ARE EXPOSED.
TO ABUSE WHILE MOTHERS ARE
PREGNANT.
EACH MONTH OVER ELEVEN THOUSAND
CALLS IN LA COUNTY REPORT IS A
BIT SUSPECTED CHILD ABUSE AND
NEGLECT PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES DO.
DO NOT GO OUT ON EVERY REFERRAL.
WE GO OUT ON CALLS THAT COME
FROM MULTIPLE PROVIDERS FROM
HOSPITALS CLINICS SCHOOLS OR
WHEN THE SOCIAL WORKER.
HAS DETERMINED THAT THE
SUPPLEMENTAL HEALTH ASSESSMENT
BY PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES
NECESSARY I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
A FEW STORIES WITH YOU TO
ILLUSTRATE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
ROLE THE PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE
PLATE IN THE TOWER FOR
ASSISTANCE.
I HAD A SIX YEAR OLD CHILD WHO
WAS NOT THE PRIMARY REASON FOR
THE REFERRAL THE MOTHER HAD
SEVEN TWO CHILDREN THE CHILD
WITH A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
POUNDS.
THE CHAO HAD A TRAIT DUE TO
MORBID OBESITY N. SLEEP APNEA
WHEN I WENT TO THE HOME AND
DISCOVERED THAT THERE WAS HE
TANKS WHICH OXYGEN TANK THAT WAS
LEFT NEXT TO THE HEATER.
ALSO THAT THE CHILD HAS NOT BEEN
FOLLOWED UP ON THE WITH THE
PULLMAN KNOWLEDGES THAT MANAGES
THE TRADE FOR OVER A YEAR THE
MOTHER THROUGH ALL THE SUPPLIES
IN THE CLOSET.
AND WILL BASICALLY NOT TAKING
CARE OF THE CHILD.
SO DO TO MY A A I'M GOING
DILIGENCE THE CHILD WAS SAID
CONNECTED TO THE POLL MONOLOGIST
I SUBMITTED MY MEDICAL CONCERNS
THE CHILD WAS A MINUTE A NEATLY
INTO.
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT THE CHILD
WAS ALSO MONITOR BY DOCTOR EVERY
TEN MINUTES DUE TO THE CRITICAL
ILLNESS OF THE CHILD THE CHILD
HAD MULTIPLE BACTERIAL.
DIFFERENT TYPES OF INFECTION
AROUND THE TRACK AND IN THE
TRICK AND THE DOCTORS THAT THE
POINT TOLD ME THAT I SAY THAT
CHILD'S LIFE.
ANOTHER STORY I WANT TO MENTION
IS THAT I HAVE A FOURTEEN YEAR
OLD ON CONTROL DIABETIC.
TYPE ONE WHICH MEANS THAT THEIR
INSULIN DEPENDENT.
OF THE SOCIAL WORKER NOTIFIED ME
THAT THE SCHOOL SAID THAT THE
CHILD'S BLOOD SUGAR WAS FIVE
HUNDRED I ASKED THE SOCIAL WORK
AND TAKE THE CHILD TO EMERGENCY
ROOM TO HAVE THAT MEDICAL
ASSESSMENT.
DUE TO I HEARD ABOUT THE PAIR'S
NOT COMPLIANCE AND UNSUPERVISED
IN SUBDIVISION OF THE CHILD.
ALSO I DID COMPLETED THE JOY
HOME VISIT THAT SAME WEEK I WAS
ABLE TO ASSESS THE FAMILIES NEED
SAW THAT THERE WAS SOME EMOTION
THE SO THEY NEED TO BE CONNECTED
TO MENTAL HEALTH.
MOM WAS CRYING AND STRUGGLING
WITH THE TEEN TEEN ALSO
STRUGGLING.
SO I WAS ABLE TO CONNECT THEM
ALSO I WAS ABLE TO LOOK AT THE
THE METER FOR THE BLOOD SUGARS
AND NOTICED THAT THE CHILD HAD.
SEVERE HIGHS CONTINUOUSLY FROM
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED TO
SIXTEEN HUNDRED CELLS ABLE TO
SHOW THAT THAT FAMILY THAT IF
THEY GO ON CHECK AT THE INSULIN
IF THE BLOOD SUGAR IS UNCHECKED
AND NOT COVER.
THE NO CHILD THE BLOOD SUGAR
WILL KEEP GOING UP IN THE CHAO
COULD POSSIBLY DIE.
SO WHAT DO TO MY DILIGENCE I
RECOMMENDED THAT THE FAMILY ALSO
GO BACK INTO THE ENDOCRINOLOGIST
TO BE RETESTED ON HOW TO MANAGE
THE DIABETES REGIMENT WHICH IS
STILL SO IMPORTANT.
ALSO OF THAT IMPACT IF WE WERE
IF I WAS ABLE TO GO IN SOONER.
LIKE THE ONE WITH THE TRICK
THEY'RE NOT PREVENTED THE CHILD
FROM BEING DETAINED AND KEPT THE
CHILD IN THE HOME WITH THE
DIABETIC PATIENTS.
I WAS ABLE TO SO FAR KEEP THE
CHILD IN THE HOME DUE TO THE
SERVICE CONNECTIONS AND THEN
ALSO TO DO A FOLLOW UP VISIT. TO
MAKE SURE EVERYTHING THAT I HAD
SUGGESTED IN RECOMMENDED THAT IS
IN PLACE AND THAT THEY ARE
FOLLOWING IN FOLLOWING THE
DIABETIC A PROPER REGIMENT PRO
THE DOCTOR'S ORDERS SO THEN I
WILL MAKE THAT DETERMINATION AT
THAT TIME. TO PREVENT THE CHILD
FROM BEING REMOVED FROM THE HOME
WE LIKE TO KEEP THE FAMILIES
TOGETHER.
SO PROVIDING THE APPROPRIATE
SUPPORT PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES
LINK FAMILIES TO PREVENTATIVE IN
INTERVENTIONAL HEALTH SERVICES.
TO AT RISK CHILDREN BEFORE
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS BECOME
LIFE THREATENING PROTECTING
CHILDREN.
THE TECHNICIAN WITHIN AGAINST
UNNECESSARY HELP THE CLIENT AND
THE WARNING CHILD FATALITY.
SO AS YOU CAN SEE THE FIRST
EXAMPLE THAT I THAT I HAD
MENTIONED I SAY THAT CHILD'S
LIFE.
SO PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES ARE WE
WE HAVE THAT UNIQUE SKILL TO
WHERE WE CAN ASSESS THE CHAO
FROM HEAD TO TOE AND DETERMINE
WHAT IS NEEDED IN THE TYPE OF
SERVICES FOR THAT CHILD.
SOME OPEN IT TO SUPPORT OUR OF
EARLY INTERVENTION PILOT PROGRAM
OF EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION.
WITH A FEDERAL MATCH OF THE
EIGHT POINT.
TWO FIVE I JUST HAD TO
COMPLAINTS ABOUT THIS. ONE IS
THAT IT'S LA COUNTY AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALMOST AND I ARE IN SAN
BERNADINO.
SECONDS THAT WE WOULDN'T HAVE
YOU I'VE GOT.
TO I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU THAT --
I JUST IN THE WAY THAT YOU
PRESENT THIS -- IT IS CLEAR THAT
YOU ARE DEDICATED TO THIS
ABSOLUTE AND WHEN WE HAVE
DEDICATED -- TO PEOPLE SUCH AS
YOURSELF IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO BE TO LISTEN -- YOU YOU ARE
DOING THE WORK.
JUST AS WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER
WE TALKING TO THE FOSTER YOUTH
THAT'S IMPORTANT OVER TALKING TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTUALLY DOING
THE WORK NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT
IT.
I THANK YOU I UNDERSTAND ALSO
BECAUSE THAT WAS ONE OF MY
QUESTIONS Y. LA COUNTY WHY SO
MUCH FOR JUST ONE COUNTY.
WERE UNDERSTAND LA COUNTY AS ONE
THIRD.
OF ALL THE CASELOAD FOR THE
STATE OF CALLAHAN'S A LITTLE BIT
THERE'S SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
FOSTER YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA ALONE
AND LA COUNTY HAS.
TWENTY THOUSAND SO WE'RE HUGE
COUNTY YES YOU ARE -- IF WE
COULD GET THE PILOT GOING IN AND
THEN EVENTUALLY IF I COULD TO
ONLY DISCREDIT STATEWIDE
ABSOLUTE ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT SEVEN GET OR OR LOOK
AT SOME TYPE OF PILOT PROGRAM --
IN BOTH AREAS I THINK ON A ON A
DIFFERENT SCALES.
SINCE WE'RE THE ONLY ONES LEFT.
RIGHT NOW YEAH YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW COUNTY REMAINS THE
LARGEST COUNTY WITH WITH THE
GREAT GREAT NEED THIS OVERLOOKED
ALSO COUNTY AND WE HAVE MULTIPLE
COMPLEXES BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
SOCIAL ECONOMICS AND ALSO
THEY'RE NOT.
ALWAYS EDUCATED A LOT ON THE
BELOW SIX GRADE LEVEL SO THERE'S
A LOT OF EXTRA THINGS THAT WE
HAD TO DO AN AUDIT TAKE CARE OF
OUR ANOTHER REASON WHY SHOULD BE
A PILOT PROGRAM IN BOTH COUNTIES.
IS BECAUSE A LOT OF THE MEMBERS
AND CLIENTS TO DO -- TRAVEL ON
BECAUSE IT'S SO CLOSE FROM LA
COUNTY IN DECEMBER YOU KNOW
COUNTY SO IT COULD BE SERVING
THE SAME FOLDED STARED JUST A A
FOOD FOR THOUGHT.
AND IF WE KEEP TALKING WILL
DAVID GIVE YOU EVER REASON
POSSIBLE.
THE HOUSING IS LESS EXPENSIVE SO
WE KNOW THAT.
THAT LA COUNTY HI THAT'S RIGHT
THAT'S RIGHT BUT THE POPULATION
DOES CONTINUE.
TO MOVE DOESN'T SEE COUNTY LINES
IT SEES THE NEED GOING.
AND EVERYWHERE THIS NEED IT SO
WE WOULD -- AVIC OUR IN OUR
ADVOCATING FOR A PILOT PROGRAM
ALSO ASSEMBLY NO COUNTY.
WE GOT TO GET WATER LA FOR FOR
YOU GUYS BUT BECAUSE THEY ONLY
COUNTIES HAS THE ONE THIRD OF
THE FOSTER USE.
IF WE CAN GET THAT PILOT GOING
TO NAIL BEEN CORRECTED AND THEN
WE CAN DISTRIBUTED THROUGHOUT
THE OF THE COUNTIES I THINK.
YOU'LL PROBABLY BE HAPPY ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE YOU WON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THE ONE LITTLE BUGS
AND DIFFERENT THINGS OTHER
PROBLEMS BUT ENOUGH.
IT IS DEFINITELY THERE IS A NEED
FOR THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MS HARRIS --
IT ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
THE ADMINISTRATION ONE MORE PLUG
FOR SAN BENITO COUNTY YES THERE.
IS THERE A I WOULD GREG ROSE TO
THE DEPARTMENT I JUST AS A
SOCIAL WORKER MYSELF CLEARLY THE
THAT THE SKILL SET FROM THE
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE -- IS IS --
IS DIFFERENT AND OFTEN
COMPLEMENTARY AND I WOULD JUST
SUGGEST SUGGEST THAT IF THE IF
THIS IS A PRIORITY THAT WE COULD
WE WOULD HAVE TO HAVE A LOOK AT
THE IMPLEMENTATION WORK WITH ON
IMPLEMENTATION ACTIVITIES.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS HER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE TO ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT CONTINUATION OF
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME -- FRANK
MECCA FEEL.
TO THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FRANK MECCA EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CWD A I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF MY ORGANIZATION THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES THE CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORT OF HOUSING AND HOUSING
CALIFORNIA.
AMR SEEKING TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY IN. TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
CONTINUE AND EXPAND THE BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM. TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN OR COALITION
ADVOCATED FOR THE CREATION OF
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM.
BASED ON WHAT WE SAW WITH THE
GROWING CONCERN IN CALIFORNIA
OVER THE LINK BETWEEN CHILD
WELFARE INVOLVEMENT AND
HOMELESSNESS AMONG FAMILIES.
AT THE TIME NATIONAL DATA
INDICATED ABOUT ONE THIRD OF
CHILD OFFER INVOLVE FAMILIES
WERE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
AND MORE HOMELESSNESS BUT CAN
NOT IN AND OF ITSELF BE A BASIS
FOR REMOVAL THERE'S ABSOLUTELY A
LINK BETWEEN REFERRALS TO CPS.
AND HOMELESSNESS.
AND EVEN MORE COMMON FAMILIES
HAVE COMPLIED WITH COURT ORDERS
AND RULES OR OTHERWISE READY TO
REUNIFY WE KNOW ARE NOT BEING
REUNIFIED BECAUSE JUDGES ARE
LOATH. TO REUNIFY CHILDREN TO
THE STREETS.
I'M IN SO WE LITERALLY HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE THEIR CHILDREN
IN FOSTER CARE FOR NO OTHER
REASON.
BUT FOR THE FACT THAT THEIR
PARENTS CAN'T FIND SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE PLACE TO LIVE.
AND SO THE BRINGING FAMILIES
HOME PROGRAM WAS CREATED AS A
DEMONSTRATION PROGRAM THE
TRAILER BILL.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN IT USES
THE HOUSING FIRST MODEL AN
EVIDENCE BASED INTERVENTIONS.
THAT WE'VE SEEN SUCCESSFULLY
WORK IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS IN
THE COUNTRY.
COUNTY AGENCIES COLLABORATE TO
OFFER HOUSING SUPPORTS.
RENT RENTAL ASSISTANCE FIRST AND
LAST MONTH'S HOUSING
MODIFICATIONS FOR EXAMPLE -- TO
ALLOW FOR SUCCESSFUL
REUNIFICATION OF CHILDREN WITH
THEIR FAMILIES ACCORDING TO THE
S. S. IS DATA.
BETWEEN THE START UP IN FEBRUARY
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN IN JUST
OVER ONE YEAR OF OPERATION THE
PROGRAM IS PERMANENTLY HOUSE
FIVE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOUR
FAMILIES.
WHICH IS ALREADY EXCEEDING BUT
FIVE HUNDRED FAMILY GOAL THAT WE
ORIGINALLY SET FOR THE PROGRAM.
AND DURING THE COURSE OF THE
DEMONSTRATION WE'VE ALSO GAIN
BETTER DATA ABOUT THE LINK
BETWEEN HOMELESSNESS AND CHILD
WELFARE INVOLVEMENT.
ARE COUNTIES FOR EXAMPLE
REPORTING NOW THAT HALF OF CHILD
WHILE BROOMBALL FAMILIES ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS -- SO
FUNDING FOR THE EXISTING
DEMONSTRATION IS SET TO EXPIRE
ON JUNE THIRTIETH AND SOAP WILL
WE WILL BE TAKING NO MORE
REFERRALS -- IN THE TWELVE
COUNTIES THAT ARE PART OF THE
DEMONSTRATION -- WE ALSO KNOW
THAT ONLY IN JUST THE TWELVE
COUNTIES THAT ARE DEMONSTRATING
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME THEIR
FIVE HUNDRED IS TIONAL FAMILIES
THAT ARE DETERMINED ELIGIBLE BUT
ARE WAITING BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE.
THE RESOURCES -- WE ALSO KNOW
THAT IT'S PART OF THE
DEMONSTRATION DSS WAS TASKED
WITH THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
COLLECTING DATA AND REPORTING ON
THE OUTCOMES AND WE KNOW THAT
THAT THAT THAT WORK IS IN
PROCESS.
BUT CLEARLY THE EARLY RESULTS
THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THAT THE
REPORTS WERE MY MEMBERS INDICATE
THAT THIS IS AN EXTREMELY COST
EFFECTIVE AND BENEFICIAL PROGRAM
AND SO WE'RE REQUESTING.
THAT THE PROGRAM BE RE
AUTHORIZED FOR TWO MORE YEARS
AND BE INCREASED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION.
SO THAT WE CAN BOTH EXPAND.
THE DEMONSTRATION WITHIN THE
EXISTING COUNTIES BUT ALSO
EXPAND TO NEW COUNTIES WHICH I
SHOULD SAY IS SORT OF THE ARK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
TRUCK WHEN IT CREATED AND THEN
EXPANDED THE COW WORKS HOUSING
SUPPORT PROGRAM WHICH THIS IS IN
SOME WAY MODELED AFTER.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
COMMENTS FROM THE ADMINISTRATION.
PERHAPS IT'S A SIGN OF OUR CLOSE
COLLABORATION ON THIS OF MISTER
MECCA STOLE ALL MY STATISTICS.
WELL TO BE FAIR -- WE STOLE THEM
FROM PETE'S STAFF THE YOU KNOW
THE THINGS THAT I'VE SAID THE OF
A HE NOTED THE EVALUATION WON'T
BE DONE UNTIL NEXT YEAR.
I WOULD ADD IN ADDITION TO THE
FACT THAT IT'S FIVE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR FAMILIES THAT HAVE
SO FAR BEEN REUNIFIED THAT'S
TWELVE HUNDRED KIDS.
JUST TO ADD THAT NUMBER IN THERE.
AND FROM A PROGRAM OPERATIONS
STANDPOINT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
ALTHOUGH IT'S EXACTLY RIGHT THIS
WAS A ONE TIME THREE MILLION
DOLLAR PROGRAM WITH AN
EVALUATION COMPONENT IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT PROGRAMMATIC LEE TO TO
RUN SOMETHING STOP IT AND
RESTART IT IF THAT DECISION IS
MADE TO RESTART.
ADDITIONALLY I'D NOTE THAT WHEN
YOU REUNIFY FAMILY WE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME IN THIS HEARING ON
ISSUE ONE ON C. C. R. WHEN YOU
RE UNIFY THESE ARE KIDS THAT
DON'T NEED A RESOURCE FAMILY
BECAUSE THEIR WITH THEIR
FAMILIES.
SO AGAIN ALL THESE THINGS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP IN A RELATIONSHIP
WITH EACH OTHER.
SO -- SHIP [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IS THERE FOLLOW UP THAT'S DONE
WITH THE FAMILIES TO SEE IF THE
PLACEMENT HAS BEEN PERMANENT AND
SO THESE THESE ARE FAMILY THERE
ACTUALLY ARE UNDER COURT
SUPERVISION -- EITHER
VOLUNTARILY OR OR THROUGH A
PETITION BEING FILED SO.
ON THE DECISION TO REUNIFY HAS
TO BE APPROVED BY THE JUDGE.
AND SO THE JUDGE WOULD SAY THAT
THIS IS A FAMILY THAT'S REMOVED
ALL OF THE SAFETY CONCERNS.
DAVE COMPLIED WITH EVERYTHING
THAT WE REQUIRED AND AND I THE
JUDGE I'M READY. TO TO ORDER
REUNIFICATION BUT FOR THE FACT.
THAT THE PARENTS DON'T HAVE A
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE PLACE TO
LIVE AND SO -- THAT THE
CONDITIONS FOR REUNIFICATION I
E. THAT THE CHILD WILL BE SAFE
WITH THAT FAMILY.
IN THIS CASE HAVE ALREADY BEEN
MATT AND ARE CERTIFIED TO BY THE
JUDGE BEFORE THEY WOULD ISSUE
THE REUNIFICATION ORDER.
WHAT WHAT WILL HAPPEN IF?
FUNDING IS A PROVIDED.
KIDS WILL STAY IN FOSTER CARE
LONGER.
AND PARENTS WHO SHOULD BE WITH
THEIR CHILDREN AND CHILDREN WHO
SHOULD BE WITH THEIR PARENTS
WERE BOTH SUFFER THE TRAUMA OF
BEING SEPARATED.
BRITAIN BUT FOR THE ONLY REASON
BEING THE FACT THAT HOUSING IS
SOEXPENSIVE AND SO DIFFICULT TO
FIND.
AND THEY NEED HELP WITH IT AND
THE CURRENT SYSTEM WAS NEVER
BUILT. TO PROVIDE HOUSING
SUPPORTS AS PART OF THE
REUNIFICATION MILIEU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YOUR AVAILABLE SPACE WHICH OF
PLEASE DO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF LET'S GO
TO ISSUE NUMBER NINE OUR LAST
ISSUE.
WE HAVE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF
ANY TABLE ALREADY -- C. W. S.
TRAINING AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT YES WHAT WE'RE HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION.
AND WE'RE SEEKING TEN MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR DSS NOT
FOR COUNTIES.
AND IT'S FOR DSS. TO AUGMENT THE
EXISTING CHILD WELFARE TRAINING
THAT THEY PROVIDE TO OUR WORKERS.
THIS -- INVESTMENT WOULD
LEVERAGE TWELVE ADDITIONAL
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SO READ THE RESULT IN
TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN REALIGNMENT AND
SH THAT SHIFTED THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF TRAVEL FOR THE
COUNTIES.
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF FUNCTIONS
THAT WERE NOT REALIGNED AND
TRAINING WITH ONE OF THEM.
THE BELIEF AT THE TIME AND I
THINK IT'S THOUGH IF IT'S THE
RIGHT BELIEF WAS THAT FOR
PURPOSES OF ENSURING CONSISTENCY.
AND ACHIEVING ECONOMIES OF SCALE
THAT THE STATE SHOULD BE THE
PROVIDER OF TRAINING IN THE
STATE HAS A ROBUST
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE REGIONAL TRAINING ACADEMY SO
SORT OF IF IT'S NOT BROKE LET'S
NOT TRY TO FIX THAT.
THE TRAINING WITH CAP WITH THE
STATE.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT FUNDING FOR
STATE TRAINING HAS NOT KEPT PACE
WITH THE MAJOR CHANGES IN THE
PROGRAM IN RECENT YEARS.
YOU'VE HEARD ALL ABOUT C. C. R.
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE CHILD AND FAMILY
TEAMING THE KD ES.
SETTLEMENT FOR EXAMPLE.
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
FEDERALLY REQUIRED PROGRAM
IMPROVEMENT PLAN THAT REQUIRES
THAT WE IMPROVE OUR PRACTICE AND
ONE OF THE METHODOLOGIES FOR
DOING THAT.
IS IS BETTER TRAINING -- SO
THEY'RE ALL THESE IMPERATIVES TO
ENHANCE THE TRAINING AND AND IT
REALLY HAS SORT OF NOT KEPT UP
WITH SORT OF LANGUISHED AND SO
WE'RE ASKING FOR THIS --
AUGMENTATION FOR THE STATE TO
ENHANCE ITS CONTRACTS WITH THE
REGIONAL TRAINING ACADEMIES TO
PROVIDE -- THAT.
MORE TRAINING FOR THE REASONS
THAT I'VE MENTIONED BUT ALSO
SOME OTHER ENHANCEMENTS TRAINING
OUTSIDE OF THE CLASSROOM LIKE
WITH PEERS SO THAT THEIR OTHER
MODALITIES OF LEARNING.
TRAINING FOR SUPERVISORS BECAUSE
WE ALL KNOW THAT SUPERVISION IS
AS IMPORTANT. TO OUTCOMES AS AS
THE WORK OF THE LINE -- CASE
WORKER.
TRAINING FOR SPECIALTY
POPULATIONS CHILDREN WHO'VE BEEN
COMMERCIALLY SEXUALLY EXPLOITED --
FOR EXAMPLE AND IS ALSO -- A
PROVISION IN OUR REQUEST TO
ALLOW FOR THE GATHERING ABOUT
COME DATA TO SEE IF THE TRAINING
IS ACTUALLY IMPROVING THE
PRACTICE -- AND SO -- THAT IS
THE BASIS FOR A REQUEST AND WE'D
BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
ON THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IN
THE MORE MORE SPECIFICS TO
OPERATIONALIZE OUR REQUEST.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION.
ON PAIN OF ECHOING MISTER MACKEY
YET AGAIN YOU KNOW HE'S RIGHT
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TRYING TO
CHANGES IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM -- UP TO THIS POINT UP TO
THIS POINT THE APPROACH HAS BEEN
RE PRIORITIZING THE EXISTING
TRAINING BUDGETS WHEN WE LOOK AT
UPDATING CURRICULUM AND SO FORTH.
WE HEAR HIM SAY ON ON BEHALF OF
HIS MEMBERS WHO ARE DOING THE
WORK THAT MORE IS NEEDED.
AND HE ALREADY TOUCHED ON OTHER
THINGS I WOULD SAY WE WANT THE
TRAINING TO REFLECT MODERN
PROVEN APPROACHES REUSABLE
CONTENT PROMOTE LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES.
FIELD BASED FOLLOW ON TRAININGS
HE MENTIONED SUPERVISOR TRAINING --
SPECIALTY POPULATIONS NEW TOPICS
FOR FOR FOR THOSE -- AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMENT AS WELL
ABOUT COLLECTING OUTCOME DATA
YOU'VE HEARD ME TALK ALL DAY
TODAY THAT WHEN WE INVEST IN
SOMETHING WE WANT TO KNOW
WHETHER WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
WORKING WHETHER WE'RE GETTING
WHAT WE EXPECTED.
YOU KNOW ALL AND MAYBE THE FINAL
COMMENT THERE ARE A COUPLE
THINGS YOU NEVER HEAR AND ONE OF
THEM IS MY RATE IS TOO HIGH.
AND THE OTHER THAT YOU NEVER
HEAR IS I'M OVER TRAINED.
RIGHT ON I MEAN YES [inaudible]
HELLO. FOUR WONDERFUL WHAT.
THANK YOU ALL FOR THAT -- AND
NOW I'D LIKE TO OPEN IT UP.
TO TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
ON ISSUES TO THROUGH.
NINE I ALSO TRIED THEM TO FIGHT
WHAT ISSUE YOU'RE SPEAKING ABOUT.
AND AGAIN WE ASK THAT YOU KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS TO WONDER ONE
MINUTE.
YES HI -- MY NAME IS TASHA
MATTHEWS I AM A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH SPEAKING ON IN -- IN
SUPPORT OF THE FFA SOCIAL
BECAUSE GETTING AN INCREASE IN --
PAYMENT -- JUST BECAUSE I GREW
UP IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND I WAS
IN FOSTER CARE MY WHOLE LIFE
FROM ONE MONTH OLD TELL TWENTY
ONE YEARS OF AGE.
I WAS WORKING MORE WITH THE
COUNTY EVEN FFA BUT I SAW HOW
THE OVERTURN OF COUNTY SOCIAL
WORKERS AND JUST THAT CONSTANT.
LAKE WANTING TO TELL THEM WHAT'S
WRONG WITH MY FOSTER FAN FAMILY
AND LIKE ISSUES GOING ON WITH
THIS ONE PLACEMENT WHEN
UNFORTUNATELY NOT GETTING TO DO
THAT UNTIL WAS. TOO LATE AND BY
THAT TIME I WAS ALREADY AN
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE AND THEY
TOOK ADVANTAGE OF ME
UNFORTUNATELY -- THEIR FRIED AND
SO I'D THEN THEY FOUND OUT WITH
ISSUES AND IN BY THEN IT WAS
THERE'S SO MUCH TIME THAT WENT
BY SO I'M TOTALLY IN SUPPORT OF
YOU KNOW SUPPORTING US
SPECIFICALLY FFA SOCIAL WORKERS
AND SEEING THE WORK THAT THEY DO
JUST WORKING IN THAT.
AGENCY AND SO JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE YOU
GONNA BE A SOCIAL WORKER.
TO NO I'M I'M MORE THINKING LAW
LAW SCHOOL RIGHT NOW SO WE'LL.
YEAH.
YEAH I'M AN ATTORNEY AS WELL --
GREET THANK YOU YES THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MELISSA VIA
GOMEZ AND I'M A FORMER FOSTER
THAT AS WELL -- FROM SAN DIEGO
WAS IN FOSTER CARE FOR ELEVEN
YEARS BUT THE FOR THE FIRST
THREE YEARS IN FOSTER CARE WAS
AT THE COUNTY AND MOVED ABOUT
THREE TIMES.
I CAN'T RECALL WHO MY SOCIAL
WORKER WAS BUT WHEN I WAS ABOUT
EIGHT I FINALLY WENT INTO AN FFA
AGENCY AND I WAS ASSIGNED AN FFA
SOCIAL WORKER.
WHO'S STAYED WITH ME FOR SEVEN
YEARS AND ACTUALLY STILL
CONTINUE HAVING A RELATIONSHIP
WITH HER AT THIS TIME I MEET
WITH THEIR ONCE A MONTH -- BUT I
CAN TELL YOU FROM THE MOMENT
THAT I MATTER SHE GOT ME -- ON A
PLAN FOR SUCCESS SHE NOTICED
THAT I WAS THREE GRADES BEHIND
AND I CAN TELL YOU I WOULDN'T BE
HERE STANDING IN FRONT OF YOU
WITH A DOUBLE MAJOR IN SOCIOLOGY
AND CRIMINOLOGY.
AND NOW ADVOCATING FOR FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH AND I AM THE
YOUNGEST OF FIVE I WAS THE ONLY
ONE THAT WAS ABLE TO GET INTO AN
FHA AGENCY AND UNFORTUNATELY MY
BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
A REPEATING THE CYCLE AND I DO
HAVE -- NEPHEWS AND NIECES THAT
ARE IN FOSTER CARE NOW.
SO I DO ADVOCATE FOR THE
INCREASE FOR FFA SOCIAL WORKERS
BECAUSE THEY'RE SO IMPORTANT AND
WE NEED MORE OF THEM SO THAT.
MORE FAST YOU'D HAVE
AGENCIES.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON JORDAN SO SO
CALIFORNIA'S CONNECTION AN
ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTS
KERN A FORMER FOSS YOU'VE TO
IMPROVE THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
TO LEGISLATIVE POLICY AND
PRACTICE CHANGE.
I DO WANT TO GIVE.
A SHOUT OUT TO A G. DETAILS IN
JAKARTA CARSON THE MORE IT'S A
STUDIO -- FOR GIVEN THEIR
EXPERTISE THEIR TESTIMONIES AND
THE USE PERSPECTIVE WITHIN THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM -- HERE IN
SUPPORT AND ISSUE TO REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS AMONG FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH ADVOCACY PROPOSAL -- ISSUE
THREE ON PROMOTING HOUSING
STABILITY FOR TRANSITION AGE
YOUTH ADVOCACY PROPOSAL -- ISSUE
FOR ELIMINATING BARRIERS TO
ENTER AND RE ENTER EXTENT OF
FOSTER CARE ADVOCACY PROPOSAL
AND ISSUE A CONTINUATION OF
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME ADVOCACY
PROPOSAL OUR VISION FOR THE
ORGANIZATIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR YOUTH.
COULD GROW UP TO BE HEALTHY AND
VIBRANT ADULTS AND WE BELIEVE
THESE PROPOSALS WILL CONTRIBUTED
THEIR DEVELOPMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AT THE SENATE JOHNSON WITH THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW
HERE FOR ISSUE FIVE SEVEN AND
THE NON DISCUSSION ITEMS ISSUE
TEN ON THE OFFICE OF FOSTER
CAMPUS PERSON.
AND THE ISSUE ELEVEN ON THE
STATE TRIBAL -- ED EQUAL
COMPLIANCE ITEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HELLO MY NAME IS ON
THE WITH THE ADDRESS I'M I'M A
SOCIAL WORKER AT A SPRINT FOSTER
CARE AGENCY AND FRESNO I'M HERE
IN SUPPORT OF ISSUES TWO FOUR
AND SIX I JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT YOU
RECONSIDER -- AS I HAVE FOURTEEN
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IN BEING A
FOSTER PARENT AND I'VE SEEN A
LOT OF CHANGES AND REMEMBER THAT
THESE CHILDREN ARE OUR FUTURE OF
TOMORROW.
THANK YOU AGREED THANK YOU.
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE DO SUPPORT
ALL THESE PROPOSALS BUT I DO
WANT TO POINT OUT A FEW -- ISSUE.
THREE THIS ONE IT WAS ONE OF OUR
LOBBY DAYS ISSUES THIS PAST
MONDAY WHEN WE HAD OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS IN THE CAPITAL -- ALSO
SUPPORTIVE OF ISSUE FIVE ISSUE
SIX ON THE MINIMUM WAGE -- FOR
FFA AGENCIES I THINK IT WAS
POINTED OUT THAT THAT SOMETHING
WE REALLY MUST DO -- AND THE
ISSUE NINE WHERE A CO SPONSOR OF
THE CW AS TRAINING THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS NANCY PRESS
MARTINEZ I'M A SOCIAL WORKER
WITH.
A STERN AND FRESNO AND I'M
SUPPORTING ISSUES TO FOR AN
ESPECIALLY.
SIX ARM FOR WAGES THAN INCREASES
FOR SOCIAL WORKERS A LOT OF US
AS AS WE HEARD EARLIER WE WE
NEED MASTER'S DEGREES TO GET
INTO THESE JOBS AND SOME OF US
GET INTO SIGNIFICANT THAT.
AND THEN WE START WORKING IN THE
FIELD AND GET PAID -- NOT ENOUGH
AND ARE IN THAT FOR A LONG TIME
AND I'VE SEEN MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES LEAVE THAT ARE VERY
QUALIFIED AND VERY PASSIONATELY
FOR OTHER JOBS AND OTHER PLACES
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO
STAY IN.
AND SOCIAL SERVICES WITH THESE
PACE OF THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SERRA MICHAEL
GASTON WITH YOU FORWARD.
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
FIVE THE FOSTERING SUCCESS FINE
AND IF I MAY UM OUR YOUTH BOARD
MEMBER DEVOTION ARE MADIGAN'S.
WHO WAS A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
YOU CAN BE HERE TODAY BUT SHE
WANTED ME TO SAY THAT THIS BILL?
GIVES FOSTER YOUTH A SHOT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THE REAL WORLD AND
THAT'S WHY SHE URGES YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BUDGET [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING JACQUI ONE WITH
GRAYSON -- ENDING ENDING CHILD.
REDDING CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN SO
EAGER TO SUPPORT. TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE SEVEN AND YES SEVEN AS A
SOCIAL WORKER I ACTUALLY WANT TO
SUPPORT THE THE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASE TO RATE SO THAT'S
SEPARATE AND APART FROM GRACE
BUT THANK YOU.
AND SO EVANS HOLDEN FAMILY
SERVICES AND I'M THE CO I WILL
ONE HAVING CONTINUAL DIFFICULTY
RETAINING SOME OF OUR WONDERFUL
FISH WORKERS HAS WITH HEAD
STABILITY AT STUFF MAKES SUCH A
DIFFERENCE TO THE YOUTH WE WORK
WITH.
SO WE SUPPORT THE SUCH WORK
INCREASE ALSO WORKED WITH MANY
TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH WE DO
SUPPORT THE BILLS TO AND HANS
ALL SERVICES TRUCK TRANSITION
AGE YOU THOUGHT THAT YOU TWO
THREE AND FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
CNN IF AN WITH CHILDREN NOW WE
SUPPORT ALL THE ASKS AGAIN
CHILDREN DON'T HAVE JUST ONE
NEED THAT MANY NEEDS OF THE MORE
OF THESE YOU CAN FIND THE BETTER.
I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT TWO AND
THREE RIGHT NOW THE HOUSING
CRISIS IS JUST REALLY HITTING
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE HARD SO
EVERYTHING THAT YOU CAN DO TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE AT LEAST
HOUSED IN SHELTERED IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU.
WESLEY SABER JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT ISSUE TWO THREE FOUR
SIX EIGHT NINE STRONG SUPPORT OF
ALL OF US THANK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALEXIS BERRY'S FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH AND NOW KERN
ADVOCATE IN SUPPORT OF THE BUT
SMITH'S PROPOSAL AND ALSO AS A
FORMER HOMELESS YOUTH IN FULL
SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER TWO FOR
THE HOMES PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WOULD BE SANTOS SEIU CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF ISSUES THREE SEVEN
EIGHT AND NINE IN REGARDS TO OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE PROPOSAL WE
ARE MOST WELCOMING OF EXPANDING
IT TO INCLUDE ANY OTHER COUNTY
ALTHOUGH WE NEED A LITTLE MORE
MONEY.
NOT LA MONEY BUT A LITTLE MORE
MONEY -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
ME GIVE A HEARTY CAMPBELL
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF
CONTINUED FUNDING FOR THE
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM.
AND I JUST WANT TO ECHO MISTER
MAC AS COMMENTS ON HOW IMPORTANT
PROGRAM IS WE HAVE -- WE'RE ONE
OF THE TWELVE COUNTIES IN HOUSE --
OVER NINETY FAMILIES AND I
PERSONALLY SEEN THE IMPACT THAT
THIS PROGRAM CAN HAVE SO I URGE
YOU TO CONTINUE ANTHONY THIS
PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
JERRY JOHNSON THE QUANTITY OF
FAMILY SERVICES IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE SIX AND JUSTICE YOUR
PERSONAL.
I WENT FOR NINE YEARS WITHOUT A
RAISE.
IT'S MY GIRLS FROM HIGH SCHOOL
AND COLLEGE I COULD REALLY USE
THE MONEY BUT BECAUSE OF MY AND
MY SALARY WAS LOCKED.
MY VALUE FOR DOLLAR DROP AND
THAT'S THE SITUATION A LOT OF
OUR WORKERS ARE NOW.
THANKS THANKS FOR STICKING WITH
IT BECAUSE THE KIDS THAT YOU
HELPED OBVIOUSLY WORK.
THAT THAT WAS SO IMPORTANT I
MEAN DURING THIRTY ONE YEARS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR DOING
THAT.
JULIE MCCORMICK CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER OF CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF ISSUES --
TWO THREE FOUR FIVE SEVEN AND
AIDS -- I THINK AS THROUGH THE
END OF AN FROM CHILDREN NOW SAID
CHILDREN.
IN FOSTER YOUTH ARE IN NEED OF
ALL OF THESE ISSUES WHAT YOU CAN
FIND WOULD BE GREAT I DO WANT
ESPECIALLY HIGHLIGHT AND THANK
MADAM CHAIR FOR COMMENTS.
IN REGARDS TO ISSUE -- FOR THESE
ARE SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD SEVENTEEN
HAVE YOUR OLD IN DESPERATE
SITUATIONS CHILDREN'S AUTHOR OF
CALIFORNIA'S A PROUD CO SPONSOR
THAT ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR CO SPONSORING THE
JUSTIN GET CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES -- WHEN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ISSUE THREE ON
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE INITIATE ON
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME --
COUNTIES CONTINUE TO COME BACK
HOMELESSNESS AT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IS NO IMPORTANT MORE
IMPORTANT PLACE TO INVEST THEN --
INSURING THAT CHILDREN YOUTH
HAVE SAFE AND SECURE HOUSING SO
WITH THIS FUNDING.
COUNTIES CAN CONTINUE AND EXPAND
ON EXISTING EFFORTS TO SERVE
THOSE CHILD WELFARE INVOLVE
FAMILY IS AN OLDER YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JESSICA --
ENZYME A MASTER'S LEVEL SOCIAL
WORKER I'VE BEEN IN FFA SOCIAL
WORKER FOR THE LAST SIX YEARS
THANK YOU DONNA AND I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY THAT 75% OF THE CHILDREN
PLACED IN FOSTER CARE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO ARE NOT
IN RELATIVE.
CARE OUR PLACE THROUGH AT THE
FACE -- AND HAVE A SOCIAL
WORKERS SEE THEIR KIDS IN
FAMILIES USUALLY WEEKLY
SOMETIMES MULTIPLE TIMES A WEEK.
SO WE'RE KIND OF THE FIRST
RESPONDERS IN THIS -- SITUATION
IN ADDITION I AM ALSO FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH SO -- FOR ME AS
SOMEONE WHO WAS ABLE TO GET TO
COLLEGE AND OBTAINED A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
AND TO FIGHT TO ALSO GET A
MASTER'S DEGREE -- TO ENTER A
FIELD THAT I TRULY AM PASSIONATE
ABOUT AND TO FINALLY GET HERE
AND THEN TO FIND THAT MY WAGES
ARE STAGNANT.
IS IS BEYOND DISAPPOINTING SO
DEFINITELY WOULD LIKE TO
ADVOCATE IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
NUMBER SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WHAT A GREAT SUCCESS STORY?
HI MY NAME IS GORDON RICHARDSON
I'M A SOCIAL WORKER WITH
UPLIFTED ON THE SERVICES -- WE
SUPPORT ON ALL THE ISSUES
THROUGH -- THAT WERE DISCUSSED
THIS AFTERNOON A FIVE THREE NINE
SPECIAL ATTENTION TO THE BFA
RATE INCREASE.
AND YOU KNOW TECHNOLOGY MATURES
A COMMENTS THAT THIS IS
COMPLETELY RATIONAL -- PART OF
THE REASON WE'RE HERE IS BECAUSE
FFA RATES ARE ONE OF THE VERY
FEW RATES THAT ARE NOT.
INCREASED WETTON COSTS INCREASE
ACCORDING TO SEE AN AYE INDEX.
AND THAT'S NOT RATIONAL.
AND I THINK THAT -- WE COULD
AVOID THIS IN THE FUTURE IF WE
LOOK AT THAT ISSUE AS WELL --
DEEPLY APPRECIATE YOU
CONSIDERING SUPPORT FOR THIS --
TWENTY SIX POINT SEVEN MILLION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING AND WHAT THE
PROCESS WITH A PROFOUNDLY
SERVICES WE PROVIDE SERVICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BOTH
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AND FOSTER ON
WERE ALSO FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY.
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO ADDRESS
THE IMPACT OF THE MINIMUM WAGE --
Là ON SOCIAL WORKERS AND FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCIES WE ALSO SUPPORT
ISSUES TWO THREE FOUR AND FIVE
AND ALL THE OTHERS ON THE LIST
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KRISTIN POWER THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUES THREE FOUR AND SIX AND
ALSO WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE DSS NON
DISCUSSION ITEMS.
IN SUPPORT OF THE OFFICE OF THE
BUT FIRST THEN AND ALSO GREATER
RESOURCES FOR A QUICK COMPLY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO AT LEAST MADRID WITH
DESPAIR NET I'M HERE IN SUPPORT
OF A ISSUES TWO FOUR AND SIX I
WANT TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT IT
SHOULD NUMBER.
TWO I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE TO
WORK -- FOR THE TV PLUS PROGRAM
FOR THE PAST TEN YEARS OF MY
LIFE -- HAS.
ABOUT THE YOU KNOW I I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU GUYS REMEMBER IN THE
TIME FOR YOU KNOW WE HAD A
COUNTY MATCHING WE HAD THIS THIS
AND THAT.
I BREAKS MY HEART THAT.
WE HAVE YOUTH AMY MENTIONED
EARLIER FOUR HUNDRED YOU THAT
CAN I GET INTO THE PROGRAM.
THIS IS AN EXISTING PROGRAM YOU
KNOW EARLIER THE DIRECTOR
MENTIONED THAT WE WANT TO SEE
RESULTS.
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT HAS
PROVEN YEAR AFTER YEAR THAT IT
IS EFFECTIVE THAT IT IS CHANGING
IN LIFE THAT IT IS.
CREATING THE OFFICE COULD CHANGE
THAT HAVE YOU KNOW WHETHER WE
LOOK AT IT FROM A FISCAL OR
HUMANITARIAN POINT OF VIEW IS
HAVING AN IMPACT.
RIGHT NOW I'M I'M ON THE
COACHING CONTRACT ACROSS THE
STATE AND COUNTY KEEPS THINGS
WITH.
WHY CAN'T WE SERVE MORE?
WE HAVE BEEN OPERATING WITH THE
SAME ALLOCATION SOME COUNTIES
FOR EIGHT NINE YEARS THAT.
BREAKS THE HEART TO TELL THE
YOUTH YOU KNOW WE CAN DO THAT I
BROUGHT A LOT OF OUR YOUTH WITH
ME EARLIER TODAY I TOLD THEM
THAT.
I CAN GO UP THERE AND SPEAK ALL
THEY WANT BUT YOUR VOICE TO THE
ONE THAT COUNTS.
BUT BECAUSE THEY WORK AND THEY
GO TO SCHOOL THEY HAD TO GO BACK
OP SO JUST ON BEHALF OF THEM I
INALL OF OUR YOUTH I WHEN I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT -- ISSUE
NUMBER TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALEXIS PETERS I WORK
WITH THE SPELLING OF HIS WHILE
I'M HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO
OFFICE -- I HAVE BEEN IN THIS
FIELD FOR OVER SIXTEEN YEARS
I'VE DONE A LOT OF DIRECT WORK
BEFORE HE MOVED INTO MANAGEMENT.
AND I HAVE WATCHED THESE SHOES.
AGE EIGHTEEN GO INTO NOTHING.
AND THEY END UP ON THE STREETS.
ANYWAY I WILL TELL YOU OF YOU
PROBABLY KNOW BUT WE WILL
DEFINITELY SUPPORT ISSUES TWO
FOUR AND SIX AND LET'S HELP ALL
ARGUE PLEASE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CAN LUIS GONNA SPEAK ON ISSUES
TWO FOUR AND SIX A MAP THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOU
THEN THANK YOU FOR THE
DISCUSSION ESPECIALLY ON ISSUE.
FOR I'M IN A WHILE WE'RE SITTING
HERE SENT THE LANGUAGE OVER SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE WE CAN
CONTINUE THIS DISCUSSION AND
MEETS I'M ACCORDINGLY AND BEFORE
THE IN THE MONTHS THAT THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR TIME INTENTIONS
DETAIL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MERRY FRAME I AM A
CURRENTLY DIRECTOR OF QUALITY
ASSURANCE YEAH I AM A FORMER
SOCIAL WORKER WHO WORKED IN --
AND LIVES IN SAN MARINO COUNTY
THAT HIS SPENT A LOT OF TIME
WORKING WITH CHILDREN WITH
SPECIAL HEALTHCARE NEEDS AND
OTHER NEEDY CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE FROM.
ZERO TO TWENTY ONE AND WE ARE
SPENDING A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TIME WE SEE THEM ONCE A WEEK WE
HAVE CONTACT WITH THEM EVERY DAY
THESE ARE EXTREMELY NEEDY KIDS.
AND THE SOCIAL WORKERS NEED TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE WHAT THEY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THESE CHILDREN.
AND I AM ABSOLUTELY ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF TWO THREE AND FOUR I
WORK WITH EMANCIPATED FORCED
FOSTER YOUTH IN A HIGH DESERT
AREA OF SIMMERING DINO.
AND I SEE THE YOUTH WHO COULD
NOT GET INTO THP THE NUMBER OF
KIDS ON A WAIT LIST DOESN'T EVEN
TOUCH BECAUSE THERE ARE A WHOLE
BUNCH OF KIDS THAT NEVER EVEN
MADE IT TO THE WAIT LIST.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO POINT TO GET
ON THE WAIT LIST SO THEY HAVE TO
FIND SOMETHING ELSE IF IF
POSSIBLE.
SO THAT NUMBER IS ACTUALLY
PROBABLY NOT THE MOST ACCURATE.
AND SO WE SUPPORT ALL OF THESE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OPERATORS HAVE GUESTS WITH
SENECA FAMILY OF AGENCIES ARE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WAS HERE
EARLIER TODAY.
I IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
INCREASE IN WAGES FOR THE FOSTER
FAMILY SOCIAL WORKERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
CRISTO NUMBER IT'S CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF JOB AND FAMILY
SERVICES IN SUPPORT OF TWO THREE
FOUR FIVE AND OF COURSE SIX THE
FOSTER CARE RATES INCREASE.
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SEE A
CONTINUATION OF THE BRING HOME
FAMILIES.
A PROGRAM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO A CHAD BELLEROSE C. S.
BERNETT TO BOTH A DIRECTOR OF MY
FRESNO OFFICE AND A RESOURCE
PARENT MYSELF THE LAST TWELVE
YEARS SERVICE SEVENTEEN ALL
RIGHT NOW THAT'S GETTING READY
FOR COLLEGE.
AND IT'S BEEN A A WORLD WHEN
THERE BUT IT'S SHOWS THE
IMPORTANCE OF THOSE THE
STABILITY IN THAT CONTINUUM OF
CARE FROM WORKERS AND SO IN
SUPPORT SPECIFICALLY OF TWO FOUR
AND SIX AND I CAN'T REALLY SAY
ANYTHING MORE THAN THAT WORKERS
AND OTHERS HAVE ALREADY SAID
BEFORE AND THE IMPORTANCE.
IN THE RATIONALE THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD EVENING DIANNE WARREN A
SPARE NET FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY
WE HAVE LOCATIONS IN SACRAMENTO.
SAN JOAQUIN FRESNO TULARE KERN
LOS ANGELES SAM BERNIE DINO --
MONTEREY CONTRA COSTA VENTURA
COUNTIES I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUES TWO FOUR AND SIX AND I
REALLY APPRECIATED THE
CONVERSATION AND CONCERN TODAY
THAT WAS SHOWN. FOR YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE -- WAS VERY HEART
WARMING FOR ME TO HEAR YOUR YOUR
ALL YOUR CONCERN -- FOR FOR OUR
YOUTH AND AND IN PARTICULAR TO
FOR ITEM NUMBER.
SIX OUR COUNTIES ARE LOOKING TO
FF FACE FOR THE FAMILIES FOR
THESE CHILDREN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THESE KIDS ARE COMING OUT
CONGREGATE CARE.
THEY'RE RELYING ON FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCIES TO HAVE THE FAMILIES
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS FOR THESE
YOUTH AND THE FAMILIES.
AND IF WE DON'T HAVE THE RATE
INCREASE WE'RE NOT GOING TO
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE THERE TO
TO OFFER THAT SO I I FEEL LIKE
IT'S VITAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON PEAK MASS BUT TO
LOW WITH A SPEAR IN IT AND ALL I
OVERSEE THE GREATER BAY AREA
OFFICE.
WE PROVIDE SERVICES TO OF THE
WHOLE BAY AREA COUNTIES.
OF I HAVE BEEN IN AND AROUND.
CHILDREN FAMILY SERVICES.
FOR THE ONE THREE THIS THIRTY
FIVE YEARS ON THE PRIVATE SIDE.
MY WIFE AND I BETWEEN THE SOCIAL
WORKERS WE ALSO HAVE BEEN
RESOURCE FAMILIES SINCE -- TWO
THOUSAND FOUR WE'VE HAD.
ADOPTED GUARDIANSHIP AND
FOSTERED.
OVER. SEVENTEEN CHILDREN.
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT. TWO FOUR IN
SIX IN SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE WE
ARE IN THE BAY AREA.
REALLY IS CHALLENGING TO RECRUIT
AND HIRE SOCIAL WORKERS WHO WITH
THE COST OF HOUSING WITHIN THE
BAY AREA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
HELLO AGAIN JORDAN WITH
CALIFORNIA'S CONNECTION WANTING
TO SHOW OUR ORGANIZATION SUPPORT
ON THE NON DISCUSSION ITEM ISSUE
TEN ON THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL ON THE OFFICE OF
FOSTER CARE -- BUT IT'S OFFICE --
JUST PERSONAL PER -- PERSPECTIVE
ON IT I DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THE
POSSIBLE RIGHTS UNTIL I WAS
INVOLVED IN CALIFORNIA'S
CONNECTION WAS IN THE SYSTEM
SINCE NINE AN AGED OUT.
AND ON FOR EVEN THOUGH I WASN'T
ABLE TO LEARN ABOUT MY RIGHTS
AND I KNOW ABOUT THE FOSTER ON
BUT IT'S OFFICE HOTLINE I WAS
ABLE TO SHARE THIS INFORMATION
WITH MY YOUNGER SIBLINGS WERE
STONE CARE.
AND FOR FUTURE USE WILL BE
ENTERING THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
SO JUST GOT ONE IT SHOWS A POOR
ON ADDITIONAL STAFF FOR THEM
THAT'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU.
HI AM J. BERLIN I'M CEO OF
ALTERNATIVE FAMILY SERVICES AND
FFA IN ADOPTION AGENCY IN THE
BAY AREA ALSO HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON ITEM SIX
THE MINIMUM WAGE BUT IN A WAY
ALL THE ITEMS THAT YOU'RE OR
MANY OF THE ITEMS THAT YOU'VE
HEARD TODAY REALLY INTO RELATED.
YOUR SISTER IS QUITE RIGHT THE
SOCIAL WORKERS DO ALL THE WORK
THE IF IN FACT WE ARE LOOKING AT
CC OR IN A COMPREHENSIVE WAY AND
YOU ARE LOOKING TO TRY AND
RETURN.
THAT CHILDREN TO FAMILY BASED
SETTINGS IT'S THE SOCIAL WORKERS
TO CREATE THIS FAMILY BASS
SETTINGS THE RETENTION OF FOSTER.
FAMILIES IS BASED IN -- ALMOST
DIRECTLY ON THE LEVEL SUPPORT
THEY RECEIVE FROM THE SOCIAL
WORKERS THE APPROVAL OF NEW
FAMILIES IS DONE.
UP A BY SOCIAL WORKERS THE
MINIMUM WAGE IS A MAJOR
WORKFORCE ISSUE FOR US BUT EVEN
WITHIN A LARGER CONTEXT I WOULD
I WOULD -- I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
LOOK AT THE ROLE OF THE FAA
WITHIN THE C. C. R. I DON'T
THINK IT IS A HEAD THAT HAS BEEN
PAID A SUFFICIENT.
ATTENTION. TO DATE.
AS WELL YOU KNOW WHAT.
START HERE THIS MORNING IN THE
CONVERSATION ON IT ITEM NUMBER
ONE SO WITHIN THAT CONTEXT
THANKS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS MARYLAND
SEX AN ASSISTANT DIRECTOR FOR
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA YOUTH AND
FAMILY PROGRAMS WERE BASED OUT
OF BUTTE COUNTY AND SHASTA
COUNTY AS WELL -- DEFINITELY
HERE FOR THE INCREASE IN THE FFA
SOCIAL WORKER SALARIES YOU'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT THAT HOW
IMPORTANT THEY ARE.
AND HOW MUCH THEIR RELEASE
COMPLETELY INVOLVED WITH -- THE
CHILD AND ALSO AS A PREVIOUS
FOSTER CHILD WAY BACK IN THE
SIXTIES AND SEVENTIES -- IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN SUCH A BLESSING
TO HAVE ALL THESE THINGS IN
PLACE FOR ME WHEN I TURNED --
EIGHTEEN BUT I DIDN'T HAVE THAT.
BUT SO ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAN
DO TO IMPROVE THE LIVES AND THAT --
OUTCOMES OF THESE FOSTER YOUTH
WE SHOULD BE DOING WHETHER IT'S
THE REUNIFICATION OF THE FAMILY
AND IF WE CAN'T DO THAT THEN
SUPPORTING THOSE KIDS IN
PROVIDING THE BEST OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THEM FOR THE FUTURE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LEE CSE SO I'D AND I
AM A RESOURCE FOR THEM.
I HAVE TWELVE CHILDREN AND EIGHT
WHICH ARE IN THE HOME RIGHT NOW.
FIVE OF THOSE I AM IN THE
PROCESS OF ADOPTING TO THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
AND SADLY MY CHILDREN CONTINUE
TO KEEP HAVING A LOSS OF AND
CARING ADULTS IN THEIR LIFE.
THEY THIS LOSS OF THE CARING
ADULTS ARE LIFE IS SPECIFICALLY
HAPPENING.
BECAUSE OF THE LOSS OF THE
SOCIAL WORKERS THAT HAVE WORKED
WITH THAT.
SINCE MY FIVE CHILDREN HAVE.
BEEN PLACE WITH ME THAT I'M THE
ADOPTING AND WE HAVE LOST.
THE STATE HAD LOST FIVE SOCIAL
WORKERS TO JUST IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINETEEN AS THEY HAD TO
LEAVE.
WITH -- TAPE GATE HAVE BETTER
EMPLOYMENT.
AND THE ONE SOCIAL WORKER I DID
FIND HER.
AND WHEN WE CALL TURN OVER
WRITER OUR DRIVER IF HE WAS THE
UBER DRIVER AND IT JUST BROKE MY
HEART TO HEAR LIKE IN TO SEE.
THAT SOMEONE WHO SHOULD BE A
PROVIDERS OF SELF CARE IS UNABLE
TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS GERRY
MCCULLOUGH OF REPRESENT AFS
FAMILY SERVICES ALTERNATIVE
FAMILY SERVICES -- I WOULD LIKE
TO BE IN SUPPORT OF TWO FOUR AND
SIX HEARD A LOT FROM -- PREVIOUS
FOSTER -- FOSTER YOUTH -- I WAS
OUT OF FOSTER YOUTH BUT MY
MOTHERWAS SO I'M MORE
GENERATION REMOVED -- AND I HAVE
RATED AND PROGRESSED TO BE A
SOCIAL WORKER AND DIRECTOR A
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY SO.
THE SAYING THAT -- THERE A LOT
OF YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE WHO LOOK.
LIKE ME THERE ARE A LOT OF
MINORITIES A LOT OF MALES AND
FEMALES A LOOK LIKE ME AND IN
ORDER TO MY MOTHER DIDN'T HAVE
THAT.
I'M I'M GOOD WITH A TIME WHERE
THERE WERE NO IF A PHASE SO SHE
TO HAVE SOMEBODY TO COME AND
CHECK ON HER EVERY WEEK -- A. B.
IN THE TRENCHES WITH THEIR SOUL --
I WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT SIX
BECAUSE A LOT OF US.
WITHOUT THAT YOU WON'T SEE A LOT
OF US THEY WILL GET A CHANCE TO
SEE THEMSELVES AND SEE WHAT
SUCCESS LOOKS LIKE.
SO.
IN SAYING THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS HECTOR LUIS MIGHT
THE US JUNIOR.
AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF FOSTER
CARE FOR AN FFA TLC.
AND COME BEFORE YOU BECAUSE I
HAVE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING WITH SOME OF THE MOST
AMAZING AND MOST SACRIFICIAL
SOCIAL WORKERS.
THE ODDS -- DO IT.
FOR LITTLE TO NOTHING.
AND THEY ALSO LAST THAT LONG
LITTLE TO NOTHING AND SO I'M
HERE SUPPORTING TWO THREE FOUR
AND SIX AND PARKING ON SIX SO
THAT WE CAN MAINTAIN THE
CONTINUITY.
AND THE CHILDREN THAT WE KNOW
LOVE AND CHOOSE TO SURF.
THANK YOU.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
EIGHT THE BRINGING FAMILIES HOME
PROGRAMS THEY'VE HAS TO MORE
THAN SIXTY FAMILIES UTILIZING
THE FUNDING.
AS WELL AS ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
BERNADINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
NINE THE CHILD WELFARE SERVICES
TRAINING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS YURI
CAMERA AND I OVERSEE A FOSTER
CARE PROGRAM IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA -- WE'VE SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT TURN OVER SOCIAL
WORKERS OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS
MANY CITING SALARY AS A REASON
FOR DEPARTURE.
OUR FAMILIES OFTEN STATE THAT
THE STRONG RELATIONSHIPS THAT
THEY HAVE WITH SOCIAL WORKERS AS
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS THAT
THEY ARE SATISFIED.
AND ABLE TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
AND STABILIZE YOUTH IN THEIR
CARE.
AND AT THE SAME TIME THEY HAVE
STATED HIGH SOCIAL WORKER
TURNOVER IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CONCERNS.
SOCIAL WORKER STABILITY AS HAS
BEEN STATED ARE DIRECTLY IMPACTS
THE STABILITY OF YOUTH IN OUR
CARE AND THE RETENTION OF
RESOURCE PARENTS THAT WE
CRITICALLY NEED.
AND SO I SUPPORT THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO ADDRESS THE IMPACT OF
THE MINIMUM WAGE LOSS.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA HARRIS
FAMINE FFA SOCIAL WORKER.
I'M IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE SIX THE
INCREASED WAGES FOR FFA SOCIAL
WORKERS.
AT THE CONSTANT TURNOVER DO LOW
WAGES ARE NEGATIVELY IMPACTS THE
STABILITY OF YOUTH -- AND BIRTH
FAMILIES AS WELL AS BEING ABLE
TO RETAIN RESOURCE FAMILIES --
AND ALSO IMPACTS THE CASELOADS
AND QUALITY OF SERVICE OF THE
REMAINING SOCIAL WORKERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS FOR CARDINAL
AND AND I'M A FFA SOCIAL WORKER
INTERN -- I MEAN IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM NUMBER SIX I'M A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH AS WELL -- WHO WAS
INSPIRED TO PURSUE MY MASTERS OF
SOCIAL WORK UP I'LL BE
GRADUATING IN MAY YEAH -- IN SO
A YOU KNOW I'M I'M JUST HERE TO
REALLY SAY THAT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE I WAS
FILTERING THROUGH SERVICES AT A
TIME FFA SOCIAL WORKERS WERE NOT
A THING -- IN WHICH I'VE TURNED
EIGHTEEN AND DIDN'T HAVE A
SUSTAINABILITY PLAN AND SO IT'S
VERY DETRIMENTAL TO A YOU FLOOR
FILTERING TO SERVICES SO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU CONGRATULATIONS.
HELLO -- I'M DOCTOR LAURA
HEIGHTS I AM A CEO OF A FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY WE PROVIDE
SERVICES THROUGH THE SACRAMENTO
REGION.
AND I ACTUALLY AM IN SUPPORT OF
ALL OF THE ISSUES ADDRESSED HERE
ARE FOSTERING YOUTH REALLY NEED
EVERYTHING WE CAN GIVE THEM TO
BE SO -- SUCCESSFUL AND WE IN IN
TURN ARE OBLIGATED TO SERVE
THESE FOSTER YOUTH IN THE BEST
WAY POSSIBLE.
IN PARTICULAR ISSUE NUMBER SIX
IS OF URGENT.
NEED FOR US SO -- I'M REALLY
HOPING THAT YOU CAN UNDERSTAND
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS OUR
SALARY ISSUES FOR OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WHAT?
ROB GETTY I WORK FOR A LARGE
STATEWIDE FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY I
OVERSEE OUR ADOPTION PROGRAM WE
HAVE FIFTEEN OFFICES STATEWIDE.
JUST RAN THE NUMBERS OF TURN
OVER WITH OUR SOCIAL WORKERS --
THE LAST FIVE YEARS IT'S BEEN
DOUBLE DIGIT TURN OVER WITH OUR
SOCIAL WORKERS.
AND OF THOSE OF THAT TURN OVER
DOUBLE DIGIT TURN OVER. 59% HAVE
LEFT. FOR OTHER STATE COUNTY
JOBS HOSPITALS AND WE CAN'T
COMPETE WITH OF SALARIES WITH
WHERE THE RATE IS NOW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I THINK ISSUE NUMBER SIX IS A
VERY POPULAR.
ONE SO I WOULD ASK THAT IF YOU
IF IF THAT'S THE ONE YOU WANT TO
SPEAK ON WOULD YOU GIVE US YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION AND
THE ME [inaudible]
TOO THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING I AM LAURA
RICHARDSON I'M WITH QUEEN ANNE
OF FAMILY SERVICES AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE.
SIX THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING I'M JUST GONNA
LEARN WITH QUEEN IF IN A
SERVICES AND SUPPORT A NUMBER
SIX AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M DAVE WESSON I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE FOSTER PARENTS
BECAUSE SO I WAS A FOSTER PARENT --
MANY YEARS AGO WHEN.
I WANT TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE --
CONTRIBUTION A DIFFERENCE IN MY
COMMUNITY AND SO I TOOK IN A OF
OF FOSTER CHILDREN PARTICULARLY
AT TEENAGERS THE MAJORITY OF
THOSE WERE PROBATION CHOOSE THE
TEENAGERS.
AND I WOULD HAVE NEVER MADE IT
IF IT HADN'T BEEN FOR FOSTER
PARENTS OF FOR THE SOCIAL
WORKERS THAT KEPT ME IN THE GAME
SO I WON SAID NUMBER
[inaudible]
SIX THANKS.
GOOD EVENING CARRY OUT I MEAN
THAT'S WITH ONLY PUT FAMILIES
I'M IN SUPPORT OF ALL THE ISSUES
INCLUDING TEN BUT PARTICULARLY --
NUMBER SIX WE ARE CRITICAL TO
THE VISION AND MISSION OF CCAR
AND SERVING OUR CHILDREN FOR
SAFETY PERMANENCY AND WELL BEING
SO APPRECIATED THANK YOU THANK
YOU IT'S CLEAR WITHOUT YOU CAN'T
[inaudible]
CAN'T SUCCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NOR MY
THE GAY AND THE FOUNDER OF A
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY BASED IN
LOS ANGELES AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT NUMBER.
SIX THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS OFTEN
A MEDINA AND I'M AN
ADMINISTRATOR FOR AN FFA IN THE
CITY OF ORANGE.
I'M ALSO HERE TO SUPPORT ISSUE
NUMBER SIX THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A
SPENT ON SUBTLETY GUESS I'M A
SUPERVISORFOR THE LA OFFICE.
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF NUMBER SIX
AND I ALSO HAVE TO TELL YOU THIS
BUT I AGREE WITH YOUR SYSTEM
WILL FUND THE SOCIAL WORKERS DO
ALL THE WORK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF A BIGGER
TOO MUCH CREDIT.
SHE'S GONNA BE WATCHING THE TAPE
LATER.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DAILY NEWS ON
TV AND I AM A MSW SOCIAL WORKER
WITH REALLY PUT FAMILIES I'VE
WORKED -- WITH AGENCY FOR ABOUT
TWELVE YEARS AND I THINK THE
MOST ALARMING THING I'VE SEEN
SPECIFICALLY MOST RECENTLY IS
THE LACK OF ATTENTION WE'VE HAD
OF SOCIAL WORKERS.
THE KIDS THAT WE SERVE COME FROM
HISTORIES OF TRAUMA AND ABUSE
AND THEY NEED ATTACHMENT AND
CONSISTENCY AND THEY'RE JUST I'M
NOT GETTING THAT.
AND A BIG PART OF THAT IS
BECAUSE OF THE A LACK OF OF
DECENT WAGES I I ACTUALLY LEFT
THE AGENCIES.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO TO GO PURSUE
HEALTH CARE WHERE I COULD HAVE --
INCREASES AND NOW I AM STAGNANT
IN MY SALARY BUT I'VE COME BACK
BECAUSE I LOVE THE WORK AND I
LOVE WHAT WE DO SO THANK YOU ALL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS AMY HEILEMAN
FROM CHILDREN'S BUREAU SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN LOS ANGELES ORANGE
COUNTY KERN RIVER SIDE.
NUMBER MEDINA AND WE SUPPORT
NUMBER ALL OF THEM BUT NUMBER
SIX PARTICULAR THANK YOU.
HELLO BILL RICHARDSON A CORNEA
FAMILY SERVICES.
OF ME TO ON NUMBER SIX THANK YOU.
UNDER JOHN'S FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LANCER CHILDREN FAMILY SERVICES
WHO WHO BROUGHT YOU ISSUE SIX
TODAY I ALSO WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
WE EXPRESSED OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
A NON DISCUSSION ITEMS THAT THE
BIGGER THE BCP'S THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS ON
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN
SUPPORTING THE FORFEITURE OF
WHICH WOULD PROGRAM.
AND ITS EXPANSION IT'S NOT
COMMITTEE ISSUED TEN BECAUSE
IT'S IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR THE
CHILDREN TO KNOW THEY HELP SOME
PLACE TO COOK TO CALL IN
ADDITION TO THEIR THEIR SOCIAL
WORKERS THANK YOU [inaudible]
Q. [inaudible]
WELL.
YOU WERE THE LAST.
ONE WELL I I DO WANT TO THANK.
ALL OF YOU -- FOR YOUR CONTINUED.
ADVOCACY AND AND WORK IN THIS
AREA IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
AND YOU'RE RIGHT WHEN YOU YOU'VE
GOT A FINITE AMOUNT OF MONEY.
AND YOU'RE GOING TO FIGURE OUT
TO YOU KNOW WHERE YOU'RE GOING
TO BALANCE IT OUT.
WELL I ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT SOME
OF THESE OVER LAP.
AND WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO PROVIDE.
ALL OF THESE SERVICES JUST
FIGURE OUT HOW THE BUDGET IS
GOING TO BE -- SET UP SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THE OVERLAP IN THE
DUPLICATION -- THE ISSUE NUMBER
SIX EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND IT
JUST IT DOES SEEM LIKE AN
OVERSIGHT.
THAT NEEDS TO BE REMEDIED BUT I
AGAIN I THANK YOU ALL AND I
THINK OUR SOCIAL WORKERS BECAUSE
JUST LIKE ROSA SAID.
YOU ARE THE ONES WHO DO ALL THE
WORK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND THANK YOU
ALL -- THIS WEEK I DO WANT TO
REITERATE OR I WANT TO SAY
BECAUSE I DID NOT SAY IT BEFORE.
THAT THE ISSUES A WILL BE HELD
OPEN.
I THANK YOU ALL.
THIS CONCLUDES TODAY'S HEARING.
THE TO TAKE EVEN THE USER ESTHER